This college algebra course is different than other college algebra courses. Like many other
ones, you will be learning all the concepts from an experienced university professor.
But in this course, the instructor Ed Protowski will also show you how to implement all the
concepts in Python. This course is for everybody, but especially those interested in computer
science. Hello and welcome to the Algebra with Python course. My name is Ed and I'll be your
guide on this adventure. So we're going to learn about algebra and how to write Python code to do
all of your algebra. Because there's so many different things that you can do with formulas.
You learn these formulas. Hey, anytime you have a formula, you can write code to use it.
So that's what we're going to do. We're going to write some code using the Google CoLab notebook.
That's Python, a Jupyter notebook, essentially in your Google Drive. So one of the next things
we'll do is look at how to set that up. We're going to go through each unit. We're going to
look at the math. We're going to look in the actual lessons. I'll be writing things on the board
and we'll look at the concepts, how to do the math on the board. And then we'll look at
then how to write the code to do this. And you'll be able to create your own CoLab notebooks.
In fact, I hope you do create your own notebook or two along the way, building your own
resources that you can use. You can also, you know, once we set it up, you can also actually
download the CoLab, the Google CoLab app, and you have access to each of these notebooks on
your phone. So, you know, you can make your own like, you know, super calculator that you have
access to on your phone, you know, solve all kinds of things, you know, and that's great.
You know what, you know, building these resources, but also understanding how to use them so that as
you go further in math and in writing code and eventually leading up to, you know, working in
data science, that you really understand these concepts and you know how to use all the formulas
that you're creating. So that's really, that's the idea. That's what we want to do. And each unit is
going to be a lot like this. I'm going to talk about the math, you know, we'll do some things
on the board and then we'll flip it and we'll look at how to do that with code. I'll include
all the resources for you. And then in addition to the core concepts in each unit, the next thing,
then what we'll do is I'll have another video or two of extra working through the problems.
So, you know, you know how to write the code, you're building your resources,
and then we'll just work through a bunch of extra problems, you know, putting this into practice.
And it'll be really great. You know, you'll learn algebra, you'll learn code,
and you'll have all these skills under your belt that you can use for a lot of other things. And
we're going to build upon these in future courses. So I hope you enjoy. Okay, so let's look at how
to set up Google CoLab in your Google Drive. So in your Google Drive, hopefully you have it organized
in folders and, you know, you have a, you'll set up a folder for this course. That way, you know,
you can have all the documents and notebooks and everything there, just like I have here,
and you will have access to all these documents you see, you know, soon enough. So
if we take a look at the little yellow infinity symbol, that's the Google CoLab.
And, you know, if you want to create a new Google CoLab, you're in the folder where you want it to
be, click on new, and it won't be here, and you go to more, and then it'll be down here.
So Google CoLab. Now, if you don't have it already, if you have not yet set it up,
then you go down to connect more apps. And, you know, it's begins at C, it might show up,
you know, here. But if not, then you can search, you know, and look at this like CoLab, even if
you just do Co, it comes up. But if you type in CoLab, then it'll come up. There we go. And again,
mine's already installed. But if it wasn't, you'd see it there, you click on it. And this blue
button, instead of saying uninstall, it would say install. And then you'd have have it available.
And there we go. Then when you go to new, and then you can go to Google CoLab laboratory,
and it loads. There you go. So as you see, I like the dark theme for CoLab. So that's just the one,
that's just what I picked. You know, you can change that. So this little block here, this is
where you're going to write the code, you know, it's set up to write a block of code. And in
addition to that, you have the ability to add more code or more text. So you see, you can add
another block of code, you can add more text. And if you click up there, it just adds it in line.
And, you know, if you type text, now, if I hit enter, that just gives me a new line,
I have to click somewhere else to get out of that. So there you go, you can add code or text by
doing that. Also, if you might have noticed this appear, if you hover around the middle,
you can add code or text. And that works anywhere. You see, so you can add, you know, text right here,
in between these two. And there we go. And that text actually, besides writing text, you can
actually use some a few HTML tags to, you know, make new line breaks, or some things like that.
And then if you get really fancy, you can use the latex math notation to display different math
formulas. But we'll get to that soon enough. Alright, so you have all these different things
you can do, you know, your code, your text. And one of the other things you want to do first,
like any document, give it a name. And you'll notice the familiar setup compared to other
Google Docs, you can, there we go. Let's just call this week one example. All right, so,
you know, give it a name, you know, you don't want to leave all your stuff just untitled,
might be, you might forget, and it might be hard to find later. And you can write your code there,
whatever you'd like to put in there, print. Okay. And, you know, there we go. It just sits there as
code until you run it. And you can click this run button, or if you're familiar with the Jupiter
notebooks, you can hit shift enter, that'll run it also. And there we go. This, this is the output
here. Notice you can also do a lot of math right there in the print statement. So if you just
put in math formulas, you see hit enter, it just gives you a new line, run it. You can do all sorts
of math formulas. And remember, the add, subtract, multiply, divide, that all works, that's built in.
The, the exponent would be
this asterisk, two of them. So there you go. So that would be three to the fourth power.
And you see it'll, it'll do the math right there. If you wanted to do something like square root,
you have to import something. And we'll get to imports as we go through a lot of this.
But notice you can, you know, you can have your text, you can have, do your math for,
for a lot of simple things. You can just do that right in the print statement.
One of the other interesting things you can do is, and if I make this,
I'll just make that B for a certain reason, then you have a table of contents here.
Now this has nothing because I don't have any headings or sections. So that's what the
table of contents looks for. If you click on a new section, then you can, I'll just leave
it as new section and call it good right there. You see it shows up in the table of contents.
And if you double click, now this B is underneath that section. So if I click on this arrow,
it becomes minimized within that section. And then here, A, if I want to make this its own section,
then take a look at the section heading. If I double click on it, it's that hashtag that
would be normally used for a Python comment, but we're, but we're in the comment.
It would be normally used for a Python comment, but since we're in the text part, then you would
just use it to indicate a new section. So I can go up to here, this text, and I can make it a new
section. You probably don't need the space, but I like it. And again, click somewhere else to get
out of that. So now I have A and I have my new section here. So I can do some different things.
I can put some, I can put some code here and I can, in this code, I can move it up. See the
arrow over there? I can move it up. And then maybe I'll make B, double click on this, and maybe I'll
make B its own section. I'll click somewhere else. And so I can have all these sections
and now B is its own section. That kind of didn't matter because I don't have anything underneath
of it. There we go. Put text in here, click somewhere else, and then I can collapse it.
So you see, I can have these different sections collapsed, and then they all show up in the table
of contents, A, new section, B. So if you give them names more than A, then you're going to have
them more than A and B. It becomes useful because you can find them in the table of contents.
And then you just click to expand each section in whatever else. And you can have, within the
section, you can have code, text, you know, and as many of those blocks as you want. And that section
goes until you create a new section. So some good useful things you can do in building your own
Google CoLab notebooks. You might decide that you might like that as a way to organize them,
you know, keep them in sections. So that helps. Also, the Google CoLab, like everything else in
the Google Drive, it does save automatically, but it doesn't do it as often. So you do have a file
and you do have a save here, and also the normal shortcuts, Ctrl S, or Command S. So that does
work. And that way, sometimes, you know, if it goes a while in between saving, if you try to close
it, it might actually prompt you to say that you might need to save it. So that's just something
to think about. You know, you actually do actually make an effort to save things here in the Google
CoLab. So we set up our code. We can do math right there in the print statement. We set up our
sections, table of contents, and all these sections, you know, within the view, you can actually
expand or collapse them all at once if you want. You know, that's kind of interesting. And through
all the code we're going to work on, you know, you also have down here one of the other things
that looks like, you know, XML or HTML tags, and it's a bunch of code snippets that you can use,
you know, copy and paste, try these right in your Google CoLab right here. So some pretty cool
things to explore. And there we have it. You're going to be building your Google CoLab notebooks.
You might want to build one for algebra and, you know, just continually add to it, in this,
in which case, definitely make sections because that's going to be a helpful table of contents
to find what you want. So you could do that. You could make a different notebook, you know,
for each unit or each week or however you want to organize it. But then the idea is you're building
these resources that you will have access to. And as well as installing it on the Google Drive,
you can also download and install the app. So that'll be useful. Have it on your phone.
That when you first run it, you need to do a few things to go through setting it up, you know,
authentication and such. But, you know, it doesn't take that long.
All right, so we have this, you're going to be building your stuff in your Google,
in your Google CoLab and it's going to be exciting. We'll get to a lot of,
a lot of interesting things. So let's get into the math next.
So we can't talk about proportions without talking about ratios. And ratio is another
word for a fraction. So this two out of four, I can write that as, well, two out of four,
but I could say two fourths. I can call it a fraction, but it's also a ratio.
And then a proportion is two equal ratios. So if I know that these are equal, then there's other
things I can do with this. And one of the things that works and becomes very useful is cross
multiply. So if these two are equal ratios, then I can cross multiply, multiply the diagonals.
I can do two times 10 equals four times five. And that's another way to write this. So then I can
get it out of the proportion mode and I can use this to double check or I can solve for things.
So two times 10, we see 20 equals 20 and then that's true. So, you know, we confirm that that
works. We can always do this. If these were other numbers, I can check to see if this really is true
cross multiplying, because if that doesn't work, then that wouldn't be true. And I can also use it
if one of these numbers is unknown. So if I have three out of six equals X out of four. Now there's
other ways to solve this, but this is the go-to way because it works every time. So when I do my
when I do my cross multiplying, then I can do this three times four is 12 equals six X. So there we
go. Three times four is 12 and then six times X is six X. And then I know that the next step I'm
going to do is going to be dividing by six. So then I get that X equals two. Now in doing that,
we can jump ahead and say, okay, let's I know that when I multiply this diagonal, I can picture this
step. It's going to be six X. So the next thing I'm doing is dividing by six. So a lot of times we
just put this in one step. So I multiply the diagonal that I can divide by the other number
because I know that the next step and then my answer is X. So we can really make use of this
in writing code. I can see the proportion and I can then just put this all in one step to solve
for X. And again, that's it's the go-to way it works every time. So I can write code to then prompt
for these numbers, cross multiply and then solve for X. One of the ways this is also useful is
some of the other applications. If I have, let's say I'm converting something like miles to
kilometers. So if I have one mile is about 1.6 kilometers, then I can set this up. This is the
ratio that I know. So as long as I have miles and then kilometers, then if I know one, I can figure
out the other. This unknown can be either place. So if I have two miles, then how many kilometers
is that? You see, we can make use of this. I know that I'm cross multiplying two times 1.6 divided
by one. And then, so there we go. So X would be 3.2. And again, multiplying the diagonal that I can,
two times 1.6 dividing by the other number, which in this case, it's convenient that it's one.
So then I can solve. So this is what we're going to use. And we're going to take a look at
how to put this into code. And so prompt for these four numbers or three of them,
and then figure out the fourth one. So let's take a look at how that'll happen. So let's take a look
at the code. So we're going to see here how much easier it is to write some code to solve some of
our problems. And just like proportions, we have that cross multiplying that we know works every
time. So I'm going to put just a display here to remind us that we're setting up the proportion.
And here's what it looks like. N1, D1 equals N2 over D2. So N for numerator, D for denominator.
And if I have a proportion, I would know one of the ratios. So I would know, let's say N1 and D1.
And then N2 or D2, one of those I would not know, but I would know the other one. So I have my
comment here in the code, put a zero in for the unknown value, because realistically, none of
these values would be zero. That would just, you know, you wouldn't even need to think hard about
that, that zero is everything out, or if it's in the denominator, it's undefined. So that would
never occur in something that we're really trying to solve. So I would know N1 and D1, and I would
just change these numbers, put in my numbers that I know, and I'll put a zero in for the one I don't
know. And then I'll put two if statements. So I have if N2 equals zero. And there we go. Notice
the setup of the if statement in Python. If N2 at the double equals, because I'm testing it,
I have a colon. And then the indentation afterward is one, two, three, four spaces, I would hesitate
some people use a tab, I would hesitate to not use a tab. They don't often give you the right number
of spaces. So indent four spaces. And then I have the answer is, and I'm going to just do that cross
multiplying. So you see D2 times N1 divided by D1, that cross multiplying that we that we know,
and then we'll print out the answer. And we'll do the same thing here. If it's D2 that I don't know,
so my if statement, if D2 equals zero, colon, four spaces indent, and then this answer,
notice the cross multiplying. So D2 is what I don't know. So I'd be doing N2 times D1 divided
by N1. And then I'd print out that answer. So there we go. And then given these one over two
equals what over 16. And then if I would run this, and it will output the answer right here. There
we go. N2 equals eight. Or if I had this, I'll keep this and maybe I'll put this one as zero.
Rio, and if we run it, there we go. Really straightforward. We want to get to this point
that we know these we know these formulas, and we can just put something in here, maybe even
display something to set it up, and cross multiply, solve any proportion this way.
Now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit, let's look through some extra problems.
And I'm going to work through extra problems using the CoLab notebook. So you can see how
you can apply these resources that you're building and use these to solve problems that might come
up in a textbook or in day-to-day life. So we're going to go through some more extra problems here.
We're going to work through some extra problems here relating to some things that might come up in
working with proportions and ratios. And one of the things that comes up, we work with mixed
numbers. And in math, I might write it like this, but then you think, how could I do this in Python?
And Python, remember, you can even do math in the print statement. So you could put this as one and
two thirds becomes one plus two thirds, and you see two divided by three. Notice I didn't even,
sometimes I use parentheses, extra parentheses, but we really don't, Python knows order of
operations. So you could have one plus two thirds, plus three and four thirds. So it'd be plus three
plus four divided by five. And, you know, you can change up minus seven. You can put that all in a
print statement there and it would output the answer. Now, later on in the third unit, we're
going to also talk about converting that output. If it was a weird decimal into a fraction or mixed
number, but we'll get to that. So you can do this, but even also at this point, you could,
if you wanted to, instead of print and you don't need the parentheses, but I'll just keep them
there, you can store them as a variable. So if you had something that you wanted to store as a
variable and then use that later on, or any one of these, you know, convert a mixed number stored
as a variable, because some of these, like two thirds, that will come out as a mixed number,
mixed number, or the one and two thirds that will come out as that repeating decimal. Well,
later on, you might want to keep as many of those decimal places as possible and storing
it as a variable will do that for you without you having to write down all the decimals.
So really, that's the whole thing. We're trying to build, you know, for all the different times,
you might use a calculator. Hey, might as well use Google CoLab because you can have all these
formulas in there, store variables and everything. So for all the different times, you might need to
work with mixed numbers. Yeah. Print it out, store it as a variable and continue on and
work with the rest of the problem. So if this comes out as a repeating variable,
let's take a look at one other thing here. If this comes out, so let's just say I have that
one and two thirds. So we know the one, but if I look at the two thirds, you know, that would be,
you know, 0.6 and it keeps repeating. You know, it'll keep repeating. If you get output like this,
how would you know that that would be two thirds? Well, one of the ways you can do this is we can
throw in some other variables here. Let's call, let's call this X. So X is all these repeating
decimals. So if it repeats each, um, each place, then I just need to multiply it by 10.
You see, and that keeps going because if this keeps going and then this keeps going, then
if I subtract them 10 X minus one X, so that would be nine X equals six. Now notice I did not rewrite
it, but I am subtracting this bottom row minus the top row because then all these decimal places
line up and it would subtract. So multiplying it by 10 moves it over. Now I have six points something
and when I subtract 10 X minus one X is nine X, then that all cancels. And if I have nine X,
how do I get to X divide both sides by nine? So we get six over nine, which we know then mathematically
we can reduce divided by three is two divided by three is three. And actually this works,
any single digit that repeats is a factor of nine. So if I have, um, if I have anything else,
and actually I might use the same, same formula, but if I have anything else, like if I have, um,
um, point four and it's a four that keeps repeating. So then 10 times that would be four point
and as many fours as you want. So then when we subtract 10 X minus X is nine X. And then when
I subtract this, everything after the decimal subtracts. And so your answer is four and divide
by nine X equals four over nine. Now, so this works for any number one, one through nine,
but this is kind of interesting then, um, how, what if you get a point nine repeating?
Because would that be then nine over nine? Yes, maybe. So if I have point nine repeating,
and so then 10 times that would be nine point and as many nines as you want,
we'll do the same thing. So nine X equals, so you see if this is point nine repeating,
this still follows 10 times that. And then when we subtract,
it all lines up, it becomes nine X equals nine over nine, which is one.
So you see some algebra acrobatics. How do I show that point nine, nine, nine repeating equals one?
And these are kind of the things that we want to bring in. Um, some of the other things that we
can do, you know, this works out nicely just seeing it on the board. But later on, as we do
different things to convert decimals to fractions, you can see that it'll work in the code too.
But yeah, some math acrobatics, this is kind of what we want to be able to do.
We want to also sometimes use the code to show different ways to get to solutions.
And when we see it get to a solution in different ways, it kind of like
reproves, Hey, this works. This is the true solution.
So these are some of the things that we can do, um, with proportions and, um,
you know, some of the other things we'll do, we, you know, we could look at like converting, um,
convert converting, uh, money like.
Yeah. So if I have, you know, let's say, um, you know, one U S dollar is right now,
I just looked this up. It's 1.29 Canadian dollars. So if I want to convert, then I can set up my
ratio and proportion as long as you know, I know one of these, so I know the ratio.
And then as long as I know one of these, I can figure out the other.
And in the code, you remember, we just add it, whichever one I want to figure out,
I put a zero there because either way zero over anything is zero. So that would not apply here.
You know, the zero in the numerator, the answer is zero and zero in the denominator would be
undefined. You know, you could look up different, uh, images of divide by zero online, you know,
things like going into the abyss and all kinds of fun things like that.
But yeah, we don't want to divide by zero. So if I know one of these and neither of these would be
zero, that just really would, we would never arrive at that situation. So, you know, we saw
that that's why we would put a zero in for the one we want to know. And there we go. As long as we
have it set up, you know, then I can figure out, oh, okay. Well, in that case, you know,
um, how many, I'll put the question mark here since we're not in the code, you know,
okay, if one U S is 1.29 Canadian, then what's one Canadian hour worth. And then you see cross
multiply divide by 1.29 and you'll get that exchange rate. So that's how we can change it from unit
to this one, one U S to how many Canadian, we can change it to one Canadian to how many U S
you know, cause very often you find exchange rates and they'll give you it in one direction.
And maybe you want to find it in the other direction. So these are some things you can
use this for. We can also do things like miles to kilometers or, or whatever,
you know, other unit conversion you want, but you know, if you have one mile
is 1.6 kilometers, um, it's that exactly 1.6, you know, there's like, you know,
another nine meters or something, but okay. And then there we go. If I want to convert
then as long as I have miles and I have kilometers, then it'll work out. And we looked at how to
put that in the code. So now that you have these tools, you can convert anything. As long as you
have that ratio of one aspect of it, then you can, you know, plug in one of these two numbers and
figure out the other. So, you know, here, you know, some, some of the good things, and these are some
of the things we want to do in the extra practice section. You'll see this come up in every unit
that, you know, we're going to get to the core, um, core skills in those units are going to build
your ongoing, uh, CoLab notebook. So you have some resources and then we'll have an extra practice,
um, extra practice, extra problem section where we then use some of the things that you've created
and let's apply this and let's solve a bunch of extra problems. So there we go. Um,
and we will, uh, we'll go on to the next unit.
Here, we're going to look at four different ways to solve for the unknown number.
And in algebra, we often call this X just because X works nicely, X marks the spot. So
if I have, I had to put four different situations here, add, subtract, multiply, divide. So I put
simple numbers because you might be able to do this in your head to see the answer, but the algebra
explanation is you want to see what you're doing and do the opposite. So then if these two sides
are equal, both sides of the equal sign, if you do the same thing to both sides, then they stay equal.
So that works. What am I doing? I want to do the opposite to cancel things out. Then the next thing
is do the same thing to both sides of the equal sign. I'm going to show this with the four different
algebra operations here. So if we have X plus three equals five, so in each time,
the goal is that I get X equals something. So I would like that X by itself on that side,
on the left side of the equal sign. So what am I doing? I'm adding three. So I want to do the
opposite, subtract three, and then I'm going to do the same thing to the other side. And three minus
three is zero. I don't have to write plus zero. Five minus three is two, solved. X equals two.
So it's like Sherlock Holmes eliminating possibilities, and then we get to the answer.
So the next one, if I'm subtracting, I'm going to do the opposite. So again, my goal is X equals
something. So X minus two, if I add two, that cancels. That's why I add two, and then I do the
same thing to the other side. So negative two plus two is zero. Don't have to write plus zero.
Have to write plus zero. And then 10 plus two is 12. There we go, solved. We go to multiplying,
very similar. Also notice in writing math, most textbooks, you won't see the fact that you won't
see a multiplication symbol at some point. Just the fact that they're next to each other means
that I'm multiplying. Now we have to remember this in Python syntax, you have to put that
multiplication symbol. But here three X means three times X. So to get X by itself, I'm multiplying,
so I have to want to divide. And notice I'm going to write that like a fraction, divided by three,
and then divided by three here. Now here's something else about the notation. Three divided
by three is one, but I don't have to put one X. You could, but you don't have to. In most places,
you won't see it. One X. Any other number there, I'd have to write the number, but one,
we often don't write that. So then 12 divided by three is four. And we go here, X divided by four.
Somehow, whatever I teach this, everybody's like, get it, get it, get it. Confused. It's the same
thing. I'm dividing. So I'm going to do the opposite, which is multiply. Now in this case,
I might write it, how can I write multiplied by four? I might even just put it in parentheses,
just saying it's next to that, so that means I'm multiplying. That's one way to put it. And so here
I'll put in parentheses. So divided by four times four cancels out, so it's one, and then that's one
X. And then here, two times four is eight. So with some simple numbers that we see these methods here,
add, subtract, multiply, and divide. And the key is no matter what the numbers, no matter
what else you encounter, how complicated the numbers are, it's the same method.
So we recognize this method, then whatever number comes up, then we can figure this out. Because
this I can do in my head, but supposing I have instead of X plus three, supposing I have X plus
7.2 equals 11.1 or something like that. So supposing I have something like this,
how could I solve it? Oh, I have an algebra method. What am I doing? I'm subtracting,
in this case, 7.2 from both sides. And so then I get X equals, and even if it was something more
complicated, I know what I'm doing on the calculator. I'm subtracting 11.1 minus 7.2,
and then I know what I'm doing on the calculator. There we go. So we can also use this
anytime I have a two-step equation. And in the two-step equations, it's more like
order of operations in reverse, because the addition is the easiest. So if I have something
like 4X plus 6 equals 22, so two steps, I'm still going to combine those same four steps
we were talking about. I'm just going to do one than the other. And I'll look at the addition.
Like I said, like order of operations in reverse, the addition or subtraction is going to be the
easiest to do first. If I then subtract 6 from both sides, so if I have minus 6, minus 6, so then
I have 4X equals 16. And now I get to my second step, divide by 4, divide by 4, divide by 4,
divide by 4, then I get X equals 4. So we have our two-step equation. And in all this, some of these
are, you're going to get quick enough at this that it's not even worth trying to write code
or anything to solve this. But some of these, as they get more difficult, then it will, and
there's other factoring and more elaborate problems, then it would be worth it to write code
because I'll show you now how we can just put this in Python, write out the equation,
and it'll output the answer. So let's take a look at the code. So it's a lot easier to
solve for X in Python because we can just import the Sympy library here. And that's the symbolic
math library. You don't have to install anything. You can just import it.
Google Colab works nicely behind the scenes like that. And then from Sympy, we're going to import
symbols. And from Sympy.solvers, we're going to import solve. So we can import symbols to use
X as a math symbol and solve for that. And solve is going to be the function we use. So we see here,
then I'll define X equals symbols X. And that's defining that X is the variable we're solving for.
I just put this comment here. But then the next thing we have, I define this variable eq
equals X minus two. And this is the function set equal to zero. So it's X minus two equals zero
is what we're solving for. And then that's the equation. So then I just put it in a print
statement, print X equals, and Python syntax, then print that exactly, comma, and then our answer.
And here's where we see solve eq, the equation, and use X as the variable.
So we're going to solve that X minus two equals zero. And you see it outputs X equals two.
It'll print an array of whatever your answer is. This just had one answer.
But if I had something like X, X squared, X squared minus two, now that'll give me a square root
answer. Kind of interesting how that'll show up. You see square root of two, rather than try to
make that a decimal. But if we make this something that works out nicely to an integer, and we run
that, see it'll give me an array of my two answers. X squared minus four equals zero is the
equation. And negative two or positive two, either one works. And remember, then, if I have
something like two X, I can't just write two X. I have to put, I have to put two times X, because
that's Python syntax. Two X minus four. And then if we run that, there we go. It'll solve that.
There we go. Much easier. And all this stays the same. You just put your equation here, and
run it, and you can solve anything. Just make sure it's that equation set equal to zero.
Now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit, let's look through some extra problems.
And I'm going to work through extra problems using the Colab notebook. So you can see how
you can apply these resources that you're building, and use these to solve the problem.
You can use these to solve problems that might come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life.
So we're going to go through some more extra problems here. All right. So let's go a little
bit deeper, looking at different ways we can solve for X here, using Python code. And here is the
code that we were talking about before. So we import Sympy, so we can use our symbols,
and then we're still from Sympy, import symbols, and some Sympy.solvers. And here I'm just going
to define that symbol X. And this is the simplest thing. We can have all of this code, and I can
just put my equation right here. Here's my equation. And then I can solve that equation,
and I'm solving for X. Notice I don't even really need a print statement, as long as this solve
function is the last thing there. And then when we run it, we see it will give this negative 1
half. And notice the brackets around it, because it's a finite set. Nice. Solve. Pretty easy.
And if I have something that solves for even, you know, something more complex, like 2X squared
plus 1. Now this is setting this equal to zero. So 2X squared plus 1 actually won't have a real
solution. We can actually take a look at that. And you see the negative square root of I,
and that is I, the imaginary number. So it will give us this. There's other ways to make that
square root display in a better way, but we'll get to that later. And there we go. But we see,
you know, it gives us two solutions as this finite set of these two. And if I were to make it,
you know, minus 1, or I can even make it minus, you know, 4, we'll have two real solutions there.
But there's still going to be square root solutions. There we go. Different ways that this
will output. But you get this. You can put the equation in there and see the answer. It'll solve
pretty much anything you can type in there. All right. But let's start making this a little bit
fancier. What if we prompt for input? So let's say I want this to be, you know, somewhere else, and
rather than somebody going in and finding that correct line and putting the code there,
we can just prompt for the input here. And notice the function is input, and then it's going to
display this. Enter equation. And I even have it as zero equals to remind the person that it must be
equal to zero. You could add another print statement saying make sure x is the variable,
you know, if that's what you'd like. And this input does come in as a string. But the fact that we
are using these symbols, it will be able to interpret that. And here then we're solving
and just putting that into a print statement. There we go. So we have this prompts you enter
the equation. And maybe I just make it three x minus six. How about that? There we go. Something
good. One solution. Three x minus six, because if x is two, then that works. Okay, that's great.
But again, if, you know, I have multiple solutions, or maybe if I just don't want it to look like this,
maybe I want it to be a little bit fancier. So, again, this solve stores this as a finite set,
so we can do more. All right, we're going to import all the rest of these. Now, here,
knowing that it's a finite set, I'm going to store that answer as this variable called solution.
And then this particular equation, I know this has one solution, so I'm just going to have it
display solution index zero. And that's going to be the first solution, which in this case is going
to be the only solution. So when we run it, there we go. And again, this is pretty useful if I want
it a little bit nicer output, just like having that nice user interface, you know,
having it display zero equals and then waiting for the prompt. So, you know, some other ways we can
do this. And, you know, here's saving this. Okay, that's great. Now, what if I have multiple answers?
And what if I don't know how many answers I'll have? So I'm going to put this here,
so if I enter the solution, now, maybe I'll just put the first one here. We'll get we'll get to
this one next soon enough. So I'll just take the same solution that I know has one solution.
And just like we were doing before, I'm going to solve it and store that as a solution. Now,
notice my loop here and Python has this great
method of iterating through everything in that list. So for S in solution, so there we go, every
item in that solution set, whether it be one, whether it be however many,
it'll iterate through that. So S is that solution. And then it'll go through. It'll be that solution.
And each time, I'm just going to print x equals, and then I'm going to print out S. So, you know,
we make use of the Python shortcuts. There we go. So 2x minus 4, the solution is 2. And we went
through and did this. So what if I have something like something that has multiple solutions? So
what if I have something like something that has multiple solutions? And so I'd also supposing I
want to prompt for this. All right. So what if I just plug in something like this? Now, this,
I know is going to have three solutions, because the three possibilities that would make that zero.
So let's see what this does. Again, loops through, and it will output all three solutions very nicely.
So we see we're building some of these things behind the scenes that will output one or multiple
solutions and output it in a nice way. So we see, you know, if you're going to copy some code that
you're going to use, this is the one to do it. Because, you know, you could even like, you know,
you take out this, this was my demonstration. But there we go. And you really don't even need these.
So this could be your code. And that will work for anything, because it's going to prompt anybody,
you or you or anybody else using this to enter the enter the equation. So there we go. You see,
we're building some tools here that we can use to solve. All right. What other ways can we do this?
Now, some interesting things. We're also this time, we're going to call it VAR for variables,
and we're going to use x, y, but we'll come back to the y. And we have this one first. You can,
because you can use this for multiple equations, but I just call this one first. So there you go,
two x plus 10. All right. Now, we know that this is set equal to zero. That's kind of the
the go-to way of doing this. But then this simpy syntax, we're actually going to spell it out and
define it. EQ first, comma zero, saying that this is set equal to zero. Because then I can solve
for x. That's great. And this solution I just called sol.
And since I have this one, I know that the solution is, you know, there's only one. So I
just put salt. You know, that's my finite set. And I want the index zero. So this is it. And
actually, these are factored results, but this is actually going to give me a nice actual answer
because I can get that answer. X is negative five. All right. Now, here's where y comes in.
Now, I have to have y there. If I define y as a variable. Now, down here, I can say, supposing
this is equal to y. And you see that works. So spelling it out here that it's equal to y.
But now I now I'll solve for x. So that's kind of interesting. And then when we do this, you see,
Python could actually do some of this factoring for you. You know, rearranging an equation
algebraically. So now it's solved. Why over two minus five. Pretty cool. So we can do something
like that. We can rearrange things. And then if I have this, you know, I could I could change it
around a little bit or whatever. But some different things you can do. The default is make this equal
to zero. Make this equal to zero. But this gives you this other flexibility. You can call it equal
to y. And then you can do some other things you can solve for it. So pretty cool. As you do this,
as you incorporate this into, you know, some of the notebooks that you're going to create, tinker
around with this and, you know, try some different things. You know, that's the idea. You go through
some different some different formulas or different equations in a textbook and say, hey, can I
try this? Like, we could take a look at this and say, all right, let's see, solve for y. Now,
what about if I have two x, then, then if I want to solve it for and you can even include y in here.
So there we go. And if that's included in y, then I still might then go back down here and say that
this is equal to zero, because that's kind of the default way for that to go. And I, I can still go
back and solve for x, and it should end up being very similar. Because, you know, if I want to
do something very similar, because whether that was, you know, without this minus y saying it,
it's equal to y or with this minus y saying it's equal to zero, see algebraically very similar.
And, you know, we could even just to show you, we can even say this to x minus y. And we can run
this. There we go, x is y over two, all kinds of different things you can do. If you need to
rearrange this, you can put that in this setup here. And then, you know, what is, what is this
set equal to now? And what am I solving for here? And in this case, it pretty much will be index
zero for that solution set each time. So these are some cool things you can get the code to do all
the factoring for you. Well, here's some other factoring. Supposing I have something like this,
you know, we can divide out common factors. Now, you might see this, two x, two times x,
ten times y, plus four. Now, supposing this is another thing in SymPy, I can just factor it.
You know, I'm not saying that's equal to zero or anything. I just want to take a look at this.
I don't want to factor it. Look at that. And SymPy also does the nice display on the output, too.
So you see, there was a common factor of two. And that worked. Now, supposing I had this,
and let's say this is three, which then doesn't factor at all. So when I run it,
you know, it will just output that because it's not factorable. All right. Now, what's really
interesting is if I have something else, like x squared, and let's say x squared minus four. Now,
you may or may not be familiar with that factoring, but I can factor something like that, too.
I look at that. It'll factor that out. That's the correct factoring of that, x minus two, x plus two.
So it will do a lot of really interesting factoring for you. So pretty good. Here's another one that
we can, you know, just to show you that we can even take it to the next level.
X to the third minus two x squared minus five x plus six. So we have that. And if I factor that,
there we go. Look at that. It breaks it down into these factors. So some of these really good things,
you know, knowing that you can set your factoring, you know, you know, you can set your
factoring, you can make your own factoring calculator here. All right. So let's take a look
at some of the functions here. So when we have, you know, we have that, we can factor. And then
you've been doing some of this practice with these functions. So I want to show you, you know,
you know, looking at these and this different input, how we can, how these functions are working that,
you know, remember you were doing the practicing the one step functions,
the one step addition, one step multiply. There we go. Now, that first one I want to show you
is because you can't do string to a fraction. This print, this works out just fine. But when
we take this input, now other inputs, if it's actually a number or a decimal, you can do this
and you can cast it as a float. So that's a number that could include a decimal. But if you know that
it's going to be a fraction, this float won't work because that slash for the fraction doesn't
parse nicely. So then this will give an error. Now, just because it says fraction here, that's
just a display. If I just disobeyed that and put in a number, then it wouldn't give me an error.
But if I, as soon as they use that divided by, I need that. So that's our first function here
is how do I convert the string input, including fractions to a float? So this is the way Python
functions work. I'm going to use this DEF to define it. And then once I define that function,
I give it the name of the function. I need the open and closed parentheses. And this particular
and this particular one will also have input. So I define this variable in the parentheses.
That's going to be the input and then colon at the end. So once I define that,
then everything under this is indented for spaces. Yep. And I recommend don't use tabs,
use indentations. So then I have an if statement and if, and then here's the condition. If this
is true, colon, and then that's indented for spaces. Okay. So I take this input string
and I'm testing to see if this fraction bar is in there. And notice if this exact character in,
in string, cause that's what I called it. That's my input. If it's in there, then we have this split.
Each string has this split function. So you can split it and say, all right, at this point,
I'm going to split it. And then that creates two different arrays. Now this was all based on string
input. So it's going to be two string arrays or two or one array with two elements. And so it's
going to be ND. I call that for numerator denominator. So then ND zero is going to be
everything before that. And ND one is going to be everything after that. So if this was a fraction,
if somebody put a fraction in there, then ND zero, everything before that would be the numerator.
So I'll cast it as a float, store it as N for the numerator. And then ND one is everything after
that. So I will cast it as a float, store it as D for denominator. And now see, we had to split,
we had to detect that split that string. And then each of these two elements individually, cast
them as float numbers. And now these are numbers N and D. And now I can actually do that division
N divided by D. So you see, because that slash doesn't work for for parsing numbers, I have to
like work around it. And now I have ANS as this answer. And then I have the return statement. So
this, this function doesn't have a print statement, just returns this. And we'll see where how that
comes up. But it just, you know, wherever this function is, it'll out, it'll put that answer.
So that's if it has that. And if it doesn't, because I want to be able, I want to use this
either way. So anything else, colon, indent, then I won't have a problem. So I'll just take that
in string cast as a float. That works. So anything else you put in, we're good. And then again,
return ANS. Now, where this comes in, I'll come back to that one, is in the one step multiply.
So here's this function, one step more. And I put this common in here, to remind myself or anybody
else using this, that it uses this function. So we need to make sure that it's in the same place.
All right, so here's, here's the idea to generate, you know, some practice problems for you import
random. And then here, I'm going to get random dot Rand int from one to 11. So that's going to be
a random integer, and I'll store it as variable A. So that's going to be a random integer,
including one, but not including 11. So one could show up, 10 could show up, but 11 won't.
So that's, that's the way the random integer works. It includes the first one, but not the last.
And then B, I just wanted to make this two to 24. So given these two random integers,
notice what we're going to print here. So AX equals B. So we see it's always going to be something
times X. And I just want to display this. So I didn't need to worry about the Python syntax with
to show the multiplying. All right, so AX equals B. And then you would know, what do you want to do?
You want to divide both sides by A. So you know that, and we're going to take your answer, input,
you know, X equals, and whatever your input is, we'll store it as ants in.
And then the actual answer at this point is going to be, we know divide both sides by A,
so the actual answer is going to be B divided by A. So then this was the actual input, notice,
still a string. And that's where we're going to use that in our function that we created earlier,
string frack. So see, it's going to take that answer, run it through that function,
run it through that function, and return right here, that answer.
So that way we can easily compare it because this function will return that answer, and then
the double equal sign to compare, and we're going to compare it to the actual answer.
So there we go. So that's the return statement, wherever I don't have to
print or output anything, it just returns that value right here where I have the function.
And if it's, if it is good, we're going to print correct. If not, try again,
but then print out the answer. So there we go. And now it'll loop through this. Well, this will do
it once, and then, you know, we can create a loop to have as many of these as you want,
practice one-step equations. So there we go, and then test them each time.
And then test them each time. So, you know, we have the simplest one-step addition,
is another very similar one. There we go, import random, display the problem,
random integers, and yes, you can go through negative numbers if you want.
All right. And what are we printing out here? X plus A equals B, because then
you know that to solve for X, subtract A. So we'll take your input. What do you think X equals?
But also we're going to calculate exactly B minus A. What is it really? And then down here,
we don't need to do anything else. We just say, if A and S equals answer. There we go.
And here, see, we can cast the float, cast the input as a float right away, because we're not
expecting anything fancy. You see the other one, knowing that I'm going to divide, you know, I need
to address all the other things that could come up. And there we go. If it's correct, there we go.
If not, and then we print out the answer. Cool. So some different things you can do, and you know,
one-step addition with negative numbers, just we just did in a slightly different way. So here's
a bunch of things that we can do, just practicing your own ability to solve. But we'll also get
more into some other functions later, but, you know, good to see these functions. But yeah,
yeah, here we go. Just some of the things you can do, factor or solve. So these are the things
that you want to be able to do and, you know, set up, you know, start again, start building your own,
your own CoLab notebook. So by now, you might have some things that, you know, solve for proportions.
You might have some things to, you know, solve for X and, you know, maybe you can even copy one of
those, you know, convert fraction input to something, you know, feel free to, you know, copy,
copy these, tweak them, make use of them on your own. And, you know, you see you're building your
library as well as really understanding the code as you're building this. And, you know, hopefully
your understanding of the math, understanding of the code gets deeper and deeper as we, as we go on
here. All right, so I think we're ready to go on to the next unit. So let's talk about fractions and
decimals and how to convert from one to the other. Well, fractions, when I say out of, like this
could be one out of 10. If I say out of, that means divide. So any fraction numerator divided by
denominator, you can do that on your calculator and it most likely is going to return at your
decimal. There you go. So fractions, decimals, you know, pretty easy. Calculator, do the decimal,
you know, pretty easy. Calculator, do the division and then, you know, you have your decimal. But
what about doing it in the reverse process? So when we look at this, this, I would read each of these
one out of 10, I could call it one tenth or 0.1 is what you would get if you did that division.
I would still call that one tenth because that first decimal place is the tenths. So that would
be one tenth. Or then if I had one out of a hundred, then there we go, two decimal places.
So tenths, the second one, the hundredths. So whether I write it like this or like this,
I would still call it one hundredth with the th. Then, you know, I just wrote it one more,
you know, third decimal is would be thousandths. So, and it would keep on going. So knowing that
we have that, you know, tenths, hundredths, thousandths, then that would be our denominator
if we want to convert it back the other way. So if I would, if I had something that I would,
you know, 0.234, so something that I wanted to convert, then I would take this as tenths,
hundredths, thousandths. That's where it ends. So then I could make that 234 out of a thousand.
And I could reduce that, but that still is the fraction that I'm looking for. So 234 out of a
thousand. Or if I had something, you know, like 0.4 one place, that's one tenth. So that would be
four out of ten. And again, I could reduce it or I could leave it as that, you know,
that that's converting my decimal right to a fraction. And when we get into the code,
we're going to look at how to see here. I'm just looking at this and remembering these tenths,
hundredths, thousandths, et cetera. It could keep going. You could convert any decimal,
but I'm looking at these remembering the place values and then saying, oh, that's three. So I'll
have ten with one followed by three zeros, you know, one decimal place. So my denominator is
one followed by one zero. And we get into the code, we're going to look at how to do that
in a different way rather than just, well, there's a few ways you can like take it as a string and
count how many places, or we're going to, you know, one of the lessons we're looking at the
logarithm way, probably the string and just counting it, that's probably a little more
straightforward. We'll do that one. But there we go. Converting these, you know, how do I get this
and then, you know, how do I reduce it? Okay. So we think we have it all worked out, but what about
if I have a repeating decimal? So supposing I have 0.3333 and it keeps repeating.
And mathematically, if I was writing this, you put the line over one of the, the part that repeats.
So I really could just keep it as one, but I want to show you three repeats, just put it over the
three. So that keeps repeating. Okay. So we were just talking about, you know, how many decimal
places and then put it over that. But if it keeps repeating, where do I stop? So let's take a look
at a trick how to do this. We want to get to the end of the repeating. So if it only repeats one
repeats once, then if I multiply this, let's, let me call this X and actually I'm going to write
this down a little bit further. This is, that's going to make sense in a second here. So if I say
X is my 0.3333 repeating. All right. So if that's my value, I only need to multiply it by 10 to move
the decimal place once. And then that cancel out. So if I have 10 X, then that's 3.3333, et cetera.
And these keep repeating. Now, the reason I do that is because of all the repeating decimals,
everything that repeats now is going to line up. And so if I subtract these,
what can I do on the left? 10 X minus X is nine X equal sign still there. And three point, all this
minus zero point, all this that cancels all this, however many decimal places you want to go,
it all cancels and my answer's three. And then one step of algebra, solve for X divide both sides by
nine. So I get X equals three over nine because nine divided by nine is one. So that's one X,
three divided by nine. And I could reduce that as one third if I wanted to. Now keeping it as three
over nine, you know, that's nice, like bonus math insight. If I have a single number that repeats,
it's that number over nine. That's the fraction. So if I had four over nine,
if I had four, if I had, you know, very similar type, type of question, but if I had
something like, uh, if I had zero point four repeating, so then 10 times that would be four
point or four, et cetera. They both keep repeating. Do the same subtraction. 10 minus one is nine X.
And when I subtract these, all the repeating decimals cancel. So four point this minus point
four is exactly four. And when I divide both sides by nine, X equals four over nine.
So there we go. And, uh, so one more bonus here. If I had nine repeating,
we could do the same thing. And you would think 0.999. That's not exactly one. And well later on
in calculus, we can look at limits and how 0.9 repeating. If it keeps on going for all practical
purposes, that is one. But if we did this, it would be nine's repeating and we divide by nine
and you get X equals one. So it kind of works out nicely, but this is, this is how we can do this.
You know, notice we're not looking at code here. Now we're just taking this. And, um, if we have
something that repeats, then that's what we need to do. We need to find out where it repeats. If I
had something that repeated, um, you know, three, two, two places over and over again, uh, let's do
that one. And just to give you an idea of a different way, if I have something that repeats,
then if I have, uh, so X equals, uh, 0.090909, something like that, and it's the zero nine that
it's the zero nine that repeats. So I need to multiply it by a hundred to line it up. So 100
X because that would move the decimal place twice and that makes it 9.090909, et cetera.
So when I do that now, same method, if I subtract these, that's 99 X equals nine because then that
cancels. So then X equals 99, uh, nine over 99 and fine, perfectly acceptable answer, but we can
reduce this divided by nine. So that's one out of 11. We'll get into reducing fractions and also the
code for that too, but you see, this is, this is one way. If you have something that repeats and
maybe you're right the way you write the code, it might seem to break it. If, if you don't, uh, if
you don't find some way around it, this is the way around it. So we can convert any repeating
decimal, but now we're going to, what we're going to do is we're going to get into the code and how
to take any decimal. Just here's the decimal input. How can I find a way to count how many spaces that
is and reframe that as a fraction so that given the decimal and then turn it into a fraction
related to that is percents because remember the first is 10th hundredth. So the first two digits
are the hundredths and that's really what percent means out of a hundred. So percent is all the same
thing. And then just, I'm always looking at the first two decimal places. That's my percent.
So, you know, very similar, but just the first two decimal places. So let's take a look at the code
and we'll see how to convert any decimal to a fraction. All right. So let's talk about how to
convert decimals to fractions with code. And first we'll get some background here because this is
going to be useful. So if I have 10 two different exponents, let's take a look at the positive
exponents. So 10 to the first power, we see this first one, 10 to the first power, 10 to the second,
10 to the third. We'll see these come up. What happens when we take 10 to a positive exponent,
10 or anything else to the zero exponent, and then we'll take a look at 10 to the negative one
or negative two or negative three. So this will just print these out, but let's take a look at
what this does. So we see 10 to the first, second, or third becomes 10, 100, 1,000, 10 or anything
to the zero is 1. And then the negative exponents are how many decimal places? 0.1, 0.01, 0.001.
So these are the things we're looking for and we're going to make use of this as we convert our
our decimals to fractions. So the next thing, we'll take a look at how to get user input.
And we have this formula here, user input, open parentheses, and in quotes here, this is what it
will display. And then you'll see then a box, you know, then asking for input. And then here we're
going to store that as text as that's the variable. For our purposes here, we're just going to show
you that you can enter a number and we're going to print it out. I call the variable text just
to remind you it comes in as a string. We can't do any math with it yet. But one of the things I can
do, any string, I can figure out the length of that string. So we're just going to print that out.
And I just have, again, this comment here, if I tried to do math with it, then there would be an
error. So let's take a look. So you see, enter a number. And then if I had a number with a decimal,
like 0.123, I hit enter. You see 0.123, the length of it is four, because as a string,
these are four characters, the decimal point counts as one character. So different things I can do
with this. So I, you know, if I wanted to enter a number, now, if I have, if I cast it as a float,
now I can do math to it. And I can cast it as a float or an int for integer. So just keeping in
mind, you know, things I might want to do with this, a float can have decimal places. So that's
usually my default cast. But, you know, if you definitely know that you want it to be an integer,
we would use that. But we're going to enter a number, cast it as a float and store it as
the variable number num. Now I can do math to it. I'm going to print out num plus four. So we'll see.
There we go. If I enter a number, there we go. And if I have 0.123, then hit enter. You see now I can,
now I can add. All right, or whatever other math operation you want. Once you cast as a float or
an int, then you can do math to it. And the float, because it can handle decimal, any math
operation that there might be a chance of a decimal use float. Okay, so we're going to put all this
together. So converting this input, which will come in as a decimal. So I'm going to take this input
and here's what I'm going to print out. Enter a decimal number to convert. There we go. So we know
that that's input and that's going to be stored as digits. And we know that that's a decimal.
And we know that that's going to be a string. So to get the number of decimal places, the next thing.
So I'm going to use this, the length of that input digits, and I'm going to cast it as an integer
first. So notice that happens first. Then I'm going to subtract one, because remember as a string,
that decimal point is going to count when I do the length of that string. So I want to subtract one
because I don't want that decimal. So now whatever decimal enter minus the decimal point itself,
that's going to be an integer that's going to be the exponent. And now here I go back to digits
that is still a string. Now I'm going to cast that exactly as a float number. I'll store that as n.
So now I know how many decimal places it took to make that and the number itself is a float.
So let's talk about our fraction. My numerator is going to be n times 10 to a certain exponent,
10 to that exponent. So in my previous example, point one, two, three, then it's going to be,
you know, that was four, the length of that was four, so minus one, so the one, two, three becomes
my exponent. And then when I multiply it by that exponent, it makes it a whole number. And since I
know it's going to be a whole number, I will cast it as an integer. So that's going to be my
numerator. And then the denominator is going to be 10 times that exponent. So you see that that is
what we were doing before we were doing the code. You know, how many digits, how many decimal places,
and then, you know, my numerator is that times 10 to that many des- 10 to that exponent, and the
denominator is just 10 to that exponent. So three decimal places would be that times 10 to the third,
and then the numerator denominator would be 10 to the third, and it gets you that decimal place.
Now, that's numerator and denominator for any fraction. Percent is just the first two decimal
places. So whatever n is, I'm going to multiply it by 100, because then that just gets the percent.
That decimal, move it over tw- move decimal place twice, which is multiplying by 100. So now we'll
see the output, the decimal. There we go. We just repeat the decimal again. The fraction, numerator,
and I'm just going to print this out to show you it's numerator over denominator, and then the
percent, and then I'll print out the percent symbol. There we go. This, remember, in math means
something else, but here I'm putting it in quotes. It'll just be the percent symbol. So we're going
to enter a decimal number to convert, and there we go. Point, uh, one, two, five, enter. There we go.
The decimal, point, one, two, five, and then the fraction is 125 out of a thousand. That's correct,
and the percent's 12.5. And we can run this again and do this for however many decimals we want.
Um, you know, point two, enter. So it's point two, two out of 10, or 20 percent.
And there we go. The same things we were doing, and this is what we want to get,
look at throughout this course. You know, the steps that we're doing in math, we can break
this down, and we're pretty much doing the same steps, but then now once we have this written in
code, then, you know, you have a formula that you can reuse. Okay, I'll bring up this, bring up the
script here, and I'll be able to convert any decimal to a fraction. There we go.
Now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit, let's look through some extra problems,
and I'm going to work through extra problems using the Colab notebook, so you can see how you can
apply these resources that you're building, and use these to solve some of the problems that we
have, problems that might come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life. So we're going to go through
some more extra problems here. So now I want to show you how to put together your own calculator.
You know, this is what we're talking about here. You're making resources for yourself. So in all
the things that I'm showing you, and you'll have access to all these different, uh, resources here,
but you're going to put together yours. So you're going to click on new, and you would have already
the Google Colab, so go over to Google Colaboratory, click on it, and now this is going to be yours,
so actually I will call it that. I'm going to put the underscore, it accepts spaces though,
your calculator, and you just hit enter or click somewhere else, and there we go. So this is what
you can do to put together your calculator based on things that we've been doing so far,
and then things that we do further on in the class, then you can add to it. So you can go through and
go to, let's say, the week one notebook where you solve for proportions,
and here's some things you can do. So if you click on this text here to set up the proportion,
let's copy that first. So you click on that text and go all the way over the three dots.
This looks like copy, but it actually doesn't do what you're expecting it to do.
Click on the three dots, copy that cell, and when you go back to your calculator,
I'm just going to click in the open space here and paste it, Ctrl V or Command V. Actually,
it's kind of cool. So, you know, Ctrl V for the Windows, Command V for Mac, and CoLab accepts
either one, and then we can go back. That's your proportion set up there, and let's copy this again
over all the way over the three dots, copy cell, and your calculator, and we're going to paste it.
So you can have this, you know, we don't need this. If you have an extra one, that one,
the trash can over there. So there we go. Now you have your text set up proportion,
and then it really is then self-explanatory. You know, you see the setup and put in N1, D1,
N2, D2, and even the comment there, put the zero in for the unknown value. So you can go through
each of these. Then if we look at week two, now we were doing a lot of things for solving for X,
and maybe you don't need to do the simplest one. Maybe you like the prompting. You can include
that. Doing more with the solution, how we split it up. Now, I personally, I like this one, so that
might be the one that I copy as one of them. And what you can do is, you know, click on here,
because notice this one, I personally like this one. It prompts for the input, already showing
that it's something equal to zero. You know, there we go. We already have X as the symbol, and then
this also prints out multiple solutions if you have them. So this is nice. We can copy this.
And when you go back into yours, now if I just paste this, that's great. I actually don't need that.
And notice it didn't paste where I wanted it to be. So watch what we can do here. I'm going to click
in here and use these arrows. I'm going to move it down, and actually down one is just fine.
Now, we wanted some text in there. So right above it, you hover there, add text, and
solve for X. Maybe I'll just add that text there. So there's more from that week. So we have that.
That's nice. Now, this solve in other ways, that was pretty good. And then notice there's also
factoring. So you could include something like this, solve in other ways, or factor,
you know, simpy.factor. Now, I might include this because you'll see we'll come back to
the one of the other ones. So if we copy this, and this is just factoring, we can actually
do this. And this is just factor when there's, you know, nothing else to solve. You see, so maybe
we'll copy this cell, and paste this down here. Now, maybe I'm going to add text and just put
factor. And down here, then I will paste it. Didn't show up where I wanted to. I can use the
arrow, move it down. So, you know, there we go. We have set equation equal to zero ready to solve.
But we can even make this, you know, equation to factor. And see, you can put this however you
want. There we go. And then, you know, you can factor things. So we have these. We can go into
the next week. Now, notice to put it all together, because when we went through and looked at some
of these leading up to converting a decimal to a fraction. So this was putting it all together.
You're prompting the person to enter in this, and then we're going to convert that output, the
decimal, the fraction, the percent. So that's nice. Maybe we copy this. And the factoring we'll get
back to. So then we go down to here. Maybe I'll paste that here. And that's good. So we just want
some text ahead of it. Decimal to fraction. So you see now you're putting together your resources
here. And we don't need that output right now. Now, we have one more here. Factoring and solving
for a variable. And notice it's when I paste this, I might put it with the other one. But we see,
remember we did this, then you have the left side, which could be equal to zero, and the right side
of the equation, which could be anything. You know, this would be about the only thing that
you would need to change here. Change the variable you want to solve for. And I put all these as
your basic common variables that you would use, but you know, you could always change that too
if you want, but you might not need to change that line. And then this one will solve it,
even if it is something that you can just, you know, solve for a variable.
It doesn't come down to an exact number here. So that might be a nice one. And then we keep this
example in here. You know, copy this. Now, we might put this in here with factor solve for x,
factor solve for x, and factor solve for a variable. Maybe we put it in here somewhere.
And notice you can just click and add code. I'll click right in here and paste it.
And this will be pretty much right where I want it to be. Then I might delete this,
add some text, solve for a variable.
Now, these are just some examples here of how you could put this together.
So that then you have your resource here, proportion. There we go. Solve for x, factor,
solve for a variable, convert decimal to fraction to percent. And then things that we do later on,
you could add more into this here. Now, supposing you want you you want it to put a lot here and
then you add all this, that's this is a lot of scrolling. So one of the things you can do is,
is now I'm going to start with proportion. I like so right around here, you could there's
there's multiple ways to do this. You could insert, you go up top, insert
a section header cell. So I'll do it one way this way. I'll do insert section header cell.
And actually, I want that above. So I noticed this, when you double click on this, you see
some of this. These text boxes accept HTML, look at that the br to split the split the line,
and they accept latex, which is how to format various things fractions, formulas,
all kinds of things. So in this new section, and you see, because it's in this text part,
that's not a comment in Python, it's the new section. And I might just make this proportions.
Okay, so now, you see, it takes that and all these cells become a part of that section.
I don't want that. But what I want to do is, if this next one, I want to make this
this section, and I don't need another one, I think that'll be the section header.
There we go. So I'm just going to put this here. Now that's a new section.
So we see proportions now just has the two cells, the text about setting it up, and then the code.
And solve for x has just one cell because that section said it all. And then we have the code.
There we go factor. And maybe you want to say something more than just factor,
but you can make this a section heading. Solve for a variable. There we go. And in seeing all this
this together. So you see solve for a variable.
Convert decimal to fraction. You know, that probably I didn't need anything else here,
solve for a variable. All the rest was explained in the comments.
And convert decimal to fraction.
So now this just has the one cell. And the advantage of doing this is, over here,
you see these lines. Now we have the table of contents here.
There we go. And I could change, you know, that's long enough. I don't like it when it goes on to
two lines, but that fits so that it's a longer title, but that's okay. And you can have your
table of contents that you can actually go through. And you see jump to proportions. Jump to solve for
x. You know, different things. And in the view, you could change the view to collapse sections.
You don't have to, but you could. And then you see you have all these.
So these are some things you can do in putting together your Google code like this.
Putting together your Google CoLab notebook. You know, I want this to be your calculator
that you're building. So then you're learning how to do all this, but then you also are building
your resources here that you can then refer to. Oh, what do I need to do? Click on it.
Enter what I need to enter and solve it. You know, you're essentially making your menu here.
So that's what I want you to do for this unit, is take a look at what we've been doing so far
and put it together in your own notebook. Some of the things we'll do later will even get fancier
and we'll, you know, make some of these into functions that you can use in different places.
But this would be a good place. Put together your notebook of resources. Here's one way to do it,
but you know, you can tweak it to the way you like it. All right. And now we're ready to learn the next thing.
So what does it mean to be a function? A function means it in math and in code that you're taking
some input and then doing something to it. And actually there are some functions in code you
don't have to take input, but in math we will. So like we were talking about our unknown number
being X, the output will be Y. So each function we want to take X as the input and then we're going
to say that the output is Y. And here we're dealing with all numbers. What am I doing to X
and then outputting Y. So you see we have like solving for X we were doing before, but now we
have a second variable and we still want the idea that just like in the alphabet X comes before Y
in science and in research, we can call X the independent variable because that's what changes
first. And then Y is the dependent variable because it depends on what X does. So if I
want to solve this or do anything to it, then I'm going to plug in a value for X
and I can pick any value. I might start with zero. So I'm going to define it over here. My input X
is zero. And then what happens when I plug that in? So that'd be Y equals two times zero plus three.
And you see I'll just put in zero in parentheses where I plug in this number because
it highlights that that's what I just plugged in. And also the fact that they're next to each other
I'm still multiplying. So when we do this two times zero zero plus three, then that would be Y equals
three and my output is Y. And if you remember then that's an XY coordinate on the graph. X is zero,
Y is three and I'd be able to plot that point and I can keep going. What other points can I,
what other numbers can I plug in? I'm even just going to keep this. So supposing I have X equals
X equals one. Plug in one. Two times one is two plus three is five. Y equals five.
And then we'll plug that in and I can plug in as many or as few. I don't have to have
integers. I tend to do that so you can see the numbers a little bit clearer.
But you know you don't have to worry about doing any other calculations in your head.
But if I have this I can put in whatever numbers I want as many or as few. I can put decimal
numbers in there and we can plot these on the graph which we'll talk about a little bit later.
But this is the essence of a function that X comes before Y. I plug in an X value and then
output the Y value. So another function notation that a lot of people like is instead of using
another variable Y and this connects a lot with the way the code's going to look. We call it
F of X and F for function. So two X plus three. So if you see these, these are the same thing.
Y equals two X plus three or F of X equals two X plus three. This notation F of X and that's
what we read F of X, F for function. We solve it the same and this connects a lot more with
your computer science. So if I have the output called F of X, one of the advantages when we get
into writing the code is that in algebra we tend to just say F for function. But in writing Python
or other code you can actually give your function a name and it doesn't have to just be F for
function. It can be add, divide, calculate the area, something really even a long phrase like that as
long as there's no spaces. So if we have this and then sometimes then let's say if I wanted to plug
into two I could write in F of two. And so again the usefulness of this notation is because I see
what what am I already defining as my input and then I know what am I doing next. I'm going to do
two times two plus three. Two times two is four plus three is seven. So F of two is seven. So now
I know that answer and when I see that X is two, Y is seven. And we'll see how this you know really
relates to the code and how we can write even a little bit more elaborate functions with code
and how we can define the input there. Then we'll look at graphing it. All right so let's take a
look at the code. So with the code and functions we can do very similar to what we would be doing
by hand writing out the math. Here I'm just going to define one X value as an example and here is
the function that Y value. Y equals four times X plus three. And you see Python syntax have to
make sure we put the times. So I'm just going to plug in that Y X value become you know substitutes
in for this X value. So it's four times five plus three and then I'm just going to print out
my solution X comma Y. So we see that and before I print that out. So that's one thing one X value
but I can loop this. So I'm going to print out this line here which is X and then I'm going to put a
tab Y. So that's defining my columns here X and Y. And then what I'm going to do is loop through
all those values. So for X in range 11 so X is going to go 0 through 10. And then I'm going to
take that same function and each time then I'm going to plug in that X value solve for Y and
I'm going to print out the X Y values. And in this case again I'm going to put the tab in between.
So this is the essence of what we're doing with a function. Each time I get an X value plug it in
solve for Y and then I have an X Y value and this is going to print this out as a table.
So when I run this we'll see it'll come out first of all we'll have that that one solution
you see five twenty three five comma twenty three that first solution and then we have our table X
Y and all of our X Y values if X is zero Y is three if X is one Y is seven etc. And we also have
five twenty three that shows up on the list too. So that's defining a function. Now Python has a
lot of other functions beyond math you can do things with and we can still use that same type
of Python function definition for our math. Here we can on this line define the function. So D E F
space and Python I can name my function anything but I'm going to use the classic math notation
F of X and then here I have a colon. So this is going to define the function everything underneath
is indented four spaces and I have Y equals my four times X plus three. That's the function
and what am I going to do then I'll return the Y value. So whenever I run this that'll return the
Y value. So you see this in use if I print here if I print five so I already know I want that to be
my X value comma and then I'm going to call this function right here F of five and it's going to
take that and run it through there we go. Same type of thing same type of thing then we'll
define this and when we run this it's just going to print that 523 and next we could put this in a
loop I could just take the same loop here and I'm going to copy this and I can just take that same
loop if I wanted to and in this case I'm going to print because I already have that function
defined I don't need this and I could really just put put that here F of X you see so I could
I could just have right here since I defined that function X F of X and I don't have my headings
and I don't have my headings here but I think we can use our imaginations there we go so printed that
one value but then in the loop just went through and looped so these are the ways that we can
illustrate a function in code and you know what we can do with these functions you know is
almost limitless you know you can have a function do anything and you can name it anything more
more complex than this you know give it a word but I wanted to show you the connection with the
classic math notation and functions in Python whether I actually just call it y equals that
that still works as a function or whether I define it and next we're going to look at graphing functions
so now when we talk about graphing functions we'll use this equation y equals two x plus three
and I'll use the x and y notation so we have our input and output you know all the different x
values and what y values match up so if you ever come across something like something like this
you can see that if I plug in both of these x and y that should make the statement true and so we
have a few of our points here and then now we're going to see how that matches up with the Cartesian
plane our x y coordinate plane it's Cartesian because Rene Descartes invented this so we have
zero zero at the center and how much I count for x positive to the right negative to the left and
it comes first like x comes first in the alphabet then my y value positive up negative down and
and my coordinate pair would be my x y so this zero three would be
zero so I'm not going left or right at all up to three plot the point now I don't also need to
write this but I'll show you so then that would be the point zero three so x y and then one five
so I would go over one up five plot the point and then that's one five two seven plot the point
now I just plotted three points but I'll tell you if you really wanted to try many in between points
decimals or other numbers that are in between you could bet that each of these whatever you know
one point something two point something they would all end up being on this line it's continuous
there's no x value that can't go into this well whatever weird fraction or decimal you know mixed
number anything so all the numbers would be on this line so with this type of function we're
going to call it linear and we'll get into other types of functions but that's where we plot a few
points and then we want to look at these patterns what type of graph does this end up looking like
so what we're going to do now is look at in the python code how to create a graph and plot points
to make a basic blank graph we're going to import this library matplotlib.pyplot and that's a lot so
we're going to we can import this as plt so I can reference this whole library as plt from here on
out and here's what we're going to do the first line is these are standard variables that we use
fig for the figure axe for the axis so these two variables and that equals plt.subplots
and then that sets this up and we'll do plt.show the base there you go import set this up and then
show and then that gives a basic graph these are all the defaults nothing else going on there
and you know we have this set up so we're going to build upon that now let's define the dimensions
here notice that was all just the first quadrant everything's positive and even only one goes in
positive and even only one goes up to one so again import matplot library plot we set that same two
first lines but now let's take a look at these dimensions now I have that plt so it's plt.axis
and I'm going to set this axis all right and it gives you the range of x values and y values I'm
going to show a better way in a second but you can do this on one line here's the dimensions and now
when we show it I want it to go from negative 10 we see across the bottom the x-axis negative 10
up to 10 zero in the middle and on the y-axis negative 10 up to 10 zero in the middle that's
great but I have no lines I have no axis and you know not the clearest so here's first of all
here's a better way to set the dimensions is I'll define them right at the beginning
as variables x min x max y min y max and that way all right I want it 10 in every direction
and I can set them here easy to see it and change it if I want to and now when I do all this this is
really what I'm doing when I set the axis size x min x max y min y max that's really the arguments
that it's taking and it becomes a lot clearer when we set it up like this so then I have this and
I can set this and then if I wanted to I say oh for this one this y value goes really a lot higher
so maybe I want that y maximum to be 20 instead of 10 and then when I run it now notice the the
size of this still looks the same but it adjusted accordingly and on my y-axis it goes up to 20
and on my x-axis negative 10 to 10
and so let's display axis lines here if I have my dimensions defined and now when I plot the axis
well that's the one we already did here the window size but I'm going to just plot them as lines so
this line here I have x min x max as my array of x values see notice it's plt.plot and I have my
array of x values and then my array of y values and the default is to make this a line so it won't
just plot two x values and two y values it'll draw the line from x min 0 to x max 0 and this b
in quotes makes it blue so we're going to do the same thing with the y plt.plot and my x values
are going to be 0 at 0 y min 0 y max and then it'll get make that a blue y-axis
just because I like blue and there we go so now we have this that will give us our x y-axis
so from everything we do now we have an axis we have a point of reference
so everything that we plot is going to you know start with this now define the dimensions
set all this up we might not even need to change any of this and that's going to give us our graph
with an x y-axis all right so how do we plot one point so we see the axis the default is a line
and I made it blue b in quotes so how do I plot a point well I make this line here
I have an array of one value which is five for the x value one value which is four for the y value
and then the r makes it red and the zero makes it a circle actually that's oh so there's some
other options you can do you can do a dash you can do different symbols but for right now I'm going
to make this a red circle and that's how we make make that circle and that's how we make that
here if I have these two and so when I run this it'll still plot those as an axis and then we'll
do five four and then that's going to be a red dot all right so if I wanted to plot multiple
now connecting with what we were doing with the functions here I'm going to set up my graph
and here in rain in my range I'm going to have the range from 10 so I'm going to go from this
from this value my y value y equals 0.5 x plus one and in this case instead of making it a table I'm
going to do plot plt dot plot and I'm going to plot that x y value as a dot so this range and
I'm going to plot these x y values and again that's the essence of graphing a function I have all
these different values and when I plot all these points I'm going to see this nice pattern emerge
that this all lines up and I'll tell you if I plotted points that were in between whatever
x values there would be they would also line up that's why it's a linear function the graph
of it's going to be a straight line and then every point on this line every x y value if I plug in
this function it's going to work so my loop to graph a function and here then we'll create a loop
to do the function and the table so like we were doing before I'm going to build upon this basic
graph that I have I'm going to print the x tab y for the heading of the table and then in my loop
I'll use the same function here I'm going to plot the point and I'm going to add it to the table
and all these it it actually won't plot all the it'll kind of save these points and it won't plot
them all it's really just going to add them all to the table and display the table because it
really doesn't show the graph until the last thing outside the loop here is going to be plt.show
when you have graphs I think Python just likes to have that plt.show last so do your other stuff
first and then show the graph so then we have this and we have our table of y values notice if I just
put one number in the range it'll do zero to that number but I can have negative five comma ten
or I could even just go back to those original values that I defined up here and make this
x min x max you see and then but as you know you can put any two numbers in here and it'll
do the range between there and you see it just abruptly starts here and abruptly ends here but
I could change that to make this x min and I can make this x max but remember I want to graph that
last point so I'll do x max plus one and I can have that range and now it'll give the full table
of values and it'll graph the full dimensions so there we go we see what we can do with the function
I have whatever math function I have plug in different values and see the results see the
numerical output see the graphing output and now we see the connection of graph the table and the functions
now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit let's look through some extra
problems and I'm going to work through extra problems using the codelab notebook so you can
see how you can apply these resources that you're building and use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life so we're going to go through some more
extra problems here so let's talk about more ways to graph and more things we can do with the graph
because we want to be able to display our data our functions so we did look already at how we
can loop through inputs you know I can define my graph and we already did this the x min and max
y min and max and we talked about how we can loop through I get x in a range and then each time I'm
going to plug this in and plot that value and that's the idea of the function that each time I get an
x value in this range plug it in for y plug it in here get y and I plot that x y point in this case
as a red dot after doing all that then we show the graph but what if we didn't have to do
a loop for our input what if we could use an array and we'll revisit this again in other units
but we have this numpy array and it's not that long of a word but it just seems to be the
convention that we import it as np and so you'll see a lot of examples throughout the internet that
np dot this or that so that's what we're going to do and again defining x min x max
so given this numpy array here's what we're going to do then given these values I'm going to define
how many points I want in my array and in this case it's going to be two times x max minus x
min I feel like that's probably enough for our purposes but that number two you can up that to
10 or whatever you want and then we see so then we want to make as many things dependent on
these values as we can that way if that changes if I change my window everything else will change
accordingly and I don't have to go through and find all these variables so yeah I get the full
range times two so that's two points through that you'll see that that's actually going to work out
just fine but you can always increase that so now they have any points this is how I define my array
of x values and since I really am only using this once I'm going to just call it x because that is
my array of x values and so numpy we have np dot linspace so we have this function here which is
going to set up our array you know space for linear graphing so it takes the argument where do
I start where do I end and how many points do I have so we see we just make all this dependent
and then I get my x value so this saves us the time of having to do a loop python will do this
for us here's all the graphs and we're going to talk about how to change some of this stuff too
in a minute so now I'll just I like to define my x value up there right where I have number of points
in the range so I have my y value and for our purposes here we'll just call it you know call
it y equals but you can graph multiple things on the same axis and you know you can have y1 y2
whatever you'd like so I just define this relatively simple linear function here so then
when I plot I'll plot x and y and if you remember before we were plotting x and y each as an array
in this case with only one element but here you see I define my x value as an array of x values
and therefore y becomes an array of y values so I can just reference these variables x y because
they each do represent an array in this case then I decided to make the line red so I put it r in
quotes so there we go and when we graph this then we can see I have my graph and yeah that looks
about like that would be 2x plus 1 with the red line all right so let's talk about some other
things we can customize here now yes r g b work well you know I just had to put b for the blue
line r g for green and if I want it to be a black line then I will put k so you see r g b c m y k
those all work as you know simplified ways to define the color of the line if you don't
put anything python will actually assign a color to each line and it'll cycle through so that if
you plot a few lines they each get a different color but if you really say you know okay I
want it specifically to be this line for this color you can define this and then other than
those major colors you can actually just write in colors then you know there's no one letter
abbreviation for pink but if I want my line to be pink I can write in the word and I can't say like
every color that will be acceptable here but it's going to be a bunch you know if you want
a line of a particular color type it in try it and there we go so we have all these different ways
to define the color of line because remember this plot when this plot graphs the default is that
it's a line so if I want it to be a point then I would have to define these definitely not as an
array but as each an array of one value and then the the letter but then something like oh for a
circle or the carrot for a triangle or something like that so or a dash so you know we could define
if we just wanted to be a point we'll see that in a second here so there we go so we have our axis
and our line but we're you know we're not done customizing it first of all let's take a look at
a look at these tick marks you know zero and then every 2.5 maybe I don't want it exactly like that
we'll change some of these things and maybe you know this seems kind of blank maybe I want to see
the grid lines so here's some other things we can do all right I'm still going to import
certainly matplotlibrary but I'm also doing numpy because we use that for some of the things for
graphing and same thing I'll define you know the window up here and the x values based on that
window so for now I'll keep this you know the same axis I just like blue so we'll keep that
now notice when we do up here figure and axis so the labels would be in the axe variable so
axe dot set x label axe dot set y label axe dot set title there we go x values y values and some
graph and I didn't mean that some graph like whatever I meant more like you know like from
charlotte's web or some graph so anyway so we have these and I commented these out we'll get to these
later and I have a few other things here so I still have one y value and then I'm going to plot that
now notice this I'm going to define this as a label you know it can have a label rather than a color
rather than a color but notice no color I can also do a color but since I don't have one we'll see
what color python assigns to us and then I decided to plot a point and in this case it's red and see
zero red or that's actually oh the lower case o so it's going to be a circular point and then
this one's going to have a label too and I'm going to plot something else here's same x values and
then notice I can define the y value up here and then say y right there or I could put the y value
in here directly either way whichever you feel like doing I don't want to show you the different
options here and again we have this label also so let's just take a look at the x label the y
late set x label y label and the title and then we'll see these different these different lines
so there we go and you know we get nice orange a different shade of blue
and I define that as a red dot so there we go but what if all right so let's see
what if I want the axis to show the grid it looks kind of plain what if I want to see the grid so
when I comment that out and this one notice true is a capital T
it will actually show the grid lines and you see it does line up to the tick marks that are already
there every 2.5 but there we go so if we want to see the grid lines and we have this I can
and we have this and now we have our x you know our labels x values y values some graph
you could actually put the graph and in one of the later units we'll look at some details about how
to even automatically if I wanted to graph one line and have the title of the graph be that line
but you know you could always just type that in you know instead of some graph you could actually
just type that in as a string you know the equation of the line okay so let's take a look at numpy
again and in this case let's say the 2.5 in each direction is not really what I want so again we
have x dot and we're going to set x ticks and set y ticks so setting these tick marks on each axis
so it's a different sort of array I'm going to do num mp dot arrange and what do I want to arrange
very similar to the way we did x values I get my minimum my maximum and then this is how often do
I want to tick mark every two numbers so that's what we're going to do from y min to y max and
you see again basing it off of those original variables if the window changes then all this
will update automatically so there we go so let's just take a look at that supposing I change the
tick marks and we see then now every two and maybe that's a little bit better instead of 2.5
and we see these now if I wanted it every one then I'm going to change that just to one and notice
this is just for the tick marks along the side but up here when we do x dot grid true that's
going to just follow whatever tick marks we've assigned so now we just change this every one
and now we get this sort of graph where I definitely can count the boxes and see you know
let's take a look at the slope of each line let's see these and python still does it around the edge
so that way it doesn't get in the way of anything that's in the middle of the graph
all right there we go so we can keep this that's that's pretty nice okay so what's one of the things
we have all these labels but we didn't see them anywhere so if you have all these labels then we
add this other plt dot legend here we go and we can see these labels so I wanted to show you that
each of these labels we can have you know this line we labeled with the equation the point I
just wrote the word point but you could put anything and the other one labeled with just
some more steeper line so we could always do this and in the same way you know even if python
assigns it you'll see the matching you know which line are we referencing which point are we
referencing so some good things that we can do with these we can have the tick marks or not we
can change how often they come up we can have the grid or not we can change these labels
all right and I encourage you just to get in and you know tinker with this you know take a look at
all some of the different ways you can you know match up different graphs you can you know set
different things and we will get into even more graphing but that's going to be when we get to
systems of equations and some other more complex graphs so then we'll revisit this and then we'll
you know go a little bit deeper try a few more things with the graph but I think I think this
will get you to be able to display any function you have and you know hopefully display it in a
way that you say yeah this is exactly how I wanted it to look there we go customizing your graph
all right so yeah get in there and tinker with this and see see different ways that you can
change the graph
so let's talk about slope how can I describe this line that's on an angle using you know describing
how it goes up and over so that's what slope is picturing these lines that have a slope to them
that they go on some sort of angle but we're going to describe them going up and over like steps how
much am I going up and how much am I going over up and over up and over like steps so if I have
two points and if I have the graph that I'm looking at that's great I can just count it down
that's great I can just count you know looking at two nice points that work out as integers that
makes it easier to count so I can say from this point to this point I'm going up three one two
three and then over one so up three over one well then my slope is three and I can do the same thing
you know from that to the next point I can go up three over one plot a point up three over one
plot a point etc and it would be the same slope anywhere on the line because it's a linear
equation it's a perfectly straight line so that's great I can count if I don't have the boxes or
you know just have things like this but if I have the points that counting that how much am I going
up that's the change in y because y tells me if I'm going up or down so if I look at this I'm going
up I just counted three but I could also subtract taking a look at the y values four minus one
or then how much am I going over and it's always over to the right so I could look at the x values
so from one then to two two minus one how much am I going over so it's always over to the right
in this case it's positive because left to right it's going up if it was left to right going down
then my second y value would be less and when I subtract then it'd be a negative number so it's
always going to the right but y would be positive if it's going up or negative if it's going down
and so if I had these and I can count but looking at this I know I can subtract so what's that
formula look like well I can write out the formula here slope m equals and that's right
m for slope because it's how much we move on the graph so somebody started using m and it caught on
caught on so we're gonna use m for slope how much we move on the graph and remember I said it's how
much am I going up so that's the change in y and I can subtract that y2 minus y1 and so I would use
a little subscripts you know y2 y1 and that indicates my second y value minus the first one
then the change in x would be very similar x2 minus x1 and again the subscript for the second
x value minus the first one okay so now that I have this formula let's plug in these numbers
and see so we'd have four minus one or minus one I'm subtracting my y values and then two minus one
two minus one subtracting the x values and what do I get four minus one is three
two minus one is one and three over one any whole number over one that you know divided by one it's
a whole number I don't have to write over one so I can just write three so that's where anytime we
see anytime you see a slope that just is a whole number it's that number over one and there we go
so we have counting if I have the graph subtracting if I just have these two points and
you know I'm using that formula so this is great it's the same formula you know anytime we have
slope for a linear equation so let's take a look at how we can turn this into code because I want
you to get into the mindset that anytime we have a formula you can write write a program for this
and you know there we go input the numbers and output in this case the slope so let's take a
look at the code and we'll see how we can do this now this part is going to be brief because I just
want to show you that you can connect any formula if you know here we we're going to define our x1
y1 x2 y2 and put that into the slope formula slope equals y2 minus y1 divided by x2 minus x1
and really then this is a useful formula and others you can just define your variables
and run it through the formula here we're just going to output the slope
there we go all you need is the two points next we're going to work on developing the full equation
but then let's take a look at how that comes together on the graph first
all right so we've already figured out that the slope is three in our two points but let's say
we have this two points and we want to figure out the equation of this line we know that this is
linear and I have these two points that we figured out that the slope m because moving from one point
to the next we went up three and over one or I just subtract four minus one over two minus one
and then four minus one is three two minus one is one so three over one we figured out that the
slope is three and we want the full equation of of this line now knowing that it's linear we can
imagine here that it would cross the y-axis somewhere and that's what the y-intercept is
the intercept is where does it cross so we have a nice formula slope intercept form and that slope
intercept form is y equals mx plus b now we call the slope m because that's how much we move from
one point to the next and we'll call the other one b because that's where we begin on the y-axis
so many things happen in this first quadrant where everything's positive so we picture that
we begin on the y-axis and then move in that direction of course you know we can go in
different directions but so I have this y equals mx plus b now what we have is our slope is m the
x y comes from any of these x y points so I'll pick one of these points and then b would be the
y-intercept it works out that way so if we take a look at this I'm going to take one of the x y
points how about I take this this first one here because it's one one that that would be nice and
easy to calculate it works for either one so when I plug in this the y value is one
and then the slope which we just figured out was three and then the x value is also one I'll just
put that in parentheses so notice mx you know in my math notation I don't have to write that I'm
multiplying just because they're next to each other so I'll do the same thing when I plug in
you know m and then plug in for x and now b I don't know so that's where I have I plug in slope
that I know one point so that's four things that I know one point one point one point one point
two things I know three of them I can figure out the fourth one and we'll do this multiplying one
equals three plus b and remember our one step equation subtract three from both sides so I get
negative two equals b so now that I have this I figured out that the slope is three I figured out
that b is negative two then I put it together leaving x y open because any x y point on this
line will work in this equation and my final equation is y equals three x minus two so there
we go we've figured out this slope intercept and so now I know that minus two it crosses down here
so that coordinate point would be zero negative two and we can see we can see why this is what
it shows up like this because when x is zero whatever I plug in as an x value it's good it's
going to zero out so three x three times zero it zeroes out and then when x is zero that drops out
and then I have minus two so we see that that works out so this is our slope intercept equation
and we can when we see this now if we know the slope we can generate the equate slope in the
intercept if I had this line I could generate that equation we're going to pretend that that's a
straight line but if I had this but if I had this line I could generate that equation oh where does
it begin at negative two oh I know that that's b and then I can count for the slope up three over
one so then I know that the slope is three and I can go the other way if I had this equation but
didn't have the graph I could say oh I'm going to begin at negative two zero negative two plot that
point and then the slope is three I would go up three over one plot a point up three over one
plot a point and if I was doing this by hand you know paper and pencil I'd probably plot like three
points and get out the roar and connect the dots but what we're going to then do here what we're
going to do here is take a look at how we can write the code to develop the equation so all I
would need is two points and I'm going to do more than calculate the slope I'm going to figure out
the full equation so we're going to look at how to take two points and develop a slope intercept
equation so now we're going to put it all together and develop the equations so like before we're
going to define our x1 y1 x2 y2 from two different points and we're going to calculate the slope
which now we're going to call m that's been the go-to variable for slope m for how much the line
moves so same formula but now it's going to be m equals y2 minus y1 divided by x2 minus x1
then I'm going to define the y intercept which is b and that's because that's where we begin many
things happen in the first quadrant where everything's positive so we begin on the y
axis somewhere where x is zero so we'll connect this with the algebra that we we looked at you
know how if how do I if if I know a point and an x so an x y value and a slope and a slope how can
I solve for b a couple steps of algebra so then b is you know y1 minus m times x1 now I have m and b
b solve print out the equation so this will just print out the equation and we'll see
that it'll display nice y equals three x plus four and I still it will still by default give it
as a float variable so three point zero it's not worth trying to cast it as integers because
this is going to work for any number and then that way does not have to be an integer
to to make this work so there we go knowing these calculate the slope calculate the intercept and
then put it all together in the formula so then let's graph it same thing here defining my x and
y points and I just kept these same points here so develop the equation m equals b equals just
because we want to print it out so that we're going to print out the full equation and now we're going
to go back to the graph that we were doing before define our x min x max now how do I want to display
this line I can graph I can find two other points so I'm going to take the x minimum so we see here
in the first line y3 I'm going to take the x minimum and I'm going to convert that times m
plus b that's going to be my y value and then I'm going to take the x maximum times m plus b
that's going to be my other y value so now I have these other two points basic setup for the graph
same as we were doing before and we have now I'm going to plot that that line plot dot plt dot plot
and my x values are going to be x min x max and my y values will be these new y values and I'm
going to plot this as a red line so if I part if I put an o in here that would put these as two
separate red points but just r makes it a red line and now when we run this
there we go we calculate the equation and we graph the line good times so I can change anything else
I can have any other two points there we go there we go two three and if I kept the same x value
we know this actually some of this would break but it might still graph it but we know that that's
not a function there so there we go six and I'll make this one eight
eight just to show that we can just change these and all the rest of this will work
solve for m and b get our equation plot them here and when I run it there we go
so 1.25 x plus 0.5 and we see then it must cross the y-axis at 0.5 and then that slope
up 1.25 over 1 there we go all right so now we can graph and
do whatever you want with the two points you find
now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit let's look through some extra problems
and I'm going to work through extra problems using the CoLab notebook so you can see how
you can apply these resources that you're building and use these to solve problems that
might come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life so we're going to go through some more
extra problems here so we're looking at how we can apply some of the things that we've been doing
to real life situations and use this information to predict things to figure out some trends
and real life or things that show up in a textbook that hopefully are realistic enough
so let's take a look at some examples here and we'll work through these so if we look at 25
a town's population increased at a constant rate in 2010 the population was 55,000 by 2012 the
population had increased to 76,000 if this trend continues predict the population in 2016 so we
want to notice that these are two x y coordinates time and population and time if you have it it's
going to be on the x-axis almost all the time so if we look at this so 2010 55,000 2016 76,000
or 2012 76,000 so when we when we do this we have I could make 2010 the x value but I could say hey
hey this is the beginning of this situation I'll call it time zero so in time zero it and 55,000
these are nice even thousand so I just might call it 55 so time zero the population is 55 and 2012
is when we have the next year so that's two years later so two and then 76 so we want to take notice
that we're recognizing these as you know x y coordinates that we can put on a graph and we're
going to use that we're going to predict in 2016 so let's take a look at how we would do that now
hopefully you've already been putting together some things that you know that you can use to graph
you know your co-lab notebooks so that you would already have this something like this set up you
know graph you've already done the imports this is the only thing that we're changing remember
this for the two points and then we're going to calculate the slope and the intercept and everything
so x1 0 y1 is 55 x2 I would want that to be 2 and y2 is 76 so you see that that matches up
0 55 2012 76 000 and these this would then be the only thing you needed to change is your two points
because all the rest of this you'd have this you know already set up develop the equation so
you know we're going to calculate the slope we're going to use that to calculate the y intercept
now we happen to know because we have x1 is 0 so we know that the y intercept is going to be 55
but that's okay we're going to print out the equation and then our classic graph now I would
normally have this set at you know negative x min negative 10 x max 10 y minimum also negative 10 y
maximum 10 so this is the other thing that we would change because we look at this graph and
an x minimum of negative 10 so in time that would be 10 years ago but you know we're we're not going
to worry about going in the past and making that negative 10 so I'll just keep it at zero and we
I'll just keep it at zero and we can you know look at it from there then x maximum 10 we can keep that
that's probably just as good you know we're looking at the most six years for this situation
and y minimum I'll also make that zero actually because y is population so y minimum being less
than zero would just be weird negative population they're not going to be in the upside down or
anything all right or y maximum and I picked 150 because we already start at 55 and then we're
going to 76 and we're predicting a few years in the future so I wanted to go up a little bit 100
didn't seem like enough so we could always change these so all we need to do is change these and
notice all the other things for the line that we're going to graph so notice even though I'm
printing out this line I'm still just using these x min and max and then two more y values to calculate
this line and we're just doing the line that way there's other ways to do this but we can keep this
for how we're going to display this line this this works for linear equations
and we still keep our basic setup now here's where we're also add the details so again hopefully you
have these and you could also comment these out and then use them as needed like I have these
commented out about setting the x ticks and the y ticks we'll see if we need to we'll see if we need
to change that and you might have the default x label as x values or y labels y values but we
can change these here time and population and I like I like seeing the grid especially for this
situation so I'm going to put that in as true so we have these details that is that you could you
could have your setup and have these all commented out that all you need to do is uncomment them
as needed and then there we go we're going to plot this linear function and then here's what it looks
like when we run it so we figured out the equation so it's going to be there it is 10.5 x plus 55
so we see this trend and we see it starts at 55 increasing about 10,500 every year
so year two we see yeah I'll estimate that as 76 year four and then year six this is what we want
now this might not be exactly 120 we could we could plug that in and see because now we have
the equation you know what what is the value at six years but also this is enough and that's why
I didn't worry about changing the tick marks because the default that it gave us I think that
actually ends up being pretty good so there we go as a good enough estimate I would say 120,000
for you know population estimates you know you know the fact that it might be you know 119,500
or something like that you know our rough estimate is going to be 120,000 and that works so you see
and then we have our dice labels time and population the grid marks help so this is how
we want to do this we can you know we can set up this equation and see the graph and that helps us
answer all these questions there we go we see the trend and we can predict the population in 2016
that's about 120,000 all right now here's another one the number of people afflicted with the common
cold dropped steadily by 50 each year since 2004 until 2010 okay so we're looking at our keywords
here so dropped steadily then we're talking about a subtraction and then I'll make time zero 2004
since 2004 is the first not first year we we mentioned this now also a lot of these in real
life yes they wouldn't be perfectly linear but a lot of times that linear trend gives us a decent
enough approximation and that's that's the idea for some of these it's enough of a prediction
so now we have in 2004 875 people were inflicted and notice even with the comma there you can
definitely see there's your xy value year and then afflicted and then in 2010 it keeps dropping
so one of the things that we can do here well this is find the linear function so one of the
things we can do is I can make 2004 times zero and then that's 875
so if we take a look at this 2004
I'll make that time zero and then this one I'm going to make 875
875 all right so now if it drops steadily by 50 each year all we have to do is we just need one
more point if this is linear so we can just do the subtract you can do the subtraction in your head
here then if we have year one then it drops 50 so then that's going to be 825 and you see that's
that's all we need two points and we'll be able to do everything else calculate the slope calculate
the intercept and display the equation I might even well now the time and population won't mean
anything so you know number of people afflicted you know okay how about how about cases number
of cases of the flu there we go so there we go time cases and you can hit control or you can hit
shift enter or click this and we see this trend negative 50 was still in the y equals mx plus b
negative 50 x plus 875 and a lot of times you would see this they'd put the 875 first and
and then subtract but that's okay now also this notice that you know my x y axis I'm not going
to show anything why because it started 875 and you see 140 doesn't cut it so we have to go to
x minimum and maximum that's fine y minimum that's fine but y maximum it can't be 150
maybe I'll call it like 900 so now we can see
the graph and sometimes you know you graph it and you say well why didn't it show up and then you
look and see oh it's the window out of bounds here so there's 875 and we see this downward trend
so there we go and we can use this to predict you know in in any year now there's other ways
to get the exact amount we can you know for any any year we can actually plug in that x value
and then solve so that works and remember that even works within a print statement so if we have
you know so the interesting thing is this plot dot show
um that needs to be last so if I do another print statement I could I would do it later
but I could right under here
you know the same place where I print this I could print so
print this I could print so what if the question was how many you know what's how many people had
the flu we might say oh look at this two years later you know we had the now we we can do the
subtraction so let's say like five years and you see given our graph here you know we see this
trend we can estimate it but we don't know exactly you know it's not detailed enough to see it so I
can say oh about in about five five years how many people were afflicted with the flu and supposing
I want that exact number so I can go back to this and then x is five so one of the things you can do
is in the print statement you can actually just do do the math and you can have like a more elaborate
print statement if you want but we can just do our math here negative 50 times five plus 875
so we see you know our negative 50 times five plus 875 and that would give us the y value what would
be the value what would be the number of people afflicted after five years and again you could
have a more elaborate print statement to say something but since we already know what that
question is now that that's 625 that that means something to me when I see it there so you see
that that might be you know could I estimate it exactly oh that's 625 and not necessarily but I
can plug in the number and get it so we see you know some different things we can do see the graph
we can answer some questions do some math for you know some specific some specific questions related
to this now all right all right linear function so here's another question when will no one be
afflicted so we want to know looking at this graph when is the y value the number of cases going to
be zero now rather than now one of the things you could expand the graph is the y value is
until it gets to zero we'll come back and do that in a second but one of the things that we could do
is if you already also have your setup to solve an equation so you know you have this and remember
this was the whole setup to solve an equation and print the solution and so the only thing we needed
to do here we keep this equation variable the only thing we need to do is put your equation there in
this case i'll put it here h 75 minus 50 x and remember it's remember the python 50 times x
so that's by default set equal to zero so when we run it so the answer is 35 over two interesting
that gave us a fraction but there you go so that's 17.5 so 17.5 years it's going to be zero
so yeah now again fictional numbers i feel like you know in 17.5 years from now no but it's not
going to be that nobody has the flu or something like that but we can actually take a look at this
and we can change the x maximum to 18 and then we can see this trend so we look at that you see then
according to this trend you know time zero and that would be you know at 17.5 years and in this
case according to these numbers who knows it may in some particular town but in 2004 so 17.5
or 18 years that would be like 2022 and yeah i feel like that would it's not that there's
nobody afflicted with the common cold all right but anyway you see the trend though we see you know
the these are realistic enough that we can use these to take a look at how we would solve these
and this is what we want to use this math for predicting trends given the information that we
have so here's another one where they even give you the partial line based on the graph they have
all right so this is showing profit so this figure one is showing profit in thousands of a company
in a given year x and they also do x represents years since 1980 so there we go if x if time
zero is 1980 so then 20 so so 20 that would be 2000 and 30 that'd be 2010 we see you know there
we go now given these we want to find the linear function all right so let's take a look at if i
want to look at these i just want to find two nice points that i feel confident that i'm not just
estimating the points so i like this first one at year five it was 10 000 now it it's interesting
because it says y in thousands so therefore 10 000 would be 10 million you see so if y is in
thousands then 10 000 would be 10 million in which case they could have just said it was in millions
but that's okay and then we have so five i'm going to shift it to millions and just make the
y value 10 so five ten and then let's find another nice point i like this 25 four so we can go back
and we can plug in in these so i don't have that zero value and we're probably going to want that
at some point so five years then we're talking 10 million and then at 25 years
then we were talking two four
four
okay so there we go we have that point five years 10 million 25 years 4 million and
since we already see this graph since i made them 10 i really could now we could we could take
a look at this and say oh yeah 12 is probably fine as far as a y maximum and we could continue
this to 30 or you know we can take it further so when i go to graph it zero x maximum 18 is not
going to be enough maybe i'll just make it a nice round 50 y minimum fine y maximum 900 that
would the scale would be so much it would this would just be in the tiny corner of the graph
so maybe we'll just call that 15 or something like that all right there we go and for this one
we could
just delete this
like the space in there we could just delete this and we have i'm going to print out the correct
the equation so when we run it so here's our equation negative point three x plus 11.5
and we see this downward trend over time and here's another one where if i wanted to
change these tick marks maybe i could change this to the x ticks
is two enough yeah yeah maybe and then i can change the y ticks is two enough yeah maybe we'll see
and we'll run it so we see we get much many more lines all right and we'll see what happens
we see we get much many more lines all right and with that we see that the uh this is 38
now just because these end up being rectangles more i might change my y ticks to one i think
i just like that better and you know in doing this you can you know change some things and go
go there we go so with this then we can really see the trend there's your 11.5 and then we can see
this downward trend down 0.3 so it should go you know over 10 it just went down three to 8.5
here we go and then 38 years later then they would have no profit because that's the trend
that we're saying there we go so whatever this company is this is their profit since 1980
and then and then there we go um
um 38 years later then they would have no more profit so who knows what company this is but
you know our fictional company is you know something would have to change but that's where
the prediction lines you know the the the simplest prediction is okay these would go in a straight
line whatever trend would continue in a straight line unless something changed but we know then in
uh normal business normal day-to-day life things do change and that's why our lines aren't always
perfectly straight but this gives a often enough of a prediction oh and you see then time and then
cases then we would change that to profit okay just just to make it official here time and profit
so there we go another another situation and we can see where it would start and then
profit declining and that's enough years that you know 11.5 million was a lot more money in 1980
and then profit declining and yeah so this this company is definitely whatever they were doing
there you know they were in uh in sad shape all right and we have the y intercept and all that
okay so we see another very very similar we'll do we'll do one more here so consider this scenario
2004 school population was 1700 by 2012 the population had grown to 2500 so all right and
again assume assume the population is growing linearly all right now how much did the population
now how much did the population grow so this a is really just the subtraction
so 2500 minus 1700 is 800 so it grew that much and then the average per year you see
anything per year the rate that's the slope and we can divide that but we're also going to then
just plug these numbers in and you'll see that we can see the slope so 2004 maybe we'll call that
time zero 2004 1700 2012 2500 and i might even leave the hundreds because we want it to be
you know more exact we know that the population would be continuous it wouldn't just jump hundreds
so 1700 and then y minimum and then we have 2500 so then after this if i wanted to graph this
yes then my y maximum on the oh i put in the wrong so there you go time zero 1700
1500 and so in 2012 so time zero and then in 2012 so that's eight years later it was 2500
so eight years later then it was 2500
so here we go okay so we'll have that and
x minimum and then the x maximum so let's just make it a nice even 10
and we could always change it if we need to y maximum 2500 but we're going a little bit
further so let's make it 3000 and see if that's going to be enough
there we go and do i want the ticks for right now see if you comment them out the graph will
as we saw it will still give you the it will still give you the tick marks it's just that the
default whatever python wanted to calculate and where you can force them into however often you
want there we go and for school population yeah all right so we see it's growing by about 100 a year
here
and maybe that's you know depending on what you wanted to estimate these tick marks might be fine
the grid might be fine and you know if you wanted to you could always add more change it you know
i think that works out so growing by 100 every year and we can use that to predict so the average
probably growth per year was 100 there we go 100 x so the slope is 100
and there's the equation for the population for two years after 2004
so we see you know we've done a few of these i think i think we don't need to do another
population model but there's some other form there's some other uh practice problems that we see
in other tech all these all these are coming from that uh textbook the second textbook algebra and
trigonometry because that's a lot of good business applications in it so you know here's the idea
that just the notation g equals f of p the amount of garbage g produced by a city with a
population p so we can go a g equals f of p and that's how we would read that so it's a function
of population and what that tells us is population is the independent variable and then garbage is
the dependent and population very often is an independent variable that causes a lot of other
trends so we look at that and we see the same type of thing the town of tola has a population of 40
thousand and produced 13 tons of garbage each week express this information as a function
so now if we have this one of the things that we would guess is that if it's a function of
population then no people would mean no garbage so in our y equals mx plus b scenario b would be
zero and notice we because we only get exactly one point here 40,000 13 tons
so if we wanted to set this up you know we want to look you know we know that we have the
python scripts to solve this but if we want to set this up we want to take a look at at
how we're going to set this up 40,000 is going to be the population and who knows maybe i might
just call it in thousands and then 13,000 is going to be the population and who knows maybe i might
just call it in thousands and then 13 tons same thing i'll just call it 13 um
and then we say well that's one point where do i get the second one but we have to look at the
situation would i think that it would start at zero zero and if that's the case then we could go
back and say so here's zero zero and then remember our x values are going to be population
so we'll call that 40 and then that's going to be 13 because it's in tons
and therefore the x minimum zero fine but x maximum 40 is probably not even enough
um 40 is probably not even enough because we start with that and we can expect that it increases
and we can expect that it increases so then let's say the x maximum would be i don't know let's make
it 100 and we'll see y minimum zero now 13 maybe make it like 50 we'll see see if that's
enough of a y maximum so there we go and we can just write this in thousands
and we can make this in tons
so thousands of people tons of garbage
so we have this trend here there we go 40,000 generates 13 tons of garbage
and we can see this trend here so there's the rate here 0.325
0.325 x so remember the x value is in thousands so every thousand people
according to this fictional scenario makes 300.325 tons so that would be
about tons 2,000 pounds so that times 2,000 would be about 650
but then if that's thousands of people so that's each person making less than a ton of
less than a pound of garbage maybe so again this is this is not the you know latest research this is
you know a couple numbers that seem realistic and then what's the meaning of this and we
would read this as f of five equals two so notice that the function like our functions in python
that five is the input and any input or independent variable that's x or you know
even though we call them p and g here so that input five and then output two so f of five is two
so we would expect then that that means that when we're talking about 5,000 people
then the 5,000 people would produce two tons of garbage so that's the meaning of that you know
five is the input two is the output so in our x y scenario here that that's what that would mean
that's what that would mean 5,000 people would produce two tons of garbage
all right and so let's go over here to 89 and another one you see don't get caught up in the
alphabet soup of of this as people use different notation notice the trend of
of i would read this as g of a so it's a function of this input a so the number of cubic yards of
dirt d is needed to need to cover a garden with a square feet so d for dirt is g of a
and we read like that g of a and the common notation you'll see in just general math is
f for function and then often we just go through the alphabet fgh for other functions we want to
talk about in python and pretty much across computer science your function can and should
have a much better name so you know that's something that computer science has an advantage of
but nonetheless you'll see this all the time you know g of a so again we notice the trend a is the
input that's the area and then given that area then how much dirt would it be so we have 5,000
square feet area requires 50 cubic yards of dirt so that 5,000 requires 50 now we're not even going
to do any calculations to this but i just want to show you that it that would be g of 5,000
equals 50
so that's just how we would write that given that input you know area that we would know
first then therefore how much dirt we need and that that would just be how we would we would
write that there's we don't need to do any math to that right now and the same thing g of 100 equals
one so 100 cubic yards or 100 square feet of garden requires one cubic yard of dirt
all right and number and question 90 we'll see just another situation f of t so there you go some
function the number of ducks in the lake after t years after 1990 so f of five is 30 so we know
five is the time years after 1990 so in 1995 there were 30 ducks in the lake and then f of 10 so
years so in 2000 there were 40 ducks in the lake and given these you see we can x y x y we can
find the overall equation plot the points graph it you know make some other predictions but that's
the notation here and this is what that means all right now 91 the interesting thing is for
just answering these questions it this won't matter but this is not going to be linear
but we can still answer these questions because each of these is still going to be the same
each of these is still going to be the same now notice h of t and now in this case h for height but
you know again another way of expressing this so as x y values x is one y would be 200 the h
the h of one is 200 so that x value is t for time in seconds so after one second it's 200 feet up
after two seconds it's 350 feet up and again this is not linear so
the same things that we've been doing actually won't work for this but we can still get the
meaning of each statement here and 92 the one to one is this is still a function but that each
x value like each x value and y value pair up like that neither of them show up again but this is a
parabola because we see x squared and we'll talk about parabolas later but the one to one
that there's actually positive x values and negative x values that might still have the same y value
so that's why it's just not one to one but it's still a function
i don't want to talk too much about that we'll get to these these types of functions later but i just
want to mention that in case you're looking at that and saying well what does this mean one to one
so in number 60 now this is also not linear and you see the height of a projectile is more like
something like this after t seconds here's the function h of t is the height of a projectile
seconds here's the function h of t equals negative 16 t squared plus 96 t
so that's showing that you know it isn't linear in fact it's a parabola because it goes up turns
around comes back down okay so the domain anytime we talk about the domain that's the the x values
so the domain is all the x values that are possible here and then the range this doesn't ask it but
the range is all the y values and this actually has a limited range so uh because this is a
parabola that goes up and then comes back down there's a maximum y value so after that y value
after that y value there's no more like y values beyond that are not a part of the range because
it'll just never get to those numbers then the domain mathematically the domain is all real
numbers but realistically in the context of the problem time zero would be the first part of the
domain so you see mathematically these other numbers exist and they don't break this problem
but realistically if i'm launching something it starts at time zero and yes i know that we
can talk about t minus whatever and talk about negative values because we're awaiting the launch
you know and this is second so if it's like t minus 10 then it's you know the t value is negative
10 and that's 10 seconds until the launch but realistically we're we want this to be time zero
and then the other one would be it does go up and comes back down so there's a time where it hits
the ground again and beyond that it's not really within the scope of this problem so let's take a
look at how we can solve this just because even though that's beyond what this is asking
i want to find out what that t value is when does it come back down to the ground all right so
negative 16 t plus 96 t we can go into this where we're going to import our symbols and instead of
t we're going to make it x just because i already have x as a symbol so you could always change it
and make a t that's fine so negative 16 and again we're going to use x squared minus 96
x and that's always the this is the equation set equal to zero and that's what i want what x value
makes the zero now negative six would not be
plus 96 t oh because i put minus
yeah all right
so it only gives us zero what if i have
so i was doing this with things that only had one solution so storing this as a finite set and i
just printed the first one but this does have two solutions you see and i mean i could get re i
could get really fancy here and then actually just make another print statement but see this is my
finite set it's not zero six as a coordinate it's x equals zero or x equals six and i could then put
this zero and i could have another print statement
there we go to show the first one and but this is just a matter of you know how you want the
output to look okay so i'm going to go ahead and i'm going to go ahead and i'm going to go ahead and
show the first one and but this is just a matter of you know how you want the output to look
and we have these you know we also have the you know which we looked at before you could
you know loop through this to get solution to get multiple solutions but there we go yes
x equals zero it's on the ground and then x equals six so that's another way that we could you know
that we could graph this and we see that it back on the ground at six now this is a little
bit ahead because we'll talk about quadratics later so yes we will we will not worry about
graphing this because we'll get into this with quadratics but this gives us the solution that
at six at six seconds later it's back on the ground so some projectile launched it went up and
turned and i'll tell you this that you know halfway through these parabolas are symmetrical so halfway
through it's halfway through it's uh at its maximum point so we could even print here
what is that maximum point and we can do that math negative 16 here's what i'm going to do
so halfway through that so that would be three would be x and you see that's really the idea
that you know we set up the situation where i have x and then i can plug in my value so zero six zero
zero six it's back on the ground so three seconds later it goes 144 feet up in the air
so realistically then the domain for this function as that's that's practical not just like
you know mathematically it exists but related to this situation the the only number the only x
values that mean anything for this are anywhere between zero and six including zero and six
because everything else doesn't really mean anything for this situation you know after
this then if it keeps going down like it doesn't go back down into the ground and the y values here
are between zero and 144 so that's my domain between zero and six including both and the
range between zero and 144 so you know these are some things we can look at you know solve
when does it equal zero and plug in some various numbers
all right so if we look at 61 just again reading reading is these we might not even need to do
any code for this we have this situation the cost of making x items is 10 x plus 500
and the fixed cost is determined when zero items are produced so find the fixed cost and remember
zero so then if x is zero that 10 x drops out and then we're left with 500 that's why it's be gate
it's b for begin you know when you know before we produce anything you know the fixed costs are 500
now maybe this is some sort of business and 500 is like rent and utilities and everything that
even if they're there they didn't make anything they still had to pay all that
and then they pay ten dollars for whatever you know for whatever they're making
so then the cost of making 25 items would be 10 times 25 we just plug that in 250 plus 500 750
all right and supposing the maximum cost allowed is 1500 what is the domain in the range so if we
have to set this equal to 1500 now if we take a look at this and i'll just again write this here
so if we have 1500 equals 10 x plus 500 and notice i'm not this isn't python syntax because i'm not
worried about doing anything with this yet but then what do i want to do i want to put this equal
to zero so if i subtract 1500 from both sides then i get zero equals 10 x minus 1000
because if i subtract 1500 from both sides and so that's set equal to zero 10 x minus 1000 then
that's where i could plug this in here so you see you can work out the math before you get to the
python code so 10 and then here i do need 10 x minus 1000 so if that's the case now with this
one i know there's only one solution so if i keep the other one that's going to give me an error
i know there's only one solution so if i keep the other one that's going to give me an error
so whatever it is we know that we could only make a hundred
because you know maybe they only have that budget you know whatever they're making they make a
hundred of them their total expenses were 15 total expenses were 1500 and then
you know then we have to go out and sell whatever they are i don't know t-shirts you know
whatever they're whatever else they're making all right
okay so we and we see these same types of things we i just want to look at the setup of this
that at the number 44 at the start of the trip the odometer on a car read 21 395
at the end of the trip 13.5 hours later the odometer read 22 125
there we go assuming the scale is miles so average speed we want to take notice that that
anything like a rate like that that slope and we have two values time zero and then the miles
21 395 and then time 13.5 and then the miles and we can go through and plug that in whether i care
about graphing this or not it still will output the slope which is the answer to this question
the average speed and that's where average speed it would be a linear function whereas realistically
we know especially over 13.5 hours the speed's going up and down you know sometimes stopped
sometimes faster sometimes slower but we get that average speed we know that whatever that answers
they're not going to that exact speed the entire time all right and 45 the driver stopped at the
gas station to fill up his tank and he looked at his watch the timer at exactly 340 this time he
started pumping gas in the tank exactly 344 the tank was full now if i was filling gas for four
minutes especially with these prices these days i would be expecting it to be a lot a lot more
money but he noticed he had pumped 10.7 gallons so surprisingly not that many not that many gallons
but what is the average rate of flow of the gasoline so again time is going to be x so if
we want to call it minutes we can call it four minutes and then 10.7 gallons so we could calculate
to gallons per minute or and again same thing plug it in you know 10 well actually this one
because we already did that subtraction is just 10.7 divided by four so some of these you know
you have these scripts and everything available but some of these you might be able to solve
even before you look at those or you could break it down into seconds how many seconds
in four minutes and you know the rate of flow per second but that's just you know other possibilities
gallons per minute is probably fine so we see all these situations we want to see like that recognize
how we can set these up and the things that you're building that you already have to be able to solve
an equation even if you know the equation is something else and you can just do one step of
algebra you know because that's it you want to get it equal to zero so keeping in mind from
from earlier that one step of algebra so then you have it equal to zero and you can solve it
so you'll have these things set up solve any equation or you know graph a solution find the
rate all that so you know if all you needed was the rate you know everything else here would be
bonus but it'll still also answer that question for you so we want to see that you know different
ways that we can interpret these questions and solve solve the problems graph them take notice
of some of the keywords and hopefully you see how you can apply some of this to different situations
that you come across you know look look for situations in in your day-to-day life and how
you can apply these all right so hopefully that was pretty useful for you so when we talk about
factoring in algebra then we're going to talk about dividing out something so any factor is
something that we're multiplying and therefore i'm looking for things like when i see a number what
am i multiplying so when i see a number like six then i can say oh what are the factors that's two
times three and here i'll put the dot for multiplying to separate the factors so you
know when i when i look at a number you know like 15 then what are the factors oh that's five times
three and it's useful to be able to think about numbers and what are the factors because that
helps us reduce fractions and simplify other other terms so for example if i had since i'll use these
two numbers here supposing i had a fraction that was six out of 15 and i said oh well i want to
reduce that fraction to lowest terms there's a better way to write this so then if i remember
that they both are divisible by three that three is a factor of both of these then i can say six
divided by three is two and fifteen divided by three is five and so this is the that reduced
is five and so this is the that reduced fraction and i got this by factoring i recognized the common
factors and i divided out those common factors so just like other parts of algebra if i do the same
thing to the left side of the equal sign and the right then it's still equal here with a fraction
if i do the same thing to the top as i do to the bottom but that has to do with just multiplying
and dividing adding or subtracting doesn't doesn't work so if i have these i can reduce you know
reduce my factors i can even keep going supposing i had something like six out of 24
and supposing i didn't recognize that 20 that six was a factor of 24 but i at least saw that they
were both even so i could then divide by two six divided by two is three 24 divided by two is 12
i could start reducing again recognizing that common factor or then i could take it further
oh three and twelve both divisible by three and then i could say three divided by three is one
twelve divided by three is four so again i factored things out and therefore reduced the fraction
now a lot of times you know we see things and we don't we see fractions and we we can't you know
especially bigger numbers we don't right away think about the common factors and we can always
do long division in a couple minutes i'll show you how to how to do this with code to set up a loop
to find the common factors that way even if you don't see them or if it's a lot and you know how
do i go through all these possible factors i'll show you how to write the code to develop a loop
to do that find those common factors but this is one of the big uses of common factors another use
and this is more related to other algebra topics we might not need this as much as far as writing
code but if i have something like you know 4x plus 16 something like that and i say oh these two
the four the 16 have a common factor which is four and i can divide that out
and we can divide it out like this way so this is another use of the term factoring
because i see these common factors and i divide it out 4x divided by 4 is what is 1x so i'll just
put x and then 16 divided by 4 is 4 so and again this has more to do with other algebra
applications but i want to show you this because this is also factoring out then you know if i have
this i see the common factor and i can divide it out and it looks like this or i can distribute
the 4 4 times x is 4x 4 times 4 is 16 and get back to that so that's another use of the common factor
one of the other things we're going to do is talk about factoring out square roots
and that also i'm going to show you how to do this but then we're going to look at the code
you know how to find common square factors and then factor them out but let's take a look at this
if i have a square root and sometimes we have square roots that don't work out evenly they're
not perfect squares but i can factor them and sometimes that helps because that those factors
cancel out with other things later so if i have let's say the square root of 24 now square 25 is
5 that's great square root of 24 almost 5 it'll be some long decimal because it's an irrational number
but if i can factor that out recognizing these common factors and now in this case i don't want
just any factor i want a square factor so if i remember that 24 is 6 times 4 that helps because
4 is a perfect square and then i can say so i want to identify these factors but i'm interested in
the ones that are square factors and four square so the square root of four is two
and then since i took the square root of four i still have that six underneath the radical so even
if i can't square root the whole number i can square root part of it and factor that out so
sometimes then even if i can't factor out something like the square root of 24 i can get it down to
something like this and that's the simplified square root this factored square root and sometimes
that's really useful now again bigger numbers things that you can't often think about oh is
this a perfect square we'll talk about how to write the code to find these perfect squares and
divide them out and even use the simpy library to display it in a nice way so that that's really
the essence of what we want to do with factory recognizing factors of numbers and this is where
even if you're going to write code the more you remember your multiplication tables the better
things will be it just makes things you know come together a little bit easier but you know we're
looking at numbers thinking about what factors made that number and then we're looking at common
factors that we could possibly divide out and so let's take a look at that we'll take a look at
the code so here we're going to do the same thing we were doing with working it out by hand finding
the common factors dividing them out and it's going to work a lot better with writing code
because it'll go through and easily find all the factors for you and to do that we're going to use
the modules operator so modulus that is the percent symbol so on the keyboard it's the shift on the
five key so what that does is that finds the remainder so i already ran it so if you print
five modules three it's like five divided by three but the whole number answer doesn't matter we just
want the remainder five divided by three three goes in there once with a remainder of two and
that's what it'll print out the two and if we want we'll just comment this one out and uncomment this
just to show you another one so 31 module is 10 so 31 divided by 10 is three but that part doesn't
matter it's a remainder of one so when we run it it'll output one now that's going to be important
for finding factors because a remainder means that it's not enough the number is not a factor
but if the remainder is zero then it's a factor and that's what we're going to do use the modulus to
find factors so i just picked this number 12 and we're going to put this up in a loop so
in our loop so i i made this variable just called test factor so we have for test factor in range
one to the number plus one because i'm dividing so i have to make sure i start at one if i start
at zero it'll give me an error and i want to include that number itself so i have to do plus
one otherwise it won't do that last number so for test factor in range and then we go to this line
here if number modulus test factor is zero then it must be a factor so then i'm just going to print
out the test factor so that's what this is going to do given my number 12 here it's going to run
through that and try each number and see if it's a factor and print it out if it is so then when i run
it see it prints there we go one two three four six and twelve all of those are factors of twelve
12 so how can i reduce fractions to lowest terms so let's take a look at this and i'm defining more
variables here my numerator let's call it 12 denominator 24 now we know that this is going
to reduce to one half and i'm going to define a variable called factor which is one that will be
a factor and who knows for some things that might be the greatest common factor so now once i have
my numerator to find the greatest common factor all right so for test factor in range one denominator
plus one because that's really it i want to you know i want to go up through everything in the
denominator beyond that the numerator it's not going to really work out so now if the numerator
module so we'll do this line here if the numerator modulus test factor is zero and denominator
modulus test factor is zero so for each of those if it's a factor of numerator and denominator
now that's going to be my variable factor and then once i have that now i'm going to divide that out
so i'm going to do numerator divided by factor and i want to cast it as an integer because that's
going to look nicer when we do you know the sense of this is that they should be integers if they're
factors so this is going to look nicer when we display it so once i find my factor and you know
you know it could stay at one or it's going to get you know the largest factor i can find once
i find that numerator divided by factor cast as an integer and i'll just call it n denominator
divided by that factor cast as an integer i'll call it d and then we're going to print out the
original numerator divided by denominator and then the reduced fraction and divided by d so let's run
this and we see that the original was 12 over 24 and the reduced is one half so there we go we can reduce
any fraction and you can even copy this code and use it within something else you have
or you can put this as its own function and deal with it that way we'll talk about creating
functions out of a lot of this code later on in the course so the first thing i mentioned about
adding it let's just do this so we had the decimal to fraction code and you know this one we already
we had an input rather than just have the number here i have this input i asked the user to enter
a decimal number to convert and remember then that input gets stored as digits but it comes in as a
string and we've done this before converted to a fraction so i go here you know the length of that
input you know how how many digits minus one well convert it to an integer because i want to have
an and minus one because that it that will come in as a string that'll include the decimal place
so there we go then that becomes my exponent and then i'll still also cast that as a float number
which is n and then as a fraction my numerator is going to be the my numerator here will be n times
10 to that exponent so what that's doing is taking that value and moving the decimal place
so there we go so the so n has all those digits including the decimal place then
this line for the numerator moves the decimal place and then the denominator is 10 to that
exponent so now i have an integer for the numerator this will end up being an integer for
the denominator and now what we're going to do is just like we were doing earlier i want to reduce
that fraction so same thing factor equals one everything else i already had that same loop
finding the greatest factor dividing it out and there we go inputting the decimal which is the
original number that the person entered and then print the fraction so when we run it
enter a decimal number to convert so let's convert something like 0.125 there we go
and it took it and it reduced it to one eighth which 0.125 is one eighth
and we can run it again just to see that if i have a point zero two
there we go the decimal and then that's one fiftieth as a fraction so we can apply that code
into other things that we've been doing all right now we're going to take it to the next level
factoring out square roots so this is all good to reduce the fractions but remember when we square
root something now this one if i just print math that square root there we go uh square you know
the square root of 25 here is five great but what if i have something like the square root of 24
now that doesn't work out nicely and by default it'll just give me that decimal answer but what
if i want to factor it and this is how we want to factor it i use square root of 12 as an example
square root of 12 because underneath the radical 12 is four times three and then four is a perfect
square so the square root of four is two and that comes out and then i have a three left over nothing
else i can do with that so that's the factored square root we want to find our square factors
and divide them out the square root of that there we go so here we have numbered a factor you could
make it user interface but i just put it here n equals 12 and max factor i just made that one
that's the one that will change and here's i put this as the key ingredient because this is how we
get to you know if i have my loop where do i start where do i stop so the upper limit of math dot
floor of math dot sqrt of n so i'm going to take the square root of that then that's going to be
that's going to be some weird decimal number now i just did this math dot floor and then i added
one i probably could have done math dot ceiling also but i just did it this way so take the square
root and whatever you know math dot floor so drop all the decimal places you know not rounded just
drop them all and then add one so that's going to be the upper limit and now we want to go here
here so for maybe factor in range again starting at one zero would give an error to upper limit
if n modulus maybe factor squared so you see i'm running through those factors and
you know each of these is the square root factor so if i square n divided by that
factor squared if that's zero then now that maybe factor is now my max factor so we go through
and we're going to cycle through all these you know divided out does this work and once i get
some factor that's what's going to be on the outside so then i have the results my original
my original number the square rooted factor square factor and there's a reason why i'm printing all
of these out here like this because we're going to build upon this and make it look nice in the next
step but to show that square rooted factor square factor max factor squared and then the integer
that's left over so for 12 since we had that example earlier we see that n is 12 and the square
rooted factor is 2 square factor is 4 and the integer is 3 even though i called it integer that
was just text it actually comes out as a float so what we have is that this gets to that factor 2
on the outside you know 4 was a part of our in-between step and then 3 and that square
rooted factor and then the integer that matches up with 2 coming out that's that square rooted
factor that's the greatest one and then 3 is the integer still in there so like i said we're going
to use simpy to make this look nice import math import simpy and from simpy import symbols
so now i have this there we go and same variables i had before upper limit there we go and it's
square rooting it but then you know find a one more to see where the maximum is going to be
the like the greatest square factor i could possibly have so then i have all these other
factor and then square they're all starting out as one and i'm going to overwrite these
so slightly different variable strategy so if maybe for maybe factor in the range
if n modules may be factor squared then we have the max factor is maybe factor squared
all right and then the other factor is n divided by max factor so we see here then this becomes
the factor that i divide out because i'm squaring it here and then i have the other factor underneath
the radical is that original number divided by max factor so then the output variables and to make
this look nice we cast them all as integers so the square root of max factor because that's what i
want the square root of it cast as an integer and then that's the square root that's my variable
square root other factor cast it as an integer there we go it i mean it essentially will be but
we need to cast it as an integer here other factor and then the output this is this its own
variable output and we see it's square root times simpy dot square sqrt other factor that's what
that output looks like in simpy and this presentation here we don't need a print statement in fact that
uh that might not make it look as nice but this simpy output so i store all that as the variable
and then when i output it here there we go it factored out as two root three
and if i put it back to my other 24 that we were talking about before we know that that doesn't
work out and so it factors that to two root six because it's six times four and then the square
root of four is two and that's what we're doing the types of things that we would be thinking
through we just want to translate that into code you know i'm thinking through all the factors
of that number and which ones are square perfect squares so 24 i want to find all these factors
that are perfect square and i find that it's four and then the square root comes out and then
the simpy makes it nice so we can do this to factor square roots and there we go so we have
this we can divide out common factors we can reduce fractions we can factor square roots
and these are a lot of the things that you know we often do by hand in math and
now you have the code that you you can do this
you can do this now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit
let's look through some extra problems and i'm going to work through
extra problems using the colab notebook so you can see how you can apply these resources that
you're building and use that use these to solve problems that might come up in a textbook or
in day-to-day life so we're going to go through some more extra problems here so we're going
to do a walkthrough of the first certification in foundational math now each of these notebooks
there's five of them we'll do three of them for this course and then two of them in the next course
but they were i also designed them to be standalone that you know the directions would be enough that
you could walk through and be able to do all this still though i'm going to give you the walkthrough
uh maybe you already did this and you want to check some things or maybe some of it didn't
uh turn out as you expected or you're stuck somewhere so you can always jump to that spot
in in this video and see so each of these steps lead you towards the certification and you know
we've built upon each thing so the first thing you're going to do is make a copy of this whole
notebook this notebook is read-only and this is what gets shared out to everybody so
so you make a copy and that copy is going to be in your google drive
uh and it will be in a folder called colab notebooks by default but if not you can put
it in whatever folder you'd want it to be you want it to be in and this is the ongoing theme
for this course you're building your resources so you're going to put this stuff in your google
drive uh especially if you have other colab notebooks or something you could make a different
folder for everything uh in foundational math one you know or algebra with python if you want
to call it that so you make your own folder you're putting all these resources in there that you'll
have so you walk through as you work through these you'll understand how to do all these things
but then you also have some code that you can reference so you have this in your in your drive
i already did this and then each of these i have as a different section heading and then you can
click on the triangle here to expand the next step and with each of these being section headings
then up here you have a table of contents that you can go through so later on when you build yours
you you can jump to whatever part you want you know you can add the table of contents by just
making each of these a section heading so you do need to acquire the testing library because
this is actually self-contained you're going to write the code and then it's going to test the
code that you wrote and see if it's correct or not so this cell you don't need to do anything to it
maybe for other things you might do in the future you might take notice of you know how we import
this other library as this raw.py file in github and really save it as a library locally here
and then you'll be able to access it so this i have the note here you may need to run this
at the beginning of every session and the only reason i said may is because maybe if you walked
away for two minutes and come back don't count that as another session but these codelab notebooks
they do time out the runtime will time out after 30 minutes of inactivity and that doesn't mean no
typing that means no running any cell or even if you are really active all day it'll time out at 12
hours so then you you know you might say wait i haven't i've been active all day and why did it
time out they have that time out too all these are security features that you don't just like
leave it open for you know indefinite amounts of time all right so you're just going to get
this library and you're going to run it and we'll take a look at this so click run
and as this is going yep it'll save the library locally and then that's what it's going to reference
so it'll say requirement already satisfied even though it said that don't think that oh why did
i do this i already it was already okay that's just what it prints out and then when you see this
test pass go on to the next step then you know you're good so it imports this and you know now
you know now we have this library available and each step will use that to test it so these first
four yes i do have add subtract multiply divide i know you know how to do these you probably even
know how to do them in python but it kind of walks you through just gradually getting familiar with
the notebook you might be already familiar with it but so you know we'll take a look so
so we go through just you know two variables and then you're going to have one thing here
with the comment change the next line now this was just add so there we go i'm just going to do
a plus b and i'm going to click run and you see two plus one is three and then it said code test
passed go on to the next step so we go to the next one subtract seven minus three so i'm going to do
c minus d and i could hit run or i can hit shift enter which i'll do that time code test passed
so this is just getting you familiar and then each of these imports the test so
so you've run that first cell and then you have the test and that's what's going to check your
code and tell you one of these steps in a little bit i'll do one that that gets it wrong
and you'll see what what it'll tell you so here we go so we'll expand multiply and again remember
multiply in python like a lot of things is the asterisk same key or most keyboards same key is
the eight so just hit shift and it's above the eight there we go e times f all good code test
passed and then we divide now when we divide here g and h now they happen to be integers and this
happens to work out but if i had them as numbers that didn't work out if they were definitely
defined as integers then i would have to do something else because if i divide the answer
and if i divide it won't work out the answer will be a float but python gets pretty flexible with
this you know i just define g equals h equals and when i divide it's not going to give me a hard
time about whether they're integers or not it's just going to divide and there we go
so you can and a lot of things that you might work through here if this is your your notebook
you might just have things where you define your input or your variables right there in the code
but you could also
actually just prompt for input and so in that case you don't have to change the code because
when when you run it it will prompt for input and then that could be the different numbers that
that you want that way you don't have to worry about changing the code so in this case enter
a positive integer it actually could for what we're doing here it could be negative but i
just put that there and then we just cast it because the input always comes in as a string
and then i need to cast it in this case as an integer to do some math to it
all right so i need to do an integer or a float and then the only thing you need to do here is
following that model i have string b and a lot of these have you know some code that something
there that won't break the code but you do need to change it all right it's not just zero it's
going to be this and you absolutely could just copy this and paste it there we go now
what if i just change this now that's really all you need to do but what if i just said oh
just for me i feel like you entered one i want to say enter another oh and i copied the wrong one
and i want to cast it as a string as i want to cast as an integer so string b okay so if i have
that now so i don't need to tinker with this at all so i might not but if i wanted to change this
to another or something like that that you know we'll see all right so enter positive integer
and another one eight
there we go so what i was saying is if i wanted to change you know some little things that might
not be central even if it gave an error it shouldn't stop you all right but this case yeah
casting it as an integer and adding it we're fine if i cast each as an integer and then i went to
divide it would give me an error oh but i didn't want to worry about that for right now we're
defining them as integers we're just adding we'll cross that bridge when we get to it
and we can get input and cast it on the same line so notice just open parentheses there we go and
i'm going to do the same thing here i'm going to copy this whole line
because that's really what i want to do
all right now here's one where i really don't need to do anything else but supposing i just
change that to another now just the way i have it
see it actually just tested a bunch of these things because you know that's part of the line and
part of the line and you know i really didn't need to change that word it so it'll tell me hey
your into your input should be this now my point here is this will not prevent you to go
from going on to the next step so you know maybe that's it maybe there's some something little
in there that like why why did it say it was never it looks correct or something like that
and maybe you're watching this video because that's where you were stuck it should not prevent you
from going on to the next step and in fact you know that's fine you can say all right i see what
what was different i'm not worried about it on to the next step but if you wanted to you say oh
okay well maybe i just should have just said this you know you could always go back through and
check it and then see there we go and then and then you can make your change so the whole thing
is that this is supposed to be just you know a teaching tool check your code and then you know
move on but you know not to get you caught in something that you know is preventing you from
moving on all right now as i was mentioning about dividing casting things as a float so the float
number allows for decimal places and most of the time i'm just going to cast things as a float
anyway because just in case somewhere along the way i need the decimal places there's only a few
situations where i might definitely need an integer certain simpy things to display we'll get to
that soon enough and counting but other other numbers that i'm going to do math to it i'm going
to cast it as a float okay so again prompt and then cast as a float we're really just going to do
the same thing and that's okay you need you know if you copy you need to know what line to copy
and need to know exactly where to put it but there we go and we don't need to change this enter a
number enter a number and see now we will divide so i definitely want them to be floats because
i didn't even say integer i just said a number so this is going to work no matter what somebody
enters in and then when we take a look then you see it's waiting for us so i will do enter number
three enter number four and 0.75 which is perfectly fine because they're float numbers there we go
good times all right so order of operations and yes python knows order of operations
so in case you forgot you know here's the acronym PEMDAS
uh parentheses exponents multiplication and division addition and subtraction so
you can and then remember the python syntax for exponents is the two asterisks so in this case
what i wanted you to do is test your knowledge of order of operations we're not even worried
about actually writing code here then you're going to put your answer here but don't don't
really think about the code see if you can do this in your head what would this actual answer be
and then you're going to put that here well you're going to put that here for your answer and then
when you run it python is going to calculate the actual answer and your answer and then you'll see
you'll see all right so let's look at order of operations everything in the parentheses first
and then multiplication and division as they come up so
uh four times two and then we have 14 divided by two so you can actually go back and forth
multiplying and dividing all day so as they come up four times two is eight and then 14
divided by two is seven so then we're going to have one plus eight minus seven and so one plus
eight is nine minus seven is two so then we take two now we're done the parentheses to the exponent
two to the third power is eight and so there you go put your answer in there
and there we go actual answer is eight your answer is eight code test passed
okay so all these things and remember you can just like the other ones you can do all this you can
put print statements you know all whatever math you want just straightforward math in a print
statement python will do that for you so those are some simple calculator tricks you can do
okay so remainder remember when we divide something that does not work out evenly we have a remainder
and the modulus operator looks like a percent sign but if i'm using it in the code
it tells me just what the remainder is there we go so as i have the directions here 10 divided by
four is two but with but as a remainder so two and then two left over so 10 modulus four
would give me two because that's the remainder or 14 divided by six will have a remainder so
so if i do eight a modulus b and again it's the percent sign on most keyboards it's on the same
key as the five but you have to hit shift so 14 divided by six now let's take a guess 14 divided
by six is two with a remainder of two so that's what we're expecting to see the printout
printout there we go now actually we could we don't need to do this but we could you know show
well supposing if i had 15 divided by six so six times two is 12 so there'd be three left over
and so a modules b would be three if you wanted to you can test these out because
this particular code is testing did you do it correctly here so if you wanted to go back and
try some different things whereas then if i go to 18 that works out evenly so the modulus would
be zero there there would be no remainder and we can use that to find factors so we'll have an if
statement here so if i have 20 modulus five so that's 20 divided by five is four works out nicely
so 20 modules five the remainder would be zero so if that zero which it is then that means five is
a factor so you see we're using the double equals to test it so that's what we're going to do here
we're going to walk through this and we're going to cast this times we do want integers because
factoring really only works with integers if you know we can divide a lot of things but
you know if it's a factor there's going to be a nice integer in there so i'm going to just
enter an integer so input cast it as int and that's going to be our number and then here
next one enter an integer to see if it's a factor and again cast that as an integer and that's going
to be test factor because i don't know if it's a factor yet and in the if statement i just have if
number now remember whatever this is if it's true it's going to do that so if number exists which
it will then it's going to do this but we're going to change the next line so what do we want number
modulus test factor and then now if that divided by that gives you zero
then we can say true it is a factor and then or else it's false
it's false so there we go and enter an integer so let's do one that doesn't work so if we have 11
and five false
and we can run it again and let's say make it 12 3 true so there we go showing how we can cast
things and we can use that to test if something is a factor that that that itself might be useful
but we're going to take that and we're going to build that into other things like this finding
factors all right finding all the factors of a number so very similar to what we did but we're
not asking for second input here we have the first input and then we want to find all the factors
so now i have my for loop for test factor in range so i'm going to take this range
let's look at this backwards here i'm going to take this range and if i just had one number in
there it would start at zero but i can't have that because that'll give me a divide by zero error
right away so i'm going to start the range at one and then end the range at number plus one
because normally the range it won't do that last number so i have to add one and now to make sure
whatever that number is i want to include that all right so now for test factor in in this range
it's going to loop through everything every number in this range and one at a time like test factor
is going to be one and then the next num next time through the loop test factor is going to be two
so it will just loop through how for that many times yeah for every number in that range
all right and this is what we're going to change the if statement so we want to say if it's a factor
so number is our in is the original number we want and each of these test factors what do we
want to do with it we want to say if number modulus test factor
equals zero just like we were doing before we're just kind of putting it in an if statement now
so i get this number and i'm going to loop through all these factors from one up to that number
and i'm going to loop through all these factors from one up to that number and then if number divided
by test factor gives me a remainder of zero then it is a factor so then i'll print it out
all right so we run it and what do we have let's say 12 12 is a lot of factors
and you see it'll print them all out 1 2 3 4 6 and 12 and we can run it again enter an integer
supposing enter like 17 1 and 17 because it's prime so that's what we're doing just showing all
the factors here this type of thing we will revisit this at another time to reduce fractions
to lowest terms okay now what about prime numbers so a prime number is a number that the only factors
are one in itself so we're going to and then anything that's not prime is composite so if i
so if i have you know five is prime because the only way you can multiply to get there is one times
five but six as one you can do one times six but you can also do two times three so you because
you have those other factors it's composite so here now we're going to have same input
and again integers because we're looking at factors and i'm going to start out with this
variable prime or comp say being prime and then same thing range now notice i started the range
two because one will go into everything and that's not what i that's not what i want that
does that won't tell me anything so i'm going to start at two up to and including the number
again not including the number because this this this time it won't include the number i
didn't add the one there because again same reason i didn't have one one and the number itself yeah
we know that those are factors but i want to find out from two through any of the other numbers
if it's a factor and very similar then if number we're going to do the same loop and you could
always go back if number divided by test factor equals zero there we go because we have the same
variables here you always double check just in case the variable names change or a slightly
different way of doing things but yes if that test factor works oh see because this is test number
so this would have given me an error
and and that's the thing with with reusing code yes we know we're all going to use a lot of copy
and paste because that helps you know if it's a whole block of code but be really careful that
it is exactly the variables and everything that match up correctly so you know a lot of times
people do too much copy and paste and then they're lost because things don't match up
so this one we call it test number so if number divided by test number if that has a remainder
of zero then that means that is a factor which means all it has to do is happen once and that
means the number is composite and it's only prime starts out that variable is prime and it stays
prime only if it goes through and we never get a factor here throughout the entire thing all right
so let's take a look if we have this and enter a positive integer so let's enter one let's say four
composite right because i can also do two times two and then let's enter one that we have seven
prime and that way you can check all kinds of other things you know oh some huge number
is it prime is a composite there we go and you know now that you have this you don't have to
change any of the code when you run this it'll you know it'll uh test it for you all right other
interesting things reciprocals so writing it in math it's the number flipped so i have this
reciprocal of two-thirds is three over two you see it just flipped and then any whole number
the reciprocal of five is one-fifth because any whole number it's understood that it's
denominator of zero or sorry sorry denominator of one so that'd be five over one so then that's why
it's one-fifth as the reciprocal and you can multiply a number by its reciprocal and get one
there we go pretty good so and there we go zero has no reciprocal because it'd be divided by zero
so we can write the reciprocal whatever the number is we can just actually flip it one divided by n
there that's actually all you need to do to find the reciprocal
and some of these might be decimals but nonetheless this will find the reciprocal for you
and we see our output here enter a number and what if i have the number as
um five see point two but that's the decimal equivalent of one-fifth
all right so just putting this in there showing you what you can do with finding reciprocals
other things we can do with the input is supposing i wanted to have an output like this
and are two numbers separated by a comma oh well now but i want to test each of these numbers
so i can split it so this i'll store it as the variable nums still didn't cast it as anything
and then here this is actually going to be an array in this case with two elements it's going
to split it at the comma and then now this array sp has two elements so i have sp0 the first one
i'll cast that as a float and then i have sp1 so that's it you know asking for it to be separated
by a comma split the input and then then cast each of them separately so sp0 and then sp1
and notice the code here just says cast it as a float so float remember to close the parentheses
over here there we go and then what do we want to do and that the directions here are then divide
the two numbers so that's why we cast them as a float divide the two numbers and we have a divided
by b all right so there we go split it cast it and in this case then we're going to divide
okay so and our two numbers separated by a comma and let's see how about we do
um this one will be a repeating decimal of eight comma nine
there you go i'd notice if you have just one number repeating the fraction equivalent is
that number over nine so point one repeating would be one ninth point two repeating would be
two ninth and this one eight over nine so there we go okay now this is building up to something here
is building up to you being able to factor square roots but let's talk about square numbers first
so factor multiplied by itself is a square and it is kind of like the area of a square you know both
sides would be the same or all sides would be the same so when i do length times width to get area
they're the same and so is that number times itself and we would use the exponents that to
the second power okay so all we're doing here is you know we're taking a number and then
getting the square so in this case it's going to take the input as n and we're just going to square
it there we go okay there we go number square all right five i'll put 25
okay so let's go the other way square root function so anything to the second power
it's squared but what if i knew the result and i wanted to square root it so if i knew the area
of my square yard but i want to know what's the side side measure so we have sqrt and that's the
first thing we're encountering here that is not built into python so we have to import the math
library and this is where colab really helps you out because a lot of times you might have to go
through some other things to install things you know in other notebooks the colab notebook import
math and you don't have it behind the scenes it works you just have to have the import statement
all right so a number to find the square root definitely going to cast as a float
all right and how do we get the square root of that once we import it it's going to be math dot
sqrt and we call it a number n
especially you know think even if things don't come up automatically just you make sure
open parentheses one two close parentheses one two we got it so we're going to enter a number
and we see here and remember to find the square root so we'll do one that works out evenly how
about 16 square roots four and we can do another one that doesn't work out evenly how about 21
and it'll give you a bunch of decimal places
i remember yep so 4.5 yeah about there we go okay
okay other cool functions the floor function this is another one we have to import math to use it
so the floor function so we have a floor function which just drops any decimals
and there we go drops any decimals and sometimes called integer part or the greatest integer
so even if it's like 3.9 it's going to drop and just go down to 3 the uh we have the floor function
we have the ceiling function which as you can imagine if floor drops all the decimals ceiling
is no matter how many what decimals are even if it's 0.1 it goes up to the next number and then
round the one we use possibly most often round remember 0.5 and above rounds up and point
anything less than 0.5 0.4 and down rounds down so we're going to look at the math that floor
function here all right enter a number decimal place and we're just going to practice doing the
math dot floor function here math dot floor of n so enter a number with decimal places so i'm going
to call it 5.99999 and when i hit enter yep and that's the floor function even if it's 0.999
drops down to five so there we go and remember supposing you went back and said oh wait floor
you know i'm upside down ceiling function supposing i wanted to do that then all right so
um 7.1 because that should round it up to eight and so that code works but because that wasn't
what these directions are it'll tell you oh you should include math dot floor and again if you
end up trying different things it doesn't prevent you from going on but if you know either if you
either if you spelled it wrong or something or you did something different it'll tell you there you go
floor and go nine point three
right good drops it okay so we're going to put some of this together finding square factors
all right so a few things we've already done we're going to import math and what we're going to do is
we're going to enter an integer to define the greatest square factor so
i'll call that max factor and right now it'll be one and then the upper limit so notice we're
stacking on these functions here uh the math dot floor of math that square root of n
but then we're going to add one to it so we want to find the greatest square factor so whatever
number you enter it in we're going to square root it that's going to of course have some bunch of
decimal places and so we could do the math dot floor and then add one to it now i realize that
now i realize that i could have just done math that ceiling and then skipped the plus one i
for whatever reason i did this i like it so i kept it but there we go that's why yes uh
so that gives us the upper limit square root of that number and then but we really want the next
number now what do we have now in my range from one to upper limit so and remember this upper
that was the square fact the square root factor i square rooted it first so for maybe factor in
that range so it's going to go through and maybe factor is going to be one and then it's going to
be two it's going to be three you know up to this upper limit so if n modules maybe factor squared
equals zero so that's it these these factors if i square them is that a factor can i can i divide
that out and if that is then max factor you see it's not going to be zero what's it going to be
you know that's and that's the idea with some of these change one line so if you go through and
think about what you're doing then we see yep i'm going through this range and maybe factor is it
and then finding square factors if n divided by maybe factor squared if that gives a remainder
of zero then max factor equals maybe factor so that's what we change there we go
so and again knowing that these were the square rooted so for our purposes here
we're just printed out squared
so we'll see this here so if i have something like 12
all the greatest square factor is four because two you see it prints out square two squared is four
that and that's a factor of 12 three squared is nine does not work out to be an integer
here okay so here we're going to build upon that code and then we're going to have
all of this
because when we look at factoring out square roots that's kind of what we're building up to here
when you have a square root that doesn't work out perfectly but yet you can factor it a little bit
that's what we want to do here so i still have get the same integer same upper limit and i just put
all these variables equal to one because we'll change those square root max factor other factor
all right and then take a look at what this is doing same thing right because i still
got that same upper limit and so still maybe factor is going through that range
check for square factors just like we did before
and then
there we go and in this case max factor equals maybe factor squared
squared there we go and then other factor is n the original number divided by max factor
so
there we go so what we have is the result is going to be that original number n equals
this times this and we're just looking at how that divides out so in this case
you don't need to change anything because i i thought that this was a little bit you know
a little bit complex to try to follow like what what i was thinking through so i didn't
through so i didn't didn't want to have you have to change anything and just take a look at what's
going on here how we're dividing that out and then when you run it so if i enter an integer
to factor maybe i'll do the same 12 here see 12 equals four times three or if i do this again
let's say 50 50 equals 25 times two and again that first part is a square factor
so now
there we go the last four steps prepares you for this so factoring out a square root this is kind
of what we want 12 if we look at the square root of 12 is four times three so then since four is a
perfect square the square root of four comes out and it becomes two root three and that's what we're
kind of building as we're building this code to do is this whatever is that square root number
i'm finding the greatest square factor and then that comes out because the square root of four is
two two is on the outside now all right and in doing this we're going to import math because
we have square root and for our final output we're going to import simpy and symbols because that's
going to give us a nice output at the end that looks like this so that's the thing you know
that's the thing you know python outputs a certain way and then if i wanted to output
that looks more like math symbols that's what we have symbolic python using our math symbols so
similar input without the radical and our square root factor using those same variables
dividing these same type of thing where we're finding maybe factor and then max factor
now in this case i kept it like this maybe factor squared so the max factor squared
max factor squared and then we divide so now we do the output so i am going to square root it again
yes and i realized that up here there's maybe factor squared and then down here i'm square
rooting it again and the key is casting it as an integer because this will be an integer at this
point oh did not want to do that there yeah because this will be an integer at this point
casting it as an integer
okay so that's the square root and then remember other factor out here was my original divided by
that max factor and if there's anything left over other that's other factor down here i'm casting
that as an integer and you know that's it i'm just taking this other factor but casting it
as an integer and you see that you can do that with variables so now it's now it's an integer
and now the output is square root which was this variable up here times simpy so this simpy dot
square root is different than math that square root and using this simpy output i want that to
be my last i want to be that to be my last thing is this output so down here after it does
this for the test that's why output the word output shows up here we store it as this here
but notice it's not a print statement it just says output and the last thing just says output
and it will display it so these types of simpy displays sometimes just need to put that there
output as the last thing
okay so what do we have uh let's take a look at our um
let's take a look at 50 as we were talking about before
so and just because this came first that's why it says test passed here and then we see the output
but 50 factors out to five root two
and if we run it again then we have you know go back to our 12 12 is two root three
and we can see how we can factor out these square roots
so there we go this is now one of the things that you can do
and this would be a bonus we could do this later is we already talked about functions
you could put all this in a function
you know all you know you don't need to the testing part but the output you could put this
the testing part but the output you could put this all in a function that would factor square roots
for you so just like you have math that square dot sqrt to output the number which may be a
decimal you could actually make your own function that would do all this and then output a radical
you know like this so some interesting things that you can do and that's kind of what i wanted
you to see the build-up of this and how we can use these you know loops and factors and do this
to factoring a square root which is something that's you know pretty interesting in math
useful for some math you get into and then you can write code to do it
all right here's some rounding just interesting things so if i just say round it'll round it to a
whole number if i have something like this if i round comma and then have a number that'll tell
me how many decimal places and if i have this round and it's a negative number that'll be for
big numbers so that will give me that many zeros so there we go so first number rounded to the
millions the second number rounded the sixth decimal places so and i do need to go back to
my print statements print round and the first number six zeros so i have to make it negative six
and then the second one print round
be and i wanted three decimal places so it'd be three
there we go and we can print so that there's my six decimal places and you see then you know
i don't want it around to the next integer it already is an integer but i want uh 14 million
14 million 500 thousand rounds to 15 million and then the next one yep rounds to 007 of course
all right there we go and fractions decimals and percents
percents so we could see here and we've done some things like this before that
here we're going to take the input as a string see i'm going to import math for for later take
the input as a string and as a string every string has this built-in len which is the length of that
string so i want to take the length of that string and then i need to cast it as an integer
now remember the person who enters this in is going to put a decimal place so that's why
i have to subtract one because i don't want that decimal place i just want how many decimal places
without that dot all right so that's going to be the exponent and then now that i've done that
now my input digits i'm going to cast that as a float so the numerator is going to be n times
10 to that exponent and i wrote it all out just to make it clear what we're talking about here so
anything with three decimal places it's going to be times 10 to the third and move doing that is
going to move the decimal place over and then my numerator is actually going to be an integer
and the denominator is that 10 to the third oh 10 to the exponent
oh 10 to the exponent there we go so there's my fraction and this is really what we're doing
anytime we're converting fractions but now we're just writing code to make it easier
so how many decimal places that's really what this is essentially doing here
how many decimal places am i talking about and then that number times 10 to that those decimal
places 10 to that exponent and the denominator is 10 to that exponent so then the percent
because now that i have it as numerator denominator now i actually really can just
go back to n if i want or i could put numerator times numerator divided by denominator whichever
one but i could do n times 100 which it's always times 100 because it moves the decimal place over
and so that's it that's the first two digits are there are your percent so n times 100 gives you
the percent and we can run it so if i have somebody enters in something like point one two five
five there we go so the decimal is point one two five the fraction is one two five out of
over a thousand and the percent is twelve point five percent
so there we go converting any input fraction decimal percent
percent and this is where i was saying that you could you could define
this you can define a function here where you can execute a block of code with one command
so you know here's the function definition d e f and then the name of the function
open and close parentheses that may take input but they don't have to and then input indented
four spaces one two three four so d e f name of the function colon anything in the function
it can be as many lines as you want and it can have comments just indented four spaces
and then there you go here's one something outside the function and then that function
is defined and then it's
it's then called it it won't do anything until it's called here
so i could have this function definition and if i took out this line it wouldn't do anything
again so now it'll have this is outside the function then it'll print this is in the function
and then back outside the function
there you go now change the name and remember to call it so
there we go and then we want to run it then change the name to fun
because it can't spell function without fun
so if i just change the name i'm gonna call it fun and now i'm gonna call the function
so that's what is the function call is when i you know when i tell all right let's run that function
now there you go same thing to show you how to define a function and then call the function
and then here's one with input
so it can take input any input we're going to call an argument so there we go
um now right here it's telling me that it's uh you know called greet a function called greeting
it's going to take this input which will store its variable name that's within the function
here and it's going to print hello whatever the name is now here outside the function so notice
at the end of your function skip a line at least one line so then that's the break and now this is
definitely not in the function and then the input and casting it as a string which is it is a string
and we'll keep it that that way what is your name and notice inside the quotes that slash n will
indicate a new line so now when we run the greeting you see it's passed you know i take that variable
and i'm going to pass that into the function so now that function takes input and then it's
going to be this variable and then it'll do the greeting so here you go what is your name head
hello there we go and now now that you see this working this is just changing the
this because it's like remembering where these are
so you know greeting and then when we call it i'm going to change this variable here
there we go so we see you know where these variables are especially in a small simple
function like this so then you see you know this variable how do how do i pass it to the function
as an argument there and then in the function definition it's expecting input and doing
something with it but the function of this should actually be the same go
yep see all good and these functions which is kind of cool you could have more than one
input so we have this so i can have multiple input in this function and then in this case
you know do something with it well we're just going to add them all but you you could use this
for any formula you have you see like i just made this add but you can use this for whatever
formula you have make a function out of it so notice here you know the third i'll leave this
as three and then it's going to expect three inputs a b c and then a plus b plus c
c and now down here i have to call it with all three variables so now notice this variable
existed before but then it just stayed there floating not doing anything and then we have
here you know now that we have have this i'm going to call the function with all three inputs
because the function is expecting three inputs and then it's going to do something with those
and so there we go
so we see enter a number and i'll enter a number
and another number six another number seven oh because there you go five and six is eleven
plus three is fourteen
so there we go
hey fun with functions now all the this function and the ones we had so far they included a print
statement as a way to show output and that's good but we could also have a function with a return
value so notice this function here then it just returns that that value
and what that does is it returns it right where you call the function so notice that
right where you call the function so notice this if we're going to take this enter a number
you know there's our input it's the float i don't know stored as variable a so now
what i print is your number multiplied equals and then right here
it's going to be that function i call that function with variable a and that's what this is
and it's just going to take it times two
there we go
all right so notice some of these you run it and then we're going to change something and then run
it again so enter a number all right there you go 16 your number multiplied is 32
so all we're doing here is changing the return statement multiply it by three instead
everything else we actually can keep the same there you go enter a number 16
enter a number 16 and it's 48 so that's the return statement is right where you call the function
that's where the number shows up your number multiplied equals and then
returns that so that's pretty useful sometimes because we want that to just be where you know
where do i want this output to be right there and so we put the function call there
so that's the return statements good useful statement here so we have all these different
things we have all these functions we you know we're looking at factoring we're looking at
solving some things you can even just solve for x and there we go x as the classic unknown
now notice here we're importing simpy again or for our symbolic math and we're going to take
it even further from simpy we're going to import symbols and from simpy solvers we're going to
import solve so all these now i'll just define it here x equals symbols and notice it's just x
in single quotes so that's telling us that we're going to use x as a symbol in math
and the way that simpy solve works is the equation has to be equal to zero
so at what i'm going to do all right well we'll see
here's the output solve for x and i even have this here zero equals and then you're going to
enter it in now what this does simpy has this built in solve and notice the output's going to
be right here so that solve we know that behind the scenes it has a return value so solve that
equation using the variable x and this is just like a subtle thing that we'll talk about at
another time but this returns a finite set and for this we're going to say this is the first
answer that we want equation zero so enter an equation and then this is going to output the
answer there we go all right enter an equation and so if i have let's let's do like you know two times x
minus eight so we can see that x must be four
four and i'll put it there now if i didn't have this
i'll do the i'll do the exact same thing two times x minus eight
it just the way it displays it because it's a finite set now that also opens up the door
to possibly if i put in something that had more than one answer i could do that and that works
too if i have let's see i'll run it again so supposing i have now this will work
even if it doesn't work out to a nice integer but i'm going to make this work to a nice integer
x squared minus nine
you see negative three and three it does have two answers and it'll output both of those
so this one
you know and
enter an equation
function x minus four so there we go
if you didn't get a syntax error you're ready for the project
so different things you can do so this is where we now can make make your own functions
and this is where i leave it open to you how you could do this you know make your own functions
like you could take one of these functions here like the factoring the square root
yeah so you could take this factoring the square root and copy all of this
and
all right so as an example of something something you could do and down here you could make this
a function so you could do
this now what's interesting is you as defining the function here uh you could define it
factor sqrt
and we definitely want input and i'm going to make it n
and i'm going to make it n so we could do this that
it factors the square root and you could make each of these then you have to make sure
you indent everything
indent everything now since we're factoring square and we don't need that input then we can actually
delete that and here we go use you know we can keep all these
and this is the thing with a function
is you do want everything to be and you can take out things like notice what it's doing in the loop
there we go then this has to be indented
and this has to be indented there we go and all of these divide up we can even keep these
and we see that we have output okay
okay
all right and this part we don't need you know
and what do we want to do we want to
do we can backspace that
okay
yes this stuff does not have a test because this is so what you have is you can define that factor
square root and then down here later we could try to call it factor
square root and you know uh let's see 20
yeah and
and oh maybe I have to return the output
it's actually kind of funny that just popped up but there we go
so you see the output but because it's in a function we have to include that as a return statement
all right so this is you know this is not the part of the function but everything else is
and these are some things you can do because then you can you know different ways you can
just define them in your own you know colab code cell with some text ahead of it you could
you know you can make them all functions but that's the idea and then you could create a menu
if you wanted to where you just have um
which one you know what function should you run
should you run you could do a table of contents there too and then that's the that's the project
you're building this multi-function calculator you're putting all these things together into
a colab notebook that you're going to be able to use and it's going to be your multi-function
calculator and then as of making this video I can't tell you exactly where to upload that that code
but hold on to it and then you'll see where to put it together for you know officially
getting the credit for passing this part of the certification and then maybe on to the next part
all right so hopefully this was useful you know how to work through this and
how to put all this together into this certification project and you know we want it to be you know that
there's more than one way to do all this so find find a way that works for you you know
making your own calculator all right and we'll go on to the next project
so with graphing a system of equations we're looking at really just graphing two equations on
on the same x y axis and we want to see where do these two lines cross that's going to be the
two lines cross that's going to be the solution to our system of equations so as an example here we
have two equations and this one's y equals three x plus ten and this other one is y equals four x
so let's say I don't know it's a place you like to go let's say costs you know four dollars admission
so four dollars times x which is every time you go then y would be the total cost and then they
have a deal oh well if you pay ten dollar membership fee then your admissions three dollars
so there you have the the decision like okay well with this membership fee my admissions lower
but when would these be the same price you know how many times would i have to go for these to be
the same price so we want you know that's just one example of the of you know the use of this
so i put these both in y equals because we're going to get into some other ways to solve this
but we're looking at just how this graph plays out here so if i graph that y equals three x plus ten
so without numbers here we're just going to estimate let's say 10 is here and you know that's
how we plot begin at 10 and then up three over over one and let's just say you know it's something
like this and let's just say that's the line and then we have y equals four x so there's no beginning
it begins at zero but it's a steeper slope you know be at zero steeper slope and then let's just
say you know it looks something like this and then they cross somewhere where do these lines
intersect that's going to be the solution to our system of equations and let's just imagine that
there are numbers here and it was you know somewhere around 10 so you know let's just say
that that would be like 10 you know 40 something like that you know i see the invisible numbers on
there so you see where these cross and depending on what you're using to graph you know it might be
clearer to see might be harder to see but we can then always test it oh if i see it looks like
that's where that's where these lines intersect we can plug that in does that work for each one
so if x is 10 so it would be three times 10 plus 10 and then y would be 40 so our question is does
that work three times 10 is 30 plus 10 is 40 yes that does work and then it would be the same thing
you know four times 10 and y is 40 and then that works so that's how we would confirm it and if we
were doing this you know old school plotting a bunch of points i could always put you know my x
y table and plot a bunch of points i was using graph paper and what we're going to do though
and the reason why i didn't worry about getting this you know these exact details this is not
drawn to scale is because i want to just you want you to see you know the the way that this comes
together two lines on the same graph my question is where do these lines intersect and then next
we're going to look at the code how can i set up a graph how can i plot two points on the same graph
and you know for whatever the answer might be however you know minute the fraction or decimal
might be how we can find the solution each time so now let's take a look at the code so if
you remember graphing one equation on a on a cartesian plane this isn't going to be that much
different one of the big things though is we're going to use the numpy library instead of a loop
so we'll talk about that more in a second but the first thing we need to do is import it here
import numpy now you know this plt that makes it a lot shorter instead of writing that plot live
dot pi plot numpy we shorten it you know it's just a little bit shorter but np seems to be the
you know the common abbreviation so we're going to do that and you'll see np dot this and dot that
throughout throughout this code so like before we are going to define our
our range x min x max y min y max there we go and one of the things with the numpy array is
instead of creating a loop like we were doing before what this does is this defines an array
of x values and the first thing we need to do then is to find how many points i want to plot so
i'll take these x values you know notice x max minus x min so how many values i have there
and that should give me an integer number but i'm going to say 10 you know 10 times this number
that's how many points i want that's actually going to be for linear equations you really don't
need that many they it displays very nicely for anything with a little bit of a curve on it that's
probably plenty and for some more complicated graphs you might do more than 10 so that gives
me the number of points i have and just again based on these so if i change the window then
this updates automatically and then here's where i'm going to define the array of x values once
so using that library np dot linspace and it gives it takes the arguments x min x max
and then how many points so there we go it's just going through these where am i going to start
and and how many points in between and i'm just storing that as x because i'm going to use that
as my x values hopefully this is looking familiar setting up you know the window size the axis
for x and y and here's where we're going to plot line one so in this case i have y1 equals
two times x there we go and what it does is that will take each of these x values rather than me
needing to create a loop it'll go through each of these x values and plot them and then i have plt
dot plot x and then y1 so here we go i have this and the second line i'm gonna do the same thing
y2 equals and this one i took it beyond linear i just made x squared minus three just to change
it up a little bit and so there we go that's my second y value and here we go what do i want to
plot here x the x values and then y2 so there we go to find the x values and show the graph so
when we run this there we have it we have our each axis that first y1 is a linear equation
light blue line and y2 was the parabola now that's a pretty good parabola just to show you that if i
had fewer points let's just say even two times this yeah that's probably low enough that you're
still going to see this become choppy yeah wasn't that bad but if i really only have
one times this then it really becomes a lot choppier because i'm only plotting every integer
and there's a lot more going on here but you see how that linear equation yeah straight line worked
out just fine but this one yeah so that's why just as a default i'll do 10 times that and so there
we go and then to graph anything else all we have to do is change these y1 okay well how about if i
oh okay well how about if i make this like negative negative 3x i'll just leave it at that
oh because
three times x there we go if you write it by hand you know doing the math often you know
you forget the multiplying so that's the key python syntax you have to remember there you go
um and let's take a look at this and maybe we'll make this one um
there we go just to the third power how about that so there we go another linear equation
and this one here cubic and we'll run this
there we go and we see
you know even this yep the curve looks nice
so there we go all you have to do is change y1 and y2 and you actually can graph more than more than
two but a lot of times we're going to do linear equations and have two lines on the same and our
questions where do they intersect so there we go numpy and use that now that we've worked through
the core skills in this unit let's look through some extra problems and i'm going to work through
extra problems using the colab notebook so you can see how you can apply these resources that
you're building and use these to solve problems that might come up in a textbook or in day-to-day
life so we're going to go through some more extra problems here okay so i want to show you just a
few other things you can do with graph with graphing and one of them is shading in between
lines or just in general above and below so if you have an inequality you can shade above the line or
below the line we see we don't need to import anything different this should look familiar from
the graphs you've been doing set up x min and maximum how many points and then you know linspace
for your array and we've been doing this before here's the line and then we're going to plot that
now this one if you're doing an inequality you could also add the other argument of making it
a dashed line but this might be hard to see this line but here's the twist here the fill between
so we're going to say from x at still the same x values and then the fill between is between these
two y values from y1 up to 10 and you could define that as a definite number 10 you know we've
already set our maximum or you could actually say up to y max like that's another way to do it and
this one we call it you know we want to make this red so that takes the other argument python will
give you a default but you know you can define these and that makes it a lot better so there we
go the fill between same x value and then you have the range of y values that's the way that's going
to work and we'll do a few lines here we'll make make some art so line two you can see again the
familiar define the line and then plot there we go but then we're going to do the fill between
between that x and y2 and y1 so you see you can define it even you know this one i'm going to go
up to the top this one i'm going to go up to the other line and then we're going to do the fill
line and here we go so fill line three very similar and there we go each of these i'm defining a
different face color and this one's going to be green where am i fill in between i'm filling
between this one that we've defined up here y3 and y2 so that's so these are just these two line
are just going to be a band and here we go i can do this one between uh graphing another one and
notice all these are just simple linear equations to show you this and we're graphing between these
two so what happens when we run this so we see we get the first one from that line up to the top
and then from there to there from there to there and there we go so if the second one if we had
let's say all right we see this red we see this yellow so if the yellow one instead of ending it
there i went up to y max it would just overlap and i know you might be you might have been
thinking hey you might have might turn orange you know yellow yellow and red but actually
it's the order of things that it graphs this that was red but then then it graphed this and then
it overwrote the red and if i wanted to i still call it a line one but if i wanted to move that
down here so now this is yellow and then this whole thing would be red
and remember because the yellow started down lower so the red will go on top of that but
but it didn't go down this far so the red didn't cover this so we see you know that's it
you know the yellow line was x plus three and then the red line was x plus six so you still
had that little gap that you know when the red went on it didn't totally cover the yellow all
right but then we can you know y1 and now this one i definitely need to put this one back because
y1 wasn't defined yet so you see it gave me that little error there so just i'll move it back and
make this official before we go on to the next thing
and we can see so since i've moved a few things around before we run it let's
let's change something else here i was saying that we need we could do the dashed line so we'll make
the red line and the yellow line the dashed line and it might be hard to see but we will hope you
can always hope here so single quotes and then i'm going to make it a dash and i'll do the same
thing with this one the other argument single quotes and i'll make it a dash so that those
two would be dashed lines instead of a solid line it's hard to see it's a little bit but you know
there we go and because these you know with the shading sometimes you might not even need to plot
the exact line i mean mathematically you might just be in the habit hey i want to also show that
line but the way it shows up on the graph you know it's not you see the dividing line it you know
it's nice but sometimes you might say oh okay if i'm making some sort of art sometimes i might not
want or need that extra line so there we go so there's some different things you can do you know
draw lines shade above and below and you can be you can get creative with this and make all sorts of
of all sorts of things and this is essentially you know what vector graphics are you know not
you know defining each individual pixel but defining the lines that you draw based on
equations and then that way you can scale things because let's say i wanted to scale that if i just
change the dimensions of my graph i could scale this line with the same code in the same equations
so that's the advantage vector graphics you can make larger things but with not much bigger file
size because it's all defined on equations anyway so there we go some some cool things you can do
with that other cool things you can create an interactive graph all right and with interact
interactive we're going to set up some sliders this one's called interactive if you might come
across some python code that defines sliders that actually uses the word slider that you know that
works too but here's what we're going to import there we go in line and the inline part is going
to get us to be able to adjust these sliders and see the effect on the graph right away
so there we go and then this interactive widget so i'm going to define all the graphing notice
is going to happen within this function so i'm going to define this function so again i made it
a simple slope intercept so i'm going to define the function of m b and then i put another variable
for zoom so notice all of your dimensions here are based on that variable for zoom
and then we still have the points and the plot that's my y value mx plus b so now this function
takes these inputs and here's the slider it's really the most of it is right here on this line
is right here on this line so interactive plot now i can make that whatever variable i want i
just decided to call it that and interactive open parentheses so the first thing is what function
am i going to run and i made it f and the main reason i made it f is so that the line this line
of code was not that long but there you go what function am i going to run and then let's define
some ranges here m will go from negative 99 b will go from negative 99 and zoom will go from 1 to 100
so notice the zoom i could make it really small and x min max you know i could zoom it all in
it's still going to be square but i could zoom it really into just one in every direction
or i could zoom it out to 100 and i could change that number as i see fit so there we go so what
we have is this and when we run that interactive plot it's going to take the input from these
sliders and then run this function so let's see how that works so a lot of times the default
puts everything right in the middle
so my slope is zero and b is zero so you might be able to see that the axis is black but this line
this blue line is on there because it's a slope of zero zero what what happens when i move that up
see look at that now i have a slope of three and as i move up b then it crosses the y-axis at a
different place it begins right there now we see it starts right in the middle at 50 so i could
bring this down and you see i can zoom in
pretty cool and see this is what i zoom if i'm so zoomed in one every direction notice b was five
so that's off the graph now i'd have to move that back now you start seeing it on the graph
and these are some cool things you can do with your graph you can add this interactive
even if you you know you're graphing all kinds of things you just want to change the zoom
this is a nice way to zoom and you know you might see some things on other calculators
where you can zoom and here's how you can write the code you can have your own
graph that zooms in and out and you can adjust some other things so there we go some cool some
cool things you can do and i just want to you know it's a good way to illustrate you know
slope and intercept as they change how does the graph change you see and then i can make b negative
and therefore across the y-axis down here and i can change the zoom you know all the way
all the way so now i'm really zoomed out and it it looks like this might even cross it zero zero
because it's so tiny it only crosses at negative three and my graph is so zoomed out but there we
go some interesting things you can do with zooming and you see that just you make that
interactive plot and then your function all the graphing happens in that function
okay so here's another interesting way to graph we can actually because all this math is going
to lead you to working with data science so let's just get a little taste of it here that somebody
else created this library this mediostat library for getting just some basic weather information
um here's you know the weather information that they take time average temperature minimum
temperature maximum temperature precipitation snow wind direction wind speed this is the wind gusts
the maximum wind gusts air pressure and the amount of sun so there you go planning setting up your
solar panels you can calculate the hours of sun at a particular place uh planning to set up your
wind turbines you can calculate wind speed at different places and here's how this works
this one you do need to install this and so we're going to run pip install
install this and so we're going to run pip install and i just made that its own separate
it's a its own separate code block and there we go we just see that this stopped running and
that installed this so there's a lot of things already built into colab you might have noticed
we've imported some things but didn't need to install anything this is a newer library and
therefore it's not already built in so some of those newer libraries the install i mean it's
really pretty straightforward pip install mediostat done so install that library now
we can import it date time that was our i was already at python library but we just
do need to import that and then now we still need to import this because we're going to plot this
this data so that's why we import that and then the install enabled us to do this import
these i've included the link here you know for all the documentation
all right so here's how it works start we'll define these variables and they take this date
time year month day year month day so i decided let's do like the first half of 2022 and
so we have uh uh created a point now the point you create this is latitude and longitude
so they don't have really built in like type in the name of a city
you want to have an idea like let you know where you live you can find it like an exact latitude
and longitude of where you are you can find latitude longitude you know somewhere you know if
you want a particular city somewhere in the city so the example that you might see if you look up
look this up you know somebody uh did this for british columbia so i changed it and did this for
philadelphia so there we go so here's a point in the middle of the city and
we can just get the data here so from that point so there we go data daily and then
um there's my data point philly and start and end so there we go so we have this you know start date
you know start date end date location and then collect the data it seems like this would overwrite it but
this does work using the same variable data equals this data equals data dot fetch so there we go
it works out and this one i just said hey let's just plot the average temperature so notice
it looks very similar data dot plot and then down here we have plt dot show but there's nothing else
we need to do it actually all the rest of it the dimensions and even some other things the way it
labels graph happen automatically so there we go we just have y equals and then we're going to plot
these three things so when i run it we see the average temperature there we go average min max
so all these things we know in a previous video we were talking about you know how to create a
legend how to label the axis and everything this already does all that for you and it'll just graph
it'll just graph what you have here all right so there we go and notice the temperature is in
celsius so there you go if you're in philly you're like hey it hasn't been 30 degrees here in a long
time but yes this is celsius so notice it's going way above that yep june july pretty hot
and then we can just change this that we can have temperature average maybe we'll we'll keep
that and maybe we'll do one of the other ones precipitation prcp there we go so we'll graph this
and we see so average temperature and then precipitation
there we go pretty cool and we can see and of course then you know there there is another one
here snow now what you can see is all right if there's average temperature below zero and
and then precipitation then you'd expect hey maybe there's going to be snow but we can
add that and you will see
so there we go snow is in green and you'd think look at that average precipitation
and there's precipitation and below average temperatures but no snow precipitation below
average temperatures but no snow or below zero temperatures and yep it's kind of weird but it
happened but just there we go here beginning january some snow february some snow and there
we go that's it so interesting things you can do and you know even we were talking about having
this on your you know having the colab app on your phone you could have you you could have
something you know related to uh you know write write another line in here to get you know to get
today's date or yesterday's date and sort you know use that as the end date and you know have your
app and click on click on something run it and you know see the historic temperatures or snowfall or
wind up till now if that's interesting you could do some other things with this so just some good
things we can do with graphing and you see just getting a little bit of taste at how this is why
python is so good for data science because a lot of people make these apis that you can just write
a few lines of code and get the get the data you need and automatically graph it it's pretty
powerful like that and you see the the graphing that we end up doing is the same you know map plot
library so pretty good some some cool things you can do with graphing and uh we'll continue on the
theme that you know next we'll look at solving equations and graphing you know all together
which ends up being tricky but we'll show you how to do it okay so yeah take a look at this tinker
with it you know set up some you know some you know weather weather report code for yourself
all right
okay now we're going to look at how to solve a system of equations even without the graph
and you can still picture the graph the idea that that's that's what this is these are two systems of
equate these are two equations two functions that you could graph but i don't need to see the graph
to get the solution and sometimes for solutions that it might not be easy to see on a graph
then you know maybe it's you know not in a nice integer solving this this is going to work each
time so we're going to look at how to do this just on paper or on the board and then we'll look at the
code on how to do this and set it up to be able to solve anything just change the equation
so if i have these two equations one of the ways to solve this and this is some version of substitution
is if we notice if this equals y and this equals y then they can equal each other then three x plus
ten equals four x so we see that if that equals y and that equals y then these must equal each other
three x plus ten equals four x and that's a little bit of the logic that's inherent in in all math
so now we can solve these what can i do to solve for x i can subtract three x from both sides
and then i get ten equals x now once i solve that x is ten well i want a point so that's my x value
i need my y value and i can plug this in to either equation so i would take this and let's say i want
to plug it into here so y equals four x then i could take that and y equals four times ten
and that gives me y equals 40
and then that's how we would get the solution we can set these equal to each other
and then solve solve usually for x and then plug that in either one of those and then
get our y value now this is very similar to how this is going to work out in the code
one of the things that makes uh sim the simpy library and solving this with python a little
bit better is this works out nicely when they're equal to y and you know that looks but if i had
equations that were not equal to y or something like that with the python code what i would do
and we would do the same thing with this is the idea that i would make i would want each of these
equal to zero so i would end up subtracting y here so i would get you know three x plus ten
and i subtract y from both sides equals zero and that's the version i'm going to want this in
when i solve it with the code and then the same thing here you know four x minus y equals zero
and then with each of them set equal to zero then you will see how that that plays out using the
simpy library but that's that's kind of the method that python uses to solve so one of the
advantages of this is they could be in whatever form they want whatever you have on the other
side of the equal sign just subtract it over and then now you have two equations equal to zero and
you can solve it so you know and there's many other ways to solve systems of equations but
that's kind of the couple ways i want to show you you know this this type of factoring where you can
set these equations equal to each other solve for one variable and then get the other one
and then we'll take a look at it now so let's take a look at the code so let's start with the
simplest way to solve a system of equations now this is especially for linear equations
so you want to set each equation equal to zero but as far as algebra steps go that's fine it
you know it doesn't have to be simplified just as long as it equals zero so here we're going to
use simpy our symbolic math library and i'm just importing everything from simpy import everything
so that's the asterisk there and we're going to define x and y as symbols so we see this
there we go x y symbols and now here's the equation set equal to zero so first one here
and the second one here then i just defined it as first and second and here's how we get the
solution so this is the lin solve is the is the formula from simpy lin solve and it takes notice
the extra brackets first comma second so it takes this as essentially an array of two different
equations and then the next argument comma x y in an additional parentheses so it's using these
symbols so linear solve these two equations because after each set equal to zero we can set
them equal to each other and use these symbols and when you run this i already ran it and we see it
comes out as a finite set now again the simplest way is there we go we set these and here's the
one line that puts it all together you can just change you know change these two equations and
run it and you know you see your answer it's pretty clear it's a finite set x is negative one y is
three supposing i want it to look a little bit nicer so still importing everything from simpy
and these symbols still have the same i'm going to use the same equations first and second
now here where i have this solution here that's the same line but now i know that this solution
variable is going to be a finite set but there's things i can do with that so i'm going to create
another variable x solution here and i'm going to take this solution dot args zero zero notice it
behind the scenes it's a two-dimensional array so i want the first thing and then the y solution
also a two-dimensional array solution dot args zero one so having this i can print
a coordinate pair so there you all print the parentheses x solution comma y solution the
closing parentheses and then when i run this there we go it will print you know negative one
three in parentheses and i can do other things with that now there we go so what if i also
want to see the graph now this gets tricky because we can't graph the same way that we would
that we would otherwise because going through loops doesn't really work with simpy of going
through numpy doesn't really work with simpy but simpy has its own plot that we can use so there
we go it doesn't work with the others but it has its own so from simpy dot plotting i'm going to
import plot and so this is the simpy plot and slightly different way i declare these variables
here var x y here then this one is similar to what we were doing set equal to zero ready to solve
that looks pretty similar to what we were just doing same with the second equation
and so this part i'm still going to go through the same thing you know get the solution get the
solution get the x solution the y solution and print so this is what i just this is all the same
what we just did before but what the other things that we can do is now that i have these and i know
that these are equations set equal to zero now simpy syntax for something set equal to zero
if i want to get it ready to factor so my y value for the first equation i call it y first
so in simpy we're going to define this as an equation first and then comma zero means
that's that first equation and i'm just spelling it out that it was set equal to zero we kind of
need that so now y first is that set equal to zero and then y1 i'm going to make this variable y1
which solves that first equation you see y first comma y so i'm going to take that here
spell it out that it's set equal to zero and then do my algebra factoring i'm going to solve for y
and solve for y and then store it as this variable y1 i'm going to do the same thing for the second
equation so set it as an equation second the second equation is comma zero y second and then
i'm going to solve it y second comma y i'm going to solve it for y so now that i have y1 and y2
i can print them because that might be interesting so it's just going to give me these so i have
y equals that i will display exactly comma and then here's the variable y1 zero and y2
zero again because you know the index of the array so we have these that i can show factor
but we were talking about graphing this so let's do that next but now i have i will display
the solution i will display these you know y equals equations and now when i plot the solution
i didn't just factor it to see that as y equals though that is really nice i actually usually like
that but to plot the solution here see now i'm going to just reference x as a symbol
as a symbol and then take a look at this i'm going to plot but notice nothing dot plot this
is just plot within simp i plot and what am i plotting this y value y1 zero and this one y2 zero
so there we go so when we factored it into y equals that helped us not just display the solution
but put this into here that this is what i'm plotting these two y equals equations and then
the x value notice also a little bit different the way we display x comma negative 10 to 10
to 10 i could you know make these other variables but that's going to work out just fine for us
so then when we run this i see the solution i have it as y equals i have that one is y equals
and then i see the graph and we see where the solution is negative one three there we go
so we can do this for you know any other ones here there we go let's just change it up maybe make
it negative 2x you know i don't know minus two and maybe this one make this like two times x
x and i don't know like plus eight change it up a little bit and so we have our first ones and
we'll solve it print out the solution factor it show the y equals equations and then graph it
and now we have this new one two six is the solution here are my two equations y equals
two times x plus two and y equals x plus four so we see these two and how do we know which one
the two times x has a steeper slope so that's got to be this one that's the bottom line
and then x plus four the slope is only one so that's got to be this top line
and we see that they intersect here at two six
all right so we see how we can solve and we can solve and graph there we go and this works for
linear equations for equations beyond linear we'll cross that bridge when we get to it which is going
to be in the upcoming sections now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit
now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit let's look through some extra problems
and i'm going to work through extra problems using the colab notebook so you can see how you can
apply these resources that you're building and use that use these to solve problems that might
come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life so we're going to go through some more extra problems
here so here again is where we're going to put together all the newer functions you've been
learning into your calculator so that you'll have these as a reference and remember we already have
where you should already have proportions set up so the text to show the setup and then the code
to enter it in and solve your proportion and remember we made this a heading so we can minimize
that there we go and we already did this converting decimals to fractions and percent so again all the
code there and that's also section heading solve for x so each week you know you're learning and
we're building and then we're going to take like the final product all of it put together so here's
one if you just have a an equation you want to solve for x pretty straightforward we'll have that
there and factoring so we can solve or we could factor you know factor out a common term or
something like that we have we have that and each of these you don't need to use our interface
because you just have this the solving solving for x we did put a user interface in there
it's going to prompt for the input and then you see that the equation set equal to zero
whereas the factoring one it's just this equation that you know there to put put it there and then
simpy dot factor okay so that's also a section heading then recently we were doing things like
solving for a variable so not just set solve for x but even if it's not a definite number to actually
rewrite it you know like y equals a over b or something like that where you don't even have
numbers this will do that for you and we defined a lot of our basic variables that we might use
it's not going to be an error to put them in there and not use them but you could always if you change
what variables you use you can always edit that part and then whatever it is whether it be
the involving numbers or a bunch of letters and variables you know left and right side of the
equal sign and then we have this then we're just going to define the variable so that way you can
pick what variable you want to solve for set it as an equation remember we did this and then we're
going to solve and this loop runs through all possibilities for s in solve for solution so
we have that that we can solve for a variable like again it's already heading and we have that
therefore in the table of contents so we're going to add the other things we've been doing slope
intercept from two points because this in itself is a very common thing to need to do so we're
going to define the two points there we go x you know x and y and then using just our slope formula
solve for b we're going to get m and b and having those two we're going to print out the equation
and then we're going to use that for the graph and you can keep this at these numbers if you want you
know you could always change this x min negative 10 and we could leave the others as is but you
could always change them to 10 in every direction if you wanted to and having those we have have
these you know for the graph and the setup the details could always add other details or change
these and you see for things that we might use we might want to see the tick marks so we have them
there so you don't have to really think about you know the exact syntax hopefully the more you do
this you remember it but it's just there and it's commented out so you can use it if you want
and then that way here we just plot the function as a red line so even if you end up changing some
of these you have a lot of things that are there by default that if you really entered in two points
you could solve whatever you wanted to solve and graph it so we have that here let's make that a
section heading then we can double click and remember it's this hashtag because it's in the
because it's in the text not in the code now that became a section heading and shows up in the table
of contents so we have that now the section heading goes all the way down to the next heading or the
bottom so that one we can minimize now this one if we minimize it that's all the rest of the
document here so besides that i might just want to graph something and remember in you know we use
this the other code as you're building it remember the slope intercept stuff came from week five and
then other ways to customize the graph came from some of the extra things we're doing in week four
in week four where we have you know again all the different things we want to do with the graph the
labels as well as setting the tick marks and this one you know we even customized the labels down
here you know and added a remember we customized it and added this whole legend here but in copying
this for yours we're going to put all these as well as the zoom that we were doing all in one thing
so this function then does all the graphing and i'm going to skip down here for a second
the slider remember that interactive plot we're going to run this function f and the only slider
we're going to have is to zoom and that's going to be our multiplier from one to i just picked a
hundred that's good and then taking that so whatever that multiplier is that will define
what we have for our x min and x max and then once we have those we can define the points
for our np dot linspace to graph and there we go and i just put this you could do the same just
two lines as by default you know maybe you want to have two lines and then you you know you want to
see where they where they intersect so this graphs two different lines and notice does not have to be
a linear equation as long as you're using python syntax whatever line you want to graph and we
i commented this out but again you could have it if you want to fill between shade above or below
and i just happen to have this one fill between same x values so the y value goes from y1 up to
y max so that would shade above and it would make it green and the next one fill between same x
values from y2 down to y min and make it blue so that would shade below so again you could have
these here in case you need them we're making these default notebooks that you can use and you say oh
okay i do want to shade above or below uncomment it and then we have the labels general labels you
can change now for this one i kept this the tick marks in there and the grid and notice because a
lot of this is based on the zoom so then how many ticks do i want and what i did is i got the
difference the how you know from x max to x min divided by 20 i tickered with this and that seemed
to be a good number to display nicely so we're going to get that divide by 20 and then round it
and then cast it as an integer so the number of ticks has to be an integer so then that was
then that way no matter what the zoom is you'll see that we can adjust the tick marks and show the
grid so this will give us a few things that we can graph you know this default and then let's see
given these equations that we have in here a lot of times i like to keep an equation in there rather
than just like make that line blank so if you run the code it works and you see something
something so here we have this graph and we see the default zoom goes right to the middle
but i could move this back down and you see everything adjusts the tick marks adjust
the graph zooms in and then you can see you know or we could zoom out
out and we see
so yeah pretty good i like kind of for this particular graph i like it zoomed in
and then you can see you know about where they where they cross so sometimes you just might
want to graph something and there there we have that and there we go we could put more directions
and you could have the whole every all the directions don't have to be the heading you
could have that and you could put an html break right after that if you wanted to and then more
words underneath that would not become a part of the heading
but for this we can just put the heading here
here we go i remember there's really no entering we just put it on a little line you just click
somewhere else and now that's also a part of the table of contents so we have that and then
solve and graph a system and this is nice it brings it all together solving it and graphing it so here
you can put in as long as you have python syntax whatever you have there is your first
and second equation and i even have an extra one here just to be able to uncomment and you can see
this will even work if you have a square root just to have different ones to show you and we've used
the linsolve before to solve uh using simpy the linsolve to solve uh two equations and this
is actually another one non-linsolve i like this one because it can be lit i just put the comment
in there it can be linear or non-linear it works out so just because you have non-linsolve does not
mean that you have to have you know something different if one of your functions is linear
but there we go the comments just so you know here's where you enter in
and then you already have the code that you would have copied this one would have been from
eight uh yeah from from uh the recent week to solve and graph you can just copy these and then
tinker with them a little bit you know as we went through and built up to these important
uh blocks of code you know take the last one that brings it all together and then
over here you know that's what you're doing you're building your your library here so solving graph
the system of equations and then this will work solve and graph pretty much anything and
i just want to show you some of these
so even if it's non-linear and you see it'll give you the solution x y this one happens to have two
solutions notice because we had the uh the loop the four loop here to account for multiple
solutions so it'll have the two solutions then also show the two y equals equations and then
graph them so that's pretty complete that's a good good one you want to have this is this type of
thing in your toolbox double click and let's make this one a heading there we go so we have that
and i've added one more thing here and we could still make this a heading
notice this code isn't complete but i put one thing in here they give you a reference point
so you certainly you would recognize that that's import so that would go first and then
you see this you would also it would be something you already graphed so the plt would already work
but notice you have this dot save fig and you're going to give it a name dot p l t
notice you have this dot save fig and you're going to give it a name dot png that's a good file type
to use notice that'll come before the plt dot show and that actually works if you put it after
i've tried this if you put this after it actually will save something but it'll be a blank graph
and what's interesting is this download can come after so that's okay i mean you could put it first
that'd be fine too but it can come after because it doesn't interfere with what this shows
and this is a way to download this to your computer or your phone there we go save the output
because sometimes you might have have something that you wanted to save so therefore you take
this and you would put if you wanted to up here you import that and then and then definitely you
you know you would just do save fig and files download so there we go and we have this now we
have all of this and one of the things you can do is in the view you can collapse all the sections
all right and now you have all these in your table of contents and you can just jump to them
if you need to there you go you have all the sections collapsed and oh do i need to solve
for x do i need to solve for variable you know i i like i like shorter headings so i might
and down save graph and download it
there you go because that's what it does is it downloads an image
so already we have so much of the core algebra that you're able to do and you and you can write
the code for it and now you have this at the ready so one of the next things we're going to do is get
to quadratics and more complicated graphs we kind of hinted at that last one you know you might if
if you haven't seen a lot of these and you say oh wow okay now this graph has a curve now it's
getting interesting so we'll get into quadratics parabolas you know where all the graphs do have a
curve to them and things beyond that so we'll add more to this all right but well well on your way
to being able being able to solve a lot of algebra problems in python
so when working with word problems not just here's a math formula solve it work with you know word
problems or some people call them story problems that's when a lot of times people have trouble
translating that into a math equation that we can solve so what i want to do is help you with some
keywords that you can find in the word problems in the sentences that'll tell you what math operation
to use and this is not all of them but this is a lot of the main ones and you know you get the trend
with this these are the things you're looking for and then after we look at these keywords we'll go
we'll go through a bunch of examples in the code and how to use these you know translating sentences
into math equations but let's take a look at these keywords so how do i know if i'm going to add well
some of the words are going to be if i just actually see plus some number plus another number
more so if i have something and then i got more how much do i have now you know the amount of
money i had increased it might even just be and you know i have you know these cards and those
cards how many cards do i have received because a lot of times that's something added to what we have
up something goes up and a lot of times calculating elevation up we're adding
it might even just come up and say added to sum also and sum means the total when i add up so we
might see some of we might see these you know the sum of three and four means i'm going to do three
plus four so these are some of the ones if you're looking and you see these then you know you're
adding okay and a lot of this it's not so exact that you could write a program to find a number
find one of these keywords and then automatically translate it to a math equation so you have to
use a little bit of your human intuition there but it it's very much in that direction see these
numbers what which one of these words are around there and that's going to give you an indication
of the path operation so let's take a look at subtraction so subtract yeah it might just say
minus less anytime i have less than i'm subtracting or it decreased the amount of money in my bank
decreased so i subtract gave because a lot of times things if i receive something that
it becomes added to what i have or if i gave then it becomes subtracted from what i have
down and that also goes again with looking at elevation it might even just come out and say
subtracted and then anytime it says the word difference or i know i want to find the difference
between two numbers that's subtraction you know we just find the difference and you know that might
be a negative difference might be a positive might be absolute value but if i if it says difference
or if i want to find the difference then i'm going to subtract all right so with multiply
so how do i know that i'm multiplying obviously things are increasing like there are you know
we want to look for that general trend things are increasing and just right away if you have that
since things are increasing you know it's multiplying or adding so how do i know that
it would be multiplying by just the word by because if i'm calculating an area of something
three by five and then i've won't you know also then just seeing the word area but three by five
means the area would be three times five of so just the word of is going to be multiply a percent
of something you have the percent and then you multiply times whatever that something is
factor because two things you multiply together are factors times so yeah three times four
you know it might just come out and say times and even if it doesn't have these it might just give
dimensions and say what's the area and anytime i'm calculating the area of something i'm multiplying
so there we go again not this is not all the numbers that lead to multiply but this is a lot
of the main one all right so divide out of so notice of would be multiplying but out of is divide
so you know four out of five that would be a fraction four divided by five
per same actually per pretty much means out of but that's another way to think about dividing
of miles per hour i would divide miles divided by hours or kilometers per hour kilometers divided by
hours quotient we don't see this word that often but that quotient means that i'm quotient the word
means that i'm dividing and actually that's the answer when i divide any rate and as i was saying
you know you know kilometers per hour or something like that but anytime i have a rate it's going to
be some sort of dividing something divided by something else usually divided by something
related to time but it's not always so anytime i have a rate i know i'm dividing something
and again it might just come out and say divided by so you know some of the key words here now i
put the word each here because that actually could go for multiply or divide it's the sense
of it you know if i have if i have 20 students in the class and i want to give them two pencils
each how many pencils do i need so then that's multiplying because i have to do 20 times two
but if i have if i know how many pencils i have and then you know i know and then i have 20 students
and i you know how many can i how many can each of them get you know if i already know that i have
20 and then i have 20 students how many can each of them get i'm dividing so each can go either way
we have to get the sense of it and dividing like subtraction if i get the sense that it's getting
to be a smaller number then i know it's dividing or subtracting you know and then we we can look
further you know what's the sense of it am i is it something you know each you know i'm dividing
it out among different things or is it just a subtraction okay so these are some of the main
things and the one that carries over a lot is or some version of is are was but is translates to
equals so that's where we get the equal sign coming into our equation and so if i have these
then i can translate you know this is was will be something like that becomes the equal sign
so looking at these keywords you know we get the numbers from the from the situation as well as
these keywords and we can put together an equation and so i wanted to give you these keywords and then
in the code what we're going to do is we're going to look at a lot of you know some sentences
and translating them into math equations and then of course solving them that's what we want to do
we want to be able to translate this you know you're not always in life going to have like here's
the math problem it's going to be you know some words and we have to translate that to a math
problem so let's take a look at how to do this let's let's apply these translate some sentences
into math problems all right so let's take a look at the code so now let's put some of this into
practice some of the math we've been talking about with the linear equations slope intercept
especially and some of the python developing equations finding slope graphing all that
let's put all this together and use that to solve some problems here and first let's look at how we
can see that y equals mx plus b pattern for a linear equation show up in slightly different
ways you know sometimes we just change out the letters a little bit but be able to recognize
that pattern so if we take a look at number one and this all comes from the textbook the one that
i have listed as textbook two algebra and trig so you know there we go page 304 you can find it
find these because we're just going to pick a few of these and i want to highlight
you know what we can do with these so if we take a look terry is skiing down a steep hill
terry's elevation e of t that's how i'd write that that's the function
um instead of just y equals we'll call it e of t elevation as a function of time terry's elevation
in feet after t seconds is given by this so e of t equals 3000 minus 70 t and we see then you know
instead of x we're using t because it's time and we have 3000 minus 70 t and then our y value is
e of t that's the function and so we see the slow the intercept come first that's where we begin
she terry begins at 3000 feet up and then goes down the slope at 70 feet per second so we see
that that is the slope the slope of our equation on the slope and negative because that elevation
is going down there we go so we can see the slope we can see where terry begins 3000 feet up
um and there we go just uh finding that slope we just look at it and we take a look at number two
now we have jessica walking home from a friend's house after two minutes she's 1.4 miles from home
12 minutes after leaving she's 0.9 miles from home what's her rate in miles per hour
miles per hour well right here we have distances in miles but the times in minutes
so if the question asks for miles per hour we definitely see also that we have two points we
have a time and a distance and then another time and distance so you know x will be time y will be
distance and having these two points we can go to our calculator now hopefully this lines up with
something that you've already created you know remember we might have called it like your
calculator and then hopefully you know then you would have created the table of contents
for the different things that we want to be able to do and we can jump to here slope intercept
equation from two points because even though the that question didn't ask for the full equation
and everything we're going to do more but the first thing it's going to do is find the slope
for us and hopefully you know that's it you know we have these formulas you made these now we can
make use of it so you would have had all this and then we would just change x1 y1 so the y value
is 1.4 but that x value it's two minutes and we have to remember so i already put this in here
it's two minutes and there's 60 minutes in an hour so it's two out of 60 you could reduce
this if you want but you don't even have to python will take care of that in the other in between
steps and the y value 1.4 miles so the second x value 12 minutes so same thing 12 minutes we want
an hour so it's 12 out of 60 again that reduces but you don't you don't actually have to and then
0.9 so having all this you can just put in these four values here calculate the slope intercept
we'll print that out so you see the equation and then we'll also graph it i mean we're going beyond
what the question is but this will give you an idea of some things you can do you already have
this and all we needed to do is recognize what these values were put them in here and then we
run it all right so this i absolutely would take this slope as three so sometimes just the way
python calculates things it might be this 0.9999 it's three and if you really wanted to seeing this
you know you could always go back and put a round function in in your code you know round it same
with this you could always round it to two decimal place to one decimal place which would be 1.5
but either way we see that remember our first point was two minutes after she left so at time
zero at two minutes she was 1.4 miles from home but at time zero she's that little bit more
1.49 or 1.5 it might round so we get our values here and you know again you could put a round
function in there but i'm not worried about that right now and also python it gives us this warning
but it's still ran occasionally that happens just the the way it calculates some things
some things you know we get a warning you know some value maybe not even related to
what we were working on gives us this warning but it's still ran it still gave us all this
and then we also have this graphed now if we have you know the x values or the y values so
so this is her time from home
so this y value notice it seems like this graph is completely irrelevant because the y value
only goes down to net 9.6 we want it down to zero and then we have negative time values what you
know what's that all about so remember mathematically a lot you know all these things already exist
these values exist you know we make this equation here negative 3x plus 1.5
but that whole equation exists so we can actually change the graph and one of the things we have
you know later on in this document is you know we can graph you can always graph and zoom
but we can just change the graph here and our x minimum if x is time we can just make that zero
because negative time you know she was still at her friend's house so that won't affect the
the walking and the x maximum i mean we can really zoom in now once we figured out that she was
going three miles an hour and she only had half a mile to go like we can make our x value really
small i don't know i'll maybe i'll just reduce it to five for this one and the y minimum
um is zero and the y maximum i don't even need that to be 10 i can even make it i'll make
it five but we don't even need to that much we can really zoom in on this because it's a relatively
short distance all right so now when we have this now we have graph we can zoom in on and
you know this is the only part we needed so we could look at this that you know about one and
a half miles away and so therefore you know she's walking about three miles an hour it takes her
about a half hour to get home and there we go we see you know the rate you know the slope the
whole equation we see the graph and then we can graph the the trip home we could also always you
know change these you know if you really needed to explain this you know to someone else you could
always put you know x values you could change that to time y value can make it distance from home so
there we go so we have these calculators that you know we're talking about it here i'm talking
about it here a lot now but if you had this at the ready you might even just you might might even
just you know see this oh i see my two values plug them in click run and you have your answer
you know move on in a few seconds here so some things we can do here notice number three very
similar and maybe we'll do number three you know a lot quicker a boat is a hundred miles from the
marina sailing directly at it at 10 miles per hour so now we already know that equation because
because it's a hundred miles away so that's where we begin at 10 miles or an hour and if we want
the distance from the marina then it's a negative 10 100 minus 10 x so we could always go here like
that's the equation 100 minus 10 x and we could always go to something else and we could graph that
and see you know just the trend how long does how long will it take for the boat to to get to the
marina there you go 10 miles an hour you might even be able to do this in your head that it's 10
10 hours to get there and that's the thing we have the setup for when the numbers get more
difficult but sometimes you can just calculate it yourself all right and we take a look at some of
these and remember a linear function we'll get into the other functions quadratics and things
beyond that but a linear function has no exponents so there we go no exponents so we see six is
linear seven is linear eight is not because we have x squared nine is linear ten is not we have x
squared nine is linear ten is not we have x squared eleven we have y squared so that's actually
not even a function like the ones we've been doing so that's another story 12 yep actually not a
function like the ones we've been doing and certainly not linear 13 if i had x in the
denominator then that would not be linear but with just a five in the denominator we're okay
so there we go and increasing or decreasing we would just look at the slope if the slope's
positive it's increasing if the slope is negative it's decreasing and remember the slope is that x
coefficient so slopes four it's increasing 15 slope is five it's decrease it's increasing
and 16 the slope is negative two so it's decreasing 17 it's negative three it's decreasing so we see
that and just like we were doing with these other problems you just like number 24 there you go you
could just plug these in two four four ten there you go run it and have your equation and see the
equation and see the graph so a lot of these you know once you have the code down you know it
becomes a lot easier there you go same thing a line if we have two points then yeah we put this
in there all right now let's take a look at 37 so these two lines now we get into the system
of equations are they parallel perpendicular or neither well one of the things we can do then is
we can look at one of our other notebook sections and we can graph these two and see so let's take
a look at this 4x minus 7y equals 10 so let's take a look at this and you would have this you know
how about this graph lines and zoom in or out remember you would have made something like that
too and we defined our function so that we can zoom in or out and we have two lines so line one
i could just graph this now also so one of the things we can do to graph these
if you wanted to is put it and this would be something that you would do you have to put each
of these in the y equals version because they're not in y equals and that's how we have it set up
to graph you see it's it's going to be y equals and they are going to be functions so we have this
well let's go to another one solve and graph a system because this one does not have to be
equal to y in fact we just make it equal to zero so i actually already put this in here
four four times x minus seven times y and the only thing we need to do is make it equal to zero so
that equals ten subtract ten from both sides you see much quicker much easier to do and then the
second one seven x plus four y equals one just subtract one from both sides and that's what we
have here so it underlines these but the moments we run it'll be fine so that works out really
well because as long as you have to set equal to zero just anything on the other side subtract it
over and remember you would have already made this hopefully and you know your first equation
your second set equal to zero and remember we're solve then we solve it and we're going to get that
solution and then we're going to also convert it to y equals here
and then graph it print the y equals version
and when we run it we see we have the solution and it's not even you know this is again more
than the question asked but if we already had the code you know we can do this the solution
and yes these are two very weird fractions that you know it would be a little bit tedious if you
were calculating this by hand we get the solution and so we also see the graph these are not parallel
or perpendicular and we see where they intersect at this value negative 66 over 65 so all you know
almost negative one little bit off and then a fraction there and then we see the y equals versions
four times x over seven minus ten over seven so we see this one has a slope of four over seven
and this one has a slope of negative seven over four oh then they would be perpendicular despite
what this graph shows so let's try to change this because the slope here is four over seven you see
even though we're multiplying by x that coefficient is four over seven and then over here it's negative
seven over four and that's what makes them perpendicular the negative reciprocal four over
seven negative seven over four that if you multiplied them together they would be negative one so if we
change the scale on this we can probably it'll probably look more perpendicular and
so this just naturally scales it this way all right so we have but that's why because
in this same window the y value goes up to 15
so the you know it perpendicular this intersection would be at a right angle
and the you know we just can't see that right angle because of the scale of the graph
all right so that work i would work for any of these now you know 38 yeah pretty easy i would
just add y to both sides you know subtract 12 on the first one and they're equal set equal to zero
and we can use that same thing same with 39 maybe we'll do another one here
here so we get
yeah if we have this let's just do yeah we'll do one more here three y plus x equals 12
so if we go back to this then i'll make the first equation then we'll have three times y
y plus x minus 12 because that i would have to equal zero three will remember python syntax you
have to put the three times y whereas algebra you won't see that multiplication symbol in there
so three three y plus x minus 12 equals zero and then on the second one eight x plus one plus y
y so on the second equation we'll have eight x
eight x eight times x plus one plus y and see i don't even for these are as bad but
you know for other ones you don't have to worry about factoring it as long as it's set equal to
zero we will get the solution and then we're going to show the y equals version and then graph it
so yep these do have a solution where a point where they intersect and notice they are not
perpendicular because the slope is negative one third you know one x over three and this one the
slope is negative eight so a steep slope at negative eight and also a negative slope but
not as steep so they will meet at this point there we go so pretty cool solving a more complicated
system of equations solving it factoring it graphing it remember if you have you know
you don't build these calculators for yourself then you have it you can answer all these questions and
some other things and so we see you know the similar things lines passing through and
in any of these you could build for yourself you know a notebook section of code that will
do this for two for two point uh two lines or you could actually go back to the one you had
and you could use the slope intercept equation for the one line and then write it in
later and then you could use the slope intercept equation again for the second line and then write
it in so that's what we have here like this one you know you have this slope intercept and you
always could then take it and you know copy that and write it in here as you know line one go back
and do the other one copy it as line two so that you know that that's one of the things you could
do if you wanted to you know take take something like that and have it actually do two instead of
one but nonetheless you know right now as i have it it was it was two separate things you can
get the equation and you could if you wanted to copy it into the next one
so all these yep same thing two points you get the equation two points get the equation
and there we go just looking at that equation you know parallel they'd have the same slope
perpendicular then you could multiply the slopes together to get negative one
and neither is anything else as long as they have different slopes so we see all these different
things you can calculate and i'll leave this to you if you want to you know go through and
practice some of these see some of these you don't have to have the full equation
or you don't have to have the the note jupiter notebook or co-lab because if you remember the
pattern that slope intercept equation here what's the y-intercept it's five you can see it and then
for this particular one you can actually count you know oh wow look at that you know we go down
five over four so the slope would be negative five over four so it would be y equals negative
y equals negative five over four x plus five or if you wanted to you could just take these two points
and plug you know go back to the notebook plug them in and see it generate the equation but
see that that'll work for any of these you know having this you can count the slope like in 58
so b is one and then from that to the next nice point it looks like you go up two and then over
three there you go there's your slope so you can you know work on these
so some of these again any of these you want to see a graph
we could just plug any of these into that other notebook section where you see the graph
the graph all right sketch a line
good and again you can practice all these if you want the tables
so really just remember x and then whatever you want to call it g of x that's the y value
and so if i want the equation then what we want is we can just take the first two points
and get the equation
so that's you know x is zero y is five and the next one x is five y is negative 10
and we can get that equation but then also if you wanted to you get the next two points
and see if it's the same slope so that's how we would determine if it's linear i mean we could
always just plot any of these points and and see what it comes out as so that's another way we could
just plot these points as their own array and see if it looks like they line up you know that's
another interesting way to do it and there we go so so yeah let me let me just show you how to do
that on on one of these and so if the x values are 0 5 10 and 15 now what you can do is in
in one of these where you're going to graph so if we have
yeah here and we'll even keep the zoom in so one of these where you're going to graph we
we have all this for the zoom but what you can do is you could make an array of the x values
all right so we could get x equals and make it you know 0 comma 5 comma and you see 0 5 10 15
and we can just make that the array 10 15 and then
and then you could now we could just comment out all of this because we don't need these and
and take this and this first one we could put you know comment out this and we could have y1
and we could have y1 and put your y values 5 negative 10 negative 25 negative 40
so there we go 5 negative 10
negative 25 negative 40 so remember that you know that that numpy essentially does give us an array
of values and we could just put our own array and if you wanted to in here we could also then put
you know make them make them dots i'll say ro so we'll make them red dots
for the points so we could have the x array have the y array and then that's what we're plotting
there we go we just commented all these out and
so we have this looks to be that they're in line and we can change the scale i like to keep
you know yep it definitely looks like they're in a line
so we could you know there we go we could say that yep that's that would be a line and you know that
works that is linear so some some of these you might just notice okay does the slope change
in in that table but also i wanted to show you for this or for this example i'm going to show you
in in that table but also i wanted to show you for this or for you know this might seem like a lot
to do for that little question but also just showing you what you can do if you have you know
more complicated sets because all of these that you know this this is designed to be practice
and just a few values just to show you but remember this is this is going to lead you
toward data science if you want to continue following this path and instead of having like
four values you might have like you know four thousand and so we want to know hey how can we
do this we'll have other ways rather than having to you know write our own array rather to grab
those values if there was like a thousand of them and then store that as an array and same with the
other y values but then you know can i do this can i just take this and plot all these points and see
what it looks like now these are the things we want to be able to do so you know there we go
some some things you know and and it answers a very simple question is it linear
because otherwise you know they might get some of these that the plot's all over the place and i
could not say that they're they all line up nicely so that's it you know here's some of these you
know missing values of a linear function and remember you can graph and actually introduce
a table of values too if you wanted to so you know those are some other things you can do
so we have these
here we go and some of these
we would have to put the slope formula so remember the slope formula is you know without
looking at the code you know find the equation of the line goes to the points here without looking
at the code the y values b plus one and then the other y values b so when we subtract that it went
up one you see the y value went from b to b plus one but then look at this the x value is a and that
didn't change so a minus a is zero so we have it's actually not a function but it would just be an
x value x equals a so these are some of the things just you know plugging in these values for uh in
the slope and you could always do some of this with you could define all of these values
if you look at the the other one that we were doing here solve and graph now the you might
have to comment out the graph probably wouldn't do too well but taking these and you know you
you know you if you define more variables you could still take these and define these values
again the solution might not be uh really possible but you could take those values and then you could
actually solve and this solves it for zero but you could actually solve it for you know solve it
for y or whatever value you want so simpy will do that for you so that's it you know you could have
you could have a make another section in your notebook that just does all that interesting
factoring all right so there we go and so we have some other ones here so so here's one um
now this we have at noon the barista knows she has twenty dollars in her tip jar and if she makes an
average of fifty cents more from each customer so remember that's an average so you might have
customers tipping more some tipping less and then it averages out so these are good estimates
because we would right away see the equation we begin with 20 and then it's an additional
because we know she's getting something more 50 cents from each customer so it's 20 plus 0.5 x
so we see that equation then we you know right away we have that 20 plus 0.5 x
and we can do something with that we could like graph it we could find values
this particular question we just says n more
so it would be 20 plus 0.5 n you know we just change that variable and then at any point
she can plug in a number for n figure out you know how many tips she has all right
and this 115 these are some of the things that you know you can calculate
a gym membership with two personal training sessions and a gym membership with two personal
training sessions cost 125 while gym membership with five personal training sessions cost 260
what's the cost per session so we take it as the membership itself is just one thing
and then you could have like you know each of these so really we have our x value would be how
many training sessions and then the y value would be the cost and so that's it even though you know
we don't it's not asking us to graph we absolutely could go back to this and two sessions was 125
and then five sessions was 260 so we could go back to this and back to the earlier one
you know slope intercept from two points and we could say you know there we go two sessions
cost 125 you know how many sessions and then dollar amount and then we have five sessions
would be then 260 and oh now this we need to change this the x minimum now that's probably
fine for five but let's take a look at this and let's see what we can do here so let's
go up to 10 y minimum zero is probably fine but the y maximum and there we go maybe we'll make it
like you know 500 we're going to go beyond that but that's fine and when we see the graph so we
can see that we're going to go beyond that we're going to go beyond that we're going to go beyond
that but that's fine and when we see the graph so we see the equation 45 x plus 35 so the membership
itself must be 35 dollars and each session must be 45 dollars and so we see this graph then you know
there we go you know and we see where we see the cost 45 you know almost halfway there
and then we see the increase okay if somebody wants to plan you know what it's going to cost
how many training sessions do i want maybe this is in a month the person wants like two in a week so
it might be about eight in a month and can calculate oh there we go eight training sessions
that'd be four hundred dollars or you know do i want to just try to just pay the 35 dollars
and not get any training sessions and you know there we go then it's somewhere around here
at the zero value and that's what we want we want to you know use these to be able to calculate
some different things you know the cost like 116 here so the linear relation clothing business finds
there's a linear relationship between the number of shirts it can sell and the price
price p that it can charge for sure so there you go selling and shirts if the price is p
and this is you know things that people want to find out because then that helps people figure out
what price you know they definitely start out like can't you know go below a certain price because i
have to make money i can't lose money but then beyond that we see oh wow this is shirts all
different prices are possible so somebody says that finds this historical data so finding data
from somewhere else some other people selling shirts oh okay i can sell a thousand shirts
if the price is thirty dollars but three thousand shirts if the price is twenty two dollars
so there we go again that classic y equals mx plus b but we just changed the letters
change the letters p of n you know the price based on n shirt n shirts is mn plus b so
there we go we can we can look at this you know n shirts now something like this
i might take that the price is the independent variable because that affects how many shirts
you can buy and so we might you know do something like that and then we'll get into in uh later
units here we'll get into other things where we can then based on that price you know given this
we can find that that you know that equation for price and then based on that price we can take
it a step further and say what would be my profit because just as an example here
so a thousand shirts at thirty dollars so it'd be thirty thousand dollars so they sold a thousand
shirts thirty dollars each but three thousand shirts at twenty two so twenty two times three
thousand is forty four uh uh sixty six thousand dollars so just lowering that not just you know
selling more shirts but the price that it had to lower or reduce to twenty two dollars not that
much different and so it sells three thousand shirts so instead of thirty thousand dollars
sixty six thousand dollars look at that almost uh more than twice the profit for a little bit
less and some people who don't look at the math of this would say that you know what is is the
you know reducing it eight dollars is that going to double my profit actually it does or at least
the revenue we don't know the cost of making the shirts but it more than doubles the revenue
just lowering that a little bit because it reached so many people
and so that's what people are looking at you know and in again in further units we'll look at the
math behind you know how to how to get this how to find that maximum profit value maximum revenue
value and you know what you know what are we looking at here how can we find that
you know ideal shirt price so there we go there we go all these others same situation linear
equation we're trying to maximize things if we look at number 18 a farmer finds a linear
relationship between the number of bean stalks she uh she plants and then the yield
that each plant produces so 30 stalks each plant yield you know how many per per acre
so 30 stocks each plant yields 30 ounces of beans but then 34 stalks reduces its 28 ounces of
beans you know they're all competing for some of the same resources so we can definitely get that
you know they're all competing for some of the same resources so we can definitely get that linear
equation and then we can try to find so what would be the maximum you know how
what would maximize the bean yield so you know it'd be really interesting so
then we get this um
um yes so notice this uh and the yield would be 30 ounces that many beans times 34 oh no sorry
30 stocks times 30 ounces see then 30 times 30 so that's 900 or then we have 34 times 28
and i'm not going to do that in my head but we can see some different values and then we'll look at
these in some of the other business applications later on so some more things if we if the town
population and like number 120 drawing linearly we can write an equation for that you know here's
another one where we often do this all the time converting temperature from celsius to fahrenheit
and we have these two values zero degrees celsius is 32 degrees fahrenheit so then we know um
100 degrees celsius is when water boils and the corresponding temp is 212 fahrenheit so what you
can do is we could just take these now we could also use this to make another function
but we could also take this you know slope intercept from an equation equation from two points and
there we go still better sub equation from two points and
we can say all right so we have zero and then 32
and celsius would be 100 and fahrenheit would be 212
here we go and see the see the graph
now the graph in this case okay and i'm not even worried about changing the values because
the main thing we wanted was this equation here 1.8 x minus 32 some people like that 1.8 is a
fraction that's nine over five so there we go that's and remember then the x value was celsius
the x value was celsius so that's how we can convert celsius to fahrenheit times 1.8 plus 32
and so if we look at the increase you know 1.8 is almost two so you know each celsius
degree increases almost two degrees fahrenheit increase so we can see that change
so if we take a look at this you know we you could always you can always make this that you know make
another function for yourself that you could you know you could just have like you could just have
celsius to fahrenheit fahrenheit to celsius you know that make another section add it you know
you know put a heading to it because remember as soon as you have the heading you know not a comment
because we're not in the code but if it's in there then it becomes a heading and it'll be in the table
of contents so you can always make some of these things for yourself and you know that's why i
want to give you some of these practice problems you know if some of these are relevant or if you
want to combine some of the things you know you have room to explore and do some different things
so there we go and then once you have that equation you can find you know there we go
that function of 28 degrees what's that become in celsius or fahrenheit or negative 40
uh that's a good one because negative 40 celsius is negative 40 fahrenheit so the one time where
they actually agree it's got to be really cold but when it's that cold they agree and anybody not even
having a thermometer would probably agree too yes it's cold so these are some of the things applying
some of some of these and hopefully this is you know find this useful some some ways you can
interpret some of the word problems and use some of the notebooks that you've been working on to
solve problems answer questions and yeah you can continue you know add more to what you have you
know make make it your calculator anytime you have different formulas they say oh this this
might be useful make a function pick a formula another notebook section all right ready to go
on to the next thing now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit let's look through
some extra problems and i'm going to work through extra problems using the colab notebook so you can
see how you can apply these resources that you're building and use these to solve problems that might
come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life so we're going to go through some more extra problems
here for these extra problems we're going to look at just ways to set up some formulas you know if
you have different situations word problems how can we decode these put them into math terms and
then use python to solve them so just here's some examples and all these come from the pages in the
first textbook you have the link so let's look at number 10 on average this happens to be full-time
canadians work 39.5 hours per week so if the typical adult requires eight hours of sleep per day
what's the percentage of hours in a single week left over for personal activities
so we need a few things here 30 so we need the number of hours in a week and
even just going through your python colab notebook we have all these different things that you can do
i'm going to click on solve and graph which we're not doing yet but in here you can just put a
the blank you know line of code here and even in the print statement you can do a lot of math so
first of all we can have the number of hours per week and that would be 24 hours times seven days
and then if we want to look at the number of hours that canadians work we're going to subtract 39.5
from that and python knows the word of operation so i can just put in here i like the spacing but
you really don't need it 39.5 so there we go uh 24 hours a day times seven days a week minus 39.5
and then we actually can also subtract eight hours a day eight times seven
times seven so we have how many total hours in the week and then minus the work hours and then minus
the sleep hours again all this in in python shift enter and we will have 72.5 hours so there we go
72.5 hours is you know and it works out look at look at that you know work sleep still have plenty
of time to go out and do things and we can do all this just know knowing what we need to do each
step you can break this up into different steps and put variables but this is just one way to do
this all right and let's take a look at another one that number 14 housing starts in winnipeg
for the first half of 20 2009 we're down 46.733 percent we'll talk about converting that in a
second from 2008 when 1500 new homes were started so from 2008 to 2009 if it was the same amount it
would be that times one or times 100 which would be times 1.00 so if it didn't change it would be
that times one but then since it went down we want to think one minus that rate so it's not the 100
percent it's the 100 minus this 46.733 and then the original was in 2008 it was 1500 new homes so
so we can just go right back to this and we have 1500 new homes times one minus that
46.733 as a decimal is going to be 0.46733 and you see that we have that that decimal
so one or you know 100 i mean it's not going to mess up the code if i put 0.00 we don't need to
but so you know that's 100 so if it was that 1500 times one that would be would not change year to
year and since it went down it's times one minus this rate you know we'll just overwrite this
and these are number of homes so we're going to round it down and we're going to say it's 799
you know that 0.005 is you know i don't know that's what five thousandths you know i don't
know they put a few boards there or something on the lot said i started but there we go we're
going to call it 799 and that's how we get this times you know one minus the rate since it
went down and in later weeks we're going to talk a lot more about percent increase and decrease
so this is not the only time you're going to see this and in that case we're going to skip some of
these other percent increase or decrease but on page 73 i want to talk about this percent change
so if 999 changed to 1049 so the amount of change we would just subtract 1049 minus 999
and we see you know we can do that you can do that in your head it's an even 50 cents
but then the percent changes we take that difference over the original number
so if it started at 999 that's the that's the difference so that's the original number
and again we can look at percent change so that 50 cents 0.50 divided by that original number 9.99
so that's we get that difference divided by the original number and as a percent we're going to
we're going to multiply it by 100 because it's the first two digits and even if I were to round it
the next number is a zero so it's really a five percent change there we go and if you really want
it to sometimes people like to put that into the formula times 100 and yeah there we go
there we go as a percent I mean if it's just for your own calculations you don't have to
make it fancier if you're doing this to explain you know costs and everything in some sort of
business proposal yeah it's nice to have the extra bit you know have it display nicely and
people can see oh this is exactly what you're talking about for your own calculations you can
put it all in the print statement and you know see see the output and there we go so if we have
1999 lowered by 10 percent so we're looking at these keywords lowered by and if it's a percent
we need that formula one minus the rate again might be new to think about it this way and
we're going to talk a lot more about it in later weeks but 1999 lowered by 10 percent so
we're not decreasing by an amount so we're not subtracting
its times
one minus three and I can even you know convert this as I'll just put this here one minus
10 remember 0.10 so I put that in there with the extra zeros but you can see that that's where we
get this one minus three if it didn't change it would be that number times 100 percent or times
one but it's times one minus three and then that's the new number there we go and this did not have
any practical connection it was just what's the number if it's a dollar amount then I'll take it
to two decimal places it's 17.99 so that'd be something like you know the the shirt cost
1999 and it was on 10 off so you end up paying 17.99 and knowing how to do these things you know
you have calculator so you can do this you know right there on your phone because you can have
this app you can set up different things for percent increase and decrease and you know you're
in the store oh what would the actual price be and at that point is it worth it there we go
we go and here we have this what about when increased by 40 is 3500 now for this
before I even get to what we're going to calculate I'm going to put a couple comments here
because I don't want the code I just want to show you the math of this if I have some amount which
I'm going to call x increased by 40 percent so if it increased then it's times one plus the rate
and then that would equal that new amount
so you know the the beginning amount or you know x or we can call it the original amount
times one plus the rate equals the new amount and I just put this in a comment we're
just looking at this formula and so if I have this
then the question is what amount number six here what amount when increased by 40 percent is 3500
so that would be x times and when it's one plus three that makes it really easy because it's one
point four I put the zero if I wanted to equals 3500 because one plus point 40 is 1.4
and then in doing this we remember solving for x I'm multiplying so I divide and now really in
the print statement I'm doing this 3500 divided by 1.4 and we see how in setting this up you know
you could write your math in here some notes for yourself the formula you're using and then
plug in the numbers so then we see what's the actual math that we're doing and then
oh dividing by 1.4 so we'll do that and that's the one thing that will print the
others are comments there you go 2500 so we have some of these all right and
I actually want to skip over to this baseball one I skipped over that because I think those others
are more straightforward now let's take a look at making use of you know as you're building these
this notebook for yourself let's make use of the system of equations one so if we look at number
15 the local baseball team sells tickets with two price zones seats behind the plate from first base
to third are priced at twenty dollars per ticket all the other seats down the baselines are ten
dollars a ticket and last night's game 5332 fans were in attendance and the total ticket revenue is
worth 71,000 how many tickets were in each zone so let's call x the good zone behind home plate
those the twenty dollar tickets and let's call y the ones that are further out so we have the two
things we want we want to know how many tickets in each zone so let's think about equations for this
so twenty dollars for the good tickets ten dollars for the lower price tickets and the revenue is
seventy one thousand seven fifty so if we go to our solvent graph and again you might have this
you might have your table of contents jump right to it solvent graph we'll call the variables x
and y and you can even write some more stuff in here and you know delete it later so let's take
a look at this if our two equations are twenty dollars times x number of tickets plus ten dollars
times y how many of those tickets did we sell equals that total seventy one thousand let's make
sure we get it exact seventy one thousand seven fifty so now we have an equation for the revenue
twenty dollars times this many tickets the good tickets plus ten dollars times this many tickets
that are further out equals this how much this much money that but the error now i have two variables
i want to solve this i need another equation so what about that second equation five thousand
three hundred thirty two fans were in attendance so x and y were the number of tickets in each
section so x plus y must equal five thousand three hundred thirty two okay so
in the way we have this set up here we can just set this equal to zero so let's take the first
equation and we're just going to put this twenty times x plus ten dollars times x plus ten dollars
x plus ten times y and then equal to zero i just subtract that other value seven one seven five zero
and then that would be that equal to zero
all right and the second equation set equal to zero so x plus y so i'll do x plus y and then minus
five three three two that would make that set equal to zero and this is the idea you can you can add
other things here if you want to factor and then just setting up these equal to zero is the easiest
way to set it up because remember we already set this up to solve factor it and then graph it
and the graph you know just might help visualize it and when we solve this so there we go
see the solution here and 1843 and 3489 so that's how many of each because when we add these up then
because when we add these up then that's going to be five three three two and there we go that now
we know how many of each each ticket so 1843 people sat you know from first base to third
and 3489 as we expect that's there's more room out there in the outfield and beyond so you know
that's how many people sat out there and now and now we can figure this out
and we see the graph just to see the comparison here
so pretty cool we can we can figure out given this information
how many people sat in each place and who knows maybe if it wasn't totally sold out we can get a
breakdown all right and you know some other applications we'll skip some of the percent
increase maybe we'll take a look at this one here so number 15 from page 84 so if gabriel is famous
for her trail mix recipe let's talk about but the by weight her recipe calls for 50 percent pretzels
30 percent cheerios 20 peanuts and she wants to make two kilograms of this mix so we could
just calculate how much of each she's mixing so pretzels cheerios and peanuts and this one
we could just go right to right to here and before i even get to a print statement
we could just define some variables in python we like to use the underscore so maybe
pretzel weight maybe we'll do pretzel uh pretzel there we go equals 0.5 times two
times two because it was 50 percent pretzels and she wants to make two kilograms cheerios is
going to be 30 percent and peanuts 20 percent so cheerios equals 0.3 times two and then
uh peanuts equals 0.2 times two now we have now we're going to we know that we have the weight of
each of these and you can put comments in there for yourself if you need to and now we want to
uh talk about the cost so there we go if we have the the cost so all of this pretzels times
9.999 and so if we have this our cost equals pretzel times 9.99 because that's how many
kilograms at 9.99 a kilogram plus and we'll look at cheerios 6.99 and peanuts 4.95
plus cheerios times 6.99
plus peanuts times 4.95
so now we have the total cost here and that should be then the cost for two kilograms
fine but the question then asks what's the average cost per 100 grams
so 100 grams compared to two kilograms is divided by 20 and we could do the comparison if we wanted
to also bring it up to the proportion earlier on in this notebook but knowing that this is two
kilograms 100 grams and so it's we can just put this in the print statement cost divided by 20
because that's the cost for 100 grams there we go so how many of each if we're making two kilograms
but then the final question uh we need to divide it by 20 we only want 100 grams
100 grams and there we go 80 cents
which makes sense because if we take a look at the total cost for each of these
yeah when we when we're buying this full two kilograms you know given these rates yeah that's
16 dollars worth of trail mix i mean you know hopefully two kilograms of this this mix
it'll last a while so she just wants to make 100 grams so that's why she is just dividing it by 20
100 grams you know so that people can eat it before it goes stale
there you go 80 cents all right not bad so some other things that we can look at
making use of these calculators that we have we can take a look at things like various like
options for things like green energy and so i i put in here you know just a link to
one thing you know one thing and it was i think i did one solar panel one battery so supposing
you know you want to buy this you know live live off the grid or you know supplement electricity
for somewhere so here's a solar panel charges up a battery and the cost was 245 dollars
and then the output is 110 watt hours now 111 so you can certainly recharge this as as as much as
possible that's just you know that output i normally would then think about this as using
111 watts for an hour and 111 watts that should be enough to charge you know power your laptop
charge a phone few light bulbs also so you know that's something you know you could easily
make use of 111 watts like i said laptop charge phone power a few light bulbs that'll be plenty
and then that way so what what this would be is so the uh electricity very often is in kilowatt
hours because we use so much and that's like 15 cents i think is about the national average
so 111 watts that's you know 10 of that a little bit less so yes that is 1.5 cents so you know this
you know this 111 watt hours and i was thinking you use 111 watts for an hour so that would save you
a 1.5 cents okay now beyond the savings if you're also doing this for the sake of being off the
grid or you know uh you want to run run some stuff like out in the middle of nowhere where you can't
really plug it in well that's the value of this but let's just say you want to compare this to
electricity cost so you know that 245 dollars and if you run this for you know
all you're making full use of all this for an hour then it'd be 16 000 hours and dividing that out
um rough estimate you know doing a little bit of rounding here thousand days you know which is
you know a little bit less than three years and if you do that you could uh you know pay for itself
in a thousand days which for a lot of investments that's not that bad
and then after that free electricity you know you paid for this and all along the way you know
you're saving this money for the thousand thousand days and then after that there you go you've
already saved enough money to pay for it and you get the free electricity i did another one just as
another comparison so this wind turbine i find all these nice you know it's kind of interesting
isn't it you know it's kind of interesting so uh did that not click there we go so this particular
wind turbine that can handle like low winds and it's rated for you know 400 watts but um
the idea is that if it's low wind it might be a whole lot less and somewhere in here
you know it can say 2.5 meters per second low wind speed which should be about five miles an hour
and even at that point it'll turn it'll generate some electricity so let's say we have something
like this and this one was 270 dollars 400 watts but low low wind it may just be 40 watts that's
okay so let's just say you can generate 40 watts for 24 hours because not dependent on the sun
not dependent on the sun you know you could have wind blowing anytime and we round that up to one
kilowatt per day 40 watts it'd be like you know 960 watts we'll round it up because this is all
just an estimate anyway so that one kilowatt hour you know on average costs about 15 cents
so if you have it somewhere where it's low wind there we go that 270 dollars divided by 15 cents
gives you how many days 1800 days so this one would be if it was low wind we're talking like
five years to pay for itself and then after that you know free electricity again even five years
not so bad as a return on your investment but i just happen to mention if you if you do live in
a windy area and let's say you can produce a constant 400 watts you know this is a lot of
places you know especially if you're near like a body of water sometimes lakes ocean bay you know
wide river you could definitely get a consistent wind and if that's the case there you go
and it would only take about half a year to pay for itself because if you're producing this 400
watts that's 9.6 kilowatt hours per day or dollar 44 and then just do that division you know 270
divided by a dollar 44 187 days you know just over half a year and really then enough wind in enough
space hey by three of them and because you're making you know you're generating 400 watts
uh three of them is probably enough to power you know somebody's house like everything so
you know you're you're you're saying you would be saving all that electricity you'd be making use
of the three of them and power the whole house yeah about six months so uh you know the same
that it would be that about that same yeah so really interesting and this is the thing like
you can do these calculations i just wrote them here but you can also bring up the google
co-lab and do these different calculations graph different things if you wanted to see see it and
that that that's the idea with having all all you know all the math calculations you know at your
fingertips you can count you can calculate things and figure out is it worth it for me oh hey if i
spend this much money and then you know generate this for electricity yeah maybe or or you might
say it's not a priority right now and you know that's it but you but you know based on the
numbers so that's that's really some of the some of the uses of of some of the math we've been doing
and you know also making use of you know the co-lab
uh graphing some different things or solving some problems so hopefully this was this was useful
and hopefully this gives you ideas of other things you can do once you set up your your uh co-lab
notebooks and you have the ability to calculate and graph some different things you know make
use of it to see what you can do to make money or save yourself money all right and we'll go on to
the next unit then so let's talk about quadratics so the word quad means square so
why would we have you know quad square but then it's and we call this x squared but yet there's a
two so where does the square come from the square in quadratics comes from the idea
so where does the square come from the square in quadratics comes from the idea and this goes back
to the original algebra back with al-khorizmi so the if i have a square and you know i don't know
each side i'm just going to call them x but then the area of that square would be x times x would
be x squared and that's where that's really where this notion of quadratics comes from you know as
actually tied to physical area the area of a square but there's a lot of other applications
and this comes up so often that we get beyond even the the actual measurements and we can use
this for a lot of other things so we look at the our equation y equals x squared so if i were to
graph this and when we get into the code we're going to get into graphing and we're going to
look at some of those applications too but when i'm going when i graph this anytime i graph a
quadratic it's going to be a parabola and you know it'll probably look like a nicer parabola
than that but it'll be a parabola so that means you know and if we can picture this the positive
values for x give me you know i square them and give me some y value but then the negative values
when i square that negative times the negative makes it a positive so that's why it curves back
around and so you know we keep going up and then these two ends go on as long as you want them to
but yeah the the negative x values get squared so then the y values would still be positive
i still can get negative y values because if in my graph i subtract something you know i can
subtract you know five or something like that so there's definitely some x values there that even
squared are less than five so when i subtract i get a negative y value so you can still do that
but you see the the general trend of the parabola here and they you know kind of look like a smile
but if you have if you have a negative x value
you so any negative x value it looks like a frown so our coefficients here that one would would
be negative so let's yeah let's take a look at this if i had any general
quadratic and this is the general form so if i have the general form of any quadratic would be
y equals ax squared plus bx plus c and that covers all the possible coefficients for
any quadratic equation so a would be my coefficient for the x squared term b would
be my coefficient for the x term and then c would be the constant and if i look at these as long as
a has a number then i can have a quadratic b and c can be zero like the original y equals x squared
oh well there's no x term b is zero c was zero and then the other one i i brought up i put minus
five so then c would be minus five b would still be zero so there we go the general form for
any quadratic and as long as a has a number to it then it's a quadratic a just can't be zero
then it's some some other type so if we take a look at this and you know a is negative it opens
down like a frown a is positive opens up like a smile and the other thing about these quadratics
is they're all symmetrical so the vertex is the point at the bottom or at the top depending on
how it turns up of where the gravel turns around so since it's symmetrical the x value
is going to be this definite formula negative b over 2a so what i have is once i have a b and c
i can plug in my four my values for a and b and get the x value for the vertex and then once i get
the x value i would plug that x value in to get the y value and then i'd have this point and then
that would be the point that if i had my parabola that would be the point at the very bottom where
it turns around and also just looking at that x value remember they're symmetrical so that would
divide the parabola nicely so we're going to look at doing this in the code importing a b and c
and then finding the vertex finding a lot of other things so we're going to make use of the code to
be able to do that so i'm not going to worry about all the factoring here but what i am going to show
you is one other thing that we're also going to look at the code but sometimes it helps to see
this formula is a lot of times when i graph this if i were to graph the parabola you know here's
my x y and you know let's say i have a parabola there i might also be interested in the roots
where does the parabola cross the x-axis and so when it crosses the x-axis then y would be zero
because you know on the axis i'm not going up or down at all so if i have something you know we
would talk about solving for x but if i have something like this yes i have equal zero and
i have one variable which is x how would i solve it we approach it a little bit differently
than we would the other the other ones because when i square root something and that's going
to happen as a part of the process when i square root something the answers the positive there's
positive or negative possibilities because if i had if i had the square if i had let's say
four and then the square root that it's positive four or negative four because if i had or
positive two because if i had two squared that equals four but if i had negative two squared
that would also equal positive four so if i'm going the other way if i have a four and i'm
square rooting yes it could be positive two or it could have been negative two and so when i'm
finding the roots for a quadratic you know setting this equal to zero one of the steps is going to
involve square rooting which gives me a possibility of a positive or negative answer and then that's
where we have you know our two possible answers and so that's how in one formula you know many
quadratics you know the way they cross they're going to cross the x-axis and touch it twice so
to find the roots i want to find out those two values and the formula will give it to us
so again knowing a b and c the quadratic formula
all right so and notice it's that
that vertex plus or minus something and then that's how we use plus or minus square root of
b squared minus four a c all over two a again so this is the quadratic formula that you know
because i have plus or minus it will give it will give me two roots you know i know and we'll see in
the code we would run through this once for plus get that answer once for minus get that answer
there we go but also since i'm square rooting something we're just we're going to stick with
the real numbers here and if i have a negative value under this radical then there's no real
solution so you know we could get into imaginary numbers and you know it's not real solution but
why should we let that stop us but for our purposes we're not going to worry about that
we're going to say that if it's negative then there's no real solution and we're going to
just stop there so in doing this i would often test this we call this part under here the
discriminant and i would often test this you know b squared minus four ac does that is that zero
actually that can be zero which is fine because that'd be plus or minus zero you know that means
it would have one root it would just touch the x-axis that's fine but if it's negative then that
means i have no roots and i would have a parabola that just never touched the x-axis so that's
that's perfectly fine it's possible and in that case i would test that first and if i knew that
then that would save me some time you know not having to do all this because you know if we did
this old school and just factored it all out you know right right in the notebook you know sometimes
it takes a while we're going to look at how to make this a lot easier you know writing the code
we're going to put these formulas in and then we're going to find the roots in the vertex
oh you know maybe we'll even graph them too so this is the formula and notice in math
they're both had the same denominator so i could i could make this all over one denominator
like that works out
you know do the adding or subtracting in the numerator all over one denominator
and mathematically that works out you know it's another way to write it so this is very often
this is the quadratic formula as we would often see it just like this all that all over 2a
all over 2a and so for as complex as this could be there's only a few formulas all right i see this
i get a b and c formula for the vertex formula for the roots we look at graphing it and then
we'll you know then we can look at some of the applications but this is where this is kind of
the essence of looking at quadratics here and so now let's take a look and we'll go into some other
um well you know how to solve these formulas and everything so let's take a look at the code
so solving a quadratic equation is much easier with code because all the formulas that we were
talking about that we would work out by hand we're just going to put them all into the code so
so you can just define a b and c once and then run those values through all the formulas you need
and output your answer roots vertex and whatever else you need so i just picked some values here
that work out uh nicely a b and c and what do we want to do let's first of all just print it
so we'll print out what our function is then we'll calculate the vertex so notice vx i call the
variable and that's the negative b over 2a that's going to calculate the x value and uh python does
no order of operations but this 2a does need to be in parentheses because it is the whole denominator
so we get that x value and then we're going to take that x value and plug that in for the one
for the y value a times and my x value vx and then square it plus b times vx plus c
so i get i plug all that in get the y value and just like before i'll print it now um
there we go we just print the equation now we have the vertex as a point
and we'll go on to the roots and the roots remember the quadratic formula d it works at abcd
but it's actually d is for determinant here that's the part that's underneath the square root
because if that's negative then i won't have any real roots and so i'll just define d as that part
under the square root b squared minus 4ac and then i'll test it here if d is greater than or equal to
zero because if it's not then i'm going to print out no real roots so if as long as it's greater
than or equal to then we're going to calculate the roots and remember it's the rest of the
quadratic formula so since i already figured out d i'll make use of that so negative b plus or minus
so we're going to run through this twice for the first root negative b plus the square root of d
and then all that's over 2a and notice parentheses for the numerator parentheses for the denominator
and then the second root negative b minus the square root of d and then all that's over 2a
so i'll print this out calculate the roots print it out or you know no real roots if that's the case
and there we go so i actually already ran this and what do we have y equals so x1 x2
x2 plus 5x plus 6 and then we have the vertex is this negative 2.5 negative 0.25
and then the roots x equals 2 negative 2 and x equals negative 3
so there we go if all you need to do is solve it it's nice to have all these formulas at the ready
just change a b and c and run it again so if we want to graph it also we can
do everything we were doing plus the graphing part remember our imports for graphing matplotlibrary
numpy i'm also going to import math for some things that we'll do i'm going to define a b and c
i just pick different numbers here and i'm going to print out a b and c so this part is very similar
i'm going to print this out calculate the vertex print that out and now we get into the graphing
so notice i didn't do the roots yet and we just have x min x max you know everything
else we were doing for graphing define the x values set up the plot and now i can graph the
parabola i just called it y1 even though i probably won't have a second y value here
ax squared plus bx plus c there we go i'm going to graph that whole parabola and then that's y1
so i'm going to plot x and y1 then i'm going to plot the vertex as a point so i put this all down
here for the the plotting parabola the vertex point and then notice this one up here by default
it's going to be a line and here i'm defining two arrays each of them with one item and then
that's going to be a red dot so then we're going to find and plot the roots everything we were
doing with calculating the roots from before but i'm going to add this one line here pi dot plot
and once i get the plot i'm going to plot root one root one zero and root two zero and remember
you know the array of my x values and then the y values and this one is going to be a green dot
so that's why it's good so it's going to be a green circle so i'm going to plot that and then
i'm also going to print out the roots because i want to see that too so when we have all this
and then we run it
it'll have your equation here there you go x squared plus four x plus one give you the vertex
and give you the roots now these roots are irrational you know that's why it gets this
wacky decimal we could you know do quite a few more lines of code to get to the
wacky radical answer but we're not going to worry about that now that that's that's perfectly fine
if you're writing this down somewhere you might round it to a couple decimal places
but here we go we plot the vertex as a red dot the roots as green dots you know see where it crosses
the x-axis and then we graph the parabola and so i can redo this then let's just try these numbers
that we were doing before one five there we go six and that's all we need to do change a b and c
and it'll run through and calculate all this there we go x squared plus five x plus six
and here's the vertex negative two point five negative point two five and then the roots
two and negative two and negative three there we go now there we go negative two negative three
where it crosses the x-axis and see the y value of that vertex is negative point two five so it's
two five so it's just below it but just barely and there we go so we can plot our quadratic formula
we can graph it we can get our roots in our vertex and for most things when you're solving
quadratics that's what you want to do so let's take a look at how a b and c actually affect the
graph so i'm going to show you some sliders here and that's going to come up again in one of the
other notebooks so how a b and c so the first thing is we're going to import this and just that way
map plot live in line and we're going to write that first and then we're going to import these
widgets and interactive the same and then the same other things we're going to do with the plot
so the way that these widgets work is we're going to put all the graphing in this function so now
we're going to connect again with functions here i still defined it just as f and that's because
later on i wanted that to be a short name for that line but you'll see so i'm going to define
this f but it's the function of a b and c i'm going to take those three things a b and c as inputs
now you could always make this say quadratic and you know do everything that you want to do
with the quadratic roots vertex we could actually take everything that we were doing before
with the plotting and with solving and put all that in this function at that point i would call
it more than just that if i might say quadratic and take the argument a b and c and do everything
you need so kind of cool that you can do that but here we're just going to focus on the graphing
so my function there we go x min x max all those i'm going to define all these things for graphing
remember a b and c would be the input so we would have those and then plot the the parabola plot
plot the the parabola plot uh the vertex as a point plot the roots as points and um
there we go this all of this here is really just extra for the sake of setting the equation as the
title of the graph i did that instead of printing it out which i guess we could we
could have done but i wanted to show you we could set it as the title of the graph and the title
needs to be a string so here i'm going to take a b and c and convert them all to strings then
i'm going to take all of this and i was you know this doesn't necessarily connect with html
but i was thinking of that h1 for the heading so i'm just going to combine all these or concatenate
all these that exact y equals combined with sa that string and i'm going to combine all these
as h1 but if i just leave it at that it'll still display in a weird way as the title there'll be
like extra quotes and i don't like that so i'm going to just find this other one h2 which just
it's just blank with quotes and that's going to be a string and i'm going to loop through this
for w in h1 you know w like for word in h1 and then h2 equals h2 plus w so i still had to convert
these two strings put it all together as h1 but then i still needed to put it in h2 if i do it
this way combining these now h2 is a nice unified string without a lot of extra quotes and so that's
you know again it's a lot to just it all leads up to the sake of for the sake of putting this
as the title okay and you know we'll see hopefully you know it looks nice and you know you see oh
that was you say oh that was worth it all right so here's where the interactive comes in so we have
this interactive plot now that's just the variable that i chose interactive plot but here's what's
really happening this interactive function so if we take a look at this so it runs this function f
so that's where the name of your function goes and that's where you see how long this line got
i wanted this to be short so i just that's why i called it f so it runs this function and then
that function and then it defines a with a range from one to nine b with a range from negative nine
to nine and c also with a range from negative nine to nine a i started at one because if it
was zero that's actually not a quadratic and i want to illustrate quadratics and so i'll start
at one so we just define this interactive plot and then notice this as the last line of code
then if i just say interactive plot it's going to print it's going to run that
so we'll see this interactive how that makes the sliders here
there we go and it default shows them in the middle and see this is what i wanted it to be
that when it starts out you see the title of the graph y equals five x squared plus zero x plus
zero you see that's it just and if i go if i make that down to one this is the parent graph the most
basic parabola you know x squared and i don't have to put the plus zero but in this case it's
going to write that every time and then we can see what happens if i move c you see
i can move c and it'll adjust the graph it'll adjust the title
of the graph there we go and then we can see what happens if i move b
b you see it moves it along here and now
it got to this point that now where it is i do have roots in the vertex that i can display
and then if i have i can see where b as i move that around
affects this whole graph and i can see then how a affects the whole graph
so we see some different things that we can do and all these are going to be accessible to you
you can tinker with these but this is all you know it was just i wanted to show you this interactive
that you can set up sliders and in this case to display the
display the graph see the roots in the vertex
you see and i move that down so we display the graph see the roots in the vertex and adjust it
with sliders you can see how a b and c affect the graph so knowing this and being able to have all
this code at your disposal you can really see you know most everything that you're going to need to
do with quadratics you know find the roots in the vertex see the graph and you know adjust it and
you know do some other things so there we go this and some practice you'll you'll know
quadratics inside and out
um now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit let's look through some extra problems
and i'm going to work through extra problems using the colab notebook so you can see how you can
apply these resources that you're building and use that use these to solve problems that might
come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life so we're going to go through some more extra problems
here so here we're going to walk through the foundational math certification too and if you
have not already done it please give this a try on your own this is for if you're if you've already
done that and you're stuck or if you just had a question about one of the parts you know we'll
hopefully answer all those and just like the other certifications this one you're going to make a copy
and put this in your uh in your google drive so you know file save a copy in your drive
and this one we're going to focus on building cartesian graphs so most of this is going to
deal with graphing we're going to look at some different functions and what you can do with that
so you make a copy in your google drive it might be in your google colab notebooks folder where
you can put it wherever you want and now hopefully you know i already did that so hopefully
you're now working from your copy and we need to acquire the testing library so the code that you
write just like the certification one the code do you write when you run it it'll run through
it'll run through these tests to see if the code is what it's supposed to be and then give you
some feedback so this first cell you don't need to do anything and you might just take note of
what you need to do here for future reference in case you want to have your own custom library that
you know you include in your colab notebook so this custom library it's on github and this
code is going to get that and save it here in a work in a local working directory so you will
need to run this for each new session as i mentioned before it'll the session will time out
because of an activity after 30 minutes at the most or even if you're busy 12 hours it'll time
out so each new session run this and it'll go through and then import the library so we click
to run yep and see just a few seconds code test passed so there we go
so let's take a look at some coordinates here cartesian coordinates and they're named from
renee decart because that's part of his name cart and you know that's it you know you've arrived
in life when your last name becomes an adjective so he among other things invented this x y
coordinate system that we're familiar with with zero zero in the center and then x moving
horizontally positive to the right negative to the left and y moving vertically positive up negative
down so then each x y coordinate tells you you know how much you're going over and how much you're
going up and we can plot all these points our go-to library is going to be matplot library
and as we were talking about importing your own personal library custom library we needed
to do that in a little bit different ways a few more lines but a lot of the common libraries
uh i say commonly you know reasonably used i've been around a little bit uh behind the scenes
google colab already did that install part so you just need to worry about importing it so you know
we have that nice benefit you know things just work in the google colab so matplotlib.py plot
and we're importing this library yeah that's a mouthful so we're going to import it as plt
that way every time i reference it plt.plt. i don't have to rewrite all this
okay so this is going to be the first thing is the basic just here's a graph there we go and
you probably could change these variables but i don't this is what's in the example
in the documentation for matplot library so i keep these and it does seem weird that you're
assigning two different variables to this but it's you could have multiple subplots we're not
going to worry about that right here but you could have multiple subplots and you know your one graph
could have like nine little graphs in it if you wanted or something like that but so that you
would put numbers in there but we're not worried about that now this establishes that this plot
exists and then plt.show that's always going to be our last thing to show it
you run it and there's our basic graph notice we didn't add anything else um
so there's not nothing going on here and zero zero instead of being in the middle it's in the
bottom left because we're just showing the positive quadrant here so just positive x
values up to one positive y values up to one and that's it and notice all these the
test and yes code test passed if you click the button correctly
so we'll go to step two all right so now we have the standard window still not highlighting each
axis and we're still going to go through import this establish this but now we're going to add
something here so this gives us the size of the graph and i just put this here we're
this would be better we're going to modify this as we go on but
that'll give us the size of the graph 10 in every direction so when we do plot.show
so you see it does give us 10 in the direction and if you follow these
the zero zero exists in the middle here even if you don't see the axis lines and zero you know
positive to the right up to 10 negative to the left down to negative 10 and on the y axis zero
in the middle positive up to 10 negative down to negative 10 so they could line up in the middle
here somewhere all right and this one was one of these that i ask you to change the values then
rerun so it's run this to see what it looks like then change the window size to 20 in each direction
so we go through here and we can just move this 20 20 in each direction
now we notice from this even the one where we only went up to one the size of this graph doesn't
change but we see the lines on the outside do and the tick marks change so now we're going up to 20
in each direction there we go code test passed so some more graph dimensions now this is where
i was saying we're going to modify this this is really what we were doing in that last one
plt.axis so what were those numbers it really was an array of x minimum x maximum y minimum y maximum
as just one group notice the parentheses and then the open brackets so that was an array and that
was that defines the window size so that's why it's plt.axis so i think it just makes much more
sense to define those as variables up here so this line here the plt.axis does not need to change
and then it's really easy for you to then change the window size if you want you just change those
numbers so there we go and this one is not one oh yeah this one is you could run it
notice it should still do the same thing there we go and then we're just going to change these
to 20 in each direction
20 you know and again we see 20 in each direction
so this is going to be our go-to way to set up the graph and as we keep going let's look at those
those axis lines that you might be making and we're going to change these to 20 in each direction
so we have those axis lines that you might be missing i know i was missing them so how do we
want to display these well we have our basic graph and we have the directions here if you
were doing this on your own that the b that we're going to see here makes the line blue
so we have this dimensions that we're building upon and these first two lines there we go
subplots the window size so now we have the plt.plot and that's going to get plot a line for us or
points now in this case we have this array here from x min to x max and then this array here
what this is is a an array of the x values and then the y values so we have
so we have it starts from x min zero and then goes to x max zero
and rather than plot to those two points it plots a line from that point to that point
and with this the line is going to be blue if you don't put something like this in here
python will pick the color of the line for you and then for the y-axis
then we're going to plot zero zero y min y max so what is this telling us it's from
the x value of zero to the y value of y min so from zero y min to zero y max it's going to
draw that line and again i'm forcing it into be this this space here whether you have this
space or not doesn't matter so there we go so these two plot statements these two these two
plot statements define whether you know define that it's going to be a line and then what color
and i even have the comments here so then you see blue x-axis blue y-axis so
y-axis so that's it we're going to show this plot and
we see the x and y-axis
we also see again the the value of defining everything up here because then all the rest
of these the size of the graph and then where these lines go to and from it's all based on
this up top so if i change the dimensions of this then everything else will adjust accordingly and
the axis lines will still go to the ends so we run it and then change b to g
and there we go change to g
b and there we go it's green
so you can make it whatever you want
i just happen to like blue so there we go changing these so now supposing i wanted
to plot a point like we saw that we did that into define a line we're going to plot a point
well see as we continue to build this define these values here and now we're going to we're
just going to end up keeping all of this as the window size and then the x and y-axis and keeping
it blue so how do i plot exactly one point so notice this array of x values of which there's
only one in there and y values so it's five four now here's what else we have it's ro that o makes
it a point in fact a circular dot so if i have just b with nothing that's going to make it a line
if i actually just had r with nothing that would make it a line but it actually has nowhere to go
too so that would be weird but ro makes it a point and we'll see we can plot other things too
so keeping all that the same and just plotting this one point
one point there we go one point and it is five at five four over five up four
now we could put the grid lines in but that'll be another story so now change the location
so the directions run it then change the location to negative five one
one okay so then we just change this to negative five and change this to one
there we go and when we run it
so we see negative five one
all right so plotting a point we indicate that it's a point this way and
plotting a line we have other ways to indicate that
so how would i plot several points
well let's take a look all right so a ray is to plot each point you know that's what we've been doing
and we can still define it as an array here i'm just going to define the array here an array of
the array here an array of x values and an array of y values so if i have these x values and y values
we go down here so notice all that's still the same and here i can plot x y now i chose x y
because you know x values and y values and i did not use exactly x and y as other variables already
so we're okay i mean you really could name these arrays whatever you want
but there we go we have what am i plotting the array of x values the array of y values
and then here i have red points for each of them now right here i only have one l one number in each
so we can add so that's the assignment for this step add two numbers to each so that also graphs
one one and two five okay so the x value would be one and the y value would be one so there you go
so i have point four two and then point one one and the next one two five so x value would be two
y value would be five and there we go all right and changing those arrays now i can plot i still
don't have to change this code plot that array and we see three different points because each of them
because each of them i made a red point so let's mix it up let's plot some points and some lines
okay so that's it hopefully you are noticing the subtle difference between the points and the lines
each plot statements takes an array of x values an array of y values and a third argument to tell
you what you're plotting so the default plot is a line if you actually skip that third argument
it would give you a line and python would pick the color rbg indicate the colors and cmyk actually
also work as just letters and beyond that there's actually a few other colors where you can just
write in the word for the color give it a try you know i'm not gonna list all the possible colors
but yeah give it a try and so these are the colors so then we have if it's a dot it's going to be
ro the o indicates a dot rs you could plot a square and then r with a little carrot symbol
would be a triangle so that if you have different things you're plotting you can mix it up and have
dots or squares or triangles and then of course that combined with the different colors you can
plot a lot of different things on one graph so notice we've already defined these arrays here
and i'll call this one line x line y point x point y so yeah not liney and pointy
and there we go so we have these we'll keep all these defining the graph the same way
and let's plot so if i wanted to plot so the directions are a lot of red line and two green
squares so if i plot here so line x comma line y and we want it to be red and it's a line so there
we go and point x point y and it's a green square gs
so you see if you've been working through the course hopefully this is a review and if you're
coming at this you know relatively new hopefully it's seeming pretty straightforward but then the
more you do this the more you just get familiar with with graphing everything and you know you'll
be able to do this right off the top of your head so we graph this
and we will see so there's the red line from that point to that point and the green squares over here
here so there we go so we see how we can graph a line and different points
okay so here's a scatter plot game and i call this making a scatter plot game
but i kind of made the game so but we could take a look so this is what we want to do we
want to look through this code how can i plot a random point and then you know you're going to
try to guess the point i made the i made this uh you know a smaller axis for whatever reason
and we'll define this once and here's what we're doing each time
if we are we're going to get an x point which is going to be a random number so notice how this
this is going to be good for different games or different things you do import random yes there's
a whole library of randomness and random dot rand int and it gives the range here from x min to x
max from x min to x max and actually the way most ranges work in python x min is a possibility but
x max is x max it will won't go to that it'll go to the number before so y point y min y max
so there we go so you see again if i change these dimensions it will still give me a random integer
that so now if x point is the random integer then i'm going to store that as my x value
store this as my y value and you see essentially it is an array with one element
you know but then and i might have been able to skip this step but i like really spelling it out
you know what what this is and now we go here i'm going to apply as a dot so there we go this
uh gives the grid now this is we you know we had their axis lines this is the grid plt dot grid so
that'll help because the game is going to be here's the point you tell me what the coordinates are
so that's what this is yes and we're going to prompt for input enter the coordinates of the
red point and that's going to be an x y with a comma so we're going to split it at the comma
and that's going to be an array with two elements so then
yes array zero so the first element cast as an integer that's going to be the x guess
and the second element is the y value cast as an integer that's going to be the y guess
and this is part of why i like to break it up here because i have this here these are the points
this defines it as an array but this is the point that we wanted so we test it if x guess equals x
point and y guess equals y point then that's going to increment your score
and there we go all this in the loop and then if statements in the loop now the loop's done
and you know in range zero to three we really because we're including zero we actually don't
need that zero the range will start at zero by default so there we go for i in range
it's going to go through it three times because it'll be zero one two and then
again python ranges if it's range three it won't do three it'll do zero one two and then that's it
it so we go through and guess it three times and then print out the score so the score
was way at the top initialize it at zero and we'll see see what happens here so you see
with the grid lines we can see so zero and look at these four five so the coordinates of the red
point would be zero five and here we have zero negative three zero negative three and this is
why i made it eight in every direction because it actually the grid lines just work out a little
bit better so what's the coordinate of this point so looks like three on the x-axis and then down
three so that would be three negative three all right and there we go you can try this out
it'd be a good way to test your understanding of coordinates
all right and step nine so now if i want to graph a whole linear equation so this was nice if i
define these two points and i can draw a line between them but what if i actually just want
the whole linear equation so numpy is the library we're going to use for that so we're going to
import numpy as np now that one i mean numpy is not that big of a word to write but as np it
just seems to be a common thing so you will see np dot this or np dot that for the different
functions all right and then we have the linspace function so that defines an array of values
an array of values when we're talking about functions we can you know loop through but
this gives us that array and we're going to plot the function with two arguments
so if we take a look at this all these so after we import numpy
same setup for the graph and then linspace
we give this now i purposefully made it a little bit less you actually
we'll get to some other things that we can do with this that'll make it even better but i made it
purposefully a little bit less than the maximum values here on the graph and then the third
argument so it goes from it's the x values is what we want for this so the x value goes from
negative nine to nine and in that there are 36 points so believe believe it or not that's
actually going to be enough which is you know four points you know like every one fourth is a point
that's actually going to be enough and notice then what we're plotting here are x values
and you see that's the array of x values numpy gives us that array so that x values and then
given this i can just put this equation in here as that's the y value each time so as it goes
through this array of x values that y value is going to it calculated each time and then that's
what it's going to plot so then when we run this we see that it actually plotted this point this
this graph there we go two x minus three and yep looks like it crossed there about negative three
and looks like about up two over one etc okay so there we go um
um and we have this run it and then change it to graph negative x plus three so all these can stay
the same now in this case since this was cut off here we didn't really notice that but if we just
then change this to negative x plus three now we see the the limitations of this
here because it cut cut off there so what can we do here well we could in this just make this we've
already defined x min and x max we could actually make this go from x min to x max and you'll see
this come up in the next things we do all right so we can create interactive graphs
so in this case we've been talking about linear equations let's let's use these widgets to make a
slider so we're going to import all these things here now you know numpy for our array of x values
matplot library for the graph for the plot and then we have we're going to import this in line
and then the widgets so we can make all the graphing happen in a function and we have
there we go function of m and b and if you're if you're working through some of the other things
in this course this might be familiar and then we'll see just you know what's the same and what's
different about what we're doing here with this function so if i have this function of m and b
everything happens in the function defining the x values y the maximum the final x values
y the maximum defining all this and in this case we're going to give it a title because
we already know that this is going to be a slope intercept equation so we're going to give it that
title all right and then we have there we go np.lin space and we could always make this now this
time i also rewrote the numbers but you could always make this just x min x max and something
else here so what are we going to do here we're going to plot x and then mx plus b
because these m and b values are going to come from slider and then the function is going to
take that so here's our interactive plot i mean i could have made the variable something different
but the function is interactive and then it takes f what's what function and then m equals so we give
it a range and b equals and we give it a range and we run this interactive plot so
so we can use this
to plot now notice it default goes to zero so as soon as i increase m you see now i have a line
with the slope of two line with the slope of four and then b is still zero but i can move this up
up and i can move it down and we see that i can adjust my graph so it's nice to have these things
that we can adjust a graph all right and then if i'm graphing a system so maybe you are already
graphing system of equations that then hopefully this is a good review if this is new then take
a look at here's one way to graph a system of equations all right same imports and same defining
these now here's where we make it a lot better so how many points do i want i'm just going to take
it also based on this x max minus x min so that's going to give me remember x min is very often
the negative so that's going to give me you know this range and then times two so that might be
enough times 10 that might be plenty for even more complicated graphs so that's how many points i
have that you know there's the range and then times two and then define the x values once and
here we are defining this linspace from x min to x max and then this many points
so we see again we're building these i have this comment in there for you but
pretty soon then you won't even need that and now we again we have
our complete uh our base of what we're importing and then the basics for the graph
so then i can plot two lines you know define y1 in terms of x because i just make my x values
x because that's convenient
and what what am i plotting x and then y1 there we go and in line two notice it doesn't have to be
linear this this plot works you know x squared minus three and what am i plotting the x values
and then y2 and we can see these so there we go all right change y2 and rerun the code
so y2 we're going to make it negative x minus three so we're just going to rerun this as
negative x minus three and we see there we go and with these you know i could define what color i
want these lines to be but without that python gives me the colors light blue then orange you
know it'll go through a few colors and then we'll go through a few colors and then we'll go through
light blue then orange you know it'll go through a few colors and there we go defining
two points so systems of equations you know so there we go that was graphing
two equations and you can graph more if you want systems of equations we're going to import simpy
so the simpy library and we probably don't need to import everything but i do for this particular
example so the import asterisk is going to import everything from the simpy library and we're going
to define these symbols so now i'm going to here i'm going to define x and y as symbols that i'm
going to use to solve so i could define these separately and you'll see in other places that we
do but what do i have i have lin solve and then notice open parentheses because that's the function
for lin solve and then what do i have i have this array of these two equations set equal to zero
zero so that's what you know it would be this two times x plus y minus one equals zero
and then the other one x minus two times y plus seven equals zero so that's how we have to set it
up if i want to solve these two it would be those set equal to zero and then i'm solving for the
variables x and y and what happens when i run it it gives me this negative one three as
as a point that's the solution there we go so one way to solve systems of equations
and if we change these to 2x plus y minus 15 equals zero so 2x plus y minus 15 we'll just
change that and then 3x so remember three times x you know we'll write this 3x but in python we
have to remember to put the multiplying symbol in there minus y so we're going to flip that part
over and that's it just 3x minus y equals zero so there we go and if we run that there we go
39 is the solution
so there you go one way one of the ways to solve a system of equations so graphing a system of
equations solving a system of equations and you may have already gotten to it set it writing the
code to solve and graph and output you know make the output even you know a little bit nicer so
if you haven't already gotten to that you will
so now we can get the solutions as coordinates so as we saw there it returns a finite set
but given that set we can convert that into an x y coordinates so also here
i split out first and second as two different as a way to put these here so now when i have this
solution i don't have to change this code then solve first second and then we define them up here
sometimes that's a little bit easier
now we know that that solution is going to be a finite set so this is how we parse it out
i'll call this variable x solution is solution dot args zero zero and then the y value is going to be
solution dot args zero one and so there we go you don't have to think through like all the different
ways that that's organized especially since you know you think that okay there's only
one x y solution but there's a lot going on here so now i have these and i'm going to go ahead and
so now i have these as x solution y solution and i'm going to print them out x equals y equals
and just for kicks i'll also print it out as a coordinate pair
so see zero zero i mean it works out
because x plus y and x minus y so they would cross a zero zero
so there we go again another way to then elevate that and solve it
just showing you different different ways that you can parse these things out
now we can even get the system from user input so i'm going to print for anybody
you know this remember to use python syntax and then notice how each equation is already set equal
to zero because i'm going to prompt for the input here first and the first equation and then second
and the second equation and i'm not even casting these as anything i don't need to because then
linsolve works out like that there you go first second and then parse the solutions so
let's do this as long as as long as two things set equal to zero and i do want an x and a y so
so i will have three times x
plus four minus y so if you think about things in terms of y equals then you could just
put a minus y here so three x plus four minus y okay
and i just hit enter and it jumped down so now the second equation and we have
all right so what if i have five times x
what if i have five times x
plus five here we go and notice the space minus y
here we go hit enter it jumps down and there we go we have an x and a y solution
pretty cool
all right and then solving graph which
which in in this whole course the solving graph we have the
you'll see as we build and you know you get more and more familiar with all the different
ways to solve and graph then you'll see that we can get more and more elegant solutions
here we're going to import matplot library and simpy and numpy so we're using all of these
so this one here we're just doing this with linear equations and knowing that it's linear equations
notice i'm only asking for m and b separated by a comma so i'll call that input mb1 because then
i'm going to split that and make that an array and from that i'm going to take
the first one and that must be m and then the next one that must be b so we see that you know take
this input i wanted it separated by a comma so then we're going to split it at the comma so that
input is a string splitting the string makes the array and then now that array the first one is
array the first element element zero i'm going to cast it as a float called m1 and then element one
the second element i'm going to cast it as a float and that's going to be b1 and we're going to do
the same thing for the second one m and b and then everything's going to be the second mb2
split it at the comma makes that array and then that array the first element cast as a float m2
second element cast as a float b2 and now that i have these
i can solve it so here we're using simpy to solve it because i'm going to say that first equation
i'm going to give it this variable first is this because i know it would be something in y equals
mx plus b so it'd be m1 times x plus b1 and then minus y that would be that set to zero
and then there's the second
and then linsolve first second and then i'm going to just in case there's
just in case there's a weird solution i want to take that solution
to three decimal places so i'll take that solution cast as a float and then round it to three decimal
places for many things you know i might not need it but i give that option so that you know whatever
comes up it works so there we go solution i'm going to find these solutions three decimal places
um three decimal places round them and now i have these the x solution and the y solution
so then to make sure the window includes it rather than give it to be my normal
my normal window and this is a float so if i cast as an integer
and then i can add 20 subtract 20 you know i gave it each of these so that way each of these
solutions i cast it as an integer and i know that my graph is going to include that solution
and then given these you know points how many points do i want and then
and then graph x because i already used x in other places so graph x is the value
for my x values so there we go min max how many points
and here's my y1 is m1 times graph x plus b1 and everything here for the weight y2 m2 times
graph x plus b2 so then when we set up the graph and line one there we go graph x y1 and line two
and the point so now i'm going to plot the point which is x solution y solution as a point
okay so that way whatever equations we have and then print out the value
so if we take a look at this x solution y solution we run this
this first equation all right so let's see let's call it three five
and let's call this one
negative one
one oh because i didn't put the comma
so three five and negative one
and there we go six
six
so we have these and we see these points this is the solution even though it showed up
as not a nice integer decimal numbers but then we see the graph and then we see the point where
they intersect and these are kind of the things that we want to build upon this is actually one
good way to plot and graph where if you know that it's linear then just prompt for those coefficients
and we can do that for other types of types of functions you know when we get to the
when we get to all the parent graphs and all the different types of functions
you see that this is one way we can prompt for you know if it's that type of function prompt for the
coefficients and then that works out to solve use those coefficients to generate something in
simpy to solve and use them again in that plot library to graph and then we can plot the point
display the answer all right pretty good
right pretty good
so the next thing we have is quadratic functions when it's not a linear equation
anymore not not a nice straight line so anything that involves x squared
is a quadratic so x squared because it could be the area of a square i don't know the measure of
the side but i know that the area would be that side times itself so if i if i have x squared in
there there's going to be a parabola and here's the simplest here's the the root formula ax squared
plus bx plus c so b and c could be zero they can be any number including zero a has to be a number
because if a was zero then i don't have a quadratic
so then you know there's the simplest one so now let's take a look at this
back to our graphing setting up our points you know range our points linspace all this to set
up the graph and i'm just going to have a basic y equals x squared so there we go x y y equals x
squared and if we run this that's the most basic parabola so a in that case would be one and b
a in that case would be one and you see it does touch it zero zero all right the most basic parabola
so now quadratic function abc's let's take a look at abc and let's you let's go back to our interactive
and we're going to use these widgets so
so this one here all right you have a and b but we forgot c and we could have also
put the values on you know in a different way but just did it this way that's fine
now notice here it's our interactive that we want ab and c so we're going to run this function f
f and we see function here of ab but i want ab and c so
that's that's going to be your that'd be your assignment add c to the slider
so there we go out here comma c equals and then i'll do the same values negative nine comma nine
nine okay so there we go so now i have this interactive i'm going to have three sliders one
for a one for b one for c and then when we define the function abc it needs three as the input
and the plot is going to be ax squared plus bx and then we have to remember we also have plus c
so now when we run it now it's all zeros that doesn't look like anything but as soon as a
as soon as a is something now we have a parabola whether it be one now we can just take a look at
what does a do to the parabola you see as a gets bigger the parabola gets narrower
and zero we don't have a parabola but negative values it flips it so positive like a smile
negative like a frown and there we go so let's let's have a positive so now what does c do
i'm going to skip over b for a second what does c do notice the parabola keeps the same shape
and c just moves it up or down
and could be zero that's fine it just touches it zero zero so that's what c does it moves it up or
down the y-axis and then b is the most interesting it moves it down and stretches the parabola a
little bit now watch what happens when we move it so that was a very negative
but now when b if b is zero it's symmetrical on the y-axis but then it goes around and then now
positive b value stretches on this side so there we go some interesting things about the quadratic
the a b and c and what they each do to the graph
so this bottom part or if it's flipped over that'd be the top part where the turnaround happens
that's the vertex so that's the point where the parabola turns around and the x value i'll give
you the formula here negative b over 2a so the parabola turns around and the x value
negative b over 2a so then given those inputs
then we're going to create the parabola now this i even have the comment here
because certainly i can print x with the two asterisks for the exponent but this is
um just another fancier way to output this and you'll see it'll come out as an exponent
it'll look like an exponent so supposing then we just prompt for these input values
we know we know we're doing a parabola so we just prompt for these input values all right then
then what would be the vertex well the x value was negative b over 2a so that's exactly what we're
going to do negative b divided by and the 2a both all that needs to be in the denominator so i do
need the parentheses so negative b over 2a because if i don't it'll divide by two then multiply by a
do an order of operations now if i have that value then given that value what do we have that's the
x value so we have a times and remember the general form of probably ax squared but what do
i have i have vx is my x value squared plus b x so that'd be vx because i want the x value of the
vertex plus c so there we go so i use this a b and c to get the x value of the vertex
and then i'm going to plug that in to get the y value of the vertex and then we can plot it
and then x minimum so for whatever we enter we'll just make sure that that does show up on the graph
so counting whatever these values are and you know there you go take it as an integer
take it as an integer and that's 10 minus 10 there we go and it's going to plot this point
so notice just that x value just that y value as a red point and
i probably could have done this based on x min x max but just doing this anyway notice
the lin space just giving us that enough before and after it and then here's the y value so then
we plot x y without the third argument by default it's going to be a line and then python will pick
the color so let's see let's take a look so it's going to show us you see that's ax squared you see
that little two that was the whole idea to get it to be that fancy so ax squared let's just try this
one a is one and b is let's say negative negative five and c is six how about that
so we see the vertex and the vertex is 2.5 negative 0.25 and we see the parabola and then
we see the vertex plotted so pretty cool and that's it just same formula so if we just prompt for
those coefficients and run it through those formulas we can plot this this graph just like
we did the linear equation plotted for m and b we can do a quadratic and plot for a b and c
so you know we could we could do this again and see some different graphs so now let's take a look
at how to apply these parabola qualities to projectile motion and yes everything going
through the air is a projectile and they all actually make the path of the parabola
pretty interesting it can't not be a parabola so as we look at these the path of every projectile
the graph of this that we're going to look at is going to be for something thrown up in the air
straight up in the air so in this case the a value is going to be negative 4.9 each time
because it accounts for gravity and that would be in meters per second squared so we know that
the a value stays the same the b value represents the initial velocity so that'll change depending
on how hard you throw the ball up in the air or launch something so that gets their initial
velocity is b and then the c value is the initial height so c would be zero if something started on
the ground you know like kicking kicking a ball and if it was on the ground you know the path of
the ball is a parabola and then in that case c would be zero the initial height in meters so
we have our classic quadratic ax squared plus bx plus c and in that case x is going to be time in
seconds and then y is the height at any given time so let's take a look at how this is similar to
what we were just doing but a little bit different so a stays negative 4.9 so i don't even need to
prompt for that if it's a projectile that's going to stay the same the initial velocity
i'm going to prompt for it and cast it as a float because remember the input will come in as a string
so rather than just say oh what's b i'll prompt it as initial velocity and then c would be initial height
now once we have those you can and i already did copy the vx and vy code from the last step because
the equations for the vertex are exactly the same so you know once we have these then we use the
same formulas vx and vy then if i'm going to graph it i'm going to change these now our default is
always 10 in every direction just seems like a good starting point but really we just are going
to be concerned about positive values here so i made x min negative one just that little bit
negative just so that you can see the axis same with y min made a negative one just so that you
can see the axis but any negative values won't apply here now because these were float values
up here so how do i get these well the x value i'll tell you this all these parabolas are symmetrical
so the x value of the vertex is exactly right down the middle sometimes we call it the line of
the middle sometimes we call it the line of symmetry so it's symmetrical so whatever that x value is and
we know we're dealing with all positive values here so whatever that x value is of the vertex
i'm going to double it so that's why i have two times vx so there you go get that x value double
it i should be at the end but i just added 20 just to be sure we see the end of it to you know and
maybe a little bit more it just gives a good perspective on the graph so that's it take that
x value double it i decided to add 20 but then we have to cast it as an integer because the other
ones came in as float values and your dimensions here have to be integers so there we go and then
sit with the y value i'll take that vy and yep that's the vertex that's going to be the highest
point of our projectile and i'm just going to add 10 to it i figure that's plenty just enough so that
you can see see this and it's not right at the edge also casting it as an integer because these
need to be integers so this should look familiar we don't need to change this i only i actually
changed this to four just to give you know four times this just just in case to make sure our
graph isn't choppy two might even have been enough but there you go four should be a nice smooth curve
to the graph and there we go we define the x values same function we've been using before and
then that that that will work again we need these to be integers for this okay and define the y
value as our quadratic ax squared plus bx plus c so now we're going to plot that same stuff we've
been doing plot and then we're also going to plot you know a red dot for the vertex and display it
so all this is going to be very similar but you'll see the prompting is a little bit different and
then the graph the scale will be a little bit different so when we run it initial velocity
uh let's call it 40 and initial height two so this could be something like a baseball that you throw
up in the air you know you could probably throw it at 40 meters per second straight up and then
by the time you release it yeah it's about two meters off the ground and so we see these and you
see these and you could always round these i didn't for this but you always could round these numbers
but we get the value of the vertex now what this means in time is that just over four seconds after
you throw the ball up in the air it will hit its maximum height of a little more than 83 meters
83.6 meters so there we go if you could throw a ball you know that that hard and you see it the
reason i have the negatives you see the blue for the for the axis so you know if you could throw
a ball at 40 meters per second then uh straight up and you know there you go wow it can reach
you know 83 meters in the air and then time wise you know four set four seconds or so in is good
where it's going to hit its highest point and then a little more than eight seconds it'll hit the
ground so there we go we can see what our parabola would be and you can use this to you know estimate
different things relating to parabolas whether it be a ball thrown or a rocket launched
yeah there we go so see i i just broke this out as you know see if everything else stays the same
see just shifts the graph and here we're going to import all these to display this and rather
than put a slider just decided to make this and i made it a negative so we take a look at this
take a look uh our x values and then we plot we decided to make create this c value c equals
and if we take a look so what do we want in in this range
i'm going to actually didn't use c itself as a as a variable before this so i can use that for c in
this range then i made it negative x squared plus c and then what are we going to do we're going to
plot it you know to find the x values ones up here and here's the y value plot it c value
and this just i did that just for the sake of setting the title you know there we go
so you'll see how you'll see how that comes up in the title and we're going to display
and this little this little display here you'll see how that that just makes it play out the
the notice i don't have the defining x min max y min y max this uh plt dot gcf will actually
just make the graph fit and each time so here's a python sleep method the argument is actually
just in seconds sometimes sleep methods are in milliseconds this one's just in seconds
so i wanted to display that and then wait a half a second then clear the output and then
and then wait so you'll see it'll display this and then clear the output
so you see
so all those different c values we can see it grow and we can run this again if you want to see this
so all those different c values and notice the the y-axis changed each time because it accommodated
the larger graph so we can see that value all i have to do is you know increment c
and it's the same shape it just moves up there we go
okay so we found the vertex but the quadratic formula since we're dealing with quadratic
equations what does this do this gives you the roots now if it was a protractor
now if it was a projectile that would be when it hits the ground so you know that's a good way to
think about it you know ground level is the x-axis and then you know the roots where does it hit and
then you know like roots of anything growing you know wants to go below but we can call them the
roots they are the x-intercepts because it's where the line intercepts the x-axis or we can call it
the zeros because y equals zero so you'll see it come up with all these different things so now
if i know a b and c here's the formula if i were to write it not in code so that if i know you know
what x value makes y zero that's the question so that x value would be negative b plus or minus
the square root of b squared minus four ac and all of that over two a and notice we have the plus or
minus because somewhere along the way deriving this you do a square root and then the square root
you have two possible answers so that and that's what it gives you the two possible answers here
but also notice this is the common way you write it but this it's the vertex plus or minus something
so we often write it like this you know all over one denominator but if you split it up this is the
vertex you recognize that formula plus this and then the vertex minus this so you see that's
another just another way to write it whether you split it into two fractions or put everything
together over one denominator but when you write it this way then you can see that's the vertex
plus or minus something and again we were saying that x value of the vertex is right in the middle
so it would make sense that that value right in the middle and then plus something and then that
value minus something you know that's where we get our two roots you know they're symmetrical
you know they're symmetrical all right so given a b and c we have this formula to be able to
find the roots now
i have again here i'm just going to import math because i need that for the square root
and i have it printed out like this where i just have the comment to remind you that that just
prints two as an exponent i think that's just a little bit nicer and so i looked that up and
found how to print that out nicer so you're going to print this and it's going to be showing you
all right ax squared plus bx plus c equals zero and given that then you're going to prompt for a
b and c so there we go now here this is where you're going to check so i just put these here
we'll define these variables here they're zero but we're going to overwrite them not here but
a little bit later because i want to define these variables that they exist outside of this if
statement but i want to run it through this if statement here now notice what this is b squared
minus four times a times c because remember that's what's underneath the square root here
and if that was negative then your answer is imaginary because you can't square root a negative
number now certainly you know some mathematicians you know years ago decided well why should we let
that stop us if they're not real but for our purposes here we don't want a negative under
the square root we're not going to go into imaginary numbers so we're going to test if this
is less than zero then we're going to print no real roots and this there's a word actually for
this stuff that's underneath the radical here and that's the discriminant because if b squared
minus four ac if that was less than zero then there's no real roots if that actually equals
zero then this plus or minus doesn't mean anything because plus zero minus zero it's the same thing
so if that equals zero then there would be one root and then any other number then it would be
two roots and i think that still comes out the most common it's going to have two roots but
these other options come out often enough no real roots what that looks like in the graph
is a parabola that does not touch or cross the x-axis so you could have that you know
just parabola and it opens up and crosses early you know at some higher y value
you so that's the discriminant and knowing that tells us you know if it's negative if it's less
than zero then there's no real roots it if it if we only have one root if equals zero and there's
only one root we're just going to print that out twice and not worry about it so how are we going
to translate this this quadratic formula into this well we're going to do x one and two we're
going to do the very similar thing just one's going to be plus in the middle one's going to be
minus so let's try this so we have negative b let's do the plus side first plus math dot sqrt
of b squared
minus four times a times c
c all right now all of that remember was in the numerator so i'm going to put parentheses around
all this as the numerator and then divided by our vertex
two divided by two a
okay so order of operations all this stuff python will know but then since i have numerator and
denominator i'll put everything in the numerator in parentheses and then everything in the
denominator in parentheses and then the second root i can really just copy this
and paste it here but the difference is it's going to be minus
there we go so now a lot of things you can do that you know in solving a quadratic very often
we already did the vertex and that and finding the roots these are really common things that
you need to do with a quadratic formula so having this there we go showing that display
so let's just try numbers that work out pretty nicely one and we have to do five and six let's
try that look at that the roots are negative two and three good now i pick those that works out as
nice integers but this will still work if you have you know like one five and let's say five
you see it does have roots definite real roots but since it doesn't certain ones don't work out
and there's actually like a more complicated square root answer for this
this that could be a bonus bonus thing to do to output that square root answer
so there we go the roots are this and this and you could always also
expecting you know that you might have some weird irrational roots you could round it to you know
three or four decimal places and i'll leave it up to you if you wanted to to you can put it put this
all together and have something where whatever the application you can prompt for a b and c
get the roots in the vertex and graph it you know as well as displaying the roots in the vertex
so you know just to show you you know we can put these two things together you know some
interesting things you can try so sometimes the graph i like the graph but i know it's a parabola
i'm much more interested in just a table of values so in this case and just for the sake of it
i made this linear so here we go we have this now notice i didn't have
a fig dot or a comma x i just have x equals so i'm not going to need the figure
here the graph i just want this because this plt dot subplot in matplot library that's that's
going to give us a table and access off right because i just want a table so here's our table
we're going to we're going to give it a title we're going to run this and then change it
and notice how this works i can define my columns and i could use another variable but i just made
it cols for columns so i can define my column headings and then each row notice it's a tuple
tuple of values so in this case in the first row x is zero and y is zero
and then what i can do is in this case since i have this for a in range i just decided to make
it from one to ten here's what we do rows dot append and then i'm going to append my x and y
values you see so x is my a value whatever that's going to end up being well it's going to be one
then two then three and then two a you know just something simple for the y value so this is this
is how you can get a table of values rather than graph it you can put it in a loop and append each
row so you set the columns set the first row and then append each row so now outside of that loop
x dot set title i've already defined it up there and then take a look at this plt dot table
and it takes the argument cell text equals rows column label equals calls cell location and you
know i feel like that's uh that location's you know okay this goes all the way over here and we
just close the parentheses there just to show you so it's still this last direction plt dot show but
what we're showing is a table instead of a graph and you see how it looks now you could always do
both so you know that would be that would always be something you could do you do both table on
table on the graph but who knows maybe you want one or the other and it as this is leading to
data science this is like an introduction there's some things you can do to generate a table values
or things like that but as you get into you know in the next math course and then certainly
when we get into the stats course we're going to look at like all different ways to make tables
so this is just one way and you can we'll see even more ways but there we go so y equals 2x
there we go and you could always make this quadratic or whatever you'd like it to be
again just for simplicity to illustrate the table itself i wanted to keep it we'll just call it y
equals 3x plus 2 and where do i need to put this well this is just because i wanted to display the
correct thing so that's going to be the title and here i this is where i'm going to take it and
a is my x value so it would be three times a plus two there we go and we run it
it you know and zero zero five ah now zero zero actually should because since this is plus two
now one of the things you can do is you could keep this and then start the range at zero
and remember for the range at zero you don't need to put anything if that that would start at zero
or you could just say oh i know what this initial value is going to be let me just put that here
so you know a couple different options there
so there we go
so there we go we have our table okay so different ways to display and i just wanted to you know
have a nice an interesting uh mini project here so we have the quadratics and we're talking about
projectiles so we could have you know we could we could you could make a projectile game
um so what this would be is remember knowing where you're you're starting from you could uh
randomize the height and location of a wall and you have a toy rocket that must clear the wall
so you can you know the game would be determined what initial velocity
would get the rocket over the wall and you could take it even further that bonus animation
path or you could you know there's some other things you could do so i left this here for you
to write but i'm going to show you here's one thing you know one one way to do this
so we imported all this stuff and actually a lot of the things i took from
uh one of the earlier steps where you're graphing a projectile so i took a lot of things from there
and i'm also going to import random and import math so here i just now i i made this a modification
so this is the what it will print out it just has to land so many meters away so you could um
randomize also like h for the height of the wall i just made it the location of like a finish line
so here's this random integer between one and a hundred and then it's going to print that a toy
rocket has to land this many meters away and then we'll go through so here we go um
so input initial velocity and instead of it it's zero zero it could i just put it made c1 it
you know just because but it really could be zero and then same things we want to represent
the vertex here and the x min what i would do is x max now i just made this 200 because
i know that the wall is going to be you know anywhere between there and 100 and you know
i just left it as that so and the y maximum i left it so that you could see where the
projectile goes but we could always go back to what we were doing before and copy the y minimum
and y maximum the same thing where we get this that where we get x min x max we could always copy
we could always copy these because that's what we want to do here we want to put these in
and that was that was the idea i want you to you know make use of code you already have that's
these these later steps that's really what what it is i want you to make use of code you already
have and then maybe modify it a little bit there we go we could have now this would be fine
because wherever that wall ends up being or the the finish line this is still gonna it will still
print everything and that'll be fine there you go path to the projectile and then here we have
the lot the line for the distance and i'll just make it a red line and so notice i just have
i just have it go all the way up to the top here location my two x values and then from zero up to
y maximum so that's just going to be a line if you wanted to also make it a wall so you could make
you know h equals and we'll do the same random integer
where do i want this to be i want this to be i don't want um
a hundred's probably plenty you could even make it a thousand
um you'd be surprised you know these rockets um
um has to uh uh clear a wall
so many meters away and there we go so if h would be the height and then down here
the height of the wall would just be h so that's the slight thing in looking at this a lot of
times the wall the scale of us the wall end up being so tiny but it's fine we'll uh we'll keep
that there so there we go so the line and plot the parabola now notice i have the roots and i
pick just one of them and as it turns out because of the way you know a is negative the the negative
b minus is the root that we want that's the one that's going to for the for our purposes here
that's the one that's going to be greater than the parabola so notice you you could you know copy the
quadratic formula again and the way it displayed i wanted to round this one so round to two decimal
places so here we have if root two is greater than or equal to location i wanted to print out the
distance i wanted to print out the distance and then tell you success and if not missed it by that
much here we go all right so this is it there is actually no test for this but you could see so
here we go a rocket has to clear a wall 85 meters away initial velocity and you could say oh okay
my initial velocity 300 and then we see that initial velocity is 385 meters away and you see
then we're still we didn't clear it so missed it by that much and you can run it again now other
things you can do with this so 19 meters away i'm still going to just really increase the
velocity of 250 let's make sure we clear it you see and we see the wall here and oh boy yes we
did clear it now some of the other things you can do is you could take this even further and knowing
that distance take that as your x value of your vertex and you could write a formula that would
always make a parabola that perfectly that perfectly clears this this wall that'd be pretty
interesting or you could modify this game to say that it has to actually get to a certain distance
um not necessarily that distance or more but maybe you say all right you have to hit a target that's
exactly 50 meters away and you don't want to miss so that would be an interesting thing because then
you could you could actually write the code and i'll leave that to you as you know as for something
as for something you could write the code to calculate the projectile that will land exactly at that spot
so there we go now for this you know upward motion one of the ways you could take half of that
you know whatever the distance half of that and then that's your x value um
of the of the vertex and you can use that to calculate you can you can use that to calculate
some formulas and as i said we'll get even better formulas as we get into pre-calc because
we will do things to adjust the angle and such to get it to be exactly a distance but there you go so
so showing you how to make a projectile game i think it's pretty interesting you know the
you know that you could and you could even make it you know like loop through this and you know you
have to how many ones do you get correct but there you go the projectile game now continuing on this
the this is going to be more like the open-ended part all the things that we've been doing
you you should put this together in a function that will graph or that will graph or display
a table solve a system of equations now if you've been working through everything else in this course
you might have some of this already put together and that's where this uh the certification project
here is you know hopefully you've built up to this so you know you get to this point you're like okay
i know how to do this and i have some of this stuff in place so they kind of just put it together to
organize it use some of the code that you've already made you know you want to have all these
different functions because then you get to the certification project too and you're going to uh
display you know this is what you want to do build the calculator that does this display the graph
and a table for any y equals input cool and you can make that prompt for input or something just
very clear in the code that you know here's where the equation is solve a system of equations without
graphing graph two equations and plot the point of intersection so there we go that's going to be
pretty big you know graphing the two solving and graphing and given a b and c plot the roots
in the vertex so that'd be some things you know we've been doing some things with linear equations
do some things with quadratics enter a b and c see the graph plot as well as the roots in the vertex
maybe also print them out you know solving and graphing systems of equations
showing the table and then you have you know these projectile games you have the projectile
game you have the scatter plot game you can even modify that scatter plot game and make it
you know something else that might be interesting so there you go so you have the things you've been
working on you put it all together to build this graphing calculator and that's going to be the
certification project and by now you're even deeper you know what you're doing in algebra and
we're about to then have some more twists and see some more complicated equations some more we can
do with this all right
so what do we mean by parent graphs and we'd have heard this in code the parent or child that the
child graphs have everything that the parent graphs have plus some other
additions and so these paragraphs are the basic patterns that other graphs then add to or change
so let's take a look at this the one the most basic would be y equals some constant which i'll
just call c here and so that would be this blue line here just a flat line no slope you know like
y equals three or y equals four or something like that it could even be negative but that's it
nothing else and whatever the constant is it's always going to be the same so that's why we
call it a parent graph and whatever the constant is that graph's going to have that same look
you know flat no slope you know nothing else going on just y equals some number
and that's why it's a parent graph because that's like the basic pattern now we were talking about
things like y equals mx plus b well the paragraph for that is y equals x just y equals x so notice
b is zero and just that basic it's not y equals a constant because there is a slope to it but
right the paragraph is just y equals x and then we can get like y equals you know two x plus one
or anything like that we can have other things so this wouldn't add anything this could add two
things you know i have a slope or i could have a different intercept you know so there we go
this so that's the parent graph another one i wanted to show here because i think the drawing
of this works better than somehow sometimes how it plays out with python but this is the floor
function and so it's this step function some people call it step function floor function
greatest integer but the floor is when you're not rounding you're just dropping the decimals even if
it's 0.9 doesn't matter we're just dropping all the decimals so it's the same value so here all
these decimals it's zero until i get to one now it's one and then 1.1 1.2 it's all the same
until i get to two so that's it there there are no in between points here it's just that integer
and then at the next integer it jumps up so again that's a parent function and the floor function
the ceiling function where no matter what it is i go up to the next number or the round function
they're all very similar looking graphs just shifted a little bit so that's why that's again
a parent graph we talked about x squared as a parabola and i didn't worry about drawing the
even the axes for these because i want to get the idea of this general shape and then x to the third
it's kind of like half this parabola bends down now the reason why i just have these is because
as you get into like x to the fourth x to the fifth all the even exponents if it's just the parent
graph look more like this all the odd ones look more like this but then if i have other things
going on in that graph so remember x squared could have ax squared plus bx plus c now if i
had other things going on it's still a parabola but it's a little bit different shape parabola
maybe it's like a little bit narrower a little bit wider or it moved somewhere else but it will
still be a parabola the x to the third if i end up with x to the third plus other things in there
then that those curves get a little bit deeper
or you know that's you know again paragraph and then beyond that we get some other things
and we'll take a look at some of this in the code too and the same with if i had x to the fourth
so x to the fourth is going to look more like this maybe a little flattened in the middle
but if i had x to the fourth plus a bunch of other things in there you know plus three x squared
something else times x you know all these other things that could have three turnarounds at the
most you know x to the fourth could turn around one two three times and you know might not be
always perfectly symmetrical but if all the if all the exponents are even then it actually would be
symmetrical kind of cool it works out that way so these other graphs we have the paragraph but then
we could have other things going on and i didn't want to draw a lot of this here because i want to
talk mostly about it when we get to the code because that way we can see the graph and the
way python displays the graph is going to be much better than my drawing we get the sense of the
parent graphs these are the basic patterns the simplest pattern of that type of graph
and then we can look at what what else we can change or add to to each function and then how
that affects the graph so let's take a look at the code so here we're going to look at all the
parent graphs and the code to create them and they're all going to start out with the same
setup we've had so far for setting up any plot mat plot library numpy set up our dimensions
our points set up the graph so this simplest one is a just a constant y equals five or if y
equaled any constant number notice x is not even in there just y always equals five so when i plot
this in the same way that i'm plotting the x-axis i'm just going to have this plot minimum from the
minimum to the maximum and then y is just always going to be five in this case i'm going to make it
a red line and that's what it looks like it's a flat line there's no slope because i don't have
that whole part of the equation no x value and y is just always five and it would be the same if
y equals you know seven point five or y equals two or you know anything flat line no slope
no slope so that's a constant graph
and then the linear graphs we were talking about linear graphs but this is
the simplest linear graph y equals x so anything else i do with that you know at have a slope
in this case it's y equals one x so the slope is one plus zero so the y intercept is zero
so again the simplest and then anything else i do that is an offshoot of this parent graph
so there's our simplest and notice everything else i do to set this up and how do i plot it
my x value and then the y value is x so there we go x x and there's my y equals x graph
the slope is one and it just goes on the diagonal like this there we go
so every point here you know three three four four five five etc
so the quadratics we were looking at quadratics this is this basic quadratic graph
y equals x squared so before i do anything else to it that's just enough to make it a parabola
and here we're plotting this my x values and then the y value is x squared
and there we go
so our parabola so in this case you know x squared so a is one b is zero c is zero that's all we have
and then any other thing we do to the x squared you know add other things x squared plus you know
uh three x plus four or something like that or some you know whatever else we would have
is uh an offshoot of this paragraph so there we go and i can make it negative and change that
and we see the negative a flips it upside down so we have you know negative like a frown positive
like a smile so i'll go back to the smile there we go again the basic paragraph x squared
x squared and then a cubic graph y equals x to the third so the quadratic is x squared because
it's like the area of a square if i know the sides the cubic x to the third because it's like the
volume of a cube if i know the sides so setting up the graph here and uh the comment we'll talk
about later just starting out with the basic x to the third and we see the graph looks like this
so some you know some of these you know i could sketch it out enough to show you but we see it
kind of looks like a parabola with the left side flipped down but not exactly and this is the
simplest cubic graph so what i wanted to show you is also supposing we have supposing i just
have other things so plot the x values and supposing i had like x to the third minus two x
squared minus three x plus four you see i can have all these other things going on in the graph
and this is how it affects the cubic graph you see it gets these deeper turns that were just
kind of flattened out before but x to the third is going to turn around at the most twice so there
we go we see these possibilities here all right so again you know now this is not a parent graph
this is you know a more complex graph the parent graph still is x to the third so we're going to
so we go x to the fourth and yes they have a name too quartic so x to the fourth and all of our
even exponents so we see i'm just plotting x to the fourth all the even exponents look a lot like
this so x to the fourth if i also had like x to the sixth notice how it's similar and i probably
need more points to make this look smoother but you get the idea now this this is where it gets
beyond what i can graphs what i can draw so i like showing showing up with the code but all these
even exponent graphs uh we might be able to do x to the eighth and it a lot look horrible
that looks kind of horrible so x to the fourth is probably the last good one
other than that then we have to change you know how many points we're doing to really make
it a lot smoother but that's where it kind of looks like a problem it just flattens out more
around zero and all of the even exponent parent graphs will look like this and i also could have
x to the fourth plus other things and then the graph would look totally different that could
go up and down as many as three times i could have as many as three turnarounds and quintic
you thought we were going to run out of names but nope x to the fifth we have a name for that
quintic all right so x to the fifth and when we look at this there we go x to the fifth
looks a lot like x to the third so all the odd exponent graphs are going to look a lot like this
but again just a little bit more flattened out and if it's just this if i have x to the fifth plus
other things then the graph could be all all over and it could turn around as many as four times
but there we go so all the even graphs are like x to the second or fourth it's symmetrical about
the y-axis and kind of looks like a flattened parabola all the odd graphs look like this x to
the third the fifth all the odd numbers look like this you know and it would go back and forth and
then with you know as they get more complex with other things going on you know you're getting
beyond the parent graphs then we have all they can actually have the ups and downs so the absolute
value graphs and there's a lot of patterns with absolute value graphs that are also the same
as they would be for x squared graphs the way the vertex can move around so the simplest absolute
value graph is just this absolute value of x but like the other graphs i could be multiplying by
something here inside the absolute value or outside i can add or subtract something
so this is how i would write absolute value with the two vertical lines here next to it not
parentheses and here's how i would put this in code abs and notice i don't actually need to import
anything that's part of the core python library so that's the absolute value of x so as i plot it
then it looks like this because absolute value means it's just the number like positive or
negative doesn't matter it's just the number so it would be like plotting y equals x and that
would be in the positive direction but y equals negative x so for all these negative x values the
y value is positive because it's absolute value so that's why instead of continuing down like
the y equals x graph it comes to a point and makes a v so there we go so just like x squared
whatever x is it's going to end up being positive when you square it absolute value just makes it
all it just doesn't do anything except make it positive and so that's why there's there's
similar patterns to some of these but there you go perfectly straight lines come to a point
that's the absolute value graph and then i can have square root graphs there we go so here's
how i write the square root if i was writing it out and if i'm plotting it i'm going to use this
now there's math dot square root and there you know and other ways to get a square root but i'm
going to use numpy dot square root because we're already using the numpy library for everything
else so since i'm already using numpy for everything else that i'm graphing i definitely
want to use np dot square root so the the comment we'll talk about in a second but here's the basic
square root graph and we can start talking a little bit about inverse functions because this
is the inverse of x squared and that's why i also included this that if i uncomment that and now run
it you see now just the square root it's just going to be positive because if i include the
negative part then that's not a function these x values have two possible y values but when i put
them together i see that it looks like a parabola on its side and that's really what it is that's
the inverse of x squared because i want to do the opposite i square root things so yeah that just
helps us see it but the full graph the true square root graph is this because then it's still a
function all these x values have one y value and then there is just no y value beyond here
beyond this all right so there we go so there's the square root graph and another way to do this
is with a rational exponent now overall for this graphing python does not like rational exponents
so i'm going to do this here and i'm going to show you that this actually did work
x to the one half exponent but if you try this for any pretty much any other fraction instead of one
half it's just not going to work it's just going to give you an error python doesn't like it but
there you go that's the same that same graph so x to the one half in solving it if you weren't
graphing it you know it works out nicely the denominator is your root so square root denominators
so square root denominators two or if i had a cube root the denominator is three so i'm going
to write it like this here x to the one third so that's the cube root of x so it's what number
times itself three times gets me x so like the cube root of eight would be two because two times
two times two is eight so we're getting the cube root and i don't need to worry about the rational
exponent here because numpy just like there's a square root there's a cube root also cbrt
so that gets the cube root and this one i can have negative values because if the factor shows
up three times i can have negative negative negative so that works so there we go i can get
the cube root of x there we go so somewhere around here i have when x is eight y is one
you know there we go and then we get the cube root so the all these parent graphs just like
the other ones i could have other things going on in this equation the cube root of x plus something
that would shift it up you know i can move it around but you know these are the basic
paragraphs these types of shapes and then other graphs are just you know versions of these
all right so the floor function now there's the floor notice it kind of looks like absolute
value but the it does have feet at the bottom that go underneath kind of like an l and a backwards l
to show you the floor the uh other function that's similar that's the ceiling function
and the floor function is the one where you drop all the decimals so it doesn't matter if it's
like 5.9 and it doesn't round you just drop it and the answer is five the floor function
just drops the decimals and just takes the whole number other times people call it the greatest
integer function or the integer part function same idea there's also the ceiling function which no
matter what the decimal goes up to the next one and we have round they all work very similar
so we have all these
and to plot the floor function now i want to show you this this is actually
the function np.floor but there's a reason why i didn't do that first because i put all this in
in a loop to graph this as a bunch of points because i feel like this illustrates the floor
function a lot better it does give these steps and sometimes on the graph people look call it
a step function so it's the same value until you get to the next integer then it jumps up
and it's that same value until you get to the next integer
so all these are just sudden jumps once it gets to the next integer and it's the same value doesn't
change because if it was 3.1 the floor is 3 if it was 3.5 the floor is 3 it's 3.6 you know all those
values if the floor is 3 and then when it gets to 4 boom then it jumps up so the the reason why i
went through all of that is that the actual floor function i feel like doesn't display well but i'll
show you you see it gives these values but these vertical lines really shouldn't exist
because it's not continuous like that and so it's just what you know numpy just wants to connect it
but that's what the floor function looks like in numpy but truly mathematically that's not what
it looks like so that's why i wanted to do the loop and show you so there we go so that's the
floor function exponential functions so now we go from things like x squared to x is the on
is the exponent so what happens when the base doesn't change but then the exponent changes
so that's two to the first to the second to the third well we can right away see that that
value is going to get really big really quickly
and so here to the exponent of x so we have we see it gets really big really quickly
and then when we think about our exponent rules when x is zero anything to the zero is one so
so all these exponential functions cross the y-axis at zero one and then for negative exponents that
flips it to the denominator so two to the negative first is one half to the negative second is
negative is one fourth and so the negative exponents for negative x values just really
get smaller and smaller so it has that curve but it's not at all parabola on the left here
that just gets smaller and smaller but actually it will never touch zero if you get on something
where you can keep zooming in you'll see that it just gets smaller and smaller but never touches
zero and then over on the right it just has that upward curve and as steep as it looks it actually
is never perfectly vertical it's just really steep and so that's the look of all the exponential
functions we use this a lot of times in percent increase compound interest things like that
but there we go that's a lot of the exponential functions here
all right so there we go so these are all the key parent graphs
all the other graphs you're going to look at in algebra are going to be some version of these
graphs oh it's like this graph but then with some some other things that we that we added
uh later on when we get into or another course in trigonometry the trig graphs are different
and one of the big differences is they keep repeating these are all you know they do one
thing and then that's it but we'll get to those graphs but for anything in algebra these are all
the parent graphs so when you look at a graph and you want to figure out well what could the equation
be that generated that graph you you say well which parent graph does it look like oh it looks
like this so it could be you know an exponential oh it has that other sort of curve it could be a
different one so you know that's why you want to get a sense of the parent graphs it helps you
develop equations to fit different curves later on and we'll get into some of that stuff okay
so there we go and you will have this as a resource too to consult as you know take a look at the
different parent graphs now that we've worked through the core skills in this unit let's look
through some extra problems and i'm going to work through extra problems using the colab notebook
so you can see how you can apply these resources that you're building and use that use these to
use these to solve problems that might come up in a textbook or in day-to-day life so we're going to
go through some more extra problems here so now that we see these parent graphs let's let's do a
little twist here let's look at the these sliders we can add to modify the parent graphs because
that's it that they're meant to be modified so that first one y equals a or any you know value
value just it's that horizontal line if we add a slider now notice the setup for the slider
that you know we're going to import this in line and it's a widget for the slider and then all of
our graphing is going to be in this function that we redefine here define and i called it the function
f because i wanted a shorter function name f of and then it's going to take a for the slider and
in this case we're going to also also going to zoom so all these values are based on the zoom
slider so you can zoom in and out and we still have these points but just all the graphing happens
here within the function set the plot and notice all this same thing but the zoom then would affect
all this and so mathematically you know if i if i wasn't writing code i would just write you know
y equals a but we're going to put it here i'm going to have two y values because just this
perfectly horizontal line we kind of have to do it this way and we're going to plot this
horizontal line just like we did with each axis you know the x values x min x max and then the
y values y one and y two which are both the same which is whatever this a value is so here's the
slider you know run this function f a goes from negative nine to nine and then the zoom so when
we run this so there we go and as i increase the slider so we see our general graph and i can zoom
in a little bit but that's what we get like y equals some constant and then i see the slider
that parent graph it's still the same look that horizontal line it's just that from the parent
graph to the child graph it just it just changes where it is see but then you know the slider and
then the zoom that becomes even more interesting when i have our classic slope intercept form so
now i have y equals mx plus b what happens when i use sliders and i'm going to change
m b and i'm you know i like the zoom in there so i'll just keep that in there
so we have everything for the zoom now here and these next few we can do the normal you know
numpy linspace and that's the array that i want to graph for my x values so here
i have y equals mx plus b so look at that m and b are still variables here because that slider
is going to affect it and then that function is going to take that input so now i can have a
slider change the m value change the b and i still have the zoom and then this is what i have
so it's right here because the slope is zero but what happens as soon as i make the slope one
now i start to see my graph and i can see the slope and then as b increases
we can see it the y intercept moves up and down there we go and some of these
you know now we have some more that we can see when we zoom in there we go and this particular
one i didn't put the grid on there but just to show you that as that parent graph y equals x
you know that's really just that's the paragraph y equals x because it does have a slope but then
i can change the slider and see the negative values and from that paragraph changing these
two values makes it its own graph but it still is that linear equation because that's the parent
graph still has those core features but then we modify it a little bit i can change the slope
i can change the slope i can change where it crosses the x-axis and sliders are a good way to
illustrate this so we have now three variables for our quadratic ax squared plus bx plus c
and so my function i'll take a b and c and zoom in
so then my y value is just this standard quadratic i remember x squared is the parent graph you know
a is one and then just x squared that would be the parent graph the simplest quadratic it's a
parabola but then when i have these three it still has that core feature of the paragraph it's still
parabola but then i change and we can see what a b and c do to these so we have this interactive
i'm going to adjust a b and c and as well as the zoom and so we see it defaults to right in the
middle so let's just put a now that's one but we can use these sliders to see what does what happens
to the graph when a increases you see it gets narrower and then what happens zero it's not a
parabola anymore but then as it's negative it flips it down there we go so we can see how these
affect you know we'll bring it back up to positive like a smile then we can take a look at well i'll
jump to c next because that's the easiest it just same shape it just moves it up or if c became
negative same shape and it moves it down and see each time i move this the it runs the function
again and then recalibrates it with these new values and then b i think is one of the most
interesting because i move it as b increases it dips down to the left kind of interesting
and then i can bring it back and then as b decreases it dips down to the right
it dips down to the right so just some interesting things that you know so this would be a b and c so
this would be x squared minus 5x minus 5 that'd be the equation here or then x squared minus 5x
minus 6 and we can zoom in and see you know i i didn't put the values on here so so exactly but
you could always do that too so we see these sliders now the reason why i like this and i
want you to notice with absolute value how similar those patterns are to the x squared the absolute
value because remember whatever x is if you square it it's positive absolute value also then just
makes it positive but the core absolute value function so you see absolute value but i'm taking
in three different values here from my absolute value parent graph i still have three sliders why
because i have a times the absolute value and then inside the absolute value i could have x minus b
that's where the b shows up and that shifts it left or right and then plus c shifts it up or down
so we see that plus c shifting it up or down and let's take a look at these so again a is zero i've
got nothing as soon as i change it now i have my absolute value and of course the big difference is
this is linear each line is linear but then it comes to a point because again positive x values
were negative the absolute value makes it positive so we see some of those similar patterns though
as a increases a times the absolute value this gets narrower just like it did with the parabola
and c keeps the same shape but just moves it directly up or moves it down and
we have b this is this just moves it exactly side to side so that's you know this is where unlike
the parabola there's no other deeper curve to it it just moves it exactly side to side so
there we go and even if c
you know c was more it's still it still moves it side to side
it still moves it side to side so b is negative eight so the if we see the zoom here
so if b was negative eight
then we see that that is the x value
value so it's at negative eight and then because it's b it's x minus b
is the is the formula so b is negative eight then that means that's x plus b negative negative
makes it a positive that's x plus b in the inside the absolute value so negative eight
and then c is three then we go up three so we can see again you know where is that point
and we see the basic absolute value and then what each of these things do and how it's very
similar to the quadratic but that has its own its own things and we can do this you know those are
the most useful i feel like for a lot of algebra you know more commonly useful but square root
functions can have a slider too
and this one it gives a runtime warning which i just left in there and it still ran because
the you can't take the square root of a negative number so you know i still have all these different
zoom values that i could you know at some point i get a negative number and it just does not
compute it won't show up but it actually that doesn't break this it will give me the error
but then that's it so here if i take a look at b and i make b zero here if we run this again
so again everything zeroes out where is it but if a is anything there we go
and we can zoom in a little bit see this curve a little bit better there we go so if a is anything
and then we see b it moves it but remember it's because like the other one x minus b is the formula
so when b increases it's really x minus three moves it three to the right
and then c also you know moves it up and again we're looking at that point where this starts
where that square root function starts whereas if b was zero and c was zero you see that's where
we start at the origin zero zero so we see you know your basic square root graph and again you have
these different values you can have a times the square root and then square root of what x minus
b and then i still have plus c outside that can shift it up or down so we see from the basic
parent graphs all these key things and we start hopefully you're starting to see the patterns of
how this comes up and you can have these sliders with all different so if we have x to the third
now all four sliders and we can see you know x to the third now for this one i just left it
as this to show this is what happens you know a increases this you know can make it a little
bit narrower but b is even zero c is negative d is even zero across is it zero zero but i just
set up you know that's where you get you know some deeper dips in your x to the third functions here
so and it's usually some mix of positive and negative coefficients that give you these deeper
dips and you can do the same thing x to the fourth and you can have five sliders because
x to the fourth would also have a times x to the fourth and then b times x to the third
c times x squared d times x to the first and then the constant e which actually would be times x to
the zero so there we go and having these you know we can adjust these they're not x these are not
always symmetrical but i picked one that actually could make it symmetrical and what that is is
notice where the zeros are because x to the fourth a is the coefficient i made that two x to the third
b is the coefficient i made that zero x squared c is the coefficient negative six and then x to the
first i mean that zero it's symmetrical because all of the even exponents have coefficients and
the odd exponents zero out so these even functions happen only if i have all even exponents
and notice i can have an e value because e is x to the zero and we'll count that as even
so there we go so some things you can see when we have sliders you know same thing with this
floor function this is just kind of cool and so what i did here is i you know still with the zoom
but i made this floor function i did this
to make these a bunch of dots because i like how that displays the floor floor function
that's really like this is really the floor function and i made these dots you know to plot
the points instead of lines and you know they're big enough that they connect you don't see spaces
between but that's really this is really the floor function as we as we know it and we see that you
know if a increases it just gets steeper and a could be negative and it could be like that
but it still has that step look to it so and then c it's almost i guess it's noticeable there you go
but that's it so this is the floor function we have the different steps and you see we still can
have that's the parent function just the floor function but then and the floor the general
parent function would be yes i would have a times this so i keep that as one and then you know
nothing else going on that would be the parent function and then we can adjust things so all
these you know that taking it beyond the parent functions you can have sliders and you know all
kinds of other things for you know there we go some some other functions we can have all right
oh this was the uh exponential function we'll end it on this here that if i have this so i still have
my a coefficient and then b to the exponent of something cx minus d now
nothing going on because a is zero but if a is at least one but still nothing going on because
i have uh b has to be a value it has to be one won't do it it has to be greater than one
it has to be greater than one and then c it's c times x this won't do it because that would make
the exponent zero out so again it would be a constant that has to be at least something
and there we go we can zoom in a little bit
a little bit there we go and you know d that could shift it and e could shift it up just like we were
doing before but you see these there's a few of these that needed to be non-zero to make this
show something so we see you know again general parent graph of our exponential function and all
the things we can do to shift it so applying some of the formulas we've been talking about
in algebra we can use these for business applications like demand and revenue so demand
would be how many would i be able to sell so imagine if we're selling laptop computers and
and i find out that you know an average price of like six hundred dollars
will get me you know i might sell like 84 million computers so we do some research we find that
you know this might be the case and then maybe i find some some particular companies might say
oh well you know what our average price is going to be triple it's going to be somewhere right in
the neighborhood of 1800 hundred dollars but then maybe they'll only sell like eight million
and then we look at this and we say okay well what should my price point be and
we can find this we can use these two as you know an x value for you know uh price and y value for
how many sold and we can do the slope formula and we can get an equation here to estimate this as
being linear and i can take a look at what the demand might be so i could do the slope you know
84 minus 8 over 600 minus 1800 so remember our slope formula from earlier and so there we go so
if we have 76 over and then the the denominator happens to be negative negative 1200 and i would
get that into an exact decimal that would be my slope and you know some it's going to be
something like negative 0.06 so then i could get that into a y equals equation you know
um you know somewhere around there negative you know 0.06 x plus and i could have the you know
what would be my y intercept i could i could go through that same formula and when we get into
the code i'll show you that we can just bring in these formulas that we already know getting
a couple points getting our slope intercept form and then i would have that value here um
there we go and yeah it's probably you know i'm gonna just rough estimate here
so let's let's just say that that would be it and then that would be notice a negative slope because
as the price gets higher you know we would graph this as you know price and you know number sold
and we would see that as the price gets higher then the number sold would be
you know less and less and at some point actually the why are some somewhere more like 50
and at some point you know we the price would be so high that nobody would want it but we would get
that as the general estimate now let's just say that's the equation here now what so that would
be the demand equation and a lot of times economists are looking for that you know um
um business owners too what would be my ideal price point well then if i use that how what can
i do to figure out my revenue well my revenue how many sold would be the demand but then the price
as i was saying is defined as the x value so at every point i would get that the x value that the revenue
is going to be the price
times the demand
the demand and in this case that price is always going to be x and if i figure this out then it's x
times negative 0.06 x plus 50 and you see that would be my y value that i could that i could graph
quick distributive property we recognize that this is
a quadratic with a negative a value so that means it's going to open down you know plus 50x
and so when we look at this then
if i have you know the price but then instead of the number sold
i want to have revenue so of course if the price is zero i have no revenue and then of course
there's some other price that is so high that nobody buys it so i have no revenue and the shape
of this graph is going to be a parabola that opens down so then i see that this is going to be a
parabola that opens down so then i see that there is some middle price that would maximize revenue
and that's kind of the thing that we want to look for you know using these formulas we're using
the slope formulas we're using the formulas we've developed to generate a slope intercept equation
this would always be true revenue is price times demand so then we can use that to develop this
quadratic and we can graph these we can find out what these what these revenue points would be
so pretty interesting then we could also apply this to profit so this is just revenue and then
we could do this and then subtract subtract the total cost we could get profit so this is really
some of the applications that we want to get to that you know using these formulas and determining
based on some data you know what should my price point be to maximize my revenue or given you know
if i already established a price point what would you know can i predict the revenue you know these
are things people put in their business plans so we see these examples that are this one example
and i when we look at the code i have two other examples so we can see how this would come
together that you you know you can use your math skills you can use your python skills
to make some business predictions and these are some of the good applications
of of all this math and writing code so let's take a look at the code all right so i wanted
to give you an another example or two to show how you can write code to work with these formulas
and for this example i'm just saying we're selling t-shirts and i've made up these numbers hopefully
they seem kind of realistic but you could define the price here and so these are all variables
here so if we define the price and in this case we're going to say we're selling t-shirts for five
dollars each and then we have the demand as our next variable and we're saying that if you were
giving away t-shirts maybe you could give away 50 you know this is business you're not really
not really going to give them away but then your demand decreases as the price increases so every
time the price increases increases now in this case again if the price if it was free you'd give
away 50 right here the price is five and then so two times the price is 10 so then the demand would
be 40 but you see how it just cascades we just define the price and then we use that to talk
about demand and then revenue is going to be price times demand now that is actually a go
standard formula the price you're selling it four times how many you sold so you see we can do this
we've you know once we've defined these then we have these other formulas that they can depend
on them and then the total cost so this is another one that you would have to know and i just
uh made it so i said four times the demand so if we have four you know the idea is that let's say
it cost four dollars to make each t-shirt all right and i'm sure sometimes t-shirts cost less
but i just said four dollars so that's where the total cost would be four dollars times
you know however many we sold and then that's the total cost so then we have profit is revenue
minus total cost makes sense what's the rev how much money do we bring in minus the cost
and how you see how we have all these we can just define these formulas now this is a standard
formula for for profit revenue minus cost and this is a standard formula for revenue price times
demand and some of these then we could develop these equations if we knew if we had some other
data so if you're making things to sell you would definitely have this information
how much does it cost to make but there you go all these then if you define the price and some
demand equation we can calculate all these and we would output you know given this price the demand
and revenue because five times forty and then the total cost we 160 you make a profit of forty
dollars and then having these this is where people can do some research and they can test things out
oh well let's say supposing i decided to make the price ten dollars instead
and we take a look at this the price increases the demand decreases as we expected
but the revenue increases and so given that cost we still have a profit of
of more than double so the price of each doubled i went from five dollars to ten dollars but the
profit more than doubled it more than quadrupled so just interesting things that we can we can see
here and how does this happen well it might be it might be helpful to see this on a graph too so
we're going to graph these things import matplot library and i'm going to import numpy i'm just
going to remind you here that the price is x and the demand is y and then we're going to change it
that the demand later is going to be the revenue now this is where if you had data this is where
you would have you know if i have at what at a certain price what would the demand be you see
and i had in mind here you know that this was you know i don't know something else here
you're buying two dollars 46 so it would it might not be t-shirts that might be really low
but let's just say you know i don't know bottle of water and you know yes it's ten dollars but
maybe you hype it up and tell people it's just this amazing bottle of water and if it's cold
or if it's really hot that day and water's cold you know you still might have some demand so
something else that you you might have but there we go so we can define these price one and demand
one so if it was two dollars then the demand is 46 if it's ten dollars then the demand drops down
to 30 as an example if just having some of this data from some other research and we can remember
these formulas we did back with linear equations because this is essentially two points price and
demand or x and y so i'm going to calculate the slope based on those two points calculate the y
intercept and then this becomes a y equals mx plus b equation so pretty cool again again if i have
you know some examples of some data that we have that we can we can test so given that equation
that's going to be my demand equation and i'm going to go through there we go x min x max
now notice this x minimum and y minimum i'm going to make zero because negative numbers for this
aren't going to really have any practical meaning i'll make the x maximum 50 and the y maximum 320
there we go the number of points that's all fine so after i define everything here
i'm going to do a couple other things i'm going to do the x label is going to be price
and then i'm going to give my graph a title so notice both these plt dot x label plt dot title
there we go and then for this one line one i'm going to have so for line one here's my demand
equation y equals m the demand equals m x plus b and so we figured out m and b up here
and so i can use those but i'm going to use x because that's the array of x values that i've
defined so we have our demand equation and then i'm going to plot y labeled demand so we see the x
label is still going to be price but for this one y label is going to be demand and then we're going
to plot x and then the demand i commented this out we'll get to that in a second
so here we go so i have my graph and then we see yes if i was giving them away for free i could
give away 50 the demand decreases as the price increases so at some point maybe like 25 dollars
um you know whatever i'm selling here that started out as two dollars you know maybe it's cds or
something you know some people still want those if i have 25 dollars you know nope too expensive
nobody wants it and then somewhere in there we have the ideal now it's not always perfectly
linear in real life but this is a good estimate so given these supposing i keep that same demand
equation and as we were saying before i can build upon that and i can have
revenue equals x time demand because as long as i keep that equation it will still use that
and then so now i'm going to plot my x value and then revenue as y value and i'm going to change
my y label to revenue so we see that we have a way to do this and when i graph this we see that yes
of course i'm going to make no revenue if the price is zero and then we said that about 25 i'm
going to sell none so i'll make no revenue but this is how the revenue goes and it's really
interesting that i can have some you know low prices and i think that that's you know the the
best i might sell the most but the revenue actually there's some middle number here
that gives me my maximum revenue and you see it looks like now if if i make new revenue at zero
and at 25 these parabolas are symmetrical so it's exactly 1250 would be the maximum revenue
or if people like round numbers you know 12 or 13 so there we go we can see how we can
use all of this and we can see that the you know the reason why revenue would be zero here this is
where the demand would be zero so this is probably the more the line two is probably the more valuable
one but having given getting some research of given prices demand price demand that if i have
a couple values here then i could plot this out and i can plan oh from other prices and demand
research that i've heard what should i make my price you know and this this is some of the research
that people can do you know you have some new product how can you determine what the price should be
all right and there you also then if you're making a business plan you could always then
download or export these images you know you've you've written the code you see the graph export
the graph as an image to include in your business plan so there we go you know a couple different
examples of how we can make use of these you know formulas the graphs and you know
generate some graph or some image and some data that we can really use
okay so let's apply some of these graphs to some other economic theories and see how you can use
python your math to plan predict you know look at trends in economics so we looked at cost revenue
profit and if we take on that marginal cost revenue or profit if it's marginal then that's the result
when making and selling one more product and for some of our examples we were doing some linear
equations and for that the marginal cost revenue is the result of the marginal cost revenue
and for that the marginal if cost is linear the marginal cost is going to be the same
wherever you are but sometimes we have costs or we saw that definitely we have profits or
revenue that are not linear and therefore we have some times when oh this is it makes more sense
from a cost revenue profit perspective to make one more and sometimes you know it doesn't
sometimes you know oh that one more is only going to get me a tiny bit of profit not worth it
and cost sometimes it goes the other way you know setting up everything making one product might
be a really high cost but now it's all set up so making two three four a hundred thousand
you know might make that worth it you know things like newspapers and book printing and
you know there's a big setup for the printer and so the marginal cost to make one wouldn't be worth
it now there's definitely you know other methods printers but for a lot of the big printers like a
big printers like a newspaper marginal cost it'd be a whole lot for one newspaper but no they're
going to print thousands and thousands so the marginal cost after they've printed you know
a hundred thousand newspapers printing one more is almost nothing as far as cost so these are the
things you know what what's it cost to make one more and you know we might notice that for revenue
and profit the same thing and so if we have revenue you know and this kind of a lot of times
comes up but you know toward the end of the day people say oh what you know what would it take to
make one more sale you know maybe it's a store should i stay open for a lot longer and everybody's
tired to make one more sale that might be you know a lot more cost to in a lot of ways for a
little bit of revenue not worth it and so they say okay these are the hours and we close
so these are some deeper analyses as we get into things beyond linear equations
we can do even more than that makes that even more interesting but just to mention that you
know as we talk about this the marginal is that at any given point what's the cost revenue or profit
to make one more all right and let's look at some other things that impact that supply and demand
and here again i'm going to give some simple numbers and make it linear equations the true
supply and demand graph it's not going to you know and in real life it's not going to be perfectly
linear there might even be a little curve to it but even at that it you know if you get the data
it might be you know a little bit of a bumpy line but we have supply and demand and we know these
definitions are at supply how much are people making you know what's the supply of whatever
i'm looking for and the demand how much will do people want how much are people willing to buy
so you know if you're looking at you know a movie the movie theater if you wanted to see it in the
theater the supplies there's only so many seats you know only so many showings you know a movie or
a play or a concert always so many seats only so many showings so that's this limited supply
and then the demand could increase if it's something really good that everybody wants to see
so a lot of times we see that you know that affects the price and that's what we're going to
look at supply demand and price and we're going to graph supply and demand on the same axis so
we'll see some similarities some familiar things here for the graph and i'm going to have two x
values as old demand and new demand and i just gave them this complicated variable and i'm going
x values as old demand and new demand and i just gave them this complicated variable name so that
it reminds you that it's an x value so we have old demand and new demand and yes i notice i made
the demand increase and then i have old price and new price so now just looking at that well
we'll see this on the graph but the price is also going to be the y value and on the same graph
i'm going to have supply old supply and new supply i made that you know two variables each of these
as i was mentioning you could potentially get data from a table supply and demand data
data you could have one table that has you know a particular price supply demand price
and you know make all these numpy notice i did not import numpy for anything i'm just
putting a few variables here and you know to illustrate the graph but you could absolutely
get that data from a table and you know make each of these numpy arrays and graph them
that would be really interesting too and that's something that we'll address later on in the
course so given these and then i have a basic graph set up adding a couple labels here i'm
going to make the x label quantity just general quantity and the y label price
and i have this title which i already graphed but we'll get to that so here's the demand function
and i'm going to plot this as a red line just because all right so notice the x and y my old x
i'm just making this just like i do it with the axis i'm going to plot you know these two x values
and these two y values and make you know make that a red line so so we see this you know i'm
not going to even put an equation to it i'm just graphing this linear equation from these points
to this point and i'm going to do the same thing for supply as a green line and same thing i'm
just going to use this data that i had these numbers that i came up with as an example
um and this graph we can take a look at this again it's simplified but it really is the general trend
of supply and demand so if i made green supply red demand then we take a look at the x axis is
quantity so the green that would be quantity supplied and the red that would be quantity demanded
supplied and the red that would be quantity demanded and then on the y axis we have price
so graphing them both on price we take a look at this and we see if the price is high
then the quantity demanded is going to be low and a lot of times we're used to seeing you know
um an independent variable on the x axis and we think cause and effect but this is really
correlations so i'm not saying necessarily one causes the other but you know it goes together
so uh at the when uh x is let's say one and y is 14 so we look at this this this demand there's very
low quantity of demand when the price is high and then as the quantity see we see the quantity
increase as the price decreases so that's what happens oh you know what is this oh it's 14
you know $14 no i don't i don't think i want it but as the price gets down lower then maybe
you know the demand increases more people would want this now supply wise people making
this they have a different incentive they want to make money so when the when the demand is low
the and when the price and when the price is low then nobody nobody wants to nobody wants to get
into this so you see we have low demand but we also have low when the when the when the price
is low here then nobody wants to get into this what you know why would i get into this new business
if i'm you know whatever i'm selling is not going to be you know that lucrative but the quantity in
the green line the quantity supplied will increase as the price increases and we see that in different
industries that you know oh you know why why are people you know getting into this industry oh
because they all see they can make money oh this is the hot item oh i can get in on this and somehow
you know uh make money so that's what we have that the supply quantity increases as the price
increases so there we go so we have these two opposite trends and this is kind of like the
core of economics because as you know i get different data this is i just did these numbers
as an example but these graphs could shift you know maybe there's some something else that affects
this that maybe you know instead of uh the supply increasing like this maybe something
causes it to increase a little bit steeper or maybe you know if we say that you know the quantity
supplied is low here for this price but maybe you know for whatever we're making that the entry
level was even at a higher price and this whole thing shifts so you know that's really what a lot
of economists are trying to do and then if this is quantity across the x-axis let's take a look at
where these lines intersect and then that would be the point of equilibrium because what we're
saying is the quantity here supplied and the quantity demanded would be the same and i mean
that's ideal you know you know let's say you have a bakery and you make fresh things every
morning and then at the end of the day you have it all sold nothing left over that's great here
on the left you know and we'll say let's say that you know for our fictional numbers that happens
at six but let's say a little bit before that so it's still to the point that the price is too high
so the demand's not really there the price is increasing but not so good yet so the supply is
not really there and we still have a gap between demand and supply so here on the left the red
line is higher there's more of a demand but not enough of a supply and then we have on the right
side of that we have more of a supply but not as much demand and that would be the one this would
be on the right that would be the one that's dangerous for anybody supplying whatever product
because you know they're getting into this trying to make money the price is starting to get to
where somebody's happy oh good the price is going up i'll make more money but then there's you know
the demand drops off so now they really have to scramble for customers you know that's trouble or
the price here or on the left for the people who want this product the demand is still higher than
supply and that's part of what keeps the price higher because the demand is there not as much
supply well then the price increases you know things like you know stock trading people argue
about this stuff all day anytime somebody wants to too many people want to sell a particular stock
oh well then you know the supply increases too many and we go to the right too many people want to
sell this you know then other people notice that you're oh you're really trying to get rid of this
and then the demand kind of goes down you know what's wrong with it and that affects price and
and on the left then we have the price is too high because there's not enough of supply supply
and you know that sometimes causes oh there's you know there's not much supply nobody wants to
sell that you know this must be good and then that kind of increases the demand and the hype a little
bit so you see this one simple graph describes all these complicated trends and we see this that you
know our goal all around is you know finding these points of equilibrium supply meets demand
you know therefore everybody you know making whatever products are making money people looking
for these products are finding them you know and you know fair trade people are paying reasonable
prices we're all trying to get to that but we see all these things happen all around there
and it's not just one direction of cause and effect it's multiple things going on as well
as just general correlations all things happening together so we look at this you know and and let's
say we say the trend is like as the price goes down how does how does that affect demand or
it goes the other way too as the price goes up how does that affect demand and the word to describe
that is elasticity so elasticity is how quickly does uh demand change when price changes
and we can look at this there's the formula percent change in demand over percent change in price
and this is again all these economic formulas i'm just going to give you a couple of them here
that when you have these formulas you can use this you know get data uh use it to graph and
then use it to calculate these formulas to answer these questions you know how elastic is that price
how elastic is that price because if things change if the price changes and then that really
changes demand then we can say it's a very elastic like it like an elastic band or something that
bounces that you know it stretches and changes easily or things you know if price changes and
it does not change demand you know things like uh gasoline you know we don't like to pay the
price goes up we don't like to pay it but if the price went up a little bit i still have to fill my
car so that demand would not be very elastic the price could change and the demand doesn't change
and you know we can so we can see that if the percent change in price let's say it's it's you
know some significant number but then the percent change in demand is like almost nothing we
calculate that you know the total value of that fraction is going to be close to zero
um and we're going to say that's not very elastic but maybe some other things um
you know a concert ticket you know there's ones i've seen where oh i'd like to go see
i'd like to go see this but the price is too much no i won't go and as the price goes down
oh i heard the price went down that would absolutely change the demand oh too much
i i won't go oh the price went down now i want to go and that really changed it you know things
that aren't essential and we would say that that would be very elastic so in calculating this
and you know down the road you could always combine all these into one thing but i'm
just going to show you like just old demand new demand old price new price and we're going to
calculate the percent change so remember then that's you know the new price minus the old so
there's their difference divided by the old price and it's going to get a decimal that we can convert
to a percent so you see again and we want to get in the habit like you you're so familiar with
you know colab that oh i have a formula i want to use you know write write a quick program to do it
and then now all we have to do is change these values up here and we can calculate everything
that we need so price change and that's the ends up being the percent change and then the same thing
with demand the new demand minus the old demand and that's the difference divided by the old demand
and that gives you a percent it will give you a decimal that you can convert to a percent and so
elasticity number is demand change divided by price change so what i have is then it'll just
print that number and here's some of the analysis so again different things oh you what you know
what's the cutoff point you can always just put these in you know a nice little if statement
statement and so if the number is greater than one then i'm going to print the demand is elastic
and notice this is you know else if so i just continue this on you know lf the number equals
one then it's unitary or proportional so sometimes you know we we do get one that's there you go an
increase i think that that proportional increase increases demand but you know
and then if it's less than one then that's inelastic that those are all the ones that
you know again it the demand hardly changes based on price and i just decided to attack one more
and so you see this is how you can you know i i like to when i do my lf statements i like to
tag on one more thing at the end you know for whatever reason suppose you know this should
capture everything if it's it's either greater than one equals one or less than one i mean it's
really but capture one other like grab bag you know what you know if something else happened
very often we'll have if and lf without you know exhausting every possibility and then you just
easily just put an else there at the end so i have some sample numbers here and then we can click
and it would print out so we get this negative 2.2 and then demand is inelastic
so as that example and we can do the same thing with supply so remember you know supply changes
um as price change because people say oh hey i want to this is a hot industry i want to get
into this or then people say oh nope it's uh you know this is cooled off i'm gonna get out um
so in uh it you know in the united states kind of recently the real estate market
market uh was hot and that's supply like okay not everybody necessarily is going to sell their
house or try to be a realtor or try to sell some property but when the prices are so good
more people decide to get into it like oh maybe i will sell this you know so that's the idea
that if the price is good and people see oh opportunities to make money they get into that
so price elasticity of supply answers that question how how responsive is this supply
to changes in price so very similar formula percent change in supply over percent change in price
and just a few values to sample and very similar formula you know new price minus the old price
divided by the old price and uh new supply minus old supply divided by the old supply
and we're going to go through the same thing elasticity number and very similar analysis
greater than one it's elastic which remember as a fraction greater than one is going to be
that this percent change in supply is much greater than the change in price percent change in price
and we have to do percent change because if we just do you know actual dollar amounts or actual
number of things supplied that really doesn't always give us a good example some things just
in general are low cost so a change of a dollar might be a whole lot some things are really
high cost like you know a change for a car that a price change of a dollar is not going to be much
at all so same thing with supply you know what what's what's the relevance you know how is it
relevant to the previous supply so that's why we do the percent change so yeah if price change is
you know a certain percent but supply change is a lot more related to that then we're going to say
oh wow that's elastic people are noticing these trends and we can go through this and same exact
analysis either supplies elastic unitary or any elastic and i just you know just had these so
there we go this number and it's inelastic because it's this tiny decimal so yeah not
everything you know supply cannot always be you know elastic and so notice you can take this
and given the old prices and old supply you could always take these things and combine them with
something like this so that therefore you could graph and if you had you know other you know
other numbers so notice this i mean even though these numbers might be fictional if you had any
bit of research that you just had a few values here you can get these you know and with these
you know six things calculate you know the graph and elasticity of supply elasticity of demand
and really just get a handle on you know where where you are in this graph and what are the
potential changes you know is it you know these graphs i kind of made the linear and it's kind of
proportional but you know very often it's going to be bumpier and you know where are you on this
graph and what's what's what's going on if you really wanted to you could even um
there's other plugins for other uh data especially things like stock prices and you could
use this uh to calculate elasticity for various stock prices you could calculate some of the trends
um and a lot of these it'll work within colab there's a lot of things that will work within colab
that are a lot of things that'll work within your google drive and those particular free tools tend
to update things like stock prices maybe like every 15 minutes at the at the most but that's
going to be enough to give some sort of analysis you know for an amateur investor take a look at
different things you know that's kind of what we want to take this and like these types of
formulas and build upon these so that you know you can uh build data pipelines and get information
at some reasonably regular level have all the formulas and calculate and say you know okay now
you know have this output at some sort of report for you let's see the graph let's see it in real
time you know pretty much real time let's run through some formulas and see you know hey i'm
thinking about investing in this what's it looking like oh it's it's very you know the demand's very
elastic so you know you really have to take notice of the price or oh this you know um
i see this trend maybe you know a supply of something that maybe i can get into
all these things we want to you know use this information to uh make decisions about what we
want to invest in yeah and you can do this all right here in colab and right here in your google
drive so uh we'll get in some more some some more math now and you know the next step of our
journey so let's talk about calculating interest and usually that's going to be money i put in the
bank or in some investment or sometimes it's going to be money that i borrow and then how much extra
am i paying so the simple interest formula is exactly that simple and it's good for short term
it's good for you know not a lot of money if it's long term but the longer you go with this
the less accurate it's going to be and we'll see why that is but for short term principle times
rate times time it gives you the interest so if i was borrowing something what you know let's say
you know i have borrowed you know a hundred dollars and the rate would be uh
0.05 so the rate's always a percent converted to a decimal so the rate would be five percent
and as a decimal it'd be 0.05 and then the time would be always in years so you know let's say
i borrowed a hundred dollars for two years then what in what extra interest would i owe on that
so there we go that would be another ten dollars
so what i would then say is okay well you know given this rate if i needed a hundred dollars now
and it's going to take me two years to pay it off you know maybe if it's going to take me two
years to pay off a hundred dollars maybe calculating interest isn't my biggest problem but the uh if i
if you know i could calculate oh how much extra would that cost me an interest now to figure out
the total amount that i would pay i would take that interest and i would add it to the original
principle because i have to pay that hundred dollars back plus the extra ten dollars so let's
take a look at this you know if time is one like let's say one year and what that is is that's
compounding that's the notion of compounding that i'm taking that interest and then i'm adding it to
the principle so let's say the time was one year and so
so this would be times point zero five times one then the interest would be five dollars
and then what am i going to do i'm going to i'm going to add that together so i'm going to say
you know the principle plus the interest
um is is going to be five dollars now the reason why we compound it is because after let's say
a year so then i have that new principle plus the interest but then that new principle plus the
interest that's my new amount and then that would then generate another five percent of the interest
generate another five percent in interest so you see that becomes my new principle times five
percent gives me my new amount of interest and then i'd have to add that so you see i would take
that you know times that point oh five there we go and then i take that amount and add it to the
new new bit so that could potentially be a lot you know every time i have to calculate the interest
add it to the principle again and then recalculate it but let's take a look in terms of algebra what
what's really happening here so if i have this the original principle plus the interest
and i probably don't even need the parentheses here so the principle
plus but remember the interest was principle times rate times time
so we're doing a little bit of substitution there so the compounding part principle plus the interest
but the interest remember that was this formula so i'll just put that in here and notice if i
factor out p so you see the things we were doing before with common factors that comes around again
then i factor out p times one plus rt but supposing t is one if t is one then that would be r times one
which you know times one i really don't have to write that and then i won't write it in this step
so we see a nice algebraic way to write this where i have the original calculating the interest and
then also adding it now we're not going to stop there what makes this really useful
because that is now my principle calculating the interest for that one year and then now that's my
new amount what happens when i have to calculate it for the next year well what did i do to the
original principle i did principle is what i started out with and then i did times one plus
the rate so if i had to do it again for the next year it would be times one plus the rate again
because that's what i did to get the principle plus the interest and then again times one plus
the rate and when we think about this in another way it really makes sense because we're seeing
really makes sense because we're saying that that principle times one plus the rate is that i'm
saying you know this original principle 100 or whatever it is if that rate is five percent
you know then that's 1.05 so you know what do i have i have a hundred percent of it plus the extra
five percent and then doing that you know that 105 percent every time we can even simplify this
that that principle times one plus the rate because if that's what i'm doing every time
how can i simple that with an exponent and that's where time comes back in i have that exponent of
time because every year then i'm doing that times one plus the rate times one plus the rate and so
now we get from simple which is nice principle times rate times time to get just the interest
and again good for a short term but you see on long term this is the formula that we want that
compound interest because that accounts for every time it goes a little bit bit i earn some interest
but then that becomes a part of that new principle and then that's earning some sort of interest
and if this was my money in the bank that's great that's good news for me but then if this is money
that i'm borrowing then the bank is going to be wanting to do this sort of formula to make sure
that they get all the money that they that that they deserve you know and then i have to make
sure that i pay that extra interest so that's where we get the principle uh simple and compound
interest and then we get to this so then that's the you know that's the formula and then that
gives you you know your new amount so there we go a new amount and then when we get to the code
we're going to talk about that new amount we're going to call it annuity we're going to call it
a maybe as a variable a for amount but then it'll be annuity which is a fancier word for the amount
that we end up with so there we go the connection with simple and compound interest and we'll take
this a little bit further when we get into the code so let's take a look at that let's take a
look at the code so we're looking at simple interest as the well as the name says simple
because it's good for short term and for some things that might be good for an estimate
but we just get principle times rate times time equals the amount of interest and there we go
again short term because we're going to do some other things to it when we get to longer term
and that's what we'll get to here so the principle if we just put some example numbers here thousand
dollars let's say i borrowed money from the bank a thousand dollars the rate five percent so it's
always the percent the annual rate converted to a decimal and then time is always in years so if i
borrowed a thousand dollars from the bank they said okay it's five percent interest for three
years i'll pay it back here's the formula interest equals prt and when we run it there we go we get
a hundred and fifty dollars in interest so i'd pay back that thousand plus the extra interest
but right away then that tells me the cost of borrowing that i need it now and i don't have it
so that's going to cost me 150 dollars so then i want to find out the total amount well then
the new amount is just that principle plus the interest and there we go i'm going to calculate
the interest just like we did before and then this new amount is principle plus the interest
so there we go and we add that that hundred and fifty plus the thousand makes it eleven fifty so
now i have that new amount okay so most of the time we're going to be calculating the interest
and then adding it to the new amount it's very rare that i'm paying just the interest or somehow
just the amount and not worrying about interest so here's what we were just talking about that new
amount is that new amount is principle plus the interest and if it's for one year that's
principle plus for one year that would be p times r times t which would be one so that won't change
it so that would be the new amount principle plus the interest so some algebra that common factor p
if i divide that out i get p times one plus r and if i do the distributive property i get back to
this so p times one is is p and p times r is p r now this is going to be very useful that we factored
out this p because now i have that new amount just that original p times one plus r and the
and the rate is always going to be some decimal that it's going to be pretty easy to add that to
one one plus point oh five is one point oh five you can do that in your head it doesn't even feel
like a step and then this is what you're going to enter in the calculator so there we go that
one step that you automatically would do in your head and you're most likely going to have the
calculator for these so that was what you would enter in the calculator p times one plus r
now again this is for one year and 50 so if we go back to that original supposing the time was one
year just to show you that this works one year that'd be fifty dollars in interest and for one
year then then the new amount would be 1050 so that what we're doing there adding the interest
to the principal that's compounding and compounding is exactly that adding the interest to the
principal and then calculating the percent interest from this new amount so let's look at how this
happens over a few years so if my original amount is p so then the next year it's p times one plus
r but now that's my new amount so so again the next year so p is the time zero after one year
after one year i multiply times one plus r and after another year i multiply times one plus r again
and we'll just do this one more and again p after one year after two years after three years so
then that's just the same as making this an exponent p times one plus r to the third power
because i'm multiplying this factor one plus r three times and now we have compound interest
that instead of having to go back and every time calculate the interest simple interest add it and
then do it again you know in some loop i have one formula that does the compounding and all i need
to do is add the exponent for how many years so now the annuity from the original e times one plus
r exponent t so that's 1157 now it's not an error that this is different and remember the original
was 1150 when i did this by hand i just you know calculated the interest based on simple interest
and then added it but that's after three years that was 1150 and like i said simple interest is
good for short term but the longer it goes the less accurate it is so when i have this comp when
i'm compounding it every year notice that's every year that i'm adding the interest and then the
next year so remember after after one year it was 1050 so then for this for year two i'm getting
that five percent interest on not on a thousand but on 1050 and on the next year i get that five
percent interest on that new amount so that's the compounding it's like a snowball that rolls down
the hill and accumulates more snow and gets bigger and bigger as it goes down that's what we're doing
every time we're compounding because i'm still taking that rate five percent of a larger and
larger amount so compounded i get 1157 just that same amount over three years i earned an extra
seven dollars just because the formula was better so time is always in years and that's compounding
every year but we also have a formula supposing compounding happens n times per year so that gives
us this more complicated formula but that's okay we see how it connects t times one plus and instead
of r we're doing r over n because this is happening n times per year so that rate isn't always an
annual rate so i have to divide it by how many times i'm recalculating it but since then
every year was the exponent the exponent becomes nt how many times a year times the number of years
so then i'm compounding however many times as an example here i put it as 12 because that's pretty
common monthly we know recalculate compounding 12 times a year so then one plus r for n what's in
these parentheses gets smaller but then the exponents larger and it still ends up working out
if this is money now if this is money you're paying back it ends up paying you end up paying
more but if this is money you're putting in the bank earning interest then it works out in your
benefit so that thousand dollars five percent for three years but now this time compounded 12 times
per year i use the extra parentheses for any fraction so there you go instead of just r here
it was one plus r over n i put that in parentheses also and you definitely need the parentheses here
to make sure that stays because that is the whole exponent nt and remember the python syntax you
know in math we might skip the multiplying symbol because we're just they're next to each other but
python have to put that asterisk there so there's the annuity the other thing we're going to talk
about this instead of just amount that's annuity and principle is the word for the amount we start
out with and annuity is the word for the amount we end up with so now the annuity compounded
monthly look at that 1161 so we go back from that simple interest that was kind of off to compounded
annual 1157 much better to 1161 because we're compounding it monthly and guess what it gets
better but first i'm going to start talking about this irrational number e now in the middle of all
these very practical money in the bank things that we can understand why am i going to start talking
about this irrational number e and yes it's e but it's a number because this is going to come up in
the next formula all right so just a quick note about e we're going to import math we're going to
import math because e is a weird number and so when i print math dot e this is the number
there we go and as a good estimate you can just call it 2.7 but in your calculations you actually
want to use this whole number so that's why i want to import math dot e i don't want to just
you know say 2.7 and call it good another interesting thing about this it's 2.7 and then
we see it's 1828 and then the 1828 repeats again that's kind of interesting but it only does that
a couple times and then it just all falls apart so math dot e use that for the irrational number e
and it's e because it's euler's number his name began with an e but uh john napier who invented
logarithms and other things when he came up with this number he named it e after uh another
mathematician that you liked euler so sometimes people call it euler's number but anyway it's e
now if we're talking about compounding n times per year we go from being irrational and talking
about e to being very rational well what if i just keep compounding it many times and that's where
we get to continuous growth so in that previous formula n could be 12 now in this example i made
it 100 because we're going to do some things with this uh you know it could be 12 every month 52
every week you know i just made it a nice round number 100 could be 365 as n gets to be a bigger
and bigger number then we get the annuity becomes this formula p e to the rt and that's why we we're
talking about e so i get this irrational number e and then the exponent is rt because as we get well
i'll just demonstrate this so let's say n is 100 and if we do that actually let's even make it
52 so compounding every week and then here i'm going to compare these two formulas so this one
i call the variable n times so there's the there's our other formula p times one plus r over n to the
nt and then we're going to compare that with our continuous growth p times math dot e exponent rt
and then we're going to print it this one or this one
one so n times we remember that from before 1161 that should be the same number
and then the continuous growth 1161.83 so it's pretty close but it's a little bit more for the
1161.75 1161.83 it's pretty close but the continuous growth gives us even more
and if n gets to be a much larger number like a thousand
you'll see it gets really close 1161.829 or 1161.834
so we see if we took it to two decimal places they actually round to be the same
and that's the idea with continuous growth you see it it's not that it's always going to be more
than this it's that as n gets larger it approaches this value so if i have anything that's compounded
a lot or other things beyond money in the bank or things like that that i can say are continuous
growth applications you know population increase or things like that then i'm going to use this
and you know i can call it annuity i can call it the you know the new amount but i'm going to use
this formula so it's very useful for anything continuous growth it comes up a lot i mean
throughout math and calculus some version of this comes up a lot so i have this kind of
formula so i have this continuous growth formula if i want to calculate this all right now
for really large amounts
the mortgage formula and the mortgage payment formula is if i have a really large amount of money
and that's usually a mortgage you know as an example i think this might be you know pretty
close to the average mortgage these days 240 000 so that's a large amount of money and then time
is 30 years that's a long amount that's a long time so for such a large amount of money over
such a long period of time then it actually really makes a difference how like if i'm paying just a
little bit you know every month the fact that i'm paying you know a little bit and then that
principle reduces just a little then the next month i'm earning interest on that slightly lower
principle well that really makes a difference so if we use any of the other formulas to calculate
mortgage payments it's going to be a lot more than you know you would expect you'd be like oh my gosh
how can i afford that but when we use this more complicated formula this accounts for the fact
that we're paying it off gradually and looking at all that then we can take a look at for that given
amount of time what would my monthly payment be so that it'll work out nicely you know if i'm
paying over 30 years times 12 months that's 360 payments so i can calculate it if i borrowed
this amount of money after exactly 360 payments my balance is zero and it works out so just
given that i can figure out the payment and then we'll look at you know how that plays out so this
being a complicated formula if we want to write code for this and most of the time you're going
to you this you don't even usually enter this into your calculator you're going to make a formula
that you can plug in the numbers here so that's what we're going to do and here's how i decided
to break that down i just took the numerator that r over 12 one plus r over 12 12 t and just that
numerator i made it a variable and we see r over 12 times one plus r over 12 to the 12 t all right
and they did the same thing with the denominator so just the denominator and i have one plus r
over 12 so the exponent 12 t and then minus one separate from that so i have numerator denominator
two separate variables so then the payment see i didn't forget about that p for principle there
the capital p for principle so i'll talk about the so i'm going to round this because this is
going to be a weird number and the first part is p times numerator divided by denominator so there's
my mortgage payment so p times numerator divided by denominator and then i'm going to round that
because that's going to be a very long decimal i'm going to round that so it takes the first
argument and then the second one how many decimal places there we go so when we take a look at this
and when we run it mortgage payment 1362 and 69 cents so given that then we know that's the payment
that will make this work out that after 360 payments of this so each time you know we're
still accruing interest and we're still making a payment and it's going to work out now
to see how that plays out we call it the amortization schedule so and that's it
that's the mortgage payment schedule and yes all these have the word more in it uh which
means death you know kind of like you know what's what's true life you know death and taxes
and i guess mortgage but yeah it was very morbid when people first came up with this word but it
came up with this word but it stuck we will end this after this with something much more positive
so you know don't worry i don't want to leave you in the more morbid state so the mortgage payment
schedule if i take this there we go given these three things i just rewrote i just rewrote
all this how we're going to calculate the payment all right so i'm going to print this payment just
like what i did before so that's all the same as what we just did but the amortization schedule
is i want to have a loop to show the interest amounts and we can also do this in a spreadsheet
that's pretty common and later on in the course we'll talk about that so i can i'm going to have
a loop so i'm going to set this new variable called balance and the starting balance is going
to be that original p principle okay then i'm going to print this which is going to be my headings
month i'm going to put a tab there balance put a tab and then interest so that's what i want i want
the number you know what month am i talking about what's the balance at that point and then what's
the interest that i'm paying for that month so here's what we have in my loop for a and range
and how many months 12 t okay so the interest is round so again i'm going to round these
because calculating these you know it's going to be a lot of weird decimals i want it to be
two decimals dollars and cents so the interest that we're going to pay is this is simple interest
again because that short term this is only for one month and then we're going to manually compound
it here in this loop so i do want simple interest it still has usefulness balance times so that's my
p for that month times r and then t is 1 12th so i'm not just going to multiply by one i'm just
going to divide by 12 but that's what it is this is the original simple interest prt
the balance is the principle for that month rate and then time is 112 so i'm just going to divide
by 12 so there we go and all that i'm going to round it to two decimal places so now that i have
the interest this will still calculate the interest and i just put this here for the sake
of the displaying is that i only want if a is divisible by 24 you see remember the modulus
a remain a divided by 24 if the remainder is zero then or if a is 359 which is going to be
almost the last month so these are the ones so i'm rather than print out every single month i
would just want to skip a few normally if i know if i put this in a spreadsheet i'd want the whole
schedule and i'd print out all 360 months but only for these we're going to print out a select few
so i want a and then tab so that you know a is going to be what month because that's a in
range and then tab balance tab and then interest so there we go that's what's going
to line up month balance interest so then after i do this so i put this line last because the
first time through i want it to be the current amount and then i'm going to increase the balance
so you see what i'm doing to increase the balance here all right i'm going to round
balance plus interest minus payment so you see that's what's happening every month
so we're manually compounding it the balance at that month plus the interest that accrues that
month minus the payment and then round it to two decimal places so when we run this
so we have the payment is 1362 just so we figured and then here we have our abbreviated table month
balance interest so month zero we start out owing 240 000 as we expected but look at that this is
why it makes a difference you're paying 1100 in interest just for that month that's a lot of money
and you know that's it it's you know it's almost the whole mortgage payment you know it's shocking
at first after you do this enough times you come to terms with it and say yes that's right i'm
paying almost all interest at the beginning you know and then 1362 pay 1100 so really then
notice that only 262 is going toward the payment now we could see this really increase slightly
but at month 24 we've paid down some things but it's probably not as low as you'd expect it to be
you'd think like oh i'm paying so much i'd expect this balance to be lower but you see you really
just chip away at it and even then you're paying less interest but it's still more than a thousand
dollars and that's you know month 24 so after two years and you see after month 48 you're paying a
little bit less interest we do see this moving in the right direction you're paying this down
and you're paying a little bit less interest but probably not going down as quickly as you'd want
and that's why i just wanted to skip ahead you know every two years we check in and see the balance
and you know how much interest we're paying you know we take a look at this
now you know we take and we look at this so if we have just over 140 so remember we originally
borrowed 240 still a 140 but at this point now that difference we start building annuity or
start start building equity in in you know if this is a mortgage equity in the house which means
the house is worth is worth a lot more than what we owe and so you could borrow money against that
you know home equity loans that's where that comes in as you start getting lower
and you know the the value of the house is worth a certain amount and then you only owe a certain
amount the difference you know you can actually borrow money against that that'll be a discussion
for another time so we have this and finally now it's still a lot i mean you know sometimes it's
you know to think about wow i'm still you know look at that 20 years in i'm still paying more
than five hundred dollars a month just in interest you know it but at least that's only five hundred
dollars a month and you know we're getting the vast majority of our payments are going at this
point to paying off the mortgage and now when we take a look you know look at that double digits
instead of three digits thirty thousand and then the amount of interest at that point is a hundred
and forty one dollars so uh i wanted to skip ahead and then just do month 359 because look at that
now the balance at that point is just under what the mortgage payment would be and then the interest
is this tiny amount and that would be if you know month 360 when you make your last payment it ends
up being like four or five dollars more than the normal mortgage payment but then it's done
so it works out that that that monthly payment you know using that formula gave us that monthly
payment 1362 and 69 cents and that monthly payment did work out that that exact payment
as you know we're look at the amortization table at 360 months it was you know it we paid it off
and there we go for an extra five dollars the last month i'm not going to stress about that
so these are you know interesting things to think about seeing how using these percent interest
payments applied to loans how that plays out how you're paying off interest how we're making use
of the simple interest and then paying down this balance so this mortgage is the most common but
for any large amount of money over a significant amount of time we would use this formula does not
have to be a mortgage car payments not always because a lot of times they're a lot lower but
if it was a car payment for like particularly expensive car or over that over a longer period
of time then we might use this doesn't have to go to 30 years that time can be anything so we see
this you know paying off this debt over time so let's use something very similar but let's turn
it around and have something positive retirement account estimation now this one instead of owing
money you know this p is not money that i'm borrowing it's money that i'm going to put
into an account and instead of owing money every month i'm going to contribute and so there's no
formula for this that i'm just going to estimate this oh okay let's say 350 just because uh you'll
see you'll see how this plays out and i just picked these numbers here so let's say the
principle is a thousand and this is just estimation here well let's say you start out with a thousand
dollars now this is where the estimation comes in most of the time the retirement account you know
any decent fund manager is going to be able to get you point eight percent or eight percent interest
so now this is your money growing in an account this isn't you paying off a debt it's your money
growing in an account so if you had a thousand dollars and we estimate that it's growing at eight
percent per year that's great and i made this time 38 years as you know not entirely random it was i
just thought like age 22 till age 60 38 years so you start it put a thousand dollars in this
account and then you start saving that you know from that point like you know your whole career
you put away 350 every month in this account okay and i'm going to establish this other variable
annuity which i'm going to start out the original is p so now here's my loop for the contribution
and the percent growth so again 38 years so for a in range 12 t so there you go because every month
we're contributing something so notice what we're doing with this annuity we're taking the annuity
that we already have plus the monthly contribution and then that's going to grow
one plus r over 12 because that's a monthly notice that percent increase formula but this is monthly
so the exponent if it was nt the exponent n would be 12 and t would be 112 which cancels out to one
so i don't need to write the exponent of one but that's where this comes from it is that same
formula r over n to the nt but nt and is n is 12 t is one over 12 and so that cancels out so
so each month then if we take this and that's why i wanted to break this down still monthly
because i want to allow for this contribution here the annuity plus the monthly contribution
we want that to happen each time and then it's going to grow so in this loop now this continues
to grow so at the end we're going to print this out and i'm going to go around because
that'll end up being a weird decimal annuity okay so now the annuity is going to seem like a lot
but this is what we want to break this down if we're if our rate is eight percent so at the end
let's say it's still earning eight percent when you start taking what so the annual income from
interest you see and so that's annuity times the rate that's it and yeah i'm going to two decimal
places but that so if i have this this amount of money that i'm going to eventually get to
then the idea is that money now is yours in the bank or in this in this fund somewhere
that the annual income is just that percentage rate
so when we run it
so take a look at this annuity here so one zero six one five nine seven yes that's more than a
million dollars and if it continues to earn that eight percent the annual income just from the
interest is eighty four thousand dollars or almost eighty five thousand and that's the idea that
this money in the bank or in some investment not not in the bank not saving because nothing in the
bank is going to get you this eight percent interest that makes this happen but this retirement
investment if you're you know you have this and you can contribute something it's you're
constantly contributing and it's growing so at some point then you retire and you have this
million dollars that earns this amount of interest and i just picked you know 38 years um
the earlier you start the better and the later you stop start uh taking money out you know it
can grow even more that you could take the money out at you know uh age i just i just rough
estimated did age 22 to 60 you know if you if you start as early as you can i mean even 18 and
you know till 68 if you look at that that'd be like 50 years that really is what makes a difference
because remember this snowball so that eight percent in those later years that's eight percent
of larger and larger amounts of money and then if you get it to this million then eight percent
of a million is more than 80 000 so that's that's the idea we want to get to this larger amount
of money that just the interest on that you know if this investment keeps going just the interest
on that is enough to live on and you take the interest and then you're back to this amount
which will earn interest the next year so we want to leave you with that that positive idea of how
we can use all this you know that's that's what use all all these you know percent increase formulas
to you know turn that into money in the bank that's that's the goal here all right and you know
hopefully then it works out and if you have these this code you can tinker with this and say you
know how much do you start out with you know keep this rate maybe change the rate a little bit oh
you know my fund manager is doing really well change the time monthly contribution you can
tinker with these and run it and you know see the results so you know prepare for uh you know what
you need to do to invest for retirement so let's look at some more ways you can use these mortgage
mortgage formulas here now like we were doing before i'm going to define actually the payment
formula as its own function so there we go uh def and then payment and i'm going to take the arguments
pr t run it through this formula and i'll just return the payment so this you'll see some places
we can use this and all of these you know we're going to apply these to you know let's say you
know you're looking for a house you're comparing different things so to get this i'm just going
to run this and there we go and i don't need to run that again now i have that the formula here
so i'm going to do a similar function and i get something different because i just want to
show you this one i'm just going to define it pmt and i'm only taking the principle as the argument
because i'm going to just give a set rate and time so with this and then i'll run that through
taking the input as whatever the principle is i'm going to calculate the payment and the reason why
i'm doing this and we see these imports is because i'm going to make this a slider where
i'm just going to go from zero to three hundred thousand and see how the payment changes based on
that principle of course the slider shows it somewhere in the middle
four hundred and fifty thousand the monthly payment would be eight ninety nine thirty three
and we can see how this goes up and here's something you can do you know again if you're
comparing different mortgages or houses you can see how does this really affect my monthly payment
you know and we look at this oh two hundred and twenty one thousand
should i buy a house it's more expensive i know my payment will go up but the question is by how
much you see and we can look at this now that's great to see these exact numbers but maybe i want
to see the trend maybe there's i want to graph it so notice our standard for graphing and in this
case i just define my x maximum is three hundred thousand and my y maximum four thousand that's
going to be plenty all these standard things you would already have set up you know x min max the
points you're going to use for np dot linspace and everything you're going to do to graph
something that i don't always put in there plt dot grid just to show the grid lines and
axe dot set x label and set y label so the x will be the amount borrowed and we see that that goes
from zero to 300 000 and the y will be the monthly payment so now that payment function i defined
earlier i can just use that as my y value i only need the x that i'm going to use as a variable
here and i'm still going to give it just a consistent rate and time so you know x is
the input all these are going to given the same rate and time how does the principal affect the
monthly payment and when we run this we can see that the payment change is actually linear given
that same rate and time and this would be realistic maybe you get pre-approved from the bank so you
you would know your interest rate and you would know the time so just comparing different mortgages
it is linear how much would it increase you know for how much would the payment increase
for increases in the amount borrowed well all right this is a good visual of it but let's
get down to the numbers so it's linear i'm just going to do the slope formula
and i'm just going to pick two values you know and you know x1 and then the payment and notice
this i just put rate and time here and i define them up here just a different way of doing it
i'm using the same numbers consistently throughout this i feel like that would be good
for the consistent example and just pick two x values calculate the payment based on those x
values and calculate the slope formula and what we'll find so without rounding now notice
this is you know dollars and cents so really it would go up you know six cents for every ten dollars
of you know price increase or we can you know multiply it by a thousand here and say it would
go up six dollars you know because 5.99 i'll round up it would go up your mortgage rate would go up
six dollars for every thousand extra dollars you borrow and now you have that in in mind oh okay
an extra thousand that's going to be an extra six dollars in the monthly payment
and you know you can put things in perspective do i like it that much you know oh the extra
thousand it's only six more dollars so we see some things we can do with this we can take these
formulas that we we've been working with and we can define them as their own functions we can
use them in sliders we can graph them and finding aspects of the graph that we can use
and finding aspects of the graph we can do other analysis this is kind of like we want to be
building upon for our data analysis so this is all good and i want to actually then have like a bonus
here beyond the python i know this is almost all python but i want to get into showing how you can
do this in a spreadsheet because that will give you like that full amateurization table and i want
you also how to build that because these are some good spreadsheet skills you'll want okay so notice
the balance here is a formula but we'll get to that in a second so given that given a home price
i picked this two hundred and fifty thousand that's somewhere around the median home price
in the united states right now i want it to be some realistic middle of the road number
down payment it's going to be we want 20 percent so notice if i click on this this is cell g3
up here is the formula and i just did 20 times g2 0.02 times g2 so that way if i change this
and i make g2 you know 300,000 instead click somewhere else then it will automatically
calculate the down payment i think i do want to go back to 250,000 again that's
i feel like that's a good middle of the road number for us to use as our example
and click and it'll adjust again now then the borrowed amount i would subtract that so i'm
going to double click in this and equals g2 minus g3 actually that's exactly what i wanted sometimes
sometimes google will prompt you will give you that and notice that i can click on this and you
can see the borrowed amount and then up here this is the formula g2 minus g3 which is the home price
minus the down payment all right so let's just say the interest rate you know 0.06 and time uh 30 years
now i'm going to write the word years here i'm not going to use this number for anything else
but here the interest rate i will all right now monthly payment we can always then go right back
to this and calculate the monthly payment so we see here i just had this monthly payment there
you go six percent 30 years and i already have this so what if i just made it my borrowed amount
which was 200,000 even and i can just go to this borrowed amount
oh 200,000 now i could actually also just make another since i already have that payment
i could actually right under here write print
payment 250 uh 200 comma 0.06 comma 30
so you see i could just actually just put this in here
and
output the monthly payment all right there we go 11.99 and 10 cents
so monthly payment will be 11.99 and 10 cents
so now notice here this is just a couple of things that we can do here
and 10 cents so now notice here this is just a good reference for all the things we want home
price down payment and everything but these notice i already had to just populate over here
the monthly payment and if you'll notice i have these dollar signs here that's going to be for
some things we're going to do later i mean i don't need them over here but we're going to do some
things later we're going to drag these formulas down and it's going to adjust for according to
the row and the dollar sign will keep that the same so dollar sign g dollar sign four that means
if i ever adjust this that's not going to change it's going to stay too it's going to stay referencing
that cell g4 and same with the payment that's always going to reference g7 and that's what i
that's what i want now the interest we've been doing all these fancy interest formulas but
actually this is going to be monthly each of these is going to be a each of these roads is
going to be a month so for monthly interest we can just do simple interest equals the print that
balance which is a2 times the rate which is 0.06 times the time which is one month
so one month is one twelfth of a year so i'm just going to say divided by 12
and this works out i mean you know that's very nice but it's not always going to work out evenly
so what i want to do is i want to add another function around here round
round open parentheses and i will put you know so it rounds this and if i don't put anything else
you see it'll round it to the whole number but i want to put comma two because that'll round it
to two decimal places and this is google sheets if you you do this in microsoft excel you have to
have that comma and then however many decimal places even if it's zero google if i eliminate
that it'll just round it to the whole number so there we go so round i have my payment and
then my new balance equals the original balance which was a2 plus the interest of the crude
so that's b2 minus the payment which is c2 and i want to take this so we see even you know earned
a thousand dollars in interest you know just you know just sometimes it's a lot to stop and think
about that and all that the paid you just took a little bit off because that earned a thousand
dollars in interest and then the payment was only 11.99 so a little bit of that like 200 bucks went
to the paying down the original principle so i want to take this because then we have the balance
it accrues interest i make a payment new balance and i want to take this and carry it over here
so that was cell d2 so i'm just going to put equals d2 here
here and here now notice if i drag this down
it changed because it's calculating the interest now based on this this balance you see a3
times 0.06 divided divided by 12 and then here when i drag that down it's going to be the same
because i put the dollar sign in there it won't adjust anything and here i will drag this down one
and we see again doing that it adjusts it for this row now everything here was based on row
two everything here is based on row three and we got that by mousing over the bottom right
hand corner you get a little tiny plus sign and this is magnified but you know you'll see
the that thin plus sign and you click and drag that but we're going to do that for the entire row
so i'm holding down shift in the arrow key to highlight the entire row and i'm going to mouse
over that i get that thin plus sign and i'm going to click and drag and this is how we make our
amateurization table now notice my mouse is down below the bottom of this because for 30 years
that's 360 months so somewhere around there is where i'll stop
and these are all negatives so i'm going to take this highlight all these negative numbers and
then just delete them so now here this is you know after this the balance is a dollar so
so we can just make this 11.99 plus that additional dollar 13 and i'm not going to take it to multiple
decimals like that and that should be yes 10 cents negative 10 cents dollar three
three and that should be enough to make that we're just going to call it that many zeros
we're going to call it zero and what we have the row number is always one more because we had the
first row as headings so three given that mortgage payment it works out exactly 30 years exactly 360
months you have a balance of zero so we're going to take take this and we see this is the
amateurization table and you know you can look through it and scroll through it and see how
the payment stays the same but what happens is the amount of interest keeps going down
gradually because for such a large amount of money for such a long period of time every month the
fact that you're paying interest on just that little bit less that really makes a difference
and then that means that look you know that same payment a little bit less interest a little bit
more of it goes to the principal so you know you're you're making some progress
paying this off but it takes a while until see look at this i mean that's almost 1200 so we have
to go into you know 225 months you know we're coming up on 20 years until you know half of your
payment goes to interest or less than half of your payment goes to interest so it's just good
interesting to see that whole table and then this balance here at any given month that's the payoff
amount you know supposing you come into some money and you say oh i just want to pay off the rest of
it you know that that's the balance that's your payoff amount and we have all this now besides
showing you the spreadsheet and how you can set this up and how we can you know grab values from
other cells and how we can add formulas and how we can drag all this down that's great amortization
and you know mortgage mort you know it does sound like death because you know it is the same word
mort so let's do something more positive with a very similar type of formula so supposing
i set up the same thing balance interest i'll capitalize it and payment but i'm going to say
contribution and then new balance so let's look at this in a more positive way supposing that what
this was this amount that you owed that you're paying off but let's talk about a retirement
account that you're adding to so i don't know let's let's start by some like round number like
five thousand dollars and a lot of retirement accounts you know people managing it could
you know get like eight percent interest that's pretty reasonable to think of so we have equals
so we have equals so this is column i two times zero point zero eight
eight percent interest and then for one month so then you know one twelfth of the year so divided
by 12 there we go and maybe you know we could do this we could do this with or without rounding
i'll round it that might that might work out it'll just look nicer round and i'll round it
to two decimal places again dollars and cents okay now monthly contribution so who knows like
you know you can contribute a few hundred dollars let's start with something like this like let's
start with like 200 and we're going to change that later so with balance it gains some interest
and you contribute so it's all plus equals i2 plus j2 plus k2
and then we're going to carry that around so that's l2 equals l2
l2 and we're going to do the same thing drag this down one drag this down one
drag this down one and what we have is you know given that you know rate of interest
given the contribution you could always add more different times but i want to show you this
for about the same amount of time so if we drag this down
now this being a retirement account a lot of times people will start this earlier
so we don't really even have to stop at 360 let's stop with like 400 nice even number there
um there we go uh 401 because the first rose so what we have is this at that point then
you know this amount that you have is 469 thousand dollars and the interest every month is 3000
this 3000 so you could easily like take that interest and then you're back to 465
you take that 3106 out every month and live on that and then you're back down to this
so you know it it you know goes from this and then back to this take that out and then you're
back to this that's one way to do it i just want to show you so let's let's get even more optimistic
here and say then we contribute something like you know 400 dollars a month we're going to drag
that down in a little bit and this one let's say you know 0.085 i don't know a little bit
more optimistic on the there we go drag that down a little bit and so now that second row again is
correct and we'll drag this down and the other thing i'm going to do is take this a little bit
longer maybe even like uh 450 months or something like that 40 years would be 480 months
so we can take this even further and you'll see that just you know some of these you know you get
some poss some nice possibilities here all right and because look at this final number here so
because look at this final number here so yes that one is one million so you know that's what
we're talking about here you know one million dollars and the monthly interest is nine thousand
eight hundred eighty five dollars so this is something you know again i want to you know
take this same math and turn it around and make it positive something that you could be contributing
to and then at this point you have this money you know in this investment that you can take this
out every month or or less and you know not have to worry about it ever running it running out
take that out and then you're still left with this you know more than a million boom take that out
live off the interest and you still have this every month take that out you still have this
to generate interest the next month and these are some of the things that you can look at
that you know from the other side of it you know you owe all this money to pay off this mortgage
but then you own this house and on the same time you're contributing and you know here then you
have money that you can live off of and you know these you know these are the types of things we
want to do with our math skills look at how we can manage manage money to you know later on
in life then have this you know property that has equity and you know as value and something else
in the bank that you can live off of and there we go you know putting the math skills to use
and seeing how you can make this work for you seeing the trends that you know it seems like
now you might be working hard and owing a lot and not having that much but you know over time like
many years you build things and then you have things oh i have this that i can now you know
they've built over decades and can live off of it so that's really good and you know we were doing
some of this with the other uh python you know generating just some of the values but you see
like these you know these are some of the ways you can make this work for you and you know look
at the trends and hopefully this helps you make some decisions about investments you know
whether it be real estate or borrowing money or other retirement investments all right so that was
just you know some bonus and there we go we're in the home stretch hopefully you're really seeing
this all come together you know skills that you're building
building
so let's talk about exponents and logarithms so the exponential form
is this two to the exponent three two to the third power equals eight so we know how to do that
we've been doing this so far in algebra then logarithm is the same information rearranged
so this same information the log base two of eight equals three so the logarithm is always what's the
exponent that's what we want to know that's what we want to know and in what we've been doing so
far and in most calculators you know two to the third no problem i know how to put that into the
calculator in python they don't even have to import anything but if i know the base
and i know what i often call the result if i know the base i know the result but the exponent
is what i don't know then that sometimes becomes a problem especially when it doesn't work out
nicely like this works out but supposing you know it wasn't a nice you know a nice nice exponent
even nice exponent like three supposing you know two to what exponent gets me nine or ten
it's going to be some weird decimal but how do i how do i get that and so you know we we have
to appreciate that you know uh john napier you know spent like about 400 years ago spent like
20 years of his life figuring this out and making tables and now we have this at the touch of a
button on the calculator and we're going to look at also how to write the code for this now with
logarithms we do have to import something but you know we'll import a library you know much quicker
than spending 20 years years of your life figuring this out so if we have you know two to the third
um you know the the base is always going to be whatever you know the same thing with an exponent
what i call the base so if i have you know log base two of eight you know it's what's the exponent
now what's interesting is our count in our calculators we you know you can do the log
you'll see a log button now if i have the log if i just say the log of a hundred and supposing
i don't see any number there if i don't see a number then it's understood base 10 and we call
and we call that the common log because our number system is base 10 so if it's 10 i don't have to
write that and so the log of a hundred is two because 10 to the second power is 100
and we're going to use this a lot of times for working with scientific notation and maybe even
converting decimals so that you know that's that's where a lot of times i i'm going to use
the common log and then i might even if i'm doing things like scientific notation i might even do
the floor function because if you know what's the log uh you know like 150 it's going to be
two point something but then for converting it to scientific notation i may be just interested in
the two because then that tells me to move the decimal place too so then that would be you know
1.5 times 10 to the second you see you know different things that we want to do with uh
converting this for scientific notation all right other interesting things about logarithms well
that exponents and logarithms they're inverses of each other so if i have
um if i have the log base two of two to the third then or actually i'm not even going to put it to
a definite number i'm going to call this x because then anytime the answer is x you see if i take
the log of the exponent anytime you have a function of its inverse it cancels out to x now
now notice then what we're saying here the log base two so two to what exponent gets me two to the
x oh x is the exponent you know makes sense and the same type of thing works with if i have two
to the log base two of x exponent same thing that's exponent and log inverse because remember take a
look at this log base two of x so it's two to what exponent gets me x so remember anytime we log we
want the exponent two to what exponent gets me x and whatever the answer is it's an exponent and i
am and then in fact taking two to that exponent so i would end up with x so we see you know that
we're going to use these inverses and this is where it becomes very useful you know for whatever
for whatever base i have if i'm solving something if i have three to the x equals you know 25 now
that doesn't work out nicely if it was 27 x is three that's nice but i know i'm going to do this
on the calculator what am i going to put on the calculator well how can i get how can i get it to
x equals something well if it's three to the x then if i take the log the log base three
of this three to the x and then on the other side it's going to be the log base three of 25
so in algebra in the things you know i do the same thing to both sides what are the things that i can
do well one of the things i can do to both sides is take the log of both sides as long as it's the
same base so if i take the log and i pick base three because of this because then that cancels
down to x and then over here i have the log base three of 25 which is what i would do in the
calculator and we'll see in the code you know we're going to import a library and we'll be
able to do this you know no problem on the calculator or in the python code now another
thing is if you're on a calculator or you know you want to do different sort of python code
i could just do the common log for this it actually works out also the log of 25
divided by the log of three so the log of this divided by the log of the base and again it can
use common log or whatever i'd want for that so you know that's pretty interesting
you know what another way that like that works so change of base formula if you ever find yourself
in a situation where you don't have the ability to do the log of any base you know you can use
you can use whatever logarithm you have and do this so that's where you know exponents and logs
we use that inverse property when we're solving and that comes up a lot you know if i if i want
to look at things you know things that are growing exponentially anything continuous growth
sometimes it's you know radioactive decay for dating carbon all kinds of things sometimes i'm
in this situation exponent my unknowns in the exponent and so i want to use a logarithm to
figure that out the other log is going to be the so we have all the different bases and
the common log which is base 10 but then i also have the natural log
and if i was writing this it's i'm going to i'm going to write it as l n we'll see that a lot of
the logarithm functions in python they actually if i just say log it actually goes to natural log
not base 10 so that that's really interesting in python the default is natural log if i don't put
another base there but if i was writing it out it's l n for natural log and so if i have the
natural log of of anything so the natural log means that it's base e and so and base e
e is about equal to that 2.71828 1828 and then after that it's less than five but then you know
it just that pattern stops so oh 2.71828 so he's about 2.71828 1828 and it keeps going this is used
for a lot of continuous growth formulas so if i have you know the natural log of you know 2.7
well then my answer is going to be you know about one it's going to be a little bit less than one
it's like 0.99 or something like that you know 0.99 and i can you know i can use the natural log
for for some other things and we'll see some of the applications of that too when we get to the
code but that's where if i have base e so if if it's base e i just make this l n if it's base 10
i can just write log and if it's any other base and the bases we usually want to have them as
whole numbers but if it's any other base then i'm just going to actually write the base
so okay so we take a look at this we'll see how we can actually calculate a lot of this
in the code and that's going to be pretty useful for some of the some of the applications we have
so let's take a look at the code so when using logarithms in python we'll just import the math
library and now we have math dot log there we go math dot log and it takes two arguments the number
and then the base so this is math dot log of 10 000 base 10 so when i run it there we go it'll be
four this works out nicely for things that we know are going to be a nice integer but i also want to
show you that python weirdness sometimes even when you think it's going to be a nice integer
math dot log of a thousand base 10 so i expect this to be exactly three but when i run it
it gives me this long decimal so any of these even when you think it's going to work out nicely just
the way that this works behind the scenes you might want to just build in a rounding function here
so i'm going to round all this math dot log of a thousand base 10 and i'm going to round all that
to four decimal places so you just might want to build build that in so that way you're going to
get that answer and notice i still said four decimal places but because it worked out
not rounding not needing decimal places it didn't have to give me like four zeros after the decibel
there we go so that's just the usefulness of it that it's just worth it build the round function
in there all right so that said i have a few of these that i don't have the round function
just to show you what the exact answer might be so if i have base two there we go again import math
and then we're going to do math dot log in this case 16 base 2 so when we run it it's going to be
four and i don't have the log in there so if i have something like 15 base 2 i don't have the
rounding so you see it'll give you all that if you need these decimals all these decimals for
for something it will give you that but there you go just whatever the number is and then base
natural log i'm going to import math again and notice here i can just do math dot log of a number
and if i don't give it that second argument of what the base is it'll default to natural log
and e is about 2.7 so if we we do this we see you know it gives it that rounding now what i also
want to show you is as we were talking about before uh so math dot e if i just want to use e for anything
math dot e is going to be the most exact you know it'll give you all those decimal places you don't
have to just you know guess at it but also e to the fourth then and i store that as variable x
so if i have e to the fourth and then i take the log which is the natural log my answer should be
four because the log of that exponent or if i have e to the third the answer is three so you know if
i use that math dot e to get the most exact uh approximation of e and then log without the other
argument then it will cancel out and that'll that'll work out the same way if i did like
you know 10 to the fifth and then log you know base 10 you know that works too so
just just to show you this all right so other good uses of log or especially natural log
answering the question how long will it take for an investment to double
and i still wanted to put the algebra in here so if we have our general continuous growth formula
so i have p and then i have the annuity what number p what what it starts out as an annuity
what number it ends up so if it's doubling then whatever i have for p doubling would be two p
whatever the number is so i can divide both sides by p and then i get this e to the rt equals two
so as we were looking before about getting to exponents if my unknowns in the exponent
it what's my base and then i'm going to take that log of both sides so if it's base e i'm going to
take the natural log so on the left i have the natural log of two and on the right natural log
of e to the rt as we just saw is going to be that exponent so that's why we do that if it's base e
i'll take natural log and then they will cancel out the function of its inverse and then if i
want to solve for t now i have rt divide by r so i would have this the natural log of two divided
by r gives me how long it would take money to double so we can just put this in some code i'll
just define r as the rate here you know two percent you know sort of like a low inflation rate and
natural log of two divided by the rate so i am going to round this log two so notice no other
argument there log two and divided by r and also the rounding is no other argument so it'll be a
whole number there we go and we get it to be 35 years so if something's increasing at two percent
35 years from now it'll be double and like i said as a low inflation rate something that costs
whatever now 35 years from now it'll be about double that price so we have this or if i have
you know some investment you know oh nine you know nine percent and i say oh this you know this seems
to be doing okay i put money in this investment how long will it take for that money to double
in this case eight years so there we go so you know some people might make that determination
for what they invest in and there we go answering that question write some code so in graphing this
i want to show you this pattern of graphing the exponent and the logarithm so we're going to do
all the usual imports for any graph we're going to do all the usual you know x min x max set the
dimensions here and we've done this before when we use numpy i need the no i need this the number of
points here because then i'm going to create my numpy array np dot linspace from x min to x max
using this many points so there's my array now for this i also created a second array
array specifically because my x min i don't want it to go down to negative 10 i wanted to start
at 0.01 and we'll see that in a second and then again set up all the all the graph here so
i'm going to graph this first line here y1 equals math dot e to the x so there we go
i imported math just for this using math dot e so if i'm graphing e to the x plot that
and then line two so then if it's e to the x i want to do the natural log and so notice it's log
and i didn't use the math one here i wanted to use the np dot log for use the numpy because i'm
graphing so numpy has log built in also so i want to use that because i'm graphing that'll match up
with with the numpy array and that's this is why i wanted x2 as my argument here because logarithms
can't be zero and they can't be negative so i didn't this actually would give give an error
but it would still graph it just with that error and i didn't feel like seeing that so i i created
that other array starting at 0.01 so there we go so now i have e to the x natural log and my line three
it's just y equals x all right so this is what this looks like and this blue line that curves
upward that's the exponential function and going to the left it actually doesn't really touch zero
it just gets really really close beyond what this display can show but it doesn't ever get to zero
and then this orange line that logarithm it the x value can't be zero and then it goes up and it
has this curve to it as x gets bigger this increases but it not so much especially as it
goes on and on and then the green line is y equals x so if it looks like these are mirror images of
each other across that line that's true like any inverse functions they are mirror images across
the line y equals x so kind of cool how that works out so we see this numpy arrays of points
e to the x natural log of x and just as a slight comparison i wanted to show you that if i have
two to the x and i'm going to use this and comment out this other one so instead of e to the x if i
have two to the x all right there you go two exponent x and then here i have the log base two
and again i'm going to use numpy and you see numpy's log instead of a second argument they
have different functions so this is so log is natural log log two is log base two and then
there's log 10 so those are the main ones you'd you'd want to be able to use there we go so i'm
gonna have log two here and then the line y equals x so if i run that it's going to be slightly
different because two is not as big as 2.7 but very similar and often you know if but if it were my
drawing i i wouldn't be able to draw the subtle differences so i would say oh they all kind of
look the same you know exponential logarithmic y equals x there we go so we use these as some
good good estimates here all right we can also use logs for scientific notation now here i just had
it print out 3.2 times 10 to the fifth now i wrote that in scientific notation but it'll print it out
with with all the zeros here and here i have it as a negative exponent 4.5 times 10 to the negative
second there we go and you might be wondering about that comment why negative two works fine
why that's an important thing and there we go uh we see the output here because exponent negative
three gets weird very interesting because the exponent of positive three 10 to the third you
know got a little weird too and you see just the way it works behind the scenes the negative three
we would think that it would stop there and that'd be fine but it gives you all these other zeros
and then a five at the end unnecessary but as i was mentioning before the rounding will
will solve a lot of these problems so you know i just use this with for the for the negative four
so i have this 10 4.5 times 10 to the negative four and i'm going to round it to five decimal
places so if i have a negative exponent let's say negative four then i want to round it to five
decimal places and then that gives all of these because it'd be 4.5 and i want that extra decimal
place to show that so you see rounding rounding again works out very nicely and then if i have
negative five and greater it forces the scientific notation so as much as i want to say that i'm just
going to print this out i already have it in scientific notation i even say round it to six
decimal places doesn't matter the output python wants to put in scientific notation and notice
this e is not e 2.7 but it's 4.5 times 10 to this exponent so python uses this and a lot of
calculators use that notation also we can convert something to scientific notation
if i take this so i want to get the number of decimal places so if i take the log so this is
variable a so if i take the log of a and base 10 so this one i'm just using the math library if i
take the log but since it's not 0.001 it's not going to work out to it's going to be like one
it's going to be like one point you know it's going to be like uh this is four decimal places
is going to be four point something so that's why i want to do math dot floor to get just that
exponent i want to chop off all the the extra decimals in my answer here and then the log of
that the floor of that is going to be the exponent so that's what's going to give me that negative
four and then if i take n i'm going to round that 10 divided by that exponent and this formula also
works for larger numbers too but if i take that and then round it then in this case rounded to
two decimal places that's fine that's n i could stop there but i have this extra loop here just
in case there's rounding errors because it could work out somewhere that n ends up being
greater than 10 you know that that happens and so in that case then i then i want to make sure that
i still get true scientific notation one number than the decimal so there we go i'm going to just
if it's greater than i'm going to increase the exponent now for this one there you go a equals
point zero zero zero five and there we go it gives you point zero zero zero five equals five times
ten to the negative four and then this should work for all kinds of other exponents that you're
converting it to scientific notation if you wanted to so these are some of the uses of
logarithms you know we can see the graph that's pretty interesting but we can see
the applications the solving sometimes if my unknowns in the exponent we can see converting
to and from scientific notation so these are a few applications of logarithms and i'm sure
you will find even more so you can make use of make use of this code and enjoy
here we have the foundational math three certification three and like the others you're
going to make a copy first of all and work through this whole notebook make a copy put it in your
google drive and then from your copy we'll do first step like before according to the
testing library and later on in this unit or the next unit we'll look at the mechanics behind this
and how you can set up your own virtual your own library hosted on github and use that import that
into whatever notebooks you want so you know as you can see here we have the first step
whatever notebooks you want so you know as we get through this course you know you see the mechanics
of setting it up and then you'll learn how to set up all these things but for now i just have the
comments here you know install requests here's the library and when we run this then it will get the
library take it uh as as a new file locally here uh behind the scenes we won't have to worry about
it and it's imported there we go and this last thing says that yes it works and so we will go
on to the next step there we go and remember the runtime run uh it times out you know 12 hours
consecutively at the most or about a half hour of inactivity so you just just get in the habit if
you know working on part of this you leave come back then you go and run this first cell again
so we were looking a lot of into graphing before now we're going to graph inequalities so when
i have let's say y is greater than or equal to 2x well if i have then if i can graph a line but how
do i shade that well we have this argument here fill between and so it gives us a range of values
so we're going to go here import matplot library and import numpy like we were doing before
and we're going to set our window like we were doing before how many points you know numpy that
linspace give our points setting up the graph all this is very similar this one got a little
fancy put a title on there so we have the plot title y1 just like we would do before supposing
i was graphing this just as a line we see all the similarities there we go here's the code change
and remember this we have plot these two and then we have this third argument
we had this third argument so if you're working through this and remember you know this if you're
watching this video maybe hopefully you already did work through this so this is going through
you know double checking anything you did or if you want any deeper insight about this but then
we have the second arguments are the fill between so this one notice we have here you see it's
fill between so we still have one x value and the y values are what we're between so between y1 and
zero and i'm just going to run this to show you you see it fills between y1 and zero so
that doesn't matter you know that's not a consistent you know over on the left here zero
is up top and over on the right it's down to zero but thinking about the top of the graph
oh what if i just change that to if i want to shade above what if i change that to y max
without the caps
and then we're always shading above between that line and the maximum y value so you see then shade
below you can change it to y min and there we go and when we do that there we go code test passed
so part two well we had this one is a nice solid line and remember then that's greater than or equal
to but what if i wanted you know not that solid line so we have all the rest of the same things
here we know the logic of this so now if i have y min now that's going to change you know to shade
below and this is the only thing we're going to change if i have this remember the default
gives me a line until i do the fill between but what if i wanted this to be a dotted line
so we see you know see if i have b dash dash r dash dash gives it a dotted red line
and we run this so now we see and sometimes i'll do that i'll make the line red so that it really
stands out if i made the blue just blend in so now we know this would be less than but not equal to
and there we go yes and knowing now that we can make some lines you can define these lines
you can define these lines we can make art for example we can do that fill between and we can
fill between two different graphs two different functions oh that might be interesting then
this defaulted to notice i didn't even define the color blue here
but i can define that face color what color do i want to do i want to make this so
so if you know like a lot of your basic colors you actually can just get away with just putting
that you know i want to be green put it in green in quotes single quotes yellow a lot of the common
color names this will work out so that'll work so the directions here would be run the code
and then reverse the order so we see here like before here's the graph this is the line we're
plotting and remember we defined the x value up here once so here's this y value plot this
i'm not worried about making a particular line so two arguments are fine and now i have the fill
between and see what i have x y1 and between that and 10 or i could just easily make it you know y
max but that's fine and then i add the other argument face color red line two i have this
and fill between now notice between y2 and y1 so you know we can always define it as
you know between other values that's this is this will come up especially if you want to make art
you can define your lines and then fill between these lines i mean this is really vector graphics
so then change this you know we have this color and same thing all of these
you know this line y3 and i'm going to fill between y3 and y2 next one y4 there is that
function fill between y4 and y3 and so when we run this see that first one it filled between
there up to the top and then i did not decide to have another one to fill down to the bottom we
just left it here so if we take this and reverse the colors so we're just going to take these face
colors and make the first one blue there we go and we'll reverse them blue green yellow and then
red at the end so the next one will be green and the next one will be yellow and the next one will
be red there we go so now we have this and we see when we run it it reversed the colors
so there we go interesting things you can do and if you were making art you can make these
whatever formulas you want remember you know we were looking at all the different you know
you know quadratic you know uh exponential functions so if you want different curved lines
and you can just define that you want it to be between something and something and
where i define this linspace here once so that's the reason why all these go to the edge
but you could always for each of them you could define lines you can define that linspace as
within certain values and you can make all kinds of shapes and then continuing on what we're doing
with other graphing i kept these axis lines but you could always eliminate them too there we go
you just keep your window size but then you could always eliminate each axis again you can
again you can get creative with this make some different art all right and now we get into
looking further into factoring into representing equations so monomial is one thing uh we see that
mono is one and then it actually overlaps n o m is name that exact word is name in some languages
and then i al just makes it a noun so one thing one term so each term has a sign coefficient
and variable and an exponent we don't think about that all the time but when we see it here
definitely i see a negative sign i see the coefficients three x to the second power so
but if i have you know all of these the term x also has that so this is positive one x to the
first power just things to think about because that really comes into play for some other things
that we do with factoring etc even even a constant like five is five to the zero five
five x to the zero because x to the zero is one and this will help us you know in thinking about
each of these you can have a monomial and just make sure that you define each of these even though
sometimes these values might be one or zero and you might not display them so here we have this
now this is just a very interesting within simp i we have eq which is going to display the equation
and you see how this equation is eq and then in parentheses i'm going to have what's on the left
and then what's on the right so i define it as an equation and left and right just gets separated
by a comma so you see what we have here so just showing you that this is one way you could you
could use this within simp i for some other things that you might have been doing in in other parts
of this course you know if you wanted to make sure you have a nice display at the end you know bring
up eq you know use your variables that you already have and you see we just defined x as the as the
symbol here so we could do this and then just display it and then look at that nice display there we go
and so we have monomials one thing binomial bi is two trinomial
is three and after that we kind of stop counting so polynomial is just many poly is many
three and we'll usually put them in order so we take x as the variable we'll put them in order of
the highest exponent and if we want to graph this then it would be all that equal to y
so there we go here's your example and it continued on to the next line so what i can do is if if i
know this i this is the normal standard standard form setup so you could prompt for each of these
coefficients and then display them and so there's what we have here that's what i'm asking you to do
so we're going to use this display and we're also going to use some math we're also going to
to import everything from simpy so now we have these symbols and we want a coefficient and yes
i do want to cast it as an integer though i mean realistically the coefficients do not have to be
integers so there's our coefficient and a and b continue to prompt for variable c and d so what
you can do is you can copy this and make this c input coefficient c and then we'll do
for d input coefficient d
all right so we've done that and now we want to display the full one so we have we're going to
display ax to the third bx squared and then we do the rest plus c x
plus d and notice we you might have remembered this from before yeah in in writing the math
i just put these right next to each other ax means i'm multiplying but remember the python
notation i have to put that multiplying in there so it is ax to the third bx squared cx d there we
go now we have this this is great we have this in python notation and we were just talking about
we want to display this in a nice way oh well i have to convert that to latex which is really the
way we're going to you know to display math terminal math formulas so now we have this
i'm going to convert that python to there you go so if we have this two
two three four and five
so you see we can take this and convert it that way you have all this for things you know we're
thinking ahead we're building things that you can use you have all this that once you bring in these
coefficients you could do other math to this here and then maybe at the very end display
this this formula in a nice way so there we go that's what we have and yes that does look nice
so this is going through so interactive polynomial so now we're going to take this
this you know here's well quadratic but there we go and given this polynomial
we're going to adjust each of these coefficients so again in doing this this
certification notebook you should see that this is coming up you know things that you've done before
and hopefully you've already worked through this and you know maybe there's just some of these that
you were stuck on or if you forgot so remember we were doing before that plot library in line
and we're going to bring in the interactive from the widgets there we go all these things
and remember these the function of a b and so for this one we're going to change it to include a
third slider so there we go so my function needs to include c
because i need these three inputs great and then all the rest of these are fine
ax squared plus bx i have to add this plus c
c and so that will show the plot and then we want to make all these interactive so
i'm going to run this function a b i just need c
so we can just copy that comma
c
so now we will have three sliders a b and c and we have the interactive and then we're going to
display the interactive plot so there we go so that's how we can and you see how
you know using the same thing you can modify this to have four coefficients so now we see and it
looks like nothing because everything is zeroed out but as soon as a gets to be something
then we have a quadratic you know negative all right so that's nice and then we have b
and it's always interesting to move these and see what this does to the graph
so you can tinker with this and see remember that just moves it up or down
there we go so you can take these and you can tinker with you know once you have this i mean
code test pass but these notebooks you can always tinker with these what you know you pass the test
you know you've learned that step you can go back in there and pull around with these sliders and
see let's see what it looks like so now we're going to do exponential functions and remember
our exponential function y equals a times b to the x and there we go as long as a is greater than
zero then we'll have an upward or as long as a is greater than one it'll curve upward and same
thing as long as b is greater than one we'll curve upward all right so again thinking about
some of the exponential functions the so what we're going to do is we're going to run this code
see the sliders and then change the slider so that a actually does have negative values
instead of positive so here we have all these importing same imports and notice i made a y
minimum and y maximum a lot bigger things grow exponentially so kind of need this to display a
decent graph here we just have a and b and you see one to nine we just want them to be positive
so when we run this we're just going to see what this looks like
there we go and
either one you see as i increase this it gets to be steeper
but we see the general shape of this it just gets to be steeper and then if i change a
it just gets to be steeper and then if i change a
i'll even make this low because it don't it still will be positive
so that's that's really all these you know they kind of do the same thing
thing maybe b has a little more of an effect but then you see it's kind of that same upwards
upward curve and then as the x values get negative this really doesn't touch it's you know you can
get it's beyond what the resolution of any computer screen could do because if you keep zooming in
in you know it looks like it doesn't touch and then it looks like it does but if you zoom in
then it doesn't so you know that's the general trend so if we make this negative then we still
need to do one more thing because this interactive graph takes this range as lowest to highest so
net making it negative negative one is not the lowest we have to switch these negative nine
is the low value and negative one is the high value remember because it's more negative so if
we don't switch those also then we would get an error so we get this and we can run this and we
see just making the a value negative would make the whole graph go below the y-axis because
b to the x would be positive still so then a being negative there you go just flips it
and just a note making b negative i'm not going to even worry about doing this right now but if
we did that it works for integer values of the exponent but since this is a continuous graph
it would be integer it would be work it would work and it would be you know positive if it's
an even exponent negative if it's an odd exponent and it would go up and down like that but all
those in between values because that would be mathematically doable also in this case they
would actually be imaginary they wouldn't they would not necessarily work out well
sometimes if we had you know some of them would and it would just be a mess so we're not we're
not even going to mess with that changing b to negative it just really would end up not displaying
anything but behind the scenes that's what's happening it works out for some values but
doesn't work out nicely for others and you know a graph would be a mess but let's look at stuff
that does work out nicely percent increase so hopefully you remember the formula from
working through it in the previous unit but then we have you know all the percent increase
and if i were to graph this so we have a equals p times one plus r to the t
and a is annuity and that would be the y value if you were graphing this and you would know
p and you would know r so t would be time in years but that would be the x value if you were
graphing it and so we have all this yes p is the principal the amount you start out with r is the
rate converted to a decimal and t is time in years and just the way we often see it p usually is
capitalized so it's just interesting in in my variables i kept them all lowercase but a lot of
times you'll see that written you know they're lowercase but p gets capitalized
um all right so you have your starting amount so you can prompt for these and then you not have to
worry about changing the code well we are going to change this here so you can prompt starting
amount as input and converting all these to float numbers so you don't have to worry about changing
numbers percentage rate converted to a decimal and how many years that'll be t so we're just
going to take this equation and put it down here in python terms so we have p which we would have
gotten from here so p times and remember i have to put the times it the multiplication in times
one plus the rate and all that to the exponent of time and there we go just translating that
equation to to python and then we'll print out the annuity so when we run it starting amount
one thousand just take these nice even numbers all right and we have point zero five as the rate so
that'd be five percent and how many years then let's see uh let's say like seven years all right
and i didn't worry about putting in another function around this but you probably would
but there you go to two decimal places this is what the annuity would be thousand dollars at five
percent for seven years and then we have percent decrease very similar formula except notice we're
subtracting inside the parentheses because it's one minus three and this does this does happen we
does happen we have car value values of cars or some other products that might decrease at a
certain percentage rate every year the decay of some elements so that radioactive decay or
certain elements like carbon 14 that are very predictable so that decays at a definite rate
knowing how much that we can measure how much that is we can figure out the
the age of something some sales discounts maybe there's something that decreases
at a percentage you know every week if it's not sold so you have some applications of this
and notice we're going to do same thing prompt for pr and t and then we'll put our formula in here
very similar p times and then in parentheses one minus r close the parentheses exponent t
so there we go and we see you know the jupyter notebook the colab notebook always wants to give
us tool tips and advice on what variable and everything so there we go we have this and we'll
run it all right so there you go so let's just say i had my you know twenty thousand dollar car
that uh decreases at 0.09 which might be the you know rate of decrease who knows and then
how many years will decrease you know let's just say 10
so there you go that twenty thousand car twenty thousand dollar car average uh rate of decrease
depreciation is nine percent so it loses nine percent of its value every year for ten years so
then ten years later that car is worth seventy seven hundred dollars seventy seven eighty eight
that might be the case i mean you know this is not uh don't quote me on on this rate but you know
for the sake of practicing it that that rate's probably realistic
all right so now we have compound interest which is very much like the percent increase
but we're taking it you know we could use compound interest we could use that formula
before if it's compounded once a year so now we have this formula notice how similar it is
but it's r divided by n and then the exponent is nt so if it was compounded once per year
and is one so that doesn't that goes back to that formula we were just using
but where n is multiple times per year you know this is the formula that we we would use
and remember that that's really and that's why we wanted for any percent increase that's why we
wanted to convert it to that formula that it's something that's a multiplier and we can then
easily adjust the rate of decrease that's why we wanted to convert it to that formula
and we can then easily adjust this for how many years something you know increases or decreases
and in this case now we had the other twist also then for how many times we are calculating this
every year i mean n being 12 that's pretty common you know a lot of banks a lot of bills
you know they calculate things you know once a month so we're going to do all these starting
amount all the rest very similar and then we're going to add this line here n number of times
compounded so using this formula then we'll do p times and in parentheses one plus but now i have
r over n i'd rather use extra parentheses just to make sure that nothing gets mixed up in the math
uh r divided by n and all that to the
so you see r over n in the extra parentheses to the nt but again just to be sure i'll put that
in parentheses n times t in parentheses so that way it stays together that python doesn't actually
python might not but i want to make sure it doesn't accidentally take it to the n power and then
you know well then multiply by t so there we go p times one plus r over n to the nt
and that's going to give us our annuity so
just to be interesting let's use the same one we did two steps ago that one thousand dollars
converted to a decimal and we were saying that that was at 5.05 and we said seven years
and and 12 is pretty common but i'm going to say 52 let's say it was compounded
you know every every week all year
here so what do we get 14 18 and 82 cents and let's just quick go back and compare this
to our
increase 1407 and 10 cents so look at that just that little amount of money
made us another 11 because it was compounded that often it's a little bit more because
you have that little bit extra advantage this is money growing and then that little bit extra
percent for that little bit more time you know gets you a few more dollars so you might be thinking
well okay 52 then maybe 365 would give you a little bit more that's true and we can just
quick do that so remember that was 1418 and if we did this so that same thousand dollars percent
we're going to do the same 0.05 the same seven years but then this is going to be 365 compounded
every day so you see 1419 it gave you another dollar so compared to once a year you know you
made about 11 more dollars doing this every week but from every week to every day you know gave you
one more dollar so there is a point to where it doesn't really get you that much more and then
we start thinking about well okay can I compound it multiple times per day etc that's when we get
into continuous growth and continuous growth if i use that formula and then compounded it multiple
times a day if i compounded that like three times a day and who knows maybe i just make could even
make n like an even thousand it starts approaching this other formula for continuous growth so to
recap so there you go that's you know money compounding annually so that's the percent
increase but we take it as annually and then n times per year we have this formula and then as
n gets to be really big like i said like a thousand or something it actually approaches this other
formula pe to the rt and this is useful because as we see later better ways to even figure out
what the rate or the time would be if i know these other values so it goes from this a little more
complicated to i actually think this is a little bit easier formula p times e to the rt and that
e is not just a random variable e is this constant equal to about 2.718281828 that 1828 after looping
through that twice the next time it's not exact so it's not just like this you know keeps repeating
that would make it even easier but it actually after that second time then it's a little bit
different okay so we give the code that we're already going to prompt for these and this time
we're going to add one more import statement we're going to import math so that we can use
math.e you know you don't have to worry about typing in this because actually math.e is going
to take it to even more decimal places so we have the same thing here principal rate time and
there you go time and that can be an integer that doesn't have to be it can be an integer or float
and is going to be an integer because you can you can't like maybe you know how many times
do you compound it you can't say like oh one time i kind of like halfway did it that doesn't work
okay so now we're going to use these these same formulas we did before
annual so that's going to be p times times one plus r exponent t just like that first formula
and then this one is going to be p times one plus the extra parentheses r over n all that to the
exponent of nt so these are those two formulas and now this one we're going to use math.e
math.e so that's going to be p times math.e to the exponent of r times t
so there we go we see pe to the rt
t and now we have these three so we can prompt and let's compare these compounded annually
compounded n times per year i'm going to put an extra space in there and compounded continuously
so let's take something here and let's just say a principle of there we go 11,000 rate 0.06
and time and let's just say you know 15 years n and we only need that for one of those formulas
but let's say n is a normal 12 so given this compounded annually you would have this much
2632 compounded 12 times a year 26,995 so wow that made you know more than 630 more dollars
just by compounding it but look at that compounded continuously 27,055 so there we go yeah so you
see from here from once a year to multiple times we're talking about making you know more than 600
but then from that to compounding it continuously you know compared to the original you know we're
up to about 700 more and it kind of evens out that oh and this one i think i it gave this error
it gave this error because i used the parentheses so if you're going through this and if you know
you know these errors messages are supposed to be hints just to help you out so it was without the
parentheses and that is okay because python does no word of operations but without the parentheses
it should give us not the error so there we go and should give us the same same values here
so 11,000 rate 0.06 time 15 years and and we said it was 12 so we see same values and the error
message saying you know maybe i'll go in and change that that the parentheses are okay all
right so there we go prompting once and comparing these three different ways of calculating interest
interest so now some of this comes in where we have you know some investment here and investment
often you know something you might be contributing to for retirement and you have some accumulated
value so we have any of these formulas but we also contribute money every month and this i
will say month monthly that's that's kind of a normal normal thing so i'm not going to worry
about like all the different values that that could be okay so we have something that's going
to increase by a percentage and we're using just that simple interest formula interest equals
principal times rate times time so that is just simple interest but for one month that works out
and for one month t equals one over 12 because time in years but then over 12 you can just divide
by 12 so here if i have this we can set up a loop here so prt but then monthly we're going to
ask for the monthly contribution all right now this annuity at the beginning it is p what do you
have i have this i have this amount done so we'll keep that but it's the it's the annuity variable
that we're going to keep updating so somebody said time in years so then our loop is going to be
12 times t so monthly contributions for this long for a and range 12 t
t and now let's see we're just going to say first of all the annuity equals annuity plus monthly
all right so now that annuity value is greater and then now we want the interest just the interest
so that's why simple interest is just the interest equals annuity which is the times rate
time and then times one over 12 and i'm just going to say divide it by 12 so we see the
in principle times rate times time and then 1 12 is divided by 12 so now we have just the interest
and now again i'm going to update annuity annuity equals annuity plus interest
annuity plus interest and because i'm making this a loop then you know these other formulas
are useful for not having to do a loop but we also wanted to add in this contribution
and then there we go so you know we have a few things going on in this loop and then after all
the loop it's going to go through and each time you know add the contribution increase it by that
percentage for that little bit of time you know now update annuity and keep going so when we have
this so starting amount maybe we can say 5 000 and annual percentage rate let's be optimistic
for you know some uh you know retirement account 0.08 and then number of years but then these are
some of the things you might contribute and then have it grow for years so we can even say some
like long amount of time 35 years there we go monthly contribution so let's say like 400 there
we go so that's that's what we have you start out and then every month you're contributing 400
and you know we hope it's growing at that rate
so given this notice how notice what this number is that's a million dollars so what this is saying
is and to get some of these the the rate it it changes that's that's a good estimate but um
it's a reasonable very reasonable estimate so putting money away you know start working
put five thousand dollars away and some good account for as eight percent for 35 years and
then each you know each paycheck you're contributing contributing money then you retire
with a million dollars there you go things to think about that you can put away this little bit
that you can put away this little bit forget about it for 35 years well not forget but you know
and you know have this because if it's earning if it still is earning eight percent as a good
estimate eight percent of that million is eighty thousand dollars and that way you know eighty
thousand dollars interest you can live on that and it still has the million dollars there to
keep generating more interest so there you go
okay so we go from the positive saving money and having a million when you retire to mortgage
payments and yes more like the word for death somebody originally coined that as you know like
this death payment but nonetheless mortgage for any large amount of money over a long period
of time those other percent increase formulas won't quite do it otherwise you you will end up
paying a lot more than is reasonable so this is the much more complicated formula but remember
that's the value of you know setting these up and writing the code that you don't have to like
remember this formula or you know plug the numbers in every time you can again prompt for just like
we were doing before pr and t and figure out what your monthly payment would be
so given that some large some huge amount of money and how banks will set up your mortgage that's
um something else but knowing how much you're going to borrow and then being able to just run
it through this formula and figure out what would your monthly payment be that's going to be very
useful you and again this applies to mortgage or possibly car payments because that's also
large enough sum and a long enough time that this is a much better formula so this is the
this is the formula and again p is principal r is rate t is time and this would have n there
but n would be 12 each time so i just put 12 in there so it kind of goes along with that
formula but n is 12 each time you know there's no other setup you know daily or weekly mortgage
payments or yearly no it's it's always monthly all right there we go so we have all these so
so now i gave you a hint to do this use other variables i like other variables because
look at this r over 12 comes up a few times so you know we can make this um
um there you go r over 12 is uh you know multiplier or if you don't want to use
other variables you can do this there we go and since i don't have n because n is 12
um i could have i might have like just like math n for numerator and d for denominator
and so the payment would be n divided by d because that just might simplify this a little bit
um and then it would be p times n divided by d so i could have just my numerator so equals
r over 12 times and then in parentheses one over r over 12
oh one oh sorry one plus r over 12
12 and all that to the exponent in parentheses 12 times t
so r over 12 times one plus r over 12 to the exponent 12 t there we go so that's the numerator
not bad and then i can have the denominator equals so one plus r over 12 there we go to the exponent
12 put up with some parentheses 12 t and now when i subtract one
you see then that's definitely not a part of that
so yeah and again you could add other variables you can make r over 12 its own variable or
something like that you can make one plus r over 12 its own variable you know different ways to
do that i feel i felt like this wasn't that bad so but breaking up numerator denominator
and then payment times numerator over denominator
so we take a look at this and the amount borrowed we could just say like 200,000
uh annual percentage rate 0.07 you know some of the rates have been going up so i'm just going
to say that for now and number of years 30 is pretty common and so there we go so
there we go so 1330 and change and this helps because then you say okay well you know what's
the cost of the house and i have a down payment you know you get down to how much you're borrowing
that's one thing okay but what's really going to make the difference is knowing this what would
your monthly payment be that's the important thing and you know bonus knowledge that no matter
whatever your income is the monthly payment should be for mortgage or rent right it should be one
fourth of your income or less so just to remember you know if that's your monthly payment then each
month you should be making at least four times that or if you're not then that's not the right
house because sometimes you might say oh yeah i'm making more than that i can afford it but then you
end up being house poor yes you can afford your your mortgage payment but you can't afford much
else all right so let's go on to exponents and logarithms with exponents and logarithms
they're inverse functions they're the same information rearranged so i have this example
here two to the fourth power equals 16 so there you go two base two the fourth power equals 16
and then the log base two of 16 equals four there we go both of those have the same information
rearranged and that's what logarithms are you know picture everything on the one side of the equal
sign oh two to the fourth power i know how to do that plug that into the calculator but supposing
it's the exponent you don't know the log base two of 16 the answer is an exponent you know what
exponent gets me to that so uh this guy john napier like 400 years ago you know he was a
400 years ago he realized that that was a missing piece that that was a situation a lot of people
wanted to know the exponent for different things and he spent like 20 years of his life
developing this and it was you know very useful you know the original logarithms it was just books
you could like look them up now we have this at the benefit of you know calculator pretty easy
and we're going to take it one more we're going to even write the code that you can just put in a
couple numbers and it'll calculate it so if you use the math library and we'll also look at the
numpy library that's another way but if you use the math library so it's math dot log
and then the arguments are you know the log of what so 16 and then comma and then what's the base
so there we go and if you don't have that first argument or if you don't have the second argument
if you just say the log of 16 it takes it as base e but we'll get to that later all right so there
we go the log base two of 16 so here's the code we're going to import math and you know base i
always call the the exponent the result just because it reminds me i'm doing a logger and that's
what i want so there we go so or you know that's the the result of exponential notation so
i had somebody input the base and we're going to input cast as a float and the base can be a float
but usually it's an integer and the result and cast that as a float so what do we want to do
change the next line okay math dot log and we were just saying result comma base there we go
and it'll import this for it and it'll do this for you so that's all you needed to do for this
and we'll run it and this should check it for you there we go base 27 oh how about this base um
three result 81 so it should return four there we go nice you might be able to do some of these
in your head but if you have you know base you know three to what exponent gets you 81 all right
you can do that in your head that's four but this is useful three to what exponent gets you like 80
or gets you 85 you know when it becomes some weird decimal all right so natural logs and we
talked about e so uh this is the this is another use of a logarithm so e and uh just to recap
if you have this formula annuity equals pe to the rt there we go so supposing i want to know
how long it will take for something to double and you'll see the logarithm connection here so
you know whatever i start out with p the annuity needs to be double so if the annuity is double
then whatever p is and annuity is twice then i could cancel it out you know annuity would be 2p
so it simplifies to this and then now one of the many situations i want to know the exponent
exponent well i have base e so math terms i would say natural log i do the natural log of both sides
the natural log of two on the left and the natural log of e to the rt and remember then that cancels
the natural log of e to the rt because that says e the natural log says e to what exponent gets me
this so e to what exponent gets me e to the rt well it's obviously rt so now we're in this situation
we know that take the natural log of both sides now we're in this situation and i get natural log
of two good thing i have a calculator to do this and then if i want to know how long it takes to
double if i know the rate then i would just divide by the rate and then my answer is time so in doing
that math dot log and you see no other argument necessary if i don't put the argument or as far
as what base it is it takes it as base e natural log so there we go and in this one r input the
rate as a decimal and for this one i just put the end just it's this seemed like a long sentence so
the input comes in as a new line on a new line and once the person input the rate there we go it's
just math dot log of two divided by r is time and we'll print out it will double in t years
this is pretty useful so you can run this now this one remember you just needed to run it
so and put the rate so if
let's say i have some investment growing at eight percent and it will double in 8.66 years
six six years so some of the you know you might say all right if my investment's growing at eight
percent and we can even round this down to eight and a half and you can do things in your head
okay well eight and a half years it'll double 17 years it'll double from that you know etc
and you know you could use this to estimate some outcomes all right common logs so if i have base
10 it's the common log if you were writing this in math notation you would just you could just say
log so uh with without the little number because then you know if you don't put the little number
then oh we'll take it as base 10 because that's our number system the common log so this is what
we're going to be using when we want to have you know how many decimal places do i have we're using
things for scientific notation so in the code you see we'll just do math dot log n and then base 10
so you see uh if i don't say the base it's e but 10 even though it's common i do have to say the
base there we go so if we have this and our number with several digits or several decimal places
and this one i just separated into two lines to show you can do that also take the input
you know cast it as n the other reason to put this into two lines is you might notice this vertical
line over here maybe even before writing python you know you might have the sense of you know
you only want the lines to be so long you don't have to scroll over but python really makes that
a design decision if i continued beyond this line it would still work it wouldn't just cut off
that code but just as a convention for writing python code we usually make it i think it's like
80 characters brings it over to that line so there we go i have this one and then i didn't
want to go further on that line so i just made it a separate line casting that as a float okay so now
all right now we have the round the code so this one we have math dot floor so i'm going to
take the log of that but i'm not gonna round but instead of running i'm just taking the floor
of this because i don't want the decimals i don't i don't want to potentially round it up
and i would just you know drop the decimals math dot floor that's going to give me my exponent
and that's actually what what we really want and this is a weird python quirk when the exponents
exactly three it sometimes doesn't give you the answer you want i don't know it's just weird
python quirk so just bonus insight here after doing this enough times i just added this little
if statement here all right and we're going to print the exponent so when we run it
there we go several digits so if i have point you know zero zero zero five all right and
exponent is negative four
four yep
there we go and if we remove the math dot four function
then it will just give us it'll be you know negative four point something else and we'll
just do that there we go so you can see and i'll just to compare i'll do the same number point zero
zero zero five all right and that's it now notice in positive numbers it would be four point
something or three if this was positive three point something and it would drop the decimals
it'd be down to three but with negative numbers the floor from negative three point something the
floor of that is negative four so just interesting insight and again you're watching this video
because if you've gone through the the foundational math three and maybe you're stuck
on something you're what we want some other insight into some of these so hopefully you know
this helps all right now all that you know we can use these logarithms you know how long to take
something to double you know things like this uh number of decimal places and notice i call that
exp for exponent because well first of all that's what we're asking for in the logarithm
but also that leads to scientific notation you know how can i write very big numbers or very small
numbers without all those zeros so if i had like 45 million oh but i can write that as 4.5 times 10
to the seventh or point zero zero zero all these could be 4.5 times 10 to the negative seventh
and there we go so it's always n times 10 to an exponent and n is always one digit than the decimal
so that's what we want you know because 4.5 that's i want that one digit than the decimal
that that's the true scientific notation now this is just changing you know this one here we're
not actually writing code this is determine the value by just by counting uh i just want you know
just to see so you know as we count so how many decimal place how many places one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven because it has to be down to this so that's why we have a
one is 1.56 that's where the decimal would go and a2 would be 11 and then we're going to print that
out a that that is a1 times 10 to a2 so then we'll do this for here so the decimal point would be there
so the decimal point would be there so then it's yeah so then we would move it one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so it would be 4.13 and we have to move it in the negative direction
so it'd be to the negative 10 and so then that would print b is 4.13 times 10 to the negative 10
there we go and we run it there we go now
now this one works displays nicely this one how we want to display it here is nice but python
automatically and this is fine you know you go on the next step but python automatically converted
this one a positive 11th power fine it didn't see a reason to change that but negative 10 so that's
the python notation 4.13 e negative 10 so and this is not the same e this is just indicating exponent
so times 10 to the negative 10 so there we go in this you know hopefully also again if you're
watching this it's you know illustrating like why there's some of these quirks in python all right
so we can use these logs for scientific notation because if i want you know if i want to convert
this to scientific notation in an easy way so what do i do so i did this for for a putting
together the things we did in the last two exercises so for a i'm going to do the floor
of the log of a base 10 there we go and now i'm going to round it so
so it was a i called it x1 for exponent one and so if i have this a times 10 to the negative x1
and it rounds it to two decimal places so if that's the if that's the log then i'm going to
multiply this times 10 to the negative x1 and it's going to print this out so
i'll just show you the code and then we'll run it and you'll see so now using that as a model
what i want x2 and i want to show you that this actually works for positive or negative exponents
oh yeah
so if we have so but this one i want this for b so take the log of b base 10 and the floor of that
and if i have this then i'm going to round that so i'm going to round that um
again referencing b this time
to the negative x2
to there we go so it's what exponent got me there but then when i take that
then that will divide it out that's why it's that that's why it becomes a negative exponent
because i want to divide it out to get that early number there all right so if we run this
and this just took those so you see we get a is 2.34 times 10 to the negative 12
and b is 1.23 times 10 to the 13th
so pretty cool how you could just take this and whether i wanted to show you that whether it be
a decimal so a negative exponent or a huge number with the positive exponent either way
this this works take the log base 10 and the floor of that and that's the negative exponent
that's how we get n1 you know then we're then multiplying it by that and we can display it so
and we can display so this way now you have it you can have a code to convert anything
to scientific notation pretty cool
and that's what we get into step 19 there we go now this one very similar to what we were doing
before and we're just added one more thing of entering a number to convert to scientific
notation so see this is where you can make it as your calculator to convert because i'll just take
this and it works either way i'll copy this code that we had from before and paste it here but
i don't need the number ones because i'm only doing one thing
right and in that case if we want to print you see i even left this that's what we want to print
so we can reuse this and this is the key with copying and reusing code you can do it just
be aware to notice these little things if you just copy and paste something
there there might be a little subtle things that don't line up you know just copying pasting no
good you have to understand the code well enough to know these little things that you need to change
oh okay i needed to delete the ones here all around and you know copy and paste with the
copy paste with the follow-up editing now that works and see what you can do is now you have this as a
standalone uh you know input you didn't have to like define the variables in the code here
and there you go enter in whatever number all right so one two three
three there we go there we go
one two three
oh that's very weird
two three i got to one point two three ah look at this it see as i was mentioning it i didn't
i didn't delete the one there and that variable was still in in memory for that little bit
so it gave me this you know exponent that i was not expecting one two three
there we go
all right pretty good so anything that you have now now we have this standalone code
and then later on what we're going to do is and then maybe i'll use this as an example is we can
put all of this code within one function and so then now you can just define a function that will
convert to scientific notation and all this code is within that function and we can take that and
then that function we can use wherever all right so let's go on to the next one now we'll get to
graphing exponents and logarithms so just connecting with the math natural log is l n
putting the adjective first natural log if i was just writing it on the on the board it'd be l n
and that would be base e and so comparing y equals e to the x and y equals natural log of x
those two are the inverse functions and mirrored over the line y equals x so when we see the graph
we'll see these and then we'll see the line y equals x so we were just talking about using the math
library if i just want to calculate a logarithm i'll use math.log but because when we graph we're
using numpy and we're using the linspace function to create an array of values that we're going to
graph so i have to keep with numpy which i usually import as np so then i'll do np.log math.log as
you see if i want to do one thing yeah that works if i'm using the math library i'll use that here
i'm using np.log and np has it slightly different np has np.log 10 obviously base 10 np.log 2 for
base 2 and if i just do np.log it's going to be base e realistically we don't need to do every
other base because we have the change of base formula which i'll talk about in a second so there
we go so we have the positive x values now e to the if i was graphing this e to the x i have my
all my x values whatever i want but when i do natural log then the x value will never be zero
because remember they're inverses so in this case e to whatever exponent the y value will never be
zero as the inverse here the x value will never be zero so when i graph this hopefully this looks
familiar from other graphing we might have done i'm going to define this and i'll just use this
minimum maximum you know based on here what i did here that's fine but then when i do
log i need i'm going to use a different linspace i won't do zero i'll just pick some like really
tiny number 0.001 and that should be enough to illustrate this point so there we go all right
so i'm graphing these i'll use x1 is my array of x values and linspace goes from minimum to maximum
and then within that range i want a thousand points i mean you'll see for this you'll see a
smooth graph even if you don't have a thousand points all right there we go and then plot x1
and i'll just write the y value here instead of separating it out math dot e for my e value
and then that to the to that exponent there we go and i'll make this a blue line so then we have
the red line for y equals x then x1 and we see if i have this x1 i just can put x1 x1 because
it's y equals x so i don't need to define a new y value which i know it's the same
and here now for my log y equals log of x i'll do this linspace and then np dot log x2 so there we go
all right so we're just going to run this and then change it so we see i see this notate notation
and there we go so we have the blue line e to the x exponential function and graphing that green line
y equals x or y equals the log of x and there we go and this works for any inverse function
there are mirror images across the line y equals x but this there you go it illustrates it nicely
it illustrates it nicely all right now change the blue line and the green line because we want to
make these log base two so here instead of math dot e i'm going to make this just two to the x
you know that's fine and this one instead of np dot log i'll do np log two
now we're not going to notice that much of a difference here because
i went from a base of 2.7 to a base of 2 but there we go that's all you need to do for this one
one i don't want to include some applications here if you have the hydrogen concentration
as a decimal number that's really where the ph comes in so proportion of hydrogen
so the way this this works it's the negative log of the hydrogen concentration
so if we have 0.007 as scientific notation that would be seven times ten to the negative three
which would be a ph of three and then we see that as we got more and more zeros as placeholders
you know a really tiny decimal number then that would be ten to the negative four five six you
know ten to the negative ten you know really tiny number and that really tiny number then
ten to the negative ten would be a ph of ten you know we get the idea so that's really it i just
just taking this and if you knew the hydrogen concentration i was thinking about adding this
in as like going into the chemistry and finding hydrogen concentrations but i'll leave that for
the those of you that want to uh you know pursue the chemistry angle on this but you can you could
actually get you know various uh hydrogen concentrations of molecules and you know
work it out from there okay but nonetheless so what we want to do is we just want the hydrogen
concentration so it's the negative log and for this one i will use math so there we go so we're
going to make this negative math dot uh log and i'm going to log as decimal ten
ten there we go so that's that's really it and now that log i get that number base ten
and what do i want to do i want the ceiling so i'll do math dot
ceiling of this
there we go
perfect all right so there we go when we run this end of the hydrogen concentration
and what if i put your point two three four and there you go and i'll put let's put the number five
i could put a one there
uh math dot ceiling yes so
i would take this as we we look at this and yeah this is the function here we run the function as
is and then do the math dot ceiling so that's what we'll do we'll move our decimal place
and these are the things that i wanted to put in here as you know indications and you see
we see why this this ended up being wrong because then it gave a ph of four
putting the math dot ceiling in the wrong spot
all right so i'll do the same same one here point
i'll put a one that's okay there we go now that gives it a ph of five
there we go now that gives it a ph of five you see how that makes a difference doing the formula
first with the negative log then doing the math dot ceiling there we go now that gets a ph of five
there we go all right so now with functions here
calc these are some of the things how could we write a function well if you want a function
you're going to define the function and calculating mortgage payments okay so maybe
i'll call it mort pay and now notice you would think that it when i hit enter it gave me the
indent automatically but for other things that i do or i might use this code i am all about the
four spaces so i backspace i delete that and then i want to make sure i do the four spaces so what
can i do i can define this function here so and and this is i'll do one and then you can see how
you can do more here so if i have the mortgage payment now we also have our
um table of contents i can jump right to mortgage payments so notice i have
p r and t here
and then i will define these in here
so
here so i'm going to just copy this and actually um
there we go so i'm going to show you one way to do this and then maybe we'll do it a different way
okay there we go and more functions here so one of the things that you can do
is just put everything in here
and i might just
here we go
you probably don't need that extra line and same here so this works as
the payment maybe that's all you need you want to be able to then prompt for these things and then
print out the answer so that works another way is
what i'm going to do i'm going to copy this and i'm going to show you another function that you can do
you can do and that one
all right so mort pay
p r t and for this one i'm going to require input input p r t
t and then
i'm going to not need these
and instead of print
and i'm going to return payment
so this one's nice if that's the if and you know there we go so this one's nice if you wanted to
prompt you know this could this could go a lot of different places but this one you can put this in
maybe then just put this function in and return the payment like exactly where you know it's going
it's going to go so two different situations and that's why you know i'll make it you know
that's why you know i'll make it you know p r t so we know what the input would be and then this one
is different so there we go so that's that's one one way
and i have here more functions now the interactive polynomial graph we were working
with that too i'm going to do one more up here because i wanted to show you the scientific notation
so here we have
enter a number to convert to scientific notation so if we have this uh maybe we want the number to
convert so if i have a as my variable so there's my scientific notation there really just two lines
and if i take that and convert this i could create a function to
a there we go and maybe it just takes that input of a
there we go and
and
return
n
so that could work too
there we go so we take this and move around um
um oh but i would probably have it as a string here so i could go back to that
and instead of the print
uh i could instead of printing it
i could
i could turn this into
um there we go uh answer
answer
and so we may you know i could just make that a string and then return answer
so i probably don't need this a equals
uh
and it should give you n times 10 to the x so just to give you some examples this is where
i want you to be able to you create the functions and then the internet active
graph with sliders we we have that so turn that into a new turn that into a function
but here's the examples how you can just take and and that's the whole thing that we wanted to get
to you know through this course you learn and you're practicing and then you're grabbing the
parts that now you know and you can turn just the important parts that you're going to use later on
into their own functions and you can you know give them other names you know here's more functions
and there you go uh create a function for you know how long it would take money to double
go back to that other one again turn that into a function and all of this
is going to be in a financial app that you'll make so what you can do is you can have one display of
all of these and you could have this work out that it's within all the code here or you could
have it within uh within google co-lab where you have text that gives you like number one
calculate mortgage payment number two retirement account balance number three etc you could have
the text there and then require input which option do you want and then have all your functions so
that's that's one way to do it defining all the functions having the text input that would be like
the menu and then when you pick your option then it runs that function so that that's really what i
want to get to is that you're putting all this together and it becomes your financial app so that
you can use this for other things you know calculating your own finances and this combined
with what you're doing certifications one and two see now where the goal is that you're getting to
the end of this and you have understand the math and you have all these functions at your disposal
you know calculate things graph things solve problems and then you can apply that later so
the next unit which i call it week 15 is going to be the wrapping up and putting all this together
so we reached the home stretch in our algebra journey here and now we're going to connect
all the different things we've been doing with math we've been looking a lot at functions
taking things that turn into x lists of x y values that we can graph and then now we're going to look
at how we can get the get that data from the web from the cloud from a spreadsheet from wherever
and bring that data in whether it be columns in a table or all sorts of information and pair it up
in those x y coordinates and then we can do math to it so really that's that's the connection we've
been working with all the math content and now pretty much everything we're going to be doing
beyond this we're going to bring that math content and into the code and do a lot more code how can i
into the code and do a lot more code how can i get this data turn it into a numpy array and
then do whatever graph i can do and you know analyze the data so let's let's get to it let's
get to the code so now this is some ways you can bring in data from other sources and graph it and
do other things so let's talk about the other sources pandas is the library that really deals
with data frames tables columns rows everything like that so we're going to import pandas import
the matplot library we've done that before and we're also going to import from google colab we're
going to import files and that's also going to give our file operations you'll see that and import
io input output there we go i separate these out because you can run these once and you know this
takes a few seconds i already did it so run it once and that saves you a few seconds each time
because we want to go through you'll see test some things now we have all those imports here's
ways that we can get the files all right here's one option if you have a csv on your computer
you can upload it and because we imported that google dialogue or the google files all right so
this is all we need files dot upload and we're going to upload that you know it'll give you that
file dialogue you can search for on your computer and that's what the one you select will will store
that as that variable uploaded and then so i have my file name because we have this we're going to
take that uploaded file and iteration so iter and the argument is uploaded and we're going to go to
the next one and what that is going to do is just one time you know you selected a file and we're
going to select that and store it as file name and here that file name we know the file name and we
know that it's a csv so pandas has this nice building pd dot read csv that's what we want to
get to and don't worry about this it's because i already stored that as file name you can use this
for you know whatever file you upload so uploaded file name and it reads that io dot bytes io and
it will store it as this table so there we go these three lines from you know uploading something
you know give you the file dialogue upload it from your computer and select it now when you run this
when you select that file it's stored as table one awesome so we'll do more stuff with that table
in in a minute here another way is you can get a csv from a url so maybe you already know you're
looking at different websites and you found you know this uh url and you see this one um
uh yeah this this guy uh seems to put put out a few good examples so there we go uh faithful
dot csv old faithful geyser you know it rups for a little you know briefly but like on such a
regular basis that's why it's called old faithful and that just might be some interesting data we
can look at so i'll just store it as this variable url which is the exact address pointing right to
the csv there you go plenty you could also and i didn't include this here but you could also if
you wanted to you know make your own like you know input statement you know prompt you know for
somebody else using you know you made this program for somebody else you could prompt somebody else
to just copy and paste the url and store it you know that works too but you know this is your code
so you just put the url here store it as variable url now same type of thing but here so we have pd
dot uh because we imported pan does it as pd pd dot read csv and i just need to read that url
and that's enough and i'll store it as table one
okay and yes those imports and everything that you run i just even have notes in here to remind
you so that's good for maybe 20 minutes google colab will uh have this runtime you're running
on their server and you know colab has a runtime once we started this it will time out after about
30 minutes of inactivity or even if you're active like you know let's say you have a really
busy day i think it's like about 12 hours of running it'll time out you know you could say
well wait i haven't been inactive but there's still an absolute time out and then you have to
start it again so that gives that gives you time you can import that and then it gives you time
to go through and then run a few of these and tinker with it okay so that way you don't have
to repeat those steps and again you know importing you know importing all those that actually takes a
few seconds to run it and then prompting you know if we want to do some different things and
test some things you don't have to upload it every time that saves you a few seconds or this even
so there we go now we have this what do we want to do with it you know i have you in the notes
we're going to eventually determine what columns we want and convert them to numpy arrays and
remember numpy arrays that's what we're that's what we end up graphing so one of the things and
i even still commented this out but you could display the whole table that might be too much
especially the the more you get into big data you know that's that's going to be just time consuming
resource consuming and so i i include that in there you know just to show you can do it but
but what else might we want to do i might just want to print out so we've always stored everything
as table one for this example so i might just want to print out the headers all right so table
one dot head and if i don't put a number in parentheses it will default to five but i can
put a number in there and it's going to give me the headings and i put a two so it's going to be
that give me the headings in two rows that might be enough you want to you know let's say even if
you've seen the column you might want to see the see it here or you know you got that url you want
to take a look at it i want to see the heading i want to see the column names and i want to see
two rows give me an idea of what kind of data because if i start seeing words in there then i
know that i'm not going to be able to convert that to a numpy array all right another way i could just
store column names as a variable because if i have table one in pandas that this exists table
one dot columns there you go so now this column names is a list of the column names that's great
um and again i can i only need to do this once and now that i have the column names what can i do with
them all right instead of printing out the heading i could and i just put this here you know
new line column names and then i could loop through them so i'll count them so a in range length
range length column names so column names i'm going to get the length get that as range and
then each time i'll print that number the space and then that column name that works that's one
way to do it or another way i could actually just loop through those names call and column names
and just print that each time so let's see what that looks like all right and so these are the
benefits here so notice this is the first one we did uh there you go print table header and that
print statement that head statement gave me these but this table also had an index column
and notice their index starts at one so that's just something to remember and eruption length
and eruption wait time so there we go and notice these quotes are within the
with within the name of the call you know that's something the more you get into uh
more you get into uh working with data and maybe other people you know creating columns and
everything i'll tell you this you really want column names without extra quotes in them and
without spaces but you know there's ways to deal with that we can do this but it just it just
usually makes it easier for this stuff and for like some of the sql queries okay so now i get
an idea of what i have and here again you see the column names you know index eruption there
and the the other way we did it index eruption length eruption wait time so now that i have
these exact column names so you know i could now this is how i did it here because i had them right
here and i can see them so table one and then in those square brackets i'm going to put the name
of that column i want and then also that name in single quotes to numpy so boom that'll convert
that to a numpy array and then eruption length in minutes so again table one and then in the
square brackets and remember that extra space and those quotes were in there so i need to make sure
i include them and convert that to a numpy array so now i have my x and y values that i can that i
can plot there you know going through each of them you know it's going to be you know my first value
x is 3.6 y is 779 x is 1.8 y is 54 oh no actually i had it as index so x is 1 y is 3.6 x is 2 y is
1.8 i can graph the eruption length or i can do it for eruption wait times and i'd like to go back
to the index again x is 1 y is 79 x is 2 y is 54 so i just graphed it for that first one and we
can go back and do that for the second one also if you wanted to so we have x and y because they're
numpy arrays i can call that function x.min and this you know if if you haven't really looked at
like the entire table this just might be a good way i'll just take the minimum value minus five
because it's just a little bit of a buffer on the edge and store that as x min x max same thing plus
five a little bit of a buffer y min y max so this goes back to things we were doing a while ago
with graphing set my x min x max and each of these now notice i don't have some of the things we were
doing in other other units we were defining the points here but i already have my x and y values
defined as num numpy arrays so when i graph i can plot i can plot them here as you know
you know the x refers to that array y refers to that array and i can do a scatter plot or a line graph
so i have these here as numpy arrays and i can do them as a scatter plot or a line graph
all right let's see what this looks like
now i had it as both and it looks like a huge mess but one of the things i notice is i
i don't want the line graph is probably not useful so i'll just go i'll just comment that
out right now and run it again and we see it seems to cluster it's around here or around here
that's kind of interesting what if i change my x my y value maybe i'll keep all these points but
what if i change this so what i can do is my y minimum and these are the things this is what we
want to do now we know how to use your math graphing skills to look at this you know how
to get all this data into this graph and this is now where we get to the analysis part what can i
do i can look at this and say all right you know they're all less than six and they're all greater
well actually they're all greater than zero so i can just make my y minimum zero and i'm just
going to comment out the rest of this and i can make my y maximum six and i'll just comment out
the rest of that and when we see that we might see it seems like it clusters it's for whatever
reason it's really rare for it to be around three and remember what are we graphing here
here we are graphing the eruption length time so it really seems to cluster around oh about two
minutes or about four minutes yeah interesting so we can look at this and then one of the other
things that we can do now let's look at another twist on this you can use variables for the column
names so remember earlier we made column names this array so i can have column name zero column
names one and that's my x name and my y name i'll make these variables so that also depending on
the actual names of your columns doing that once might save you some typing because
then you can reuse that variable here just yeah i don't have to worry about all the quotes every
time now i have my x variable is that column to numpy my y variable that column just like we were
doing before but again reusing that variable save you some typing i went back to this and we'll see
why in a minute and i just want to show you that that same scatter plot back to that those original
dimensions are there but you see using that as the column name i can also set the labels for the graph
and again without having to rewrite so now we have index and eruption length
there we go then if i wanted to talk about the eruption time or the erupt the wait time so all
the things that we were doing i can just change this i still want the index but then uh column
uh columns one was the eruption length i'll change that to that was the wait time and now i have those
names everything else stays the same and again going to different columns that's why i like
giving the dimensions of the graph based on that because these numbers are very different
i'll still have the same index because they did match but instead of times between you know zero
and five i will have you know wait wait time in minutes you know 40 minutes up to even you know
almost 100 minutes so we see that now again let's get to some analysis here this looks like a mess
it looks like maybe i have this range of 40 minutes to you know more than 90 minutes and this is key
like let's say this is in yellowstone let's say you go to visit and you say okay how long should
i have to wait it just erupted i want to go do other things when should i come back well should
i come back in 40 minutes should i come back in 90 minutes you know that's a huge range you know
could keep you you know waiting there almost an hour but let's let's start looking at other
patterns here again the default i keep this index i want to zoom in on some range here
so i'll go to that index that x value i'll keep the same minimum but what if i change that maximum
value instead of that plus five maybe i'll make it like 50 and comment out the rest of this so
that's interesting i'm just going to run this again doesn't help you but it spreads it out you
see now instead of a scatter plot actually i'll keep the scatter plot because that looks nice
but i'll also make it a line graph and i'll make the dots red and the line blue
so look at that
and you see that just looks nice and if i don't you know there's my y-axis at zero but if i don't
want that then i can just make my x x minimum you know one that way and comment that that way i
comment that that way i don't even get distracted by that there we go so we take a look at this
now besides seeing the scatter pot that was a mess the line graph actually shows us some
interesting things with very few exceptions if it was a shorter weight like 50 minutes
the next one's a longer weight closer to 90 and then the next one's a shorter minute a shorter
weight longer weight you see every so often you get one that it was another long weight
but we get a shorter weight a longer weight a shorter weight you know exception longer weight
that happens most of the time so what we can do is we could look at this and say oh well how long
oh well how long was it last time and then therefore i can use that to predict and we get
that from you know we get that from looking at the graph here so yeah really interesting i mean
you could probably then now connecting this to you know real-time data science
doing this then we could graph you know a certain amount of this and always you know have another
table that always just updates you know when it erupted and how long that would require somebody
each time you know just you know maybe even we could get this to clicking a button okay it
erupted it stopped erupting and then do the calculations what was the wait time what was the
eruption time add that new data and we could be looking at this and doing some sort of analysis
to give people you know real-time estimates of it just erupted when can you expect the next
eruption and get it down even probably to some like you know uh confidence interval that you know the
that you know the point is that you would want to be able to say instead of should i get there 50
minutes later or 90 minutes later i want to be able to have i don't know like a few minutes um
you know if it just erupted and it was an 80 minute wait then you know would it be
you know 50 minutes so you get some range that you know when to show back up and you know you
don't have to wait too long and that's really what we want to get this down to we want to look at
these patterns and be able to then predict the next one you know that's really the goal you know
if i go to here and i want to be able to predict and say oh all right at 50 that was a wait time
of 60 minutes so i'm going to just predict that the next wait time is going to be more than 80
and if we really want we can just change this to like 55
so with the wait time of 50 minutes then the next one wasn't quite 80 and so that's like your range
of well i wouldn't go i wouldn't wait more than 80 minutes i might wait almost 80 and it would show
up so there we go because remember the other graph the eruption time it's you know three to five
minutes you are two you know two minutes and it could be two minutes and you missed it could be
five minutes that's not even that long so you don't want to be you know five minutes late you're
going to miss it all so yeah just interesting we can use this to predict and again looking at the
math of it we have we you know once you have those column names
so once we have we get that table what once you have that table and we get table one dot columns
we have those column names and then we can do other things with that whatever we want you know
whatever we want you know number them you know just loop through them or then
pick certain ones and i'll use that as my x and y so that's the advantage of then having the graph
minimum maximum we can try this because we want to make this template that you're going to have this
and maybe certain things you can comment out and certain things you keep in certain things you
modify just a little bit that what you can use the same code for whatever graph you have you know
whatever table you have this is a good start you start getting some analysis what what am i trying
to compare what am i trying to graph and then as you get into it then you can modify it you know
you can always then copy all this and then you know do in here then copy all this do a new code cell
some text to give you know yourself or whoever read this some some notes on what's going on in
this code cell and you know that that's the beauty of the colab notebooks you know you don't have to
like you can delete things and retry things or you can keep that and then just you know oh this is
this is interesting information keep that and then just do a new code cell or new text and
you know let's do the next next analysis so here's another way to get data into colab and
then graph it this particular library so not a csv but the full library medial stat it's a lot
of weather data so yes may install need to only install once right once per one runtime and
i just have this as its own cell there you go pip install medial stat to install the library
doing that i mean this actually might take almost 30 seconds
so sometimes that seems like forever so i already did that and here we go
um successfully installed and then we go on to the next one and for your own organization or anybody
else working with this you put put in some text areas here so now i know and it reminds me what
columns i have in this library so time uh and all the other these other teasers temperature
average temperature minimum temp maximum temperature the amount of precipitation
amount of snow wind direction wind speed the pressure so average you know air pressure
uh air pressure uh the wind gusts so uh after wind speed we have wind gusts air pressure
and the last one is uh time in the sun so you know how many minutes of sunlight
would you get and these are really good i picked these because it might be useful
you know you can things like wind speed you know plan your uh wind turbines and where to put them
time in the sun plan for your solar panels and where to put them
um so i have these to remind me and then the reminder change start and end date time
and you know point we're going to use this a lot so what arguments is this expecting point
latitude longitude meters above the ground so now we have these notes you know maybe you set this
up for yourself and you don't use it for a while and then you forget you know what you can what
variables you can use so all this you know we can just keep this same i just have the notes here
because we have from numpy we're going to import mean because we're going to use that
and then the rest of these are from you know the media stat library we definitely want
daytime plot and for media stat we're going to just import these couple things also it's just
it's useful put the documentation in you know that here's the website where all the documentation is
you know put that in there as a comment again just like the other notes for yourself or for other
people good to keep track of these things so now we know what we're expecting we can set the time
period and what i wanted to do is i just picked you know sometime you know one month in the summer
start and end so i have eight time there we go year month day your month start and end and
so the person who put out this one example online did this for vancouver so you know i just
commented that out and i did one for philadelphia and i picked a random point in the middle of the
city because it you know the uh if you want to click places and you get latitude and longitude
he had a lot of decimal places so i just wanted to round it to two decimal places and see where
you know you know in philadelphia in general and then round it to two dozen places and see
where we got so it's a some random street corner in the city and remember that third argument is
how many meters above the ground so i put 10 because this could be a wind turbine you know
on top of a building and i wanted to compare this to somewhere in the suburb so you know it are the
closely packed buildings does that affect wind speed well we're still talking 10 meters above
the ground so this is in you know residential neighborhood that is probably above all the
buildings but i picked a point in the suburbs and i picked a point that seemed to be like a relatively
open field as something to compare so now i have these two points and i can get this daily data
uh so daily so that's the function in in media stat and there we go i get this particular point
you know these are arguments that point and then start time and end time and then we go to this
daily data dot fetch and i'm going to store it as my data now we want to take this my data
my data and which one do i want i want wind speed for this one and remember our function
dot to numpy and i'm going to store that so now num data is my array and you see the these layers
that we want to do this library requires this function here i'll store that as a variable now
that variable uh got fetched that's also from media stat i'll store that but then i that's not
a numpy array so i want to make that a number i want to take that calculate you know wind speed
that column and make that a numpy array so i'll print that you know city mean equals and i wanted
to get the mean to compare so now i have the second one again i'll do the same thing that daily
function fetch the data convert it to a numpy array and in this case i'll do the suburbs mean
but remember num data and num data too they're my two numpy arrays so i can use them to plot
so we can plot the line plot the line there we go and
and so i have this you know these two things i have you know the x value is
since i know that i made my since i know that i made my start and end time you know 30 you know
30 days i wanted to make the x value there you go same thing one to 31 uh 31 instances because
it includes the first one so there we go and then i can plot these wind speed and run it
all right now i'll tell you why i have that commented out i'll tell you now that i have
these because this works like uh i wanted to again connect it with the same type of plot you know
matplot library that we use i wanted to connect it to that same matplot library that we've been
using and show you that that's what you can do you know get those arrays and plot them here
matplot.show but i commented this out this works also just a unique feature of this library um
you can just take that my data dot plot and then in parentheses you know what the y value is so
these two work so i just wanted to show you i'll leave them in there they work but in order
to connect this with the same type of math and plotting we're using i plotted them this way and
so i had it calculate and then just display you know the city mean and suburbs mean i could have
rounded it but and quite honestly this is why we do data analysis this totally surprised me
i really thought the average wind speed in this suburban area that was like a relatively open
field would have been significantly higher and it was definitely higher in the city yeah interesting
um maybe you know a little bit of a tunnel effect maybe there is some something going on with uh
you know the buildings maybe that wasn't high enough also at least in philadelphia that city
and if it's high enough that's a little bit closer to the river delaware river is you know any river
gives off a little bit more wind and this was a little bit closer so that might have had an
effect but there we go so then we see the mean but beyond that we can see the tracking you know day
to day and you know they're still these two points that i picked are not that far apart
so it tracks they're in the same area the wind speeds go up and down you know in very similar
patterns but we see that not just the mean but at every single point that city location was higher
so there we go and
you know we could take a look now i made this so that's good and we can just pick that and
we can pick like any number of days so i could since all the rest is already in there i could
just pick this and say well what about over the course of the year so maybe i make that like one
one and maybe i make that 12 31 and there we go so if it would include then there we go so 365
and 365 so i want to graph it this way so from one to 365 and 365 points if that doesn't line
up perfectly then i might have to do one more or one less but we can take this and we can run this
oh value error and it was 365 357 oh that's really interesting all right so 357 and 357
and so we can see you know the scattering but also i liked this now why what what i picked was uh
you know not 365 days that seemed like that would be it i'm not really going to overthink that
right now maybe there were some days that were missing but you know maybe that's not the
pattern but you know maybe that sometimes that happens we go and we can uh go through and you
know take out missing information or incomplete information but now we take a look that over so
the day that i picked happened to be slightly lower than average so in both it was up a little
bit you know 14 miles an hour 8 miles an hour and then we can see the patterns here so if this was
wind speed you know the average then what you could do is you know you could count based on
that average you actually don't need to plot it out because it works out given the given those
averages you can work on that so if your wind speed is you know in the city and it's you know
almost it's like 14 miles an hour throughout the year then you can look up well what size
wind turbine and it would be actually relatively small but what size wind turbine you know would
you need for 14 mile an hour winds and you can do some calculations given that size of the turbine
how much electricity would that generate for you over the course of the year yeah so pretty cool
and again you can you know you can do that with you know any other aspect of this the temperature
you know maybe you know you're trying to plan something you know you can get uh you know
temperatures just one other thing i did just was you know different so i can't i loop it through
for you know a month just to show you and and all the rest of this is the same documentation link
and what i did is i just made it a loop so you know range 1 to 11 and so that would be the
month and i have you know what month there we go and you know there we go i think i picked just
this because i thought oh well is that does that change and these monthly loops
um yeah the way that the x value displays sometimes it seems like a little cut off
but we can see we have you know wind speed and we can just see you know a few different months
over the course of it and you see each month i have the mean and then and then the graph
and and then the graph so we can just see it's just interesting you know the mean and the graph
for each month the display it a little this might be a little clunky this might just be for your own
interest or you could have something that displays them all in some nice little you know three by
four the grid it gets to be small graphs though but nonetheless we see that there's times when the
when it goes down so i just wanted to show you some of these things that you can do with this
with this with this graph and you know beyond that that there's other ways and what you can do
to in you know any other data you find if you you know you're looking up some things you might find
them maybe it's a csv but maybe somebody you know put together an entire library and with that they
not only have the data and then that's stored somewhere but you know somebody also wrote these
so that you have all these already how can i get a point and how can i get all this different data
from any of those points so things that you can make and things that you can find online that
somebody else made you know different ways that you can find this data and then graph it so trying
to give you some more tools now you know now that you know math and python and can use this to graph
you know some more tools and some more sources of data
so what i want to show you here is just a few more things that you can do right within colab
and we already looked at over here on the left the table of contents that you can
get to appear disappear then we have the search you can even search for directly for variables here
and then we have this folder icon where you can click to mount your google drive directly
and then once you do that then you can also see give it permission and down here we see
it's mounting the google drive once you do that then you'll see it has the slash through it now
so you can unmount the google drive if you want if if you wanted to do that so this makes it easy
so this makes it easy to find things and move things back and forth within your google drive
then the really big thing down here is the look at these tags you can get all these code snippets
that are already in the google colab you see adding form from fields oh i want to add a form
get the code right here you can copy it or even click it you know if you happen to be
right in the place where you want to put it you click insert all these other things camera capture
and notice this even uses javascript within python interfaces this so it's pretty cool
again all these and some of these you know downloading files
from google drive from github all kinds of things importing libraries that
you know that are in co-laboratory all of these zip reader there's a lot of other things that you
can do open files from github from your google drive from your local file system how you can
just upload those so it even gets down in here into pandas data frame and that's kind of where
we want to get our math skills too that we can take data from wherever well that's the
pandas part and then bring it in and then do some different math to it what can i graph can i
display it in different ways and that's what we want to take this to so what i'm going to do is
you'll see below this video there's other code that i'll include but i'm not going to go through
every one of these but check these out i mean there's so many different things already built
into colab that you can you can do you know open up a sample you know and tinker with it i have a
colab notebook i just call it code tester and i just have different things that i can go through
and you know let's try this let's try that and then you know you put together in your notebook
of stuff that works but here's all these things available and then i'm going to put together
another colab notebook of just a few other things you know to tackle on this end of this class to
continue you know some things that you can do with math and with code and you know we're building
upon this leading to you know working with data and doing some other interesting things with that
so check these out and you know tinker with them and enjoy
wow you made it so now having gone through this now you should have a good understanding of algebra
you should be familiar with all the key concepts and how to write the code to do all of your
algebra you should have your at least one or however you organized it colab notebook that's
ready with all of your scripts for solving all different sorts of algebra problems you made it
through certification one two and three and you have the ability to solve a lot of different
problems and you know write the code or reference code that you've already written
to solve these problems so there you go you should be you should be all set this is the
foundational math because it is the math that we're going to use and that you'll be able to use for
so many other things in math including data science data science we're going to bring up
formulas like this functions like you've been working on you know algebra level solving some
graphing so now you have an understanding of all that and then you can apply it to other things
for yeah statistics data science and a few other subjects too so if you continue on with the next
step we will do a pre-calc trig that type of topic so you know some other deeper understanding of
other graphs we didn't get to in in algebra because they're a little bit different
other sorts of patterns dealing with locations of things and circles and more angles and a lot of
triangles so that'll be something that we'll do next and again that's going to also build to help
you with statistics and data science because as you represent data on graphs or use different sort
of mathematical analyses to see relationships among data points you know the deeper math will
get you to be able to detect more and more complex relationships among data so this is the
foundation i feel like you have a good foundation hopefully you're feeling the same and there you go
you made it and on to on to the next adventure